LIKE TO GO AHEAD AND GET STARTED
HERE I THINK THANK PEOPLE FOR
THEIR PATIENTS WE HAD FLOOR
SESSION THIS MORNING IN THE
SENATE -- SESSION WHEN A LITTLE
LONGER THAN THE ASSEMBLY SESSION.
I SOME ANNOUNCEMENTS BEFORE WE
BEGIN -- FIRST OF ALL DOCTOR
JOAQUIN ARAMBULA WILL REPLACE
ASSEMBLY MATTER MEMBER FREDDIE
RODRIGUEZ FOR TODAY'S HEARING
ONLY -- WITNESS A TESTIMONY WILL
BE DRESSED A LITTLE DIFFERENTLY
TO ALLOW ADEQUATE TIME FOR
WITNESSES.
THERE WILL BE A TOTAL OF TEN
MINUTES ALLOWING FOR SUPPORT.
AND TEN MINUTES ALLOWED FOR
OPPOSITION.
ALSO ALL MEMBER QUESTIONS WILL
HAPPEN AFTER THOSE WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY HAVE HAD THEIR
OPPORTUNITY TO DO SO.
DOCTOR PAN WILL PRESENT HIS BILL.
THEN THE SUPPORT WILL HAVE THE
CHANCE TO TESTIFY FOR TEN
MINUTES.
AFTER THAT THOSE IN FORTY TWO OH
TWO WHO WISH TO GIVE THEIR THIS
WHICH IS THIS ROOM BY THE WAY --
WHO WISH TO GET THEIR NAME IN
SUPPORT MAY DO SO?
WILL BE STRICTLY LIMITED TO YOUR
NAME -- AND WHETHER YOU SUPPORT
ULTIMATELY WE ON THE OTHER SIDE
WITH THE OPPOSE THE BILL.
IF YOU DECIDE YOU WANT TO ADD
ADDITIONAL COMMENTARY ON THE
MICROPHONE WILL BE TURNED OFF.
AFTER SUPPORT IS FINISHED.
WE'LL HEAR FROM REPRESENTATIVES
FROM THE OPPOSITION FOR TEN
MINUTES.
AND AFTER THAT THOSE IN FORTY
TWO OH TWO WILL BE GIVEN THEIR
NAY THERE TO GET WHICH TO GET
THEIR NAME OPPOSITION -- CAN DO
SO AS PREVIOUSLY STATED ONCE
AGAIN STRICTLY LIMITED TO NAME
THE REPRESENT AN ORGANIZATION
YOUR POSITION ONLY.
A SERGEANTS WILL CONTINUALLY
ALLOW PEOPLE -- TO ENTERED THE
ROOM GET THEIR NAME AN
ORGANIZATION AS WE GO FORWARD --
ALTHOUGH YOU MAY BRING YOUR
CHILD TO THE MICROPHONE WE ARE
ASKING TESTIMONY BE LIMITED TO
ADULTS.
AND WE THANK YOU IN ADVANCE FOR
YOUR COOPERATION -- WITH THE
EXCEPTION THE TIME LIMITS THIS
IS EXACTLY HOW WE RUN OUR
HEARINGS -- EVERY OTHER HEARING
WE DO SO THIS IS NO DIFFERENT
THAN ANY OTHER HEARING SO ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE MEMBERS WILL
HAPPEN WILL HAPPEN AFTER ALL
PEOPLE HAVE SPOKEN IN THEIR
TESTS AND TESTIMONY TODAY.
SO WITH THAT -- WE WILL GO AHEAD
AND OPEN AND DOCTOR PAN WE WILL
BE PRESENTING.
SB TWO SEVENTY SIX THANK YOU SO
VERY MUCH -- CHAIR WAS IN
MEMBERS AND REALLY APPRECIATE
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY AND TO PRESENT SB.
TWO SEVENTY SIX THE BILL THAT IS
NECESSARY TO PROTECT THE SAFETY
OF OUR CHILDREN AND COMMUNITY IS
ART SO COUNTRY IS EXPERIENCING
THE LARGEST.
NUMBER OF MEASLES AND FACTIONS
AND OVER A QUARTER CENTURY.
SB TWO SEVENTY SIX MAINTAINS AND
RESTORES THE INTEGRITY OF THE
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS SYSTEM TO
LEGALLY REQUIRED VACCINES FOR
SCHOOL ROLE MEANT.
NOW I THANK YOU CHAIR WORDS IN
YOUR STAFF -- FOR YOUR WORK ON
THE BILL AND I AM ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK GOVERNOR
NEWSOME IN HIS OFFICE
PARTICULARLY SECRETARY HAVE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES GOLLY
WHO WORKED CLOSELY WITH BOTH.
THE ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE
STAFF AND MYSELF TO CRAFT THE
CALIFORNIA SOLUTION TO ENSURING
THE SAFETY OF CHILDREN WHO TRULY
REQUIRE MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS TO
VACCINATION REQUIREMENTS TO
ENROLL IN SCHOOL.
GOVERNOR NEWSOME IS A CHAMPION
FOR CHILDREN AND FAMILIES AND I
APPRECIATE HIS COMMITMENT TO
SIGN SB TWO SEVENTY SIX AFTER IS
PASSED BY THIS LEGISLATURE.
SB TWO SEVENTY SIX ENSURES THAT
STUDENTS WHO TRULY NEED A
MEDICAL EXEMPTION WILL RECEIVE
THE EXEMPTION.
WHILE KEEPING THE SAME CHILDREN
SAFE AT SCHOOL BY ENSURING THERE
IS COMMUNITY IMMUNITY.
THIS BILL PROTECTS THE RIGHTS OF
THESE CHILDREN TO ATTEND SCHOOL
AND ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIANS
HAVE THE FREEDOM.
THE FREEDOM TO GO ABOUT THEIR
COMMUNITY WITHOUT BEING AT RISK
OF BEING INFECTED WITH SERIOUS
PREVENTABLE DISEASES.
THERE HAVE ALREADY BEEN OVER A
THOUSAND ACTUALLY THOUSAND FORTY
FOUR REPORTED CASES OF MEASLES
AND UNITED STATES THIS YEAR THIS
IS THE MOST NUMBER SINCE.
NINETEEN NINETY TWO AND
CERTAINLY SINCE MEASLES THE
CLEAR ELIMINATED IN THE YEAR.
TWO THOUSAND THIS YEAR DEVON
OUTBREAKS WITH FIVE HUNDRED
NINETY SIX CASES IN NEW YORK
CITY TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE IN
ROCKLAND COUNTY NEW YORK.
EIGHTY ONE IN WASHINGTON STATE
AND NUMEROUS OTHER STATES AS
WELL.
AND ALL THESE OUTBREAKS HAVE
SPREADING COMMUNITIES WITH LOW
VACCINATION RATES.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA THERE'D BEEN
FIFTY TWO MEASLES CASES
INCLUDING MULTIPLE CASES OF COME
THROUGH ALLEY ACTS.
MANY OF WHICH INVOLVE
UNVACCINATED PEOPLE CATCHING
MEASLES OVERSEAS AND RETURNING
CALIFORNIA WITH THE DISEASE AND
THERE'S STILL AN ONGOING
OUTBREAK IN BUTTE COUNTY.
NOW IS REPORT IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO CHRONICLE WELL MEASLES
HAS BEEN BROUGHT TO CALIFORNIA
ON SEVERAL OCCASIONS THIS YEAR
UNLIKE OTHER STATES.
WE HAVE NOT SUFFERED A LARGE
OUTBREAK LIKE THOSE WE SEEN IN
OTHER STATES.
LIKE THE WHAT AND LIKE THE ONE
WE SAW ACTUALLY HERE IN
DISNEYLAND IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
AND THAT'S BECAUSE THIS
LEGISLATURE TOOK ACTION BY
PASSING SB TWO SEVEN SEVEN TO
RESTORE COMMUNITY TO
NEIGHBORHOODS IN CALIFORNIA.
SB TWO SEVEN SEVEN PROVED
SUCCESSFUL IN RAISING STATE
VACCINATION RATES FOR EACH OF
THE INTERNET GOT ENTERING
KINDERGARTEN CLASS ABOVE 90%
AFTER ITS IMPLEMENTATION ENOUGH
TO BEGAN RESTORING COMMUNITY.
BUT THIS PROTECTION IS BEING
UNDERMINED.
BEING UNDERMINED BY A HANDFUL OF
UNSCRUPULOUS POSITIONS WHO ARE
PROFITING FROM PUTTING CHILDREN
AT RISK IN MAKING OUR SCHOOLS
LESS SAFE.
SB TWO SEVEN SEVEN DID NOT
SUBSTANTIALLY CHANGE THE
GRANTING A MEDICAL EXEMPTION BY
POSITIONS WHICH EXPECTED DENTIST
PAY THAT EACH CHILD WOULD BE
EVALUATED BY A PHYSICIAN.
WHO REGULARLY CARED FOR THAT
CHILD AND RECEIVING THE
EXEMPTION APPLYING THE STANDARD
OF CARE?
INSTEAD AFTER PASSAGE OF SB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN WE WITNESSED
PHYSICIANS TO ADVERTISE
EXEMPTIONS FOR CASH AND SOCIAL
MEDIA AND THE INTERNET.
SOME PARENTS WOULD POSTED THEIR
CHILD'S POSITION REFUSED TO
GRANT THEIR CHILD A MEDICAL
EXEMPTION SO THEY BOUGHT ONE
FROM A DISTANT POSITION
[inaudible]
AND IT.
EXCUSE ME NO HIS SAME.
PLEASE NO CLAPPING NO NO
OUTBURSTS OF ANY KIND PLEASE.
PLEASE PROCEED DOT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU DOCTOR
CHAIR.
AN INVESTIGATION BY THE VOICE OF
SAN DIEGO OF MEDICAL EXEMPTION
SUBMITTED TO THE SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT SHOW
THAT ONE PHYSICIAN WHO WAS
ADVERTISING MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS
UNDER WEBSITE.
ISSUED ALMOST A THIRD OF ALL THE
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS IN SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
THE PHYSICIAN WHO ISSUED THE
SECOND MOST NUMBER OF MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS AT THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICT DOES NOT SPECIALIZE IN
PEDIATRICS AND IS ACTUALLY ON
PROBATION WITH THE MEDICAL BOARD
FOR GROSS NEGLIGENCE.
THIS CARE TREATMENT OF PATIENTS.
I WOULD ALSO NOTE THE PROMINENT
ANTI VACCINE PHYSICIAN BACH DR
BOB SEARS WHO'S CURRENTLY ON
PROBATION WITH THE MEDICAL BOARD
FOR QUOTE GROSS NEGLIGENCE
REPEATED NEGLIGENT ACTS. FOR
GRANTING AN APPROPRIATE MEDICAL
EXEMPTION ISSUED THE FOURTH
GREATEST NUMBER MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS IN THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
AND HE'S ALSO BEEN DISCOVERED
HAVE GRANTED MEDICAL EXEMPTION
TO STUDENTS ATTENDING SCHOOLS IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA FORMULA FAR
FROM IS PRACTICING CAPISTRANO.
IN FACT TODAY THE SAN JOSE
MERCURY REPORT ON INVESTIGATION
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS IN EIGHT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WHICH REVEALED THAT
ONLY FIVE DOCTORS ACCOUNT FOR
MORE THAN HALF.
OF THE HUNDRED EIGHTY EXEMPTIONS
ACROSS THESE DISTRICTS. THREE OF
THE DOCTORS IN THIS REPORT ARE
ALREADY UNDER INVESTIGATION BY
THE STATE.
DOCTOR CAN THE STOLAR UNDER
INVESTIGATION BY THE SAN
FRANCISCO CITY ATTORNEY ROAD
EXEMPTIONS ACROSS EVERY SINGLE
SCHOOL DISTRICT INCLUDED IN THAT
ARTICLE.
THE ARTICLE ALSO CONFIRM THAT
DESPITE HIS PROBATION A STATUS
WITH THE MEDICAL BOARD DR BOB'S
YEARS IS CONTINUING TO WRITE
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS. THREE
EXEMPTIONS WERE EVEN SIGNED BY
OUT OF STATE DOCTORS.
THE RESULTS OF THESE FAKE
MEDICOS ENGINESWAS A
QUADRUPLING OF THE PERCENTAGE OF
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS IN THE STATE.
AND THE DECLINE IN THE STATE
VACCINATION RATE BELOW 95% THIS
CURRENT SCHOOL YEAR SO WE WERE
ABOVE NOW WE'RE BELOW.
BUT EVEN MORE CONCERNING BECAUSE
OF THAT THE STATE WIDE RATE THAT
MATTERS OVER A HUNDRED SCHOOLS
IN CALIFORNIA HAVE MEDICAL
EXEMPTION RATES OVER 10%.
WITH SOME AS HIGH AS 50% MEETING
STUDENTS AT THE SCHOOLS AT RISK
FOR A MAJOR OUTBREAK AND ARE NO
LONGER SAFE.
THESE SCHOOLS REPRESENT THE
TENDER FOR DISEASE WILD FIRE
THAT CAN HARM THE BROADER
COMMUNITY.
CALIFORNIA CANNOT ALLOW HANDFUL
OF UNSCRUPULOUS POSITIONS TO PUT
OUR CHILDREN IN DANGER.
PARTICULARLY BABIES TOO YOUNG TO
BE VACCINATED IN CHILDREN WHO
GENUINELY NEED A MEDICAL
EXEMPTION.
AND THAT IS WHY THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
AND THE CALIFORNIA AMERICAN
CAPPY APTRIX ARE SPONSORING SB.
TWO SEVENTY SIX WITH THE PARENTS
OF ACTUALLY CALIFORNIA.
PHYSICIANS ARE DEMANDING THAT
THEY HOLD THEMSELVES ACCOUNTABLE
AND THE COLLEAGUES ACCOUNTABLE
TO PRACTICING QUALITY CARE BASED
ON SCIENCE TO KEEP THE PUBLIC
SAFE.
WHAT THE AMENDMENTS TAKEN UP FOR
THIS COMMITTEE BEGINNING IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE SB TWO SEVENTY
SIX WILL REQUIRE ALL MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS TO BE FILED WITH THE
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH?
AND PHYSICIANS WOULD HENCEFORTH
BE REQUIRED TO SUBMIT REQUESTS
FOR MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
EXEMPTION REQUEST WILL BE
STANDARDIZED REQUIRING ESSENTIAL
INFORMATION FROM THE POSITION
INCLUDING THEIR NAME IN LICENSE
NUMBER THE REASON FOR THE
EXCEPTION AND ATTESTATIONS THEY
HAVE ACTUALLY EXAMINE THE CHILD.
THAT THEY PROVIDE ON GOING CARE
FOR THE CHILD AND WHETHER THEY
ARE THE CHILD'S PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIAN AND THEY'RE NOT
REPLYING POSITION WILL NEED TO A
TEST THEY HAVE NOTIFIED THE
CHILD'S PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIANS
THAT THEY'RE APPLYING FOR A
MEDICAL EXEMPTION. FOR THAT
PRIMARY KERR'S PATIENT.
THE INFORMATION WILL BE
INCLUDING THE CALIFORNIA
IMMUNIZATION REGISTRY WHICH
ALREADY CONTAINS IMMUNIZATION
RECORDS FOR CHILDREN WHO
ACTUALLY RECEIVE VACCINATIONS IS
COMPLIANT WITH ALL FEDERAL AND
STATE PRIVACY LAWS.
I WOULD NOTE THAT THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH HAS TREMENDOUS
EXPERIENCE PROTECTING STE VERY
SENSITIVE HEALTH DATA INCLUDING
MAINTAIN A CANCER REGISTRY AND
INFORMATION ON PATIENTS WITH
COMMUNICABLE DISEASES INCLUDING.
SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED DISEASES
AND HIV.
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS REQUEST WILL
BE REVIEWED IN A TARGETED MANNER.
REQUEST FOR BUSINESS UNITS AND
ROLLING SCHOOLS WITH
IMMUNIZATION RATES BELOW 95% THE
RATE FOR COMMUNITY ARE WHO DID
NOT REPORT THE MUSICIAN RACE TO
SEE PH.
OR IF THEY RECEIVE REQUESTS FROM
PHYSICIANS OR MAKING AN
UNUSUALLY LARGE NUMBER OF
EXEMPTION REQUESTS.
WILL BE EXAMINED BY CLINICAL
STAFF AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH.
LL OTHER EXEMPTION REQUEST WILL
BE GRANTED WITHOUT FURTHER
REVIEW.
PHYSICIANS AND REGISTERED NURSES
AT THE DEPARTMENT CAN ACCEPT
EXEMPTIONS BASED ON EITHER THE
CDC ARE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS GUIDELINES OR OTHER
REASONS CONSISTENT WITH THE
STANDARD OF CARE.
EXEMPTION REQUEST THAT BABY
INAPPROPRIATE WILL THEN BE
REVIEWED BY THE STATE HEALTH
OFFICER WHO IS A PHYSICIAN.
OR DESIGNATE POSITION AND MAYBE
REJECTED REVOKED.
THE PARENT OR REQUESTING
PHYSICIAN CAN APPEAL THIS
DECISION TO A PANEL PRACTICING
PHYSICIANS APPOINTED BY THE
SECRETARY AT THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES.
WHO ARE PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIANS
ARE HAVE EXPERTISE IN
VACCINATION INFECTIOUS DISEASE?
IF EXEMPTION DECIDED TO BE
REJECTED A REVOKED THE STUDENT
WILL BE REQUIRED TO COMMENCE
WITH RECOMMENDED IMMUNIZATION
SCHEDULE REQUIRED FOR
CONDITIONAL AMENDMENTS WITHIN
THIRTY DAYS.
SB TWO SEVENTY SIX WILL PROVIDE
THE RECORD OVERSIGHT REQUIRED TO
ENSURE THAT STANDARD OF CARE
SAFETY GUIDELINES OUR PLIGHT.
AND ARE MOST AT RISK SCHOOLS AND
EXTEND THAT OVERSIGHT TO
PHYSICIANS TO SUBMIT SIGNIFICANT
NUMBERS OF EXEMPTIONS.
CURRENTLY MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS ARE
ISSUED BY PHYSICIANS TO FAMILIES
WHO TO SUBMIT THEM TO SCHOOLS
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICERS DO NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO INFORMATION ON
WHICH CHILDREN HAVE MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS.
THUS SB TWO SEVENTY SIX WILL
ALSO REQUIRE ALL EXISTING
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS TO BE FILED
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF THE HEALTH TO BE VALID.
THE REMAINS THEY'LL BE SUBJECT
TO THE SAME REVIEW PROCESS IS
DESCRIBED.
THE SUBMISSION OF MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS THE PUBLIC HEALTH
PROVIDES IMPORTANT INFORMATION
TO HELP CONTAIN.
AN OUTBREAK LIKE THE ONES WERE
EXPERIENCING NOW.
IN THE EVENT OF AN OUTBREAK
SCHOOL PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS
HAVE TO REQUIRE UNVACCINATED
STUDENTS REMAIN AT HOME TO
PREVENT FURTHER SPREAD OF THE
DISEASE.
IN FACT THE NEED FOR THIS
INFORMATION HAS BEEN ILLUSTRATED
BY A MEASLES OUTBREAK THAT KERR
IN THE BAY AREA LAST SPRING.
WHEN UNPACKS THE CHILD WAS
INFECTED WITH MEASLES IN EUROPE
AND RETURNED TO CALIFORNIA WITH
THE DISEASE?
THAT CHILD THEN TRANSMIT THE
DISEASE TO OTHER UNVACCINATED
CHILDREN INCLUDING A FAMILY WHO
LIED TO PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS
THAT THEIR CHILDREN WERE
VACCINATED.
IN TRUTH THIS FAMILY HAD
PURCHASED INAPPROPRIATE MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS FROM A PHYSICIAN
HUNDREDS OF MILES AWAY.
BECAUSE THEY LIED.
THE PUBLIC HEALTH WORKERS DO NOT
FOLLOW UP UNTIL THEY DISCOVERED
ADDITIONAL PEOPLE WHO WERE
INFECTED WITH MEASLES.
WHO HAD CONTACT WITH THESE EXAMS
CHILDREN AND THEY TRACED IT BACK
TO THIS FAMILY?
AT HAVING HAD MEDICAL EXEMPTION
INFORMATION COULD HAVE PREVENTED
FURTHER SPREAD DISEASE BECAUSE
THE PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS
WOULD HAVE BEEN AWARE THAT THE
CHILDREN WERE IN VACCINATED.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO CLARIFY
CORRECT -- CLARIFY COUPLE
MISLEADING CLAIMS THAT BEEN MADE
BY THE OPPOSITION TO DATE.
FIRST OF ALL THERE ARE NO FDA
APPROVED EXEMPTIONS TO
VACCINATIONS.
THE OPPOSITION HAS DISTRIBUTE A
LIST OF PURPORTED SIDE EFFECTS
OF VACCINES THAT THE CLAIMS ARE
FTA RECOGNIZE REASONS FOR
ISSUING MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS.
MANY OF THE REASONS ON THE LIST
STRAIN CREDULITY CLEANING
SOMETHING LIKE HAIR LOSS.
LET'S BE CLEAR THE FEDERAL
ADVISORY COMMITTEE ON
IMMUNIZATION PRACTICES COMPOSED
OF NATIONAL EXPERTS ON
INFECTIOUS DISEASE AND VACCINE
SUPPLIES ON GOING RESEARCH.
FROM SEVERAL VACCINE SAFETY
MODERN PROGRAMS TO ISSUE THE CDC
CONTRA INDICATIONS OF
PRECAUTIONS TO VACCINATIONS.
SECOND THE OPPOSITION HAD
FALSELY CLAIMED THAT POSITIONS
HAD NOT BEEN FOUND TO BE IT TO
BE BE ISSUING FAKE MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS AND IN FACT CITED A
PAPER PUBLISHED IN THE JOURNAL
PEDIATRICS THAT INCLUDES MEDICAL
BOARD DATA.
THAT NUMEROUS COMPLAINTS HAD
BEEN DISMISSED BY THE BOARD.
NOW IF YOU ACTUALLY READ THE
PAPER THE PAPER ACTUALLY
REPORTED THE COUNTY HEALTH
OFFICERS WERE FRUSTRATED.
BECAUSE THEY RECOGNIZE THERE ARE
MANY AN APPROPRIATE MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS HOWEVER WERE
POWERLESS TO STOP THEM SINCE THE
EXEMPTIONS ACTUALLY WENT TO THE
SCHOOLS AND EIGHT AND RECEIVE
THEM DIRECTLY.
IN ADDITION THEY RECOGNIZE THAT
THE SCHOOLS THEMSELVES HAD NO
LEGAL AUTHORITY NOT TO ACCEPT
THE EXEMPTIONS EVEN WHEN THEY
KNEW THEY WERE PROBLEMATIC.
SECOND THE MEDICAL BOARD IS
BEING STYMIED.
BY IT BECAUSE PARENTS PURCHASING
INAPPROPRIATE MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS
ARE OBSTRUCTING INVESTIGATIONS
BY REFUSING TO GIVE THE BOARD
ACCESS TO MEDICAL RECORDS SO
CASES ARE BEING DROPPED BECAUSE
THE BOARDS AND ABLE TO CONDUCT
THE INVESTIGATION.
AS I MENTIONED EARLIER BOB SEARS
WHO HAS BEEN PUT ON PROBATION BY
THE MEDICAL BOARD FOR ISSUING AN
APPROPRIATE MEDICAL EXEMPTION.
ONLY THIS ONLY OCCURRED WHEN A
PARENT COOPERATED WITH THE
MEDICAL BOARD.
IN ADDITION THE MEDICAL BOARD
RECENTLY WON AN APPEALS COURT
RULING TO OBTAIN ACCESS TO
RECORDS FROM DOCTOR RON KENNEDY
OF SANTA ROSA.
WHO ACTUALLY PRACTICES AND ANTI
AGING CLINIC?
AND IS BEING INVESTIGATED FOR
QUOTE IMPROPERLY ISSUING BLANKET
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS FOR
VACCINATION AND QUOTE.
BUT DESPITE THIS EFFORT SO FAR
THE MEDICAL BOARD IS STILL
WAITING FOR DIRECTORS TO CONDUCT
INVESTIGATIONS HE RESISTS
PROVIDING THOSE RECORDS.
NOW SB TWO SEVENTY SIX ADDRESSES
THESE BARRIERS BY REQUIRING THE
MEDICAL EXEMPTION REQUEST
INCLUDE A MEDICAL RECORD RELEASE
FOR THE MEDICAL BOARD INTO THE
PART PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND ALSO REQUIRES TO THE PART
PUBLIC HEALTH TO SHARE
INFORMATION WITH THE MEDICAL
BOARD REGARDING REJECTED
EXEMPTION REQUESTS AND THE
POSITIONS ARE ISSUING LARGE
NUMBERS OF REJECTED REQUESTS.
I POINT OUT IF THE REQUESTS ARE
BEING REJECTED THEIR OF VALID
THAT DOES NOT CREATE ANY PROBLEM
FOR THE POSITION.
SB TWO SEVENTY SIX IS ABOUT
KEEPING OUR STATE AND COMMUNITY
SAFE FROM PREVENTABLE DISEASES.
THE REPORTS OF MEASLES OUTBREAKS
THIS YEAR UNDERSCORE HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO PASS SB TWO
SEVENTY SIX TO MAINTAIN THE HARD
WON GAINS WE MADE WITH SB.
TWO SEVEN SEVEN WE MUST NOT LET
A HANDFUL OF UNSCRUPULOUS
POSITIONS TO PROFIT BY ISSUING
FAKE MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS THAT
UNDERMINE THE SAFETY OF OUR
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY.
SB TWO SEVENTY SIX HAS SUPPORT
FROM LEADING PARENT AND CHILD
ADVOCACY GROUPS.
INCLUDING THE CALIFORNIA PTA
CHILDREN NOW THE CHILDREN'S
DEFENSE FUND AND MARCH OF DIMES
EDUCATION GROUPS INCLUDING
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL NURSES
ORGANIZATION AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT INCLUDING SEE SEC.
THE COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATIONS OF CALIFORNIA THE
HEALTH OFFICER'S ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA AND THE COUNTIES OF
LOS ANGELES RENDON SANTA CLARA.
AND CERTAINLY OF COURSE SUPPORT
FROM A BROAD COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA'S LEADING HEALTH
ORGANIZATIONS YOU CAN SEE FROM
THE ANALYSIS.
NOW I AM PLEASED INTRODUCED
THREE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL WE HAVE FIRST JENNY
BLACK BALLACK A PARENT OF THE
IMMUNO COMPROMISED CHILD TO
DEPENDS ON TO MEDIUM YOU NEED TO
KEEP YOUR CHILD SAFE.
DR MARKET PARSONS A TRUSTEE OF
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION AND DR ERIC UPON US
BY THE WAY NO RELATION TO MYSELF
IS A PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER OF
ALAMEDA COUNTY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON SB TWO SEVENTY SIX TO
KEEP OUR CHILDREN SAFE THANK YOU
THANK YOU DOCTOR PAN BEFORE WE
START THE YOUR TESTIMONY BY YOUR
WITNESSES WERE GOING TO WE HAVE
A QUORUM SO WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
ROLE.
AND SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
WHAT I HEAR?
MAYES [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BONTA BURKE.
CARILLO.
FLORA LIMON MCCARTY NAZARIAN
[inaudible]
RAMOS.
YES I'M SORRY -- ARAMBULA
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
WALDRON.
OKAY.
OKAY WE HAVE A QUORUM SO THIS
WILL BEGIN THE TEN TEN MINUTES
OF TESTIMONY [inaudible]
HI.
MY NAME IS JENNY BALK AND I'M A
MOTHER OF TWO WONDERFUL CHILDREN
DALY AGE TWELVE AND BROOKE AGE.
TEN AND I'M A FIFTH GRADE PUBLIC
SCHOOL TEACHER AND HAVE BEEN FOR
TWENTY YEARS NOW.
MY DAUGHTER BROOKE WAS BORN
TOTALLY HEALTHY.
ON EASTER I IN.
TWO THOUSAND NINE AND SIX WEEKS
LATER BEGAN TO FEEL ILL.
AND SHE HAD ACQUIRED A HEART
DISEASE FROM A RANDOM VIRUS.
AND SHE WAS DIAGNOSED WITH
DILATED CARDIOMYOPATHY WHICH
MEANT HER HEART WAS THREE TIMES
THE SIZE THAT IT SHOULD HAVE
BEEN.
IT WAS TOLD US AT THE TIME IT'S
A TERMINAL DIAGNOSIS.
AND THE ONLY HOPE WOULD BE A
HEART TRANSPLANT.
THE HEART TRANSPLANTS ONLY LAST
AND AND AVERAGE TEN TO TWELVE
YEARS SO WE WANTED TO WAIT AS
LONG AS POSSIBLE TO GET THAT
TIME LINE GOING.
WE WERE ABLE TO WAIT AT HOME WE
HAD A ROLLER COASTER AND OF TWO
YEARS IN AND OUT OF HOSPITALS
WITH A VERY WEAK LITTLE BABY AN
ACTIVE TODDLER.
AND AFTER TWO YEARS.
AND IT BECAME APPARENT THAT --
HER HEART WAS NOT GOING TO KEEP
HER ALIVE ANY LONGER.
SHE WAS LISTED FOR A HEART
TRANSPLANT WHEN SHE WAS TWO AND
A HALF YEARS OLD.
AND AFTER A THREE MONTH STAY AT
UCLA'S -- PEDIATRIC ICU SHE
RECEIVED THE GIFT OF LIFE.
FROM A LITTLE ANGEL NAMED
MALACHI LITTLE ONE AND A HALF
YEAR OLD BOY.
WHO SAVED HER LIFE?
HI MY LITTLE CRAZY WARRIOR WAS
WALKING THE HALLS OF THE
HOSPITAL WITHIN ON DAY TWO WITH
ONLY TYLENOL THROUGH HER SYSTEM
WHICH I GUESS ONLY KIDS DO.
AND WE CAME HOME ONE DAY.
EIGHT SO WE WANTED TO CELEBRATE
THE END OF THIS BIG JOURNEY BUT
IT REALLY WASN'T THE END IT WAS
THE BEGINNING OF A WHOLE NEW SET
OF ISSUES.
AND WE'VE NEVER BUBBLE WRAPPED
HER AND NEVER WOULD WANT TO SHE
LEAVES AND LET LEADS A VERY VERY
ACTIVE LIFESTYLE.
SHE'S PLAYED CLUB SOCCER SHE'S
CURRENTLY ON TO COMPETITIVE
DANCE TEAMS SNOW SCHEME -- PLACE
AT THE BEACH AND PRETTY MUCH
SPENCER LIFE PLAYING HER YOU
CLEARLY ON OUR FRONT PORCH AS
THAT'S HER LATEST PASSION.
I'M ONE OF BROOKS GREATEST JOYS
IS ATTENDING SCHOOL.
UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE HER LIFE
BEGAN WITH HEART DISEASE.
AND SUBSEQUENTLY AND HAS TO TAKE
IMMUNO SUPPRESSANTS DUE TO HER
HEART TRANSPLANT.
SHE WAS UNABLE TO RECEIVE THAT
AND PROTECTION OF LIVE VACCINES
LIKE HER OLDER BROTHER DEAD.
I'M FOR MEASLES CHICKEN POX AND
OTHER DISEASES.
WE CAN ON EVERYONE AROUND HER
BEING IMMUNIZED TO KEEP HER WELL
PROTECTED.
KIDS IN PUBLIC SCHOOL WHO HAVE
ACTUAL MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS.
THEM AND THEIR FAMILIES HAVE
BEEN TO THE DEPTHS OF HELL.
THOSE FAMILIES HAVE SEEN THEIR
CHILD ON THE BRINK OF DEATH.
IF THEY HAVE A DIAGNOSIS OF A
TRANSPLANT OR CANCER OR A RARE
DISEASE.
AND BEING IN PUBLIC EDUCATION
SHOWS THAT THEY HAVE MADE IT
THROUGH TO THE OTHER SIDE AND
CAN LIVE A SEMI NORMAL LIFESTYLE
EVEN IF IT'S A TEMPORARY STAY IN
SCHOOL.
THEY HAVE THE RIGHT TO EDUCATION
IN A SAFE ENVIRONMENT WITHOUT
FEAR OF A PREVENTABLE DISEASE
SENDING HIM BACK TO THE HOSPITAL
[inaudible]
OR WORSE.
AT MY TWENTY YEARS IN EDUCATION
HAS TAUGHT ME THAT PARENTS
EVERYWHERE JUST WANT WHAT'S BEST
FOR THEIR KIDS THAT'S ALL
ANYBODY WANT.
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT PEOPLE WHO
CHOOSE NOT TO VACCINATE THEIR
CHILDREN.
BELIEVE THAT THEY ARE DOING WHAT
IS RIGHT FOR THEIR CHILDREN.
BUT WHAT THEY FEEL IS RIGHT FOR
THEIR KIDS PUTS MY CHILD IN
MORTAL JEOPARDY EVERY DAY.
WE HAVE HAD WHIPPING COUGH IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD TWO WEEKS AGO.
MY DAUGHTER DOES COMPETITIVE
DANCE IT WAS A CAN ANOTHER DANCE
STUDIO IN OUR NEIGHBORHOOD.
IT IS.
PREVALENT WE ARE TWENTY MINUTES
FROM DOCTOR SEARS WHO DOCTOR
PATTEN AT MENTIONED.
IT IS EVERYWHERE IN OUR
COMMUNITY.
THE LAWS ALREADY IN PLACE TO
PROTECT THESE MEDICAL FRAGILE
ANGELS.
SO I ASK YOU SUPPORT SB TWO
SEVENTY SIX TO ENSURE THAT THAT
LAW.
IS RESPECTED.
AND TAKENAS SERIOUSLY AS ANY
OTHER LAW OUT THERE THAT IS.
CREATED TO PROTECT INNOCENT
CHILDREN THANK YOU. SIX WITH THE
NEXT WITNESS.
I'M NOT A GREAT I'M DOCTOR
MARGARET PARSONS A POSITION HERE
IN SACRAMENTO A DERMATOLOGIST
DOING MEDICAL DERMATOLOGY OF
PEDIATRIC IN OUT OF CASES.
BUT I'M ALSO HERE MORE
IMPORTANTLY AS A TRUSTEE OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF FORTY FOUR
THOUSAND POSITIONS.
WHEN I TOLD COLLEAGUES I'D BE
TESTIFYING HERE TODAY AND NOT
THE OFF THEY SAID PLEASE GO SURE
MAKE SURE PEOPLE KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT IS THIS TO PUBLIC
HEALTH?
SB TWO SEVEN SIX PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S OF ALL AGES
PARTICULAR CHILDREN WHO NEED US.
AS A MEDICAL STUDENT THE EARLY
NINETEEN NINETIES I THOUGHT
ASIAN CHILD FROM A NATION
OUTSIDE WHO IMMIGRATED HERE.
WHO HAD MEASLES LIKE WILDLIFE HE
HAD NOT BEEN VACCINATED HE'D HAD
NEUROLOGIC SYMPTOMS HE COULD NOT
WALK HE COULD NOT MOVE MY
FACULTY SAID?
WE'VE NEVER SEEN THIS MEASLES IS
A RADIC HATED IN THE UNITED
STATES.
WE'VE NEVER SEEN THIS BEFORE
WITHOUT VACCINATION WE WILL SEE
DISEASE AND DEATH.
SB TWO SEVEN SEVEN INCREASED
OVERALLS ALRIGHT BUT IT HASN'T
GOTTEN ALL THE WAY THERE WE HAVE
TOO MANY EXEMPTIONS MORE THAN A
HUNDRED CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS HAVE
MORE THAN 10% OF THE POPULATION
NOT VACCINATED.
AND SOME OF THE SCHOOLS ARE
HIGHS IN THE TWENTY AND 30% AND
UNVACCINATED CHILDREN.
A TWENTY EIGHTEEN STUDY
PUBLISHED BY THE JOURNAL
PEDIATRICS CONCLUDED LONG TERM
IMPACT OF SB TWO SEVEN WILL BE
LIMITED UNLESS WE ENACT POLICIES
SUCH AS DOCTOR PANTS.
TWO SEVEN SIX TURNOUT FURTHER
OVERSIGHT FOR MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS.
WHY IS MEASLES CONCERNING AND
SOME OF THE OTHER ONES THE RASH
MAY NOT SHOW UP FOR FOUR DAYS A
CHILD BE CONTAGIOUS FOR FOUR
DAYS BEFORE WE MIGHT EVEN SEE
THE RASH AND BEGUN SUSPICION
THAT THE CHILD MIGHT BE
CONTAGIOUS?
THEIR CONTAGIOUS FOR EIGHT DAYS.
THIS IS DANGEROUS TO CHILDREN
SUCH AS THE ONE WE JUST TALKED
ABOUT ANOTHER IMMUNO COMPROMISED
KIDS WHO HAVE CANCER LET ME KNOW
COMPROMISED STATES DUE TO
TRANSPLANT AND THERE'S A LOT OF
THESE KIDS DOING WONDERFUL
THINGS.
IN RECENT MONTHS WE'VE SEEN MORE
THAN A THOUSAND CASES IN THE
LAST FEW MONTHS WE ARE WORRIED
ABOUT MEASLES OF THE PUBLIC
HEALTH MAJOR.
THE BILL SB TWO SEVEN SIX ENSURE
THAT APPROPRIATE APPROPRIATE
EXEMPTIONS WILL BE THE ONLY
EXEMPTIONS WE NEED TO TO PROTECT
OUR KIDS IN OUR STATE.
PLEASE.
JOIN ME ON THE FORTY FOUR
THOUSAND PHYSICIAN MEMBERS OF
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
AND VOTE YES.
TODAY AND HELP THIS IMPORTANT
PUBLIC HEALTH MAJOR MOVE FORWARD
FOR CALIFORNIANS. THREE GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR ERICA.
I AM CURRENTLY THE INTERN HEALTH
OFFICER FOR ALAMEDA COUNTY AND
I'M HERE TODAY TESTIFYING ON
BEHALF OF THE HEALTH OFFICER'S
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA.
AND ALAMEDA COUNTY HAS JUST
JOINED THE LIST OF COUNTIES AS
WELL TO SUPPORT SB.
TWO SEVENTY SIX I AM ALSO A
PRACTICING INFECTIOUS DISEASE
SPECIALIST STILL SEEING PATIENTS
AND I'M A PARENT.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SHARE MY EXPERIENCE AS A
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIAL.
REALLY NOW MORE THAN EVER WE
NEED TO COME TOGETHER AS A BROAD
COMMUNITY TO PROTECT OUR MOST
VULNERABLE FROM VACCINE
PREVENTABLE DISEASES BY
MAINTAINING COMMUNITY IMMUNITY.
AS YOU'VE HEARD WE'VE ALREADY
HAD MORE CASES OF MEASLES IN
CALIFORNIA IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN TH AND IN ALL OF LAST
YEAR.
IN EUROPE IN THE FIRST TWO
MONTHS OF TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
THEY'VE HAD OVER THIRTY FOUR
THOUSAND CASES AND THIRTEEN
DEATHS.
IN A SENSE GO BAY AREA ALONE
THIS YEAR WE'VE HAD TWELVE CASES
THAT HAVE BEEN CONFIRMED AND
ACROSS THE STATE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY OPERATION CENTRES HAVE
BEEN ACTIVATED. TO COORDINATE
INVESTIGATION OF SUSPECT AND
CONFIRMED CASES AND EXPOSE
CONTACTS.
IN MY EXPERIENCE WE TYPICALLY
IDENTIFY ABOUT A HUNDRED
CONTACTS FOR EVERY SINGLE CASE.
IN ADDITION TO THE RISK OF BRAIN
INFECTION OR DEATH AND THE HIGH
PROPORTION OF HOSPITALIZATIONS
DUE TO MEASLES.
OUR PUBLIC HEALTH RESPONSE IS
SIGNIFICANT AND COSTLY.
WE ESTIMATE THE COST RANGE FROM
TEN TO THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER CASE.
DURING THE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
MEASLES OUTBREAK PUBLIC HEALTH
COSTS WERE ESTIMATED TO BE ONE
POINT FIVE TO THREE POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLARS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND MOST LIKELY IN UNDER
ESTIMATE.
WE KNOW IN SEE THAT THESE
OUTBREAKS STARTIN AND ARE DRIVEN
BY CLUSTERS OF UNVACCINATED
PERSONS.
THIS PUTS THOSE WERE VALID
MEDICAL REASONS LIKE BROOKE NOT
DEMONIZED.
WHO HAVE YOUNG AGE -- SUPPRESSED
IMMUNE SYSTEMS PUT THEM AT RISK
OF SEVERE DISEASE WHEN OTHERS
ARE NOT VACCINATED.
WELL THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
BOARD PLAYS AN IMPORTANT ROLE
YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD THE
SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS TO THEIR
APPROPRIATE INVESTIGATION.
PUBLIC HEALTH DOES NOT HAVE
CURRENT DATA ON WHERE INVALID
EXEMPTIONS HAVE BEEN GRANTED BUT
WE RECEIVE REPORTS FROM
CONCERNED AND FRUSTRATED SCHOOL
NURSES RECEIVING MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS PROVIDED.
BY ONLINE EVALUATIONS ANTI AGING
CLINICS HYPERBARIC MEDICINE
CLINICS DOCTORS ON PROBATION WHO
ARE MILES AND MILES AND MILES
AWAY. FOR HIGH FEES RATHER THAN
BY PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS.
CURRENTLY THERE IS NOTHING WE
CAN DO ABOUT THAT.
REQUIRING PUBLIC HEALTH REVIEW
OF CONCERNING MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS
ESPECIALLY IN COMMUNITIES WITH
LOW VACCINATION RATES WILL
PREVENT THIS INAPPROPRIATE
PRACTICE.
I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT SB TWO
SEVENTY SIX WHICH WILL GIVE
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS THE
TOOLS NECESSARY TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S MOST VULNERABLE
THANK YOU.
MY MY APOLOGIES THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY --
BEFORE WE HEAR ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT WE DO HAVE I'M SORRY
NEVER MIND WE WILL HEAR OUR
DIGITAL SUPPORT.
COMING OUT OF COLLEGE EYES.
SO OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE.
COME FORWARD.
SO PLEASE AS YOU COME FORWARD
WE'RE JUST ASKING YOU TO STATE
YOUR NAME.
ORGANIZATION YOU REMAIN -- YOU
REPRESENT AND YOUR POSITION ON
THE BILL NO FURTHER TESTIMONY
JUST THAT PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS DOCTOR
SONYA CON K. H. A. M..
ON A BOARD CERTIFIED
PEDIATRICIAN PEDIATRIC ICU
TRAUMA PHYSICIAN FELLOW OF THE
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS.
DIRECTOR OF PEDIATRIC CRISIS
SOLUTIONS CONSULTING MEDICAL
DIRECTOR OF THE YOUTH CITY
PROGRAM FOR FREMONT CALIFORNIA I%
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING I'M LEAH RUSSIN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR VACCINATE
CALIFORNIA PARENT ADVOCACY GROUP
SPONSORING THE BILL THE
THOUSANDS OF PARENTS OF ACNE
CALIFORNIA URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
SB TWO SEVEN SIX THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
HI I AM A FREE ADMITTED I AM THE
DAUGHTER OF THAT PEDIATRICIAN
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ERIN HOLSINGER AND
I'M A BOARD CERTIFIED
PEDIATRICIAN AND I SUPPORT SB
TWO SEVEN SIX THANK YOU.
HELLO ON DR LINCOLN RUSYN.
I LIVE IN SANTA CRUZ. FOR THE
BENEFIT OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH AND
FOR MY GRANDSON PLEASE VOTE IN
FAVOR OF SB TWO SEVENTY SIX
THANK YOU.
SO JUST YOUR NAME.
HELLO AND DOCTOR ELIZABETH
COPELAND CHAIR OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF GENERAL PEDIATRICS AT PALO
ALTO MEDICAL FOUNDATION I URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS LINDA JUDAH AND I
URGE YOU TO VOTE YES ON SB TWO
SEVEN SIX THANK YOU.
SURE MEMBERS RAND MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION A VERY STRONG
SUPPORTER THIS BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MARIA SPERBER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
KATHERINE FLORES MAARTEN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA IMMUNIZATION
COALITION IN SUPPORT.
MATT ROBINSON ON BEHALF OF
KAISER PERMANENTE IN SUPPORT.
THE MATTER A UC DAVIS MEDICAL
STUDENT IN STRONG SUPPORT.
JESSICA RIVERA MOTHER OF TWO
MICRO BIOLOGIST AND SCIENCE
WRITER I ASK YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
DON PETERSON I'M A PARENT FROM
WEST SACRAMENTO PLEASE VOTE YES
ON SB TWO SEVEN SIX THANK YOU.
ADAM KADMON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KAREN'S AN AUTO I'M A VOLUNTEER
WITH FACTS NAY CALIFORNIA AND A
CONSTITUENT OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY.
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CATHY HALL WITH
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PTA IN
SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS LISA MANASSAS I'M A
PEDIATRICIAN A MOTHER OF THREE
AND I URGE I ASK YOU TO PLEASE
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MICHAEL PRESS OUR MEDICAL CITY
SEE DAVIS MEDICAL SCHOOL AND A
PARENT PLEASE SUPPORT.
EMAIL FAIRY PARENTS WEST
SACRAMENTO RESIDENT CONSTITUENTS
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY.
AND PARENT VOLUNTEER VACCINATE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR GALLON KING
FROM LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA
PLEASE SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JACKIE
ONE PART AN APPLICATION PURPOSES
ON THE PRESIDENT OF WASHINGTON
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND I'M
IN MY OWN OPINION I'M ALSO AN
INSTRUCTOR AT SEXTAPE FIRST THE
SCHOOL NURSING PROGRAM.
AND I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
I'M JOHN FRASER A MEDICAL
STUDENT FROM UC DAVIS -- SCHOOL
OF MEDICINE AND I SUPPORT SB.
TWO SEVENTY SIX KOBE PRESIDING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIANS IN SUPPORT ALSO ON
BEHALF OF MYSELF AS WASHINGTON
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT BOARD
VICE PRESIDENT AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS KAREN CHUNG A STUDENT
FROM UC DAVIS SCHOOL OF MEDICINE
AND STRONG SUPPORT OF SB TWO
SEVENTY SIX THANK YOU.
I AREA LOOP REGISTERED NURSE
FROM PASSED THE IN CALIFORNIA
AND I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL SO MORE CHILDREN DON'T GET
MEASLES LIKE MY INFANT.
JUST YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION
POSITION PLEASE. THREE PRICE
PROFESSOR OF LAW AT UC HASTINGS
AND MOTHER OF TWO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. TWENTY PETERSON SANTA
ROSA CALIFORNIA I AM IN SUPPORT
OF SB. TWO SEVENTY SIX I HAVE
FORTY SIX YEARS EXPERIENCE IN
THE NEONATAL INTENSIVE CARE UNIT.
JUST YOUR NAME AND POSITION
PLEASE.
ALLEN STELLAR IN OUR IN FROM RED
BLUFF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
KAREN CROMER REGISTERED NURSE I
AM IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ERIN HERMAN FAMILY NURSE
PRACTITIONER FROM OAKLAND AND
MOTHER OF TWO AND A WELDER
SCHOOL IN BERKELEY AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB.
TWO SEVENTY TWO SHARON CHANDLER
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF YES TO
COLLEGE EDUCATIONAL RESOURCES
THANK AND WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS HANNAH HENRY MOTHER
OF FOUR FROM NAPA CALIFORNIA I
AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB TWO
SEVEN SIX THANK YOU.
I'M TONY CALLING THEM A
CONSULTING FOR YES THE COLLEGE.
AS A GRANDMOTHER I'M VERY MUCH
IN SUPPORT OF THE SPELL THANK
YOU HELLO THE A DAHLE AND
REGISTERED NURSE BACKGROUND IN
BONE MARROW TRANSPLANT IN
NEONATAL INTENSIVE CARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HELLO LARA ONLYROOM CALIFORNIA
CREDENTIALS SCHOOL NURSE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SO MY AND A HIGHER ON BEHALF OF
THE CHILDREN SPECIAL TO CARE
COALITION AND MARCH OF DIMES
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
LAURIE JOHNSON FAMILY NURSE
PRACTITIONER HUGE SUPPORTER OF
THIS BILL.
HI JOHN V. META CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
DR ED NO PRE TELL FROM BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
RICKY ADAMANT IMMUNE COMPROMISED
PATIENT PARENT AN EDUCATOR IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
DOCTOR DEBORAH DAUMAN AND THE
MOTHER OF THREE AND I AM THE
CHIEF MEDICAL OFFICER OF CENTER
IS A COMMUNITY HEALTH IN SUPPORT.
CATHERINE PAUL FROM OAKLAND.
PARENTING VOLUNTEER UP WITH
VACCINATE CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB TWO SEVEN
SIX THANK YOU.
DOCTOR WAS SOFTER AND A FAMILY
PHYSICIAN AND A MOTHER OF TWO
YOUNG CHILDREN PLEASE SUPPORT.
MICHELLE GIVENS THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION A
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS IN SHOCK
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU BRIAN FIRST ASKEY
PEDIATRICIAN FROM SANTA ROSA
CALIFORNIA WORKING FOR SUTTER
MEDICAL GROUP OF THE REDWOODS
HERE ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
CINEMA COUNTY MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION STRONGLY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. FOR ME DATING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CINDY SHER WOOD FROM LOS ALRP
ALTOS -- PARENT VOLUNTEER WITH
FAST VACCINATE CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
KATHY BURKE HEALTH OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT.
SUZANNE I SURE WOULD FROM ORANGE
COUNTY -- BIOCHEMISTRY STUDENT
STRONG SUPPORT.
MAYOR MARTIN THE CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GETTING AMADOR CORRECT
CREDENTIALS CORNERS AND PROGRAM
SPECIALIST FOR HEALTH SERVICES
SAN JUAN UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN SACRAMENTO STRONG SUPPORT.
GABRIELLE ESPINOZA SACRAMENTO
COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
ELLIE POTTER CREDENTIALS SCHOOL
NURSES -- ONE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN STRONG SUPPORT.
VIDEO ONE REPRESENTING AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA
DIVISION WE ALSO CO AUTHORS OF
THE BILL'S.
CO SPONSORS OF THE BILL AS WELL
AS THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL NURSES
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
HI I'M DOCTOR MONICA US NINETY
FROM LOS ANGELES I'VE BEEN A
PEDIATRICIAN FOR TWENTY YEARS
I'M A MEMBER OF THE PEDIATRIC
DEPARTMENT AT CEDARS SINAI
MEDICAL CENTER.
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
CAN SEE NO -- ONE THE NEXT
WITNESS IS WE WILL HEAR ACTUALLY
WE HAVE TWO WITNESSES THAT WERE
CALLED WINNERS.
IN BETWEEN IN BETWEEN SO WE'LL
ASK THOSE TWO WITNESSES TO COME
FORWARD -- LACEY SCOTT.
AND JENNIFER SOME OF US.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
HELLO I'M JENNIFER SOMOS WITH
THE MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA.
THE BOARD HAS A SUPPORT IN
CONCEPT POSITION ON THIS BILL
THE BOARD SUPPORTS THE CONCEPTS
AN SP TWO SEVENTY SIX THAT ALLOW
THE BOARD TO RECEIVE THE MEDICAL
RECORDS.
RELATED TO MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS
AND REQUIRE REVIEW OF MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS ALLOWING THE BOARD TO
RECEIVE THE MEDICAL RECORDS OF
MEADOW OAK MEDICAL EXEMPTION
CASES WILL REMOVE THE OBSTACLES
OF WARS CURRENTLY FACING.
AND ALLOW THE BOARDS EXPERTS TO
REVIEW THE MEDICAL RECORDS AND
PINE IF THE POSITION FALL THE
STANDARD OF CARE.
DURING THE DISCUSSION ON SB TWO
SEVENTY SIX OF THE BOARD'S
INTERMEDIUM.
NUMEROUS FOR MEMBERS RAISED
ISSUES REGARDING THE CDC
GUIDELINES BEING TOO NARROW AND
THE APPROPRIATE INTO TO TO HAVE
OVERSIGHT OF THE REVIEW OF
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS.
WITH THE RECENT AMENDMENTS
APPEARS THAT ONE OF THESE ISSUES
HUSBAND SPECIFICALLY ADDRESSED
THE BOARD WILL BE REVIEWING THE
AMENDMENTS AND POSSIBLY TAKING A
NEW POSITION ON THIS BILL AT ITS
NEXT MEETING IN AUGUST THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THIS.
THANK YOU MEMBERS MY NAME IS
LACI SCOTTON I'D LIKE TO ENTER
MY SUPPORT.
ONLY F. SB TWO SEVEN SIX IS
PROPERLY AMENDED TO ALLOW THE
DOCTOR TO DECIDE WHAT IS BEST
FOR THEIR PATIENT BASED UPON.
THEIR PERSONAL AND FAMILY
MEDICAL HISTORY.
FIRST I I'D LIKE IT TO BE KNOWN
THAT I AM NOT AGAINST VACCINES.
I HAVE A PRIMARY IMMUNE
DEFICIENCY WHICH MEANS I AM
IMMUNE COMPROMISED AND I'M IN
NEED OF HER COMMUNITY.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS BILL HAS BEEN
PRESENTED AS AN ANTI VACCINE
FIRST PRO VACCINE DEBATE WHEN
WHAT THIS BILL ACTUALLY DOES IS
TAKE AWAY A DOCTOR'S RIGHT TO
DECIDE WHAT IS BEST FOR THEIR
PATIENTS UNIQUE MEDICAL
SITUATION AND PUTS IT IN THE
HANDS OF A GOVERNMENT APPOINTED
OFFICIAL WHO HAS NEVER.
MET OR EXAMINES THE CHILD IN
QUESTION.
AFTER THIRTY FIVE YEARS OF LIFE
FILLED WITH MYSTERY ILLNESS I
WAS FINALLY DIAGNOSED WITH
PRIMARY IMMUNE DEFICIENCY ALONG
WITH AUTOIMMUNE DISORDERS.
AND HAVE EXPERIENCED MULTIPLE
SEVERE VACCINE REACTIONS ALONG
THE WAY.
THESE IMMUNE DISORDERS AREN'T AS
EASY TO DIAGNOSIS SENATOR PAN
HAS SUGGESTED IN PREVIOUS
HEARINGS.
AND THEY ARE NOT COVERED BY THE
NEARLY DEFINED LIST OF CONTRA
INDICATIONS THAT ARE THE
CORNERSTONE OF THIS FILM.
I HAVE FIVE YEAR OLD TWINS WHO
HAVE HAD. TO HAVE A HIGH
LIKELIHOOD OF INHERITING SOME OR
ALL OF MY IMMUNE DISORDERS.
THEY HAVE ALSO HAD SEVERE.
VACCINE REACTIONS THAT MIMICKED
THE REACTIONS I'VE EXPERIENCED.
WE HAVE CONSULTED HIGHLY TRAINED
CLINICAL IMMUNOLOGISTS
RHEUMATOLOGIST AND PEDIATRICIANS
INNER CONSENSUS AS THAT IT WOULD
BE TOO RISKY TO KEEP VACCINATING
MY CHILDREN.
DUE TO THE LIKELIHOOD OF SEVERE
VACCINE REACTIONS.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE A VALID
VACCINE EXEMPTIONS THAT ARE NOT
FRAUDULENT.
OUR UNIQUE MEDICAL SCENARIO DOES
NOT FIT WITHIN THE NARROW
DEFINED LIST OF CONTRIBUTIONS
[inaudible]
IT IS.
IT IS NOT LEGAL TO DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST THE LESS THAN 1% OF
CHILDREN WITH LEGITIMATE VACCINE
EXEMPTIONS AND THE RIGHT TO AN
EDUCATION DUE TO FAMILY HISTORY
OR A MEDICAL DISORDER THAT IS
OUT OF THEIR CONTROL.
FAMILIES WITH IMMUNE DISORDERS
OR THOSE WHO HAVE SUFFERED FROM
VACCINE REACTION REACTIONS.
SHOULD NOT BE DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST IMAGINE WHAT MY
CHILDREN'S EDUCATION WOULD LOOK
LIKE IF I WAS FORCED TO HOME
SCHOOL.
THEM BETWEEN DOCTOR VISITS
HOSPITAL STAYS MEDICAL
PROCEDURES AND ILLNESSES.
LASTLY IT APPEARS THAT THE
CURRENT AMENDMENTS MADE PROVIDE
PROTECTION FOR FAMILIES LIKE MY
OWN BY CONSIDERING FAMILY
MEDICAL HISTORY.
HOWEVER I REMAIN CONCERNED. FOR
INSTANCE DOCTORS WRITING
LEGITIMATE.
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS CAN BE
UNFAIRLY TARGETED AND PUNISHED
BY THE FIVE OR MORE EXEMPTION
RULE FORCING ALL DOCTORS.
ALL OF THE DOCTORS VACCINE
EXEMPTIONS TO BE REVIEWED
IMAGINE FOR A MOMENT WHAT
OFFICES THAT SPECIALIZE IN THE
TREATMENT OF CHILDREN WITH
CANCER AND OTHER IMMUNE
DISORDERS WILL BE PUT THROUGH.
NOT TO MENTION THE STRICT
PENALTY OF NO LESS THAN A TWO
YEAR BAN ON WRITING ANY MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS IF A GOVERNMENT
OFFICIAL TAKES ISSUE WITH JUST
ONE OF THOSE EXEMPTIONS.
HE EVEN AYE LEGITIMATE DOCTORS
WILL NOT BE.
COMPELLED TO WRITE A FIFTH
EXEMPTION.
BECAUSE OF THE MAGNITUDE OF
RECENT AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE MEMBERS
TO HOLD THE BILL IN HEALTH
COMMITTEE UNTIL.
THE DETAILS -- MORE FULLY VETTED.
THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH.
MISTER CHAIR YES -- I FISHY IS A
CHAIR OF CANADIAN HEALTH AND THE
OTHER HOUSE -- THAT YOU OF
COURSE -- I RESPECT YOUR
DECISIONS -- I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY -- MAKE NOTE THAT
THAT SOUNDS TO ME LIKE
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY SHOULD BE
TAKEN FROM TIME FOR THE
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE THAT MISS DOCTOR PAN --
WAS BUT RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE
[inaudible]
PLEASE NO [inaudible]
PLEASE.
THIS POINT TO OUR LAST FOR THE
OPPOSITION TO COME FORWARD.
SO YEAH PLEASE DON'T WANT
.
OKAY WE HAVE LOOKS LIKE. SIX
WITNESSES ARE THERE MORE. EIGHT
WITNESSES YOUHAVE A TOTAL OF
TEN MINUTES HOWEVER YOU WANT TO
DIVVY IT UP WE WILL LET YOU KNOW
WHERE YOU ARE IN THE PROCESS
OKAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
STEPHANIE FETZER AND THE FOUNDER
OF A GRASSROOTS ORGANIZATION
CALLED PARENTS UNITED FOR KIDS
WE HAVE TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
MEMBERS IN CALIFORNIA.
WHO ARE VERY INTERESTED IN THIS
BILL AND THIS ISSUE?
I'VE SPOKEN WITH MOST MANY OF
YOU.
MEMBERS ON THE COMMITTEE AND I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
AND YOUR CONSIDERATION.
RESPECTFULLY THERE'S A LOT OF
MISINFORMATION.
ABOUT WHAT THIS BILL DOES AND
DOES NOT DO.
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION TODAY AND REALLY
AS WE SHARE WHAT'S REALLY GOING
ON WITH THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
POSITIONS RIGHTS MY NAME IS LEE
DUNDAS.
THIS LAW.
IS UNPRECEDENTED.
IT TAKES THE STATE GOVERNMENT
AND PUTS IT SQUARELY INTO THE
CENTER OF THE DOCTOR PATIENT
RELATIONSHIP AND IT GOES ONE
STEP FURTHER.
IT GIVES A STATE ACTOR THE RIGHT
TO BAN BLOCK COUNTERMANDED DENY
AND REVOKE.
YOUR LICENSED AND MY LICENSE
MEDICAL DOCTORS MEDICAL
DECISIONS THIS IS UNPRECEDENTED
TERRITORY EVEN AS AMENDED THAT
THAT IS WHAT'S DONE HERE.
THE ISSUE FROM MY PERSPECTIVE IN
MANY OF OUR PERSPECTIVES IS NOT
IF THE STATE GETS IT WRONG.
IT'S WHEN THE STATE GETS IT
WRONG.
BECAUSE ANY OF US EVEN A GOOD
PHYSICIAN WOULD BE HARD PRESSED
TO SIT IN FRONT OF A STACK OF
THOUSANDS OF PIECES OF PAPER
SINGLE SHEETS OF PAPER MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS.
AND WITHOUT EVER HAVING LAID
EYES ON THE PATIENT WITHOUT EVER
HAVING DONE A PHYSICAL EXAM OR
TEST ON THE PATIENT.
GET THAT ANALYSIS RIGHT.
I DON'T THINK THE PERSON ABOVE
COULD GET IT RIGHT IF YOU WERE
HERE AND I CERTAINLY DON'T THINK
I COULD OR ANY STATE ACTOR COULD.
AND WHEN NOT GO SIDE WAYS AND IT
WILL.
AND THEY MAKE A BAD DECISION AND
A LEGITIMATE A LEGITIMATE.
VALID MEDICAL EXEMPTION IS
REVOKED AND THE CHILD WANTS TO
STAY IN SCHOOL AND GETS
VACCINATED AND THAT CHILD DIES.
WHAT HAPPENS THEN THAT IS THE
QUESTION AND UNDER TWO SEVENTY
SIX UNDER SB TWO SEVENTY SIX THE
ANSWER IS NO ONE IS ACCOUNTABLE
BECAUSE STATE ACTORS HAVE
ABSOLUTE?
GOVERNMENTAL IMMUNITY.
THAT IS A FRIGHTENING IS ZERO
LIABILITY SITUATION WE HAVE AND
RUN AND COMPLETELY TOSSED OUT
EVERY SINGLE SYSTEM A CHECKS AND
BALANCES THAT KEEP ACTUAL
PRACTICING DOCTORS IN THE RIGHT
LANE.
MEDICAL MALPRACTICE CARRIER
STATE BOARD REVOCATION OF
LICENSES CIVIL ATTORNEYS AND
PROSECUTORS WHO KEEP THEIR IN
THE LIGHT WE HAVE AND RUN THAT
SYSTEM.
THE STATE CANNOT PRACTICE
MEDICINE IF YOU GO RIGHT NOW TO
THE MEDICAL BOARD WEBSITE AND
YOU TYPE IN FREQUENTLY ASKED
QUESTIONS.
CORPORATE PRACTICE OF MEDICINE
GOVERNMENTAL ENTITIES ARTIFICIAL
ENTITIES.
STATES ARE NOT ALLOWED TO
PRACTICE MEDICINE BECAUSE WHEN
THEY CAN IS A RUN AWAY FREIGHT
TRAIN AND THERE ARE NO CHECKS
AND BALANCES ON THAT SYSTEM AND
THAT IS TERRITORY NO MATTER WHAT
THE PROBLEM IS WE'RE TRYING TO
SOLVE HERE TODAY.
THAT WE CANNOT AFFORD TO BE IN
THE MIDDLE OF NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM WOULD WANT TO BE DIAGNOSED
WITH DIABETES OR THEIR MOTHER
DIAGNOSE FOR TRIPLE NEGATIVE
BREAST CANCER AND FIND OUT TWO
WEEKS LATER FROM A STATE ACTOR
AFTER THEIR NAME IN THE DOCTOR'S
NAME HAD BEEN DATA BASED.
THAT THEY WERE CANCELLING THE
INSULIN PRESCRIPTION OR
WITHHOLDING CANCER TREATMENT
ONCE WE GO DOWN THIS ROAD IT IS
A SLIPPERY SLOPE IT'S A ONE WAY
STREET AND THERE'S NO COMING
BACK.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO
ABSTAIN OR VOTE NO AND FIGURE
OUT A BETTER WAY TO SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KEN
MAC ROSENBERG AND I'M AN
ATTORNEY WITH OVER TWENTY YEARS
EXPERIENCE IN PRODUCTS LIABILITY
IN INSURANCE COVERAGE LITIGATION.
SB TWO SEVEN SIX EVEN AS AMENDED
IS ABOUT COERCION LACK OF DUE
PROCESS AND INTIMIDATION AS WELL
AS INVASION OF THE DOCTOR
PATIENT RELATIONSHIP.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS LONG
BEEN A CHAMPION OF PRIVACY AND
INDIVIDUAL RIGHTS THROUGH LAWS
LIKE THE CALIFORNIA CONSUMER
PRIVACY ACT.
BUT THROUGH SB TWO SEVEN SIX
WOULD VIOLATE SEVERAL PRIVACY
RIGHTS AND PROTECTIONS IT'S
POISED TO BE THE PARTY OF
SURVEILLANCE OVER PEOPLE.
WAIVERS ABOUT VOLUNTARY
RELINQUISHMENT OF A RIGHT BUT
THERE IS NOTHING VOLUNTARY ABOUT
THIS PROCESS. TO REQUEST AN EMMY
A PARENT MUST FIRST AGREE TO
RELEASE HER CHILD'S MEDICAL
FILES TO BOTH THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH AND TO THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL BOARD.
THIS IS AN AFFRONT TO HIPAA THE
FEDERAL LAW THAT PROTECTS
MEDICAL INFORMATION AND IT AND
RUN AROUND FOR BUG WHICH
PREVENTS SCHOOLS FROM RELEASING
STUDENTS PRIVATE INFORMATION.
SB TWO SEVEN SIX REQUIRES THAT
ALL ENEMIES BE SUBMITTED TO THE
CALIFORNIA IMMUNIZATION REGISTRY
CARE WITH NO CHANCE TO OPT OUT.
DESPITE THE OPT OUT OPTION
AVAILABLE TO EVERYONE ELSE.
THERE IS NO VALID REASON FOR
THESE PRIVACY VIOLATIONS VACCINE
EXEMPTIONS HAVE ALWAYS BEEN
WITHIN THE PURVIEW OF SCHOOLS
AND THERE'S NO HISTORY OF
PROBLEMS IN SCHOOLS DURING
OUTBREAKS WITH MONITORING THAT
INFORMATION.
SB TWO SEVEN SIX ALSO VIOLATES
DUE PROCESS WITH POTENTIALLY
CATASTROPHIC RESULTS.
FIRST APPEALING IN ANY DOES NOT
PROTECT THE CHILD SB TWO SEVEN
SIX REQUIRES THAT A CHILD WHOSE
DOCTOR HAS DETERMINED.
UPON EXAMINATION OF THAT CHILD
THE VACCINATION.
MAY RESULT IN INJURY OR DEATH TO
THAT CHILD THAT THE CHILD BE
VACCINATED DURING THE PENDENCY
OF THEIR APPEAL.
SECOND THERE'S NO UNBIASED
REVIEW AN APPEAL PROCESS THE
ONLY PEOPLE REVIEWING EMMYS AN
APPEALS OF DENIALS ARE OTHER
STATE EMPLOYEES ARE THOSE WERE.
APPOINTED BY THE SECRETARY OF
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AND
THE SECRETARY HAS THE FINAL WORD.
CHILDREN WILL HAVE THEIR MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS DENIED OR REVOKED THE
BE DEPRIVED OF THE FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHT TO ATTEND SCHOOL AND HAVE
NO ABILITY TO GO TO COURT TO
APPEAL THE SECRETARY'S DENIAL OF
THEIR MEDICAL EXEMPTION.
WITH RESPECT TO SB TWO SEVENTY
SIX REQUIREMENT THE D. O. H.
REVIEW REPORTS FROM SCHOOL TO
IDENTIFY SCHOOLS WITH THE LOWER
THAN 95% VACCINATION RATE THIS
IS REGARDLESS OF THE MEDICAL
EXEMPTION RATE IN THOSE SCHOOLS.
THAT RATE IS LESS THAN 1% STATE
WIDE IT CREATES AN UNNECESSARY
FINANCIAL AND TIME BURDEN ON
BOTH THE STATE AND THE SCHOOLS.
AND IT DOESN'T ADDRESS THE REAL
REASONS THAT SOME SCHOOLS ARE
BELOW THAT 95% RATE.
APPROXIMATELY 20% OF SCHOOLS ARE
CLASSIFIED AS NOT UP TO DATE OR
BANAL BELOW 95%.
BUT 92% OF THOSE SCHOOLS HAVE
FEWER THAN FOUR MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS IN THEIR SCHOOLS AND
MORE THAN HALF HAVE.
ZERO MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS.
SO WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THOSE NOT
UP TO DATE SCHOOLS.
THOSE NUMBERS ARE LOWER BECAUSE
A CONDITIONAL ENTRANCE AN
OVERDUE STUDENTS STUDENTS HAVE
NOTHING TO DO WITH MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS.
AND WHAT ABOUT INVESTIGATING
DOCTORS WHO WRITE MORE THAN FIVE
EMMYS PER YEAR.
THIS ARBITRARY NUMBER APPEARS TO
ARISE FROM.
A BASELESS ASSUMPTION THE
DOCTORS WHO WRITE ENEMIES ARE
ENGAGING IN UNPROFESSIONAL OR
FRAUDULENT CONDUCT.
IT FAILS TO ACCOUNT FOR
PEDIATRIC SPECIALISTS WHO TREAT
VULNERABLE CHILDREN AND IT FAILS
TO ACCOUNT FOR DIFFERENT
PRACTICE SIZES. FOR EXAMPLE YOUR
CEILING IS FIVE REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER THERE ARE TWO HUNDRED
CHILDREN IN YOUR PRACTICE OR TWO
THOUSAND OR TEN THOUSAND DOCTORS
MAY BE FORCED TO PICK PATIENTS
AGAINST EACH OTHER IN WEIGHING.
WHO SHOULD RECEIVE ONE OF THESE
FEW COVETED EXEMPTIONS IN ORDER
TO PROTECT THEIR PRACTICES?
AND NOT WITHSTANDING CLAIMS AN
UNSCRUPULOUS PHYSICIANS ARE
SELLING EXEMPTIONS DESPITE
DOZENS OF COMPLAINTS THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL BOARD HAS NOT
DISCIPLINED A SINGLE.
POSITION FOR WRITING AN
EXEMPTION PURSUANT TO SB.
TWO SEVEN SEVEN IN FACT IT'S
BEEN DEMONSTRATED IN EARLIER
TESTIMONY THAT THE BOARD HAS
AVAILABLE TO IT MEANS TO OBTAIN
MEDICAL RECORDS IF THEY FEEL
THEY NEED TO DO THAT.
MANY OF THE POSITIONS THAT SB
TWO SEVEN SIX SEEKS TO
INTIMIDATE AND CENTER ARE
ACTUALLY AHEAD OF THE AVERAGE
PHYSICIAN IN THEIR UNDERSTANDING
OF VACCINE ENTRY EPIGENETICS
GENETIC SUSCEPTIBILITY IN
AUTOIMMUNITY.
THEY KEEP UP ON EMERGING SCIENCE
AD THEY MAKE PAPER PATIENT
CENTERED DECISIONS.
BASED ON PRECISION MEDICINE IT
WOULD BE A DISSERVICE TO THIS
STATE TO ITS POSITIONS AND ITS
CITIZENS. TO CENTER AND
INTIMIDATE THOSE POSITIONS FOR
PRACTICING MEDICINE ACCORDING TO
MOST UP TO DATE SCIENCE IF FLIES
IN THE FACE OF THE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONAL CODE WHICH
RECOGNIZES THE IMPORTANCE OF
PROTECTING DOCTORS IN THE
FOREFRONT OF MEDICINE.
AND IT REPRESENTS A HUGE STEP
BACKWARDS FROM PRECISION PATIENT
CENTERED MEDICINE I URGE YOU
TRIPS STAIN OR VOTE NO ON SB.
TWO SEVEN SIX BUT YOU KNOW THAT
YOUR EIGHT EIGHT MINUTES AND
TWENTY FIVE SECONDS OF YOUR TEN
MINUTES.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR BOB SEARS I'M
A PEDIATRICIAN TRAINED AT
GEORGETOWN UNIVERSITY AND
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL LOS ANGELES.
THIS BILL WILL SCARE DOCTORS
AWAY FROM WRITING MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS FOR CHILDREN WHO NEED
THEM.
DOCTORS ARE AFRAID OF LOSING
THEIR PRACTICE AND THEIR
LIVELIHOOD OVER A MEDICAL BOARD
INVESTIGATION.
HERE IS WHY EVEN IF A DOCTOR
WINS THEIR CASE BEFORE THE
MEDICAL BOARD JUDGE AND THE
JUDGE DECIDES THE DOCTOR WAS
RIGHT.
THE MEDICAL BOARD CAN STILL PUT
THE DOCTOR ON PROBATION.
IT'S BASICALLY STOP AND FRISK
YOU ARE PRESUMED GUILTY IN MY
CASE THERE'S A LOT OF
MISINFORMATION ABOUT WHY I AM ON
PROBATION IT IS NOT BECAUSE OF A
SCHOOL VACCINE MEDICAL EXEMPTION.
WAS A BITTER CUSTODY DISPUTE
OVER AN INFANT WHO SUFFERED
SEVERE NEUROLOGICAL HARM THE
TODD WANTED TO FORCE MORE
VACCINES.
I WROTE A CORD OPINION LETTER
AND THE JUDGE AGREED WITH ME THE
JOB REPORTED NEW THE MEDICAL
BOARD. ONE DANGER OF THIS BILL
IS WHAT HAPPENS TO DOCTORS WHO
GO ON PROBATION I KNOW I'VE TO
PAY ABOUT TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR IN PROBATION FEES.
EVEN THOUGH I'VE NEVER HAD A
SINGLE MALPRACTICE CASE MY
MALPRACTICE INSURANCE HAS
DOUBLED BECAUSE OF PROBATION.
I LOST MY INSURANCE CONTRACTS
INCLUDING THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILITARY FAMILIES I WAS TAKING
CARE OF FOR MANY YEARS THAT'S
WHAT HAPPENS ON PROBATION WHAT
DOCTORS GOING TO SIGN UP FOR
THIS SOON NO ONE WILL BE LEFT TO
TO SERVE THIS MINORITY.
WHO SUFFER CAESAR'S NERVE
INJURIES ARE A LOT NEUROLOGICAL
REACTIONS YOU HAVE BEEN TOLD
THESE AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN
BROADENED -- THE EXEMPTION
GUIDELINES AND THEY'VE ADDED
FAMILY HISTORY THAT IS NOT TRUE.
THERE ARE NO REAL FAMILIES TO
GUIDELINES THAT ARE PRACTICAL
THAT ARE EXEMPT ANYBODY.
AND EVEN WORSE THIS BILL
PRESSURES DOCTORS INTO GIVING
MORE VACCINES TO A CHILD YOU MAY
KNOW MIGHT HAVE A SEVERE
REACTION AND THAT'S A TRAGEDY.
THE MINUTES TESTIMONY PERIOD IS
UP [inaudible]
YEAH.
KNOWLEDGE OF SELF DEFENSE IN
OPPOSITION.
I'M DOCTOR SHARE MILLER THE
PRESIDENT OF PHYSICIANS FOR
INFORMED CONSENT IN OPPOSITION.
AB MEN SMITH IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WE WILL [inaudible]
ON REFLECTION.
I'M GONNA GIVE DOCTOR PAN AN
EXTRA MINUTE OR TWO BECAUSE I DO
A REFLECTION DO AGREE THAT SOME
OF THE TESTIMONY THAT WE HEARD
FROM.
SOMEONE I THOUGHT WAS IN BETWEEN
DID FEEL MORE LIKE OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY.
AND SO I'M GONNA GIVE YOU AN
EXTRA MINUTE OR TWO A TEAR YOUR
LONG MY WITH THIS IS THE GIVEN
EXTRA MINUTES WE CAN DO THAT
THROUGH YOU OR YOUR WITNESSES
OKAY -- OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE NOT
PREPARED FOR THIS BUT I I YOU
KNOW I I CAN -- I I WOULD.
YOU KNOW WHAT I WILL -- ADDRESS
MANY ISSUES IN WHICH THE CURRENT
FLOWS AND I I APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION. TO SHARE I KNOW
IT'S DIFFICULT -- THERE AND
APPRECIATE YOUR RECOGNITION OF
THE CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE SO --
BUT I SO LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING
THE TESTIMONY FROM THE AYE
ENSIGN ASKED THAT WE CLEAR THE
TABLE AND DOES BEGIN THAT
SECTION THANK YOU BUT THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU.
SO ALASKA.
AS GOAL.
TO HAVE A SEAT OUT THERE AS WE
SEE THE REST OF THE REST OF THE
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION SO.
SO AT THIS POINT -- WE WILL HEAR.
FROM PEOPLE WHO ARE IN
OPPOSITION AND ONCE AGAIN AS I
DID WITH THE WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT.
LIKE YOUR NAME.
AN ORGANIZATION THAT YOU MIGHT
REPRESENT AND YOUR POSITION ON
THE BILL ONLY WILL ASK THAT ONLY
THE ADULTS TESTIFIED PLEASE.
SHOULD YOU DECIDE TO GO BEYOND
WHAT I'M ASKING FOR TESTIMONY I
WILL CUT YOUR MICROPHONE OFF --
TO BE FAIR TO EVERYBODY SO
THAT'S THE WAY WE DO IT IN EVERY
HEARING.
SO -- SO JUST YOUR NAME YOUR
POSITION IN AND ANY ORGANIZATION
MIGHT REPRESENT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
MISTER CHAIR MANUALLY ON BEHALF
OF SUTTER HEALTH IN STRONG
SUPPORT SORRY FOR COMING LATE.
MY NAME IS ADRIAN HALF'S FROM
ROSEVILLE CALIFORNIA.
AND THE MOTHER.
MY SON WILL NOT QUALIFY FOR
EXEMPTION UNDER THIS LAW HE IS
PARALYZED FROM HIS VACCINES
SINCE PLEASE CONSIDER
[inaudible]
OKAY.
TERRY ROURKE NATIONAL VACCINE
INFORMATION CENTER NATIVE
CALIFORNIAN AND SURVIVING PARENT
A VACCINE.
INJURED CHILD IN ADAMANTLY
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS AMBER BEASLEY I AM A
MOTHER OF TWO AND SOON TO BE
THREE THIS YEAR.
AND I AM HERE IN OPPOSITION OF
THE BILL.
AND STANDARD OF CARE DOES NOT
INCLUDE FAMILY HAS JUST RANGES
TO POSITION PLEASE THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JOSH WILL CALL WHEN I
WAS BORN AND RAISED IN
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY
RESIDING IN ROSEVILLE I
VEHEMENTLY OPPOSE THIS
UNNECESSARY BILL.
HI I'M TWENTY COLLINS FROM
ROCKLIN CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL MY
DAUGHTER WILL NOT BE ABLE TO GO
TO SCHOOL IF THIS BILL PASSES.
RON KENNEDY FIFTY YEAR MEDICAL
PRACTICE.
SANTA ROSA CALIFORNIA.
I AM A VACCINE INJURED POSITION.
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY AND NICHOLS THIS IS MY SON HE
WOULD BE THROWN OUT OF SCHOOL HE
NEEDS PROTECTION PLEASE SUPPORT
PLEASE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
PLEASE ALONG OCCUR FOR MARIN
COUNTY CALIFORNIA.
MY FRIEND'S SON DIED FROM
VACCINES.
IMMUNO COMPROMISED AND MEDICALLY
FRAGILE.
AND SO IS MY CHILD I VEHEMENTLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
ASK AGAIN JUST YOUR POSITION
ORGANIZATION PLEASE.
MY NAME IS JESSICA HALL AND THE
CONSTITUENTS OF KEN COOLEY AND I
OPPOSE THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S DAVID LONG OCCUR FROM
MARIN COUNTY I'M HERE
REPRESENTING THE FOUNDERS OF OUR
COUNTRY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
MY NAME IS STACY BACKER AND I'M
A CONSTITUENT OF GEN ONE AND I
THINK HE MENTALLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
ALEX MEYER FROM SILICON VALLEY
CALIFORNIA I'M A BOARD MEMBER AT
CHILDREN'S HEALTH DEFENSE I'M
VACCINE INJURED MY DAUGHTER GOT
MEASLES FROM MEASLES VACCINE.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I'M GOING TO ASK ONE MORE TIME
PLEASE JUST YOUR NAME AND
POSITION.
MY NAME IS HOLLY NOW PLAYING I'M
A MOTHER AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CHRISTINA KRISTIN AND
I AM A BOARD MEMBER OF
CHILDREN'S HEALTH DEFENSE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS KELLY ZACK'S I LIVE
IN US TO DECIDE CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS ORWELLIAN BILL.
THANK YOU I'M DR KELLY CERTAIN I
PRACTICE IN ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
SIX AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS ACTUALLY ROSE I AM A
MOTHER OF A DISABLED CHILD I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS CHRISTIAN BY LOUIS.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AND
FROM NEVADA CITY CALIFORNIA I'M
ALSO SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER.
THANK YOU.
ELAINE STEIN FROM SAN JOSE
CALIFORNIA MOM OF TO OPPOSE
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SHANNON THOMPSON I'M
A SPECIAL EDUCATION ADVOCATE
FROM SAN DIEGO REPRESENTING
EDUCATE ADVOCATE AND WE OPPOSE
AND ALWAYS WILL OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MARSHA VANDERPOOL AND A
KINDERGARTEN TEACHER --
REPRESENTING MANY KINDERGARTEN
TEACHERS WATCHING OUR CLASSROOMS
TURNED INTO TRIAGE CENTERS I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS JOY TO PLEASE I'M
FROM THOUSAND OAKS CALIFORNIA.
AND CLASSICAL HOMEOPATH AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ON ONE ARGUE LOW
I'M FROM SANTA BARBARA COUNTY
I'M A MOTHER OF THREE I AM ALSO
A FIRST NATIONS WOMAN FROM THE
SHOW MISSION ALONI AND WALK AND
TRIBES.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
DO NOT SEGREGATE MY CHILDREN
AGAIN.
OLIVIA MY COSTA ROSEVILLE
EDUCATING MOTHER OF TWO I
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
MY NAME IS SUSAN NAP I'M A CPA
AND A MOM AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
STACEY FAMILY -- I'M FROM ORANGE
COUNTY AND HIM TAKING YOU TO
PLEASE.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS DARLENE ROSETTI AL
KISA.
I HAVE A SCIENCE DEGREE
SPECIALIZING IN RESEARCH
METHODOLOGY MY CHILDREN WILL NOT
BE ABLE TO GO TO SCHOOL IF THIS
BILL PASSES PLEASE OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS DENISE SECULAR FROM
STOCKTON CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL AND HAVE WALKED AWAY
FROM THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
MY NAME IS JESSICA PERSONAL
PHONE FROM LA COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE SPELL.
HI AM JAMIE LYNN HARD AS I'M A
MOTHER OF FOUR TO SEE REALLY
VACCINE INJURED TO UNVACCINATED
I'M A LICENSED MARRIAGE AND
FAMILY THERAPIST A CREDENTIALED
SCHOOL COUNSELOR.
I REPRESENT LIBERTY LAW GROUP
HOPING ACADEMY AND HOPE FOR
AUTISM AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE SPELL.
MY NAME IS KATIE BURKE FROM SAN
JOSE CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I'M DAVID LUNDBERG A NATIVE
CALIFORNIAN WHO IS A REGISTERED
VOTER WITH A GREAT MEMORY AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS VANESSA DRAKE FROM
LOS ANGELES I SAVE MY SON FROM A
CARDIAC ARREST AFTER HIS TWO
MONTH SHOTS AND I POST THIS BILL
[inaudible]
IF YOU.
HI MY NAME IS DEBBIE LUNDBERG I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL I'M A
MOTHER OF FOUR MY DAUGHTER GOT
THE MEASLES FROM THE MAC MMR.
MY NAME IS ASHLEY REEVES I'M
FROM ORANGE COUNTY CALIFORNIA
AND WITH FAMILIES UNITED FOR
HEALTH.
WHO WILL BE LIABLE WHEN MY SON
IS FURTHER INJURED?
I OPPOSE.
HI MY NAME IS AMY BOND AND I'M A
BUSINESS OWNER IN THOUSAND OAKS
CALIFORNIA I HAVE THREE CHILDREN
ONE IS VACCINE INJURY.
I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ANGELA HICKS FROM
ORANGE COUNTY FROM FAMILIES
UNITED FOR HEALTH I OPPOSE THIS
BILL PLEASE DO NOT SEGREGATE MY
CHILD.
MY NAME IS MICHELLE SABINO I'M A
GRADUATE OF LOW MULLIN
UNIVERSITY A SPEECH LANGUAGE
PATHOLOGIST A CO FOUNDER OF HOPE
CULTURE NONPROFIT IN ST BERNARD
YOU KNOW AND I VEHEMENTLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
I'M DR ERIC SWENSON AND I'VE
BEEN TREATING VACCINE INJURED
CHILDREN FROM MOST TWENTY YEARS
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S CHRISTIAN CASTRO I'M
FROM SAN GABRIEL VALLEY A MOTHER
TO FOR KIDS THIS IS MY CHILD
WITH CEREBRAL PALSY AND I
WHOLEHEARTEDLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AMBER SMALL INJURES STRONGLY
OPPOSED.
I AM A MOTHER OF FOUR AN
EDUCATOR AND THIS BODY IS STILL
UNDER THE JURISDICTION OF THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES AND DONALD J. TRUMP IS
YOU.
JUSTIN SMALL UNDER OF CALAVERAS
COUNTY.
BOTHER FIVE STRONGLY OPPOSED.
HI MY NAME IS WENDY SILVERS AND
I AM THE FOUNDER AND DIRECTOR OF
MILLION MAMAS MOVEMENT I'M ALSO
A TWENTY YEAR PARENTING EDUCATOR
AND I'M ALSO A MOM.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AND ASK
YOU TO VOTE NO OR OF STAYING ON
SB.
TWO SEVEN SIX MY NAME IS
JENNIFER MURPHY FROM BACK OF ALL
CALIFORNIA AND MY SON DIED FROM
T. DOT THE FLU SHOT -- I
STRONGLY OPPOSE WELL.
HI I'M ANGELA I'M A REGISTERED
NURSE I RUN VACCINE CLINICS
STATEWIDE I'M STRONGLY OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL PLEASE OPPOSE THANK
YOU.
J. SONORA FATHER HUSBAND.
STRONGLY OPPOSE I CAN I ASK YOU
GUYS TO POSE AS WELL PLEASE
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS LISA BAKHSHI EMMA
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER
FROM ROSEVILLE CALIFORNIA AND
STRONGLY OPPOSED.
HI AM RE SCHAEFER FROM ATWATER
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI I AM A RURAL DAN I'M FROM
SOUTH ORANGE COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
JULIANNE WILLIAMS MOTHER I
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
HI AM KATRINA ROLE DâN I'M A
MOTHER OF TEN FROM SOUTH ORANGE
COUNTY CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS SERRA CAN CHAIR IS
I'M A MOM.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
HORRIFIC BELL.
I AM MELISSA REDWOOD FROM
OCEANSIDE CALIFORNIA I'M A
GRANDMOTHER WHO TOOK A TEN HOUR
EIGHT HUNDRED SLIDE IN CLASS ON
VACCINES FROM IMMUNOLOGY
PROFESSOR.
AND AYE OPPOSED THIS BILL.
WHEN IS AMIR AND IS ON THE
FATHER OF A VACCINE INJURED
CHILD AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES
BILL?
HI AM LARA DELLAVEDOVA I'M
REPRESENT THE NATIONAL HEALTH
FEDERATION THE OLDEST HEALTH
FREEDOMS ORGANIZATION IN THE
WORLD AND I AM HERE TO REMIND
YOU THAT YOUR PUBLIC SERVANTS.
THANK YOU YOUR CAN I TELL YOU
THAT I WAS A BILL YOU'RE GONNA
CAUSE A REVOLUTION IF THIS
PASSES.
HI MY NAME IS THALIA CRUZ I'M A
MOTHER OF THREE I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AND WE WILL
NEVER COMPLY.
MY NAME IS CAROL BULLS I'M A
TEACHER AND A MOTHER OF A
VACCINE INJURED CHILD AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS JESSE MOM OF
TWO I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
DISCRIMINATORY BELT.
MY NAME IS ROCHELLE LOWLY FROM
FRESNO AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE I
pYOU WILL NEVER TOUCH THEM THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS MORGAN SET LOW I'M A
MOTHER OF TWO ONE VACCINE
INJURED I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS HOLLY HILL AND THE
WOMEN BUSINESS OWNERS I HAVE A
MOTHER OF THREE I HAVE A
DAUGHTER THAT SUFFERS FROM
SEIZURES THAT WILL LOSE A
MEDICAL EXEMPTION PLEASE VOTE NO
OR ABSTAINED.
MY NAME IS ERIN WILKINS I'M A
REGISTERED NURSE AND MOTHER TO
FIVE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS CAPE STARK MYERS I'M
A GRANDMOTHER AND MOTHER I'M A
GRANDMOTHER OF FOUR AND A MOTHER
OF THREE WITH A VACCINE INJURED
GRANDSON.
AND I A STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
I WILL NEVER CAN.
HI MY NAME IS JENNY I'M FROM
SILICON VALLEY AND A MOTHER
REPRESENTING WISE PARENTS.
AND I URGE YOU TO OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS CHRISTIAN
JOHNSON -- A SCIENCE TEACHER AND
A FATHER TO AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS DANIELLE HAMPTON I'M
FROM SAN DIEGO I IN A LEGAL
SECRETARY PARALEGAL HEARING
CERTIFIED HEARING THAT AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE SPELL.
HELLO MY NAME IS FRITZ SALES.
AND THE MECHANICAL ENGINEER THIS
BILL WILL SEGREGATE I CHILD YOU.
IT WILL TAKE HIS EDUCATION AWAY.
MY NAME IS JENNY HENSLEY I WOULD
TELL YOU MY PROFESSION BUT I
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO WORK FOR
SEVEN YEARS BECAUSE I AM RAISING
A CHILD WHO WILL LIVE WITH ME
HIS ENTIRE LIFE.
I HAVE TWO VACCINE AND THEIR
CHILDREN AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS JULIE FULLER TEN I
AM A CITIZEN OF AMERICA MY
FAMILY'S FROM UGANDA.
AND I HAVE A DEGREE IN HUMAN
DEVELOPMENT.
AND I WAS A DAY CARE PROVIDER
FOR FOUR YEARS WHY WOULD MISS A
LOT OF VACCINE INJURY -- I
THOUGHT YOU WERE NEVER
OPPOSITION.
ARE YOU IN A SUPPORT OPPOSITION
THAT -- EXACTLY -- IT'S GOOD TO
SEE YOU AGAIN SENATOR PAN.
NOT RUNNING AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL FOR STANDING.
ONCE AGAIN PLEASE JUST YOUR
POSITION AND YOUR ORGANIZATION
AND YOUR NAME PLEASE.
MY NAME IS LINDSAY I'M A
REGISTERED NURSE AND SOME
ACCOUNTING I STRONGLY OPPOSES
BELL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS JILL HAWKINS I'M
FROM SANTA MONICA CALIFORNIA AND
I'M REPRESENTING THOUSANDS OF
VACCINE INJURED CHILDREN.
I THINK YOU KNOW MY NAME IS
HEATHER MAGNUS AND I'M FROM
SANTA MARIA I AM A MOTHER OF SIX
CHILDREN AND I HAVE ONE VACCINE
INJURED CHILD I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME'S REBECCA.
I AM A CONSTITUENT OF A AG YEAR
CURRY.
AND I'M HERE TO OPPOSE THIS BILL
PLEASE PLEASE VOTE NO THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M NANCY IS GONNA FROM
BACK OF ILL MOTHER OF FIVE WITH
THE VACCINE IN YOUR CHILDHOOD
SEIZURES AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JONNA LEE I'M A
TEACHER MY DAUGHTER WAS
HOSPITALIZED AND IS STILL STOP
STILL SUFFERING FROM HER
VACCINATIONS.
AND I URGE YOU TO PLEASE VOTE NO
I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
MY NAME IS DAN I HAVE A SISTER
I'M A CHEMIST AND A CONCERT YOU
CONSTITUENTS OF A RIVAS AND I
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO OPPOSE
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ALLISON THROWING WITH
FAMILIES UNITED FOR HEALTH MY
SON SUFFERED ANAPHYLACTIC SHOCK
AND WOULD NOT BE EXEMPT.
I OPPOSE AS THREE TWO SEVEN SIX
IT JUST YOUR NAME AND POSITION.
MY NAME IS STEPHANIE FETZER I
LIVE IN SAN CLEMENTE AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MELISSA FLOYD
REPRESENTING ORANGE COUNTY
HEALTH CHOICE A GROUP OF OVER
TWO THOUSAND MEMBERS AND THE
MOTHER OF A VACCINE INJURED
DAUGHTER AND I OPPOSE.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS HOLLY FETZER I'M FROM
SAN CLEMENTE CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
I'M CHRIS HI DENNIS.
AND KRISTIN DENNIS I'M AN
ATTORNEY WITH FAMILIES UNITED
FOR HEALTH AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS SYDNEY VETS ARE
I'M FROM SAN CLEMENTE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
DEBORAH SCHAEFER ON THE BOARD OF
ADVOCATES FOR PHYSICIANS A
RIGHTS AND A MOTHER OF THREE
VACCINE INJURED CHILDREN.
BECAUSE I DID WITH MY
PEDIATRICIAN TOLD ME THANK YOU
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
TARA THORNTON SIERRA COUNTY
MOTHER OF ONE CO FOUNDER OF OUR
KIDS ARE CHOICE REPRESENTING
OVER FOURTEEN THOUSAND CONCERNED
PARENTS.
MY NAME IS REBEKAH E. STEP I'M
FROM PALLY CALIFORNIA MY HUSBAND
AND I BOTH OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS CHINA LAMBERT I AM A
REGISTERED NURSE AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
AND TELL ME VOUCHER FOR WITH
FAMILIES UNITED FOR HEALTH OF
THE SPEECH LANGUAGE PATHOLOGIST
AS WELL THE MOTHER OF A VACCINE
INJURED CHILD AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MICHELLE FORD I'M THE PRESIDENT
OF THE VACCINE INJURY AWARENESS
LEAGUE REPRESENTING THOUSANDS OF
FAMILIES.
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY AND
CALIFORNIA AND STRONGLY OPPOSE.
MY NAME'S COURTNEY LACKEY WITH A
CV FOR PARENTAL RIGHTS I'M A
CONSTITUENT OF CHRISTY SMITH.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI ANDREA EVERS MOTHER OF
VACCINE INJURED CHILD AND
FOUNDING MEMBER OF SCV FOR FOR
PARENTAL RIGHTS.
I ADAMANTLY OPPOSE THIS HORRIFIC
BILL.
JACQUELINE AM DONNA -- COMBAT
VETERAN WITH THREE AUTO IMMUNE
DISEASES FROM BEING OVER
VACCINATED IN THE MILITARY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MELISSA MELISSA TO MATCH THEM
AND I AM -- BUT A PROFESSIONAL
IN THE PUBLIC SCHOOLS I'M ALSO
AND I WALK DESCENDANTS AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS LUCY COMO I'M A
CONSTITUENT OF WENDY CARILLO.
I REPRESENT CHILDREN'S HEALTH
COALITION ADVOCACY AND I VERY
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS.
I'M ALSO A MOTHER AND
GRANDMOTHER THANK YOU.
HELLO GINA CAMP I'M A BUSINESS
OWNER AND TO PARENT FROM LOS
ANGELES AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL [inaudible]
AT HELLO -- ANDROMEDA EDISON
FROM LOS ANGELES AND THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN RECIPIENT OF
THE PRESIDENTIAL VOLUNTEER
SERVICE AWARD. FOR MY WORK IN
HUMAN RIGHTS EDUCATION AS A
VIOLATION OF PRIDE PRIVACY
RIGHTS I OPPOSE THE STUFF.
HI CURRENT ROSS BUSINESS OWNER
AND MOTHER FROM SAN DIEGO
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
I'M TALK TO ANDREA PINKER TEN
I'M A LICENSED CLINICAL
PSYCHOLOGIST I HAVE FAMILY I
WORK WITH FAMILIES WITH VACCINE
INTO CHILDREN AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS CASEY CLAYTON
FROM TO HAVE TO BE CALIFORNIA
AND ON BEHALF OF MY VACCINE
INJURED CHILD AND CHILDREN
EVERYWHERE I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS CHRISTOPHER CLEAN HI
AM FROM TO HATCH BE CALIFORNIA
FATHER OF FOUR ONE WHO IS
VACCINE INJURED.
I'M ALSO LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER.
ON BEHALF OF ALL THREE AMERICANS
AND ALL LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
OF NEITHER COMPLY.
NOR FORCE THE DECREE OF TIME
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS TARA I OPPOSE THIS
I AM A CONSTITUENT OF MR BONTA
I'M A TEACHER AND A MOTHER THANK
YOU.
JESSICA DATING I AM I
REPRESENTING PUBLIC AWARENESS
FOR PREVENTIVE HEALTHCARE.
AND MOTHER FORTY TWO YEAR OLD
SON WHO'S BEEN.
MISSING SINCE FRIDAY AND YOU SEE
P. T. INJURED I WOULD NOT GET AN
EXEMPTION.
LISA STARK AGAIN I AM A
CONSTITUENT OF MISS ANGLER CURRY
AND I OPPOSE.
RACHEL ANDREAS I MEAN
CONSTITUENTS OF JIM WOOD I
OPPOSE THE SPELL I AM VACCINE
INJURED AND SO IS MY DAUGHTER.
MY NAME'S SPENCER ANDREAS FROM
SANTA ROSA CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA
FIREFIGHTERS OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
CRISTINA JERMAINE HALF FROM
ROCKLIN CALIFORNIA AND MOTHER OF
A DAUGHTER WHO RECEIVED BRAIN
DAMAGE FROM VACCINES I URGE
SENATOR PAN TO REVIEW THE
HIPPOCRATIC OATH AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
JUST YOUR NAME AND POSITION
PLEASE.
MARNIE SAN JOSE FROM THOUSAND
OAKS CALIFORNIA MOTHER OF THREE
AND PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER I
ADAMANTLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ASHLEY FERNANDEZ
I'M VACCINE INJURED AND I OPPOSE
THIS.
THANK YOU.
I AM FOR OTHERS LOS GATOS WE
OPPOSE.
BROUGH ANDRADE WITH YOUR
CALIFORNIA MOTHER OF A VACCINE
AND YOUR CHILD AND WE OPPOSE.
HELLO MY NAME IS JACK I AM A
COLLEGE STUDENT AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS SATURDAY WHEN I
WAS A I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
HI MY NAME IS KATHERINE TERRACE
LIKE I'M A BUSINESS OWNER AND
ALSO APPEARING HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
HI MY NAME IS CASEY AND I'M A
MOTHER OF A CANCER SURVIVOR AND
HI MY NAME IS ASPEN KEARNEY I
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
HI MY NAME IS VICKY CARNEY I'M
FROM NEWPORT BEACH AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB.
TWO SEVEN SIX I'M WERE KILLED
ACNE NOEL AND THE CONSTITUENT OF
MCCARTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB.
TWO SEVEN SIX I'M CHARLES THE
IT'S CONCERNED FATHER OF TWO
HUSBAND OF THE SCIENTIST.
COMMUNITY HEALTH ADVOCATE CO
FOUNDER -- PROTECT LINCOLN --
PETER BASEBALL COACH A NUCLEAR
ENGINEER I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GIVE.
HI MY NAME IS LOW RENT AMERICANS
I'M A CONSTITUENT OF CECILIA
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AND I'M A MOTHER OF TWO AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL BECAUSE OF IT
BECAUSE IT'S NOT IT WILL COST.
TO PROTECT THE CONSTITUTION
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JOSE SALDANA.
FROM CINEMA I'M A BUSINESS OWNER
AN ENTREPRENEUR AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS DANIEL ALDRICH FROM
SACRAMENTO ON I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CHRISTINE POTTER AND
I REPRESENT MY VACCINE INJURED
DAUGHTER AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS KIMBERLY BOMBERS.
I'M A VACCINE EDUCATION
SPECIALIST AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JOANNE THORPE I'M A
REGISTERED NURSE FROM CAUGHT
WITH CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE THIS
BILL WE MUST PROTECT ASSISTING
MEDICAL EXCUSE EXEMPTION.
MY NAME IS MEDIA GARCIA I'M A
MOTHER OF  FROM
I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS AMBER
POWERS I'M A LOS MOTHER OF TWO
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI I'M SARAH DOYLE FROM ORANGE
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
SPELL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS DOUGLAS MACKENZIE
A CONSTITUENT OF MONIQUE LIMON.
FATHER AND A PHYSICIAN.
I AM A BOARD MEMBER OF
PHYSICIANS FOR INFORMED CONSENTS
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
HI MY NAME IS RICHARD GROVER I
AM A FATHER AND A BUSINESS OWNER
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
IF YOU'RE FREE.
TO HELLO I AM GENET SALT MURDER
MOTHER OF TWO MONTHS GRANDMOTHER
OF SEVEN I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS JOHN SO BURGER I AM A
MEASLES SURVIVOR.
AND A GRANDFATHER OF SEVEN
FATHER OF TWO AND I OPPOSE THIS
POORLY WRITTEN BILL THAT WILL
AND A FIGHT CIVIL THANK YOU
DISOBEDIENCE THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S CAN STOP THEM FROM
BACK OF CALIFORNIA I'M A
COMMERCIAL SOLAR DEVELOPER.
JAZZ MUSICIAN AND PASSED MUSIC
TEACHER IN A SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER.
I OPPOSE THIS BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S REBEKAH GODDARD I AM A
MOM FIRST A TAX PAYER SECONDS A
WIFE.
A CANCER SURVIVOR A MEASLES
SURVIVOR AND I AM TO VACCINE
INJURY INJURED CHILDREN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AND
BEG.
YOU TO DO FOR COMMON SENSE.
HI MY NAME IS JODY EL FARO I'M
AN RN AND A MOTHER OF TWO I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
BECAUSE THE VACUUM FAILURE ISSUE
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S KATHERINE ONLY
DISTRICTS SEVENTY THREE FORMER
MOLECULAR BIOLOGISTS FORCED TO
GIVE UP HER CAREER TO CARE FOR
HER TWO NEUROLOGICALLY VACCINE
DAMAGED CHILDREN STRONGLY
OPPOSED THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS KATHY BURKE WHAT'S
FROM CAP -- CALABASAS CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
SUZANNE ACCORDINGLY FROM EL
DORADO COUNTY I STRONGLY OPPOSES
DANGERS BILL.
IN A TOURISM TO SO THE FROM SAN
DIEGO CONSTITUENT OF TODD GLORIA
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
REBECCA I OPPOSE UNTIL YOU MAKE
VACCINE MAKER YOU'RE LIABLE CAM.
MY NAME IS PAUL NELSON AND I
OPPOSE THIS OF THE ROTARIAN BILL
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MIKE MATTINGLY
PRESIDENT OF THE FUNKY FATHER'S
CLUB.
WE ARE REPRESENTING A HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF MUSICIANS
AGAINST TYRANNY.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS MELANIE BACH
AND I'M FROM RIVERSIDE
CALIFORNIA AND I'M HERE
SUPPORTING MY TWO CHILDREN.
STAR SUTHERLAND FROM ORANGE
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JOE WELL GAS FIRED
AND FROM RIVERSIDE CALIFORNIA
AND THE MOTHER OF THE FIVE TIMES
OVER VACCINE INJURED CHILD IF
THIS BILL PASSES HE WILL BE
REQUIRED TO GET SIXTY SEVEN MORE.
I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR LEE AND MARK
HAS I PRACTICE IN ORANGE COUNTY
AND I ALSO TREAT CHILDREN WITH
NEUROLOGICAL CONDITIONS AND A
MOTHER.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS NICHOLSON I'M FROM
SAN DIEGO TODD GLORIA.
DISTRICT AND I AM -- A STRONG
DEMOCRAT.
AND I AM URGING OTHER DEMOCRATS
TO OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CHANEL DIAL I'M FROM
SAN DIEGO AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED
TO SPELL.
MY NAME IS TAMMY AUSTIN ALSO
FROM SAN DIEGO I'M A PUBLIC
SCHOOL TEACHER AND MOTHER AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
GINNY JOY WILLIAMS CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS OWNER AND SPECIAL
EDUCATION ADVOCATE I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
CRISTIANO SAME FROM SANTA MANY
CALIFORNIA I AM A BUSINESS SITE
MANAGER AND A CHILD CARE
PROVIDER AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
JESSICA BOOKER IT IS NOT A
PRIVILEGE TO BE A VACCINE
INJURED OR GENETICALLY
PREDISPOSED.
FOR ONE MY NAME IS URSULA I AM A
I COME FROM SAN DIEGO I AM A
REGISTERED NURSE OF TWENTY SEVEN
YEARS I HAVE EIGHT MAXINE
INJURED CHILD.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS AMY TAYLOR AND I'M
A MOTHER OF TWO AND A SPECIAL
EDUCATOR.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
I AM SAYING.
I AM SHELLING PEAS.
I AM FROM CINEMA AND I STRONGLY.
MY NAME IS JENNIFER PEAS MOTHER.
ONE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE
SPELL.
GILLIAN ALAIMO WHERE THERE IS
RISK THERE MUST BE CHOICE I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS.
MY NAME IS PRETTY TO KUBIAK FROM
LOS ANGELES I MY MOTHER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS KERRY GARBER I'M FROM
LOS ANGELES I HAVE TEN
GRANDCHILDREN I STRONGLY.
OPPOSE.
MY NAME IS KEY LEASING INNER
THIS IS MY SON GRAHAM WERE FROM
CHICO AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS.
HI I'M TERRY CAMPBELL HEART
RETIRED NURSE MOTHER OF THREE
GRANDMOTHER OF THREE AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
SOUTH CAMPBELL ANOTHER
FIREFIGHTER [inaudible]
ANOTHER FATHER.
I OPPOSE THIS BILL I'VE SEEN
VACCINE INJURY IN THE FIELD IN
THE NINE ONE ONE SYSTEM THANK
YOU.
THE GENERATOR -- FROM CINEMA
COUNTY GRANDMOTHER AND MOTHER
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS KERRY JOHNSON FROM EL
DORADO COUNTY MOTHER OF TWO AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS CHARLENE SILVA MOTHER
OF THREE SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS DEMOCRATS
ATTACK ON HUMANITY [inaudible]
SO.
SEC WILL BE COMING BACK
DOWNSTAIRS HERE NOW SO WHAT I'M
GETTING OWNERS HIGHEST.
SUPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HE SPEAKS ON BEHALF OF THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS.
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE NON VERBAL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS NAY PATEL -- I'M FROM
ST CLAIR COUNTY I'M GENETICALLY
COMPROMISE OF LINE FACTOR FIVE
JUST IS NOT IS COULD NOT COVERED
BY THIS BILL.
INTO.
MY NAME IS SHANNON HI THIS IS MY
SON JOSHUA WERE FROM FRESNO IN A
SPECIAL EDUCATION ADVOCATE AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS KARENA POWER SOME
FROM MONTEREY CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AND I
VACCINATED I HAVE AN INJURED
CHILD.
JULIANNE APPEARS I AM A NURSE --
FROM O'NEILL'S CALIFORNIA I'M A
MOTHER OF THE CHILD WITH THE
VACCINE EXEMPTION AND A MEMBER
OF THE WE DID REGRET CLUB I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS NATE THE PEERS AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB.
TWO SEVENTY SIX GENEVIEVE ITALO
I'M A MOTHER AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
DANA GORMAN CALIFORNIA HEALTH
COALITION ADVOCACY IN OPPOSITION
OF THIS BILL IN ITS CURRENT FORM
WE HAVE AN AMENDMENT CURRENTLY
IN WITH THE CHAIR.
HI MY NAME IS CHRISTINA FROM
MONTEREY COUNTY I'M A MOTHER OF
FOUR AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
HI AM DHEA HANS FROM SANTA ANA
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS OWNER MOTHER
SB TWO SEVENTY SIX DISCRIMINATES
MATCH AS MUCH OUR THE RARE
GENETIC NEUROLOGICAL DISORDER.
HE HAD.
HE WOULD NOT QUALIFY FOR MEDICAL.
HI I'M NOT A FROM HOLLISTER AYE
OPPOSED HIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI SUSAN FOR HIS MASTER'S DEGREE
IN EDUCATIONAL ADMINISTRATION
MOTHER OF A SON WITH A LIFELONG
ON IN YOUR CONDITION I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ELIZABETH
GALLAGHER I'M A MOTHER OF TWO
I'M IMMUNO COMPROMISED MY SON
AND I MEAN I'M COMPROMISED.
VACCINE INJURED MY CHILDREN
MATTER I AM VERY PROUD MILITARY
SPOUSE THANK YOU PLEASE.
NO.
ONE WILL.
JUST YOUR NAME AND POSITION
PLEASE.
HI JENNIFER BRO S. ORANGE COUNTY
BUSINESS OWNER EDUCATOR MOTHER
OF TWO I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE
SPELL THANK YOU.
I'M NAY JUST ANOTHER NUMBER
AIRFORCE VETERAN.
I STRONGLY AND DEMAND WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
DON'T TAKE OUR FREEDOM THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS VICTORIA I'M OF EXENE
INJURED MOTHER I'M FROM PANEL
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI I'M TIFFANY SOLANO COUNTY
RESIDENT MOTHER OF TWO AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE ESPYS TWO
SEVENTY SIX THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS VANESSA MADRID I
AM FOR MONTEREY COUNTY I AM THE
FOUNDER OF LEADER TO CARE
CALIFORNIA I AM ALSO A
REPRESENTATIVE FOR LATINOS FOR
MEDICAL FREEDOM.
AS WELL AS THE VACCINE EDUCATOR
I AM A MOTHER OF TWO MEDICALLY
FRAGILE CHILDREN AND A DAUGHTER
OF THE MOST HIKING AND AS GOD IS
MY WITNESS I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
ALSO SECTION FIVE EIGHT OF MARKS
[inaudible]
MORE [inaudible]
YOU FARM.
I'M SAN DIEGO CALIFORNIA I'M A
SPECIAL ED TEACHER -- EARLY
CHILDHOOD I AM A MONDAY TO AND I
OPPOSE.
MY NAME IS JEFFREY PAUL RYAN I'M
A PARENT AND TWO I HAVE A
VACCINE INJURED SON YOU NEED TO
FOLLOW THE LAWS PAN.
NUREMBERG TRIALS.
THE MOTHER OF THREE ONE VACCINE
INJURED CHILD AND MY KIDS WILL
NOT BE ABLE TO GO TO SCHOOL OF
THIS [inaudible]
SUPPOSE.
MY NAME IS SHEILA SCOTT AND FROM
LOS ANGELES AND I STRENUOUSLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
CHRISTINE RIVA'S FROM CARMICHAEL --
BUSINESS OWNER MOTHER OF TWO AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI AYMERIC WHITMIRE I AM.
HAVE A VACCINE INJURED FAMILY
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS.
HI AM RONNIE JUDAH FOR MARIN
COUNTY AND THE HEALTH
PRACTITIONER AND A MOTHER OF A
VACCINE INJURED CHILD AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
HI I MELANIE LOFTIS I AM A
MOTHER OF TWO DEGREES FROM YALE.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY.
HI AM REGISTERED NURSE NELLIE TO
CAN'T GO I STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL
IT IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CAMERA CM A MOTHER OF
TWO FROM PLASTER COUNTY AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ALI RATE IN I AM A
PRESCHOOL TEACHER AND MY
CHILDREN -- VACCINE INJURED I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS VICKY WILLIS FROM
SAN JOSE I'M AN ACCOUNTANT MBA
AND EDUCATED MOTHER OF FIVE TWO
VACCINE INJURED.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS STEPHANIE DURING WEST
SACRAMENTO MOTHER OF TWO
EDUCATOR I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
RENDON LEAD IN A DAY AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
OLIVIA GORDON TIME ONCE IN
OCEANSIDE CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF
OF A VACCINE CHILD INJURED CHILD
I DO OPPOSE THIS BILL
HI I'M JUSTIN WALLACE AGE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
THE SHIPPER MISQUOTE FROM
PLASTER COUNTY I'M A MOTHER AN
EDUCATOR AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
COLIN CLIPPING FROM EL DORADO
COUNTY -- AUTUMN IN CANCER
SURVIVOR AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
I'M CHRISTY POLICE CELL
CREDENTIALED TEACHER AND A
CANCER SURVIVOR AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS BROOKE COPING AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS KELLY HERE AGAIN FROM
ORANGE COUNTY.
I AM A BUSINESS OWNER MOTHER OF
THREE AN EDUCATOR AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE.
HI MY NAME IS THE ONE T. TEN I'M
A MOM I'M FROM SAN DIEGO AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ERIN RUSH CAM A
CONSTITUENT OF KEVIN MCCARTY AN
ARCHITECT HERE IN SACRAMENTO A
MOTHER AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS DEVIN RAJON FROM LOS
ANGELES I'M IN NO SORRY IN TH
DISTRICT AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. TO ME WHAT TIME OF
DAY OF MOTHER OF TWO STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS HEATHER BASS A MOTHER
OF A BIRACIAL CHILD PLEASE DON'T
FOR THE DISCRIMINATING CIGARETTE
HER.
AYE POSES ABOUT.
MY NAME IS OLGA I'M A WIFE.
I'M A MOTHER OF FOUR BEAUTIFUL
CHILDREN.
I AM REGISTERED -- ASSISTANT
ANIMALS OR CO FOUNDER OF
ORGANIZATION NONPROFIT MINISTRY
HOMELESSNESS AND BEHALF OF MANY
FAMILIES WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS C. R. AND I'M
FOR I AM A LIFELONG CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS A THIRD GENERATION
FEMALE BUSINESS OWNER.
I'M ALSO VACCINE INJURED AND
YOUR MOST RECENT PRIVACY
VIOLATION VICTIM.
THANK YOU AYE OPPOSED.
MY NAME IS GWEN STRICKLAND ON A
MILITARY WIFE I SPECIAL FORCES
AS WELL AS A MOTHER OF A SEVEN
MONTH OLD VACCINE AND YOUR CHILD
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS LAUREN WALL FROM
APTOS CALIFORNIA I'M A MOTHER
TWO AND A CANCER SURVIVOR I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS OUT OF IT OF IN A
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS CASEY LATE
THERE I LIVE IN FAIRFIELD
CALIFORNIA MILITARY SPOUSE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS ALL IN THE CAN
YOU CALL MY MOTHER OF SIX
BEAUTIFUL CHILDREN.
AND ALSO FOUNDER OF SLAVIC
ORGANIZATION CALIFORNIANS FROM
PARENTS.
AND REPRESENT OVER A BALL TWO
THOUSAND RUSSIANS BEGIN PEOPLE.
WHO ARE ALL OPPOSES BILL?
HELLO MY NAME IS SEAN DOLLAR I'M
A FATHER OF TWO AND A DRAMATIC
BRAIN INJURY SURVIVOR AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ARE YOU SEE VERY TINY
AND FROM SANTA CRUZ CALIFORNIA
AND CENTER PAN I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS FASCIST BELL.
MY NAME IS MICHAEL HUDSON FROM
BUNNY JUNE CALIFORNIA I AM AN
EMERGENCY NURSING CALIFORNIA FOR
TWENTY ONE YEARS.
THE FATHER OF THREE I'VE SEEN
TOO MANY VACCINE INJURIES AT
WORK AND I STAND AND STRIDENT
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS NAOMI SORIA I
MOTHER OF TWO BEAUTIFUL PERFECT
CHILDREN.
AND THIS BILL INFRINGES ON OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS.
HI I'M XANDER HARA A MOTHER OF
TWO AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
ILL CONCEIVED BUILT IN ALL ITS
FORMS [inaudible]
Q..
MY NAME IS COURTNEY -- QUEST I
LIVE IN OCEANSIDE CALIFORNIA AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE SPELL
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ROSE MERRY GARDEN I'M
A CONSTITUENT OF KEVIN MCCARTY
AND A MOTHER OF A NEUROLOGICALLY
DAMAGE CHILD IN AN AT RISK CHILD
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS CHRISTINE SOME
FROM THOUSAND OAKS CALIFORNIA
HAVE A DEGREE IN SPORTS MEDICINE
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I MEAN IN A FROM.
SAN RAMON CA AND I VERY STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL [inaudible]
IF GOD.
HI THERE ADRIN MORE SAN
FRANCISCO CALIFORNIA MOTHER OF A
VACCINE INJURED DAUGHTER AND
WIFE TO A NURSE PRACTITIONER AT
THE VA HOSPITAL REPRESENTING
OVER.
THIRTY FIVE MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS FROM THE VA
HOSPITAL IN SAN FRANCISCO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
HI MY NAME IS GINA CENTER FROM
SOMEBODY FOR NOW AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL.
MY NAME IS MY NAME IS THOMAS AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS LEE VERY PROUD PARENT
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS JACK AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
Q. HI MY NAME IS CHRISTINE CROW
I'M AN ATTORNEY FOURTH
GENERATION NEEDED TO CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS READ OCCURRENCE I
AM FROM OAKLAND CALIFORNIA I'M A
RETIRED FIREFIGHTER PARAMEDIC --
I AM THAT CENTER OF COMBAT
VETERANS AND WHO FOUGHT FOR OUR
FREEDOMS MOTHER OF THREE I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
VALERIE NOBLE PRESIDENT OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTH COLLISION
ADVOCACY AND WE'RE OPPOSED IS
CURRENTLY AMENDED.
MY NAME IS TESSA HARKNESS I LIVE
IN SAN FRANCISCO.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
MALINA NOBLE STRONGLY OPPOSE.
MY NAME IS LAUREN THOMPSON MAMA
FOR AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
JOHN WHY DO AGAIN FROM WALNUT
CREEK CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
EMILY FAULCONER FROM REDDING
CALIFORNIA MOTHER OF THREE I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
DISCRIMINATORY BILL.
COURTNEY SMITH I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS SUMMER BERRY FROM
BEAUMONT CALIFORNIA I'M AN
EDUCATOR IN EDUCATED IN
EDUCATION FOR EIGHTEEN YEARS.
MOTHER TO ONE AND SPOUSE TO A
VACCINE INJURED MAN.
AND I GROSSLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN PAN MY
NAME'S JESSICA SHERMAN'S OF A
MOTHER OF TWO I SUFFER FROM
MANAGER COCKLE SEPSIS AND
MENINGITIS FOLLOWING MY D. TPM
POLIO VACCINES ARE FOUR MONTHS
OLD.
I VACCINATED MY FIRST SENATE HE
WAS INJURED THANK YOU MY SON HAS.
MY NAME IS CHRIS CARTER CA
TRAVELED HERE FROM BURBANK
CALIFORNIA MY POSITION AS A
CITIZEN AND I YOUR VEDIC
PRACTITIONER SB TWO SEVENTY SIX
IS REPRESENTATIVE OF ORGANIZED
CRIME NOT THE WILL OF THE HI MY
NAME IS CAROLYN RODEO I AM THE
DAUGHTER OF THE KING.
I AM VACCINE INJURED AND SO ARE
MY CHILDREN I STRONGLY OPPOSE
FROM CYPRESS CALIFORNIA.
HELLO MY NAME IS VERONICA
GUERRERO THIS IS MY DAUGHTER
REINA.
I'M FROM LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA
I REPRESENT MY FAMILY AND MANY
MOTHERS AND FATHERS IN LOS
ANGELES WE STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MONICA
AND FROM ROSEVILLE CALIFORNIA
AND I HAVE THREE CHILDREN ONE
INJURED AND WE WILL NOT COMPLY.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY MY NAME'S
REBECCA DE CRESCENZO I FLEW HERE
FROM LOS ANGELES THIS MORNING.
I MET I CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
WOMEN I'M A CONSTITUENT OF
ASSEMBLY WOMAN LOOSE NAME IS
NADIA HAS BEEN THAT LOCUSTS --
I'M A GRANDMOTHER OF THREE FROM
ROSEVILLE CALIFORNIA.
AND AYE OPPOSED THIS BILL.
HELLO FAMILY MY NAME IS VIOLENT
I'M A MOTHER -- PLEASE LET THE
DOCTORS DO THE DOCTORING THANK
YOU I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I'M SELENA TREVINO FROM ROB
BONTA IS DISTRICT -- I'M A BODY
WORKER I WORK AFFECTS SEEN
INJURED ADULTS AND CHILDREN
PLEASE OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS NATALIE AUSTIN I'M
FROM CHINO HILLS ON THE MOTHER
AND HEALTH EDUCATOR I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
Q..
HI I'M RAN ALVAREZ FROM ONTARIO
CALIFORNIA MOTHER OF TWIN NICK
YOU BABY IS AND AN ONGOING
VACCINE INDUCED.
AUTOIMMUNE -- PERSON DEALING
DALY THANK YOU I HAVE.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ON JULIE RICH
SENDS IN A FROM THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY AND A CONSTITUENT OF
NAZARIAN AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE SPELL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS CHRISTINA I'M FROM
RIALTO CALIFORNIA.
I'M A MOTHER OF TWO ONE VACCINE --
CHILD WHO HAD SEIZURES AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS FLOOR FRAZIER I'M
FROM STEVENSON RANCH CALIFORNIA
I WAS TWICE FAX THE INJURED ONCE
AS A BABY AND ONCE AS AN ADULT I
AM IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO THE
SPELL.
HELLO MY NAME IS JESSICA
BALLPARK IS A COME FROM VENTURA
COUNTY I'M A BUSINESS OWNER AND
MOTHER OF TWO AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS NAMELESS REFORM
I'M A MOTHER OF TWO BUCKS AN
INJURED KIDS AND A STRONGER POSE
THIS ATTACK ON THE MOST
VULNERABLE KIDS.
HI MY NAME IS DIANA ZERO I'M ON
VENTURA COUNTY AND I'M A MOTHER
OF FOUR I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU LEAGUE BALL TRACY
CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI AM ALISON MURPHY AND FROM
REDDING CALIFORNIA I MISS
STUDENT AND MOTHER OF SIX ONE OF
HIM IS DISABLED AND ALL OF HIM
HAVE MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS FOR
FAMILY HISTORY.
GIVEN THE SAME HERE FROM THE
SAME DOCTOR YOU CAN UNDERSTAND.
HI MARY I'M FROM TRACY
CALIFORNIA AND OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS GENET PRINGLE AND
FROM SHASTA COUNTY.
OF A MOTHER GRANDMOTHER GREAT
GRANDMOTHER I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS LAURIE C SOME
FROM SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS SHELBY LINDLEY
I'M FROM LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA
BORN AND RAISED I AM A
REGISTERED VOTER AND MOTHER OF
TWO PLEASE KEEP YOUR PROMISE AND
PROTECT OUR CHILDREN VOTE NO ORG
STANDING ON SB.
TWO SEVEN SHERRY BOY FROM CINEMA
COUNTY CALIFORNIA I HAVE TWO
BOYS -- WHO DON'T WANT TO HAVE
TO LEAVE THE STATE I STRONGLY
OPPOSE?
AND PLEASE KEEP YOUR PROMISES
HIM SB.
TWO SEVEN SEVEN PATRICIA CRAIG
FROM SACRAMENTO I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU. FOR
SHALL SOREK I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS PAT EMAIL INFO IN
SAN JOSE MY DAUGHTER WAS FAXING
INJURE IN A STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
NORA THOMPSON THIS IS GOVERNMENT
OVER REACH I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS CHRISTINA.
YOU HAVE THE POWER TO PROTECT
OUR CHILDREN TODAY.
PLEASE OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU I OPPOSE.
MY NAME IS LONGER RELEASE
THOMPSON MOTHER OF TWO
CONSTITUENT OF RICHARD PAN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
CAN REALLY FELLOW CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC SCHOOL EDUCATOR FIFTEEN
YEARS I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME'S KRISTINA HALL I'M
CONCERNED CITIZEN AND MOTHER AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE A SPELL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS MELINA WALLACE I'M
FROM LAKE TAHOE CALIFORNIA I'M A
MOTHER OF TWO AND A BOARD MEMBER
OF THE PTA I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AND WALKING AWAY FROM
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY MY NAME IS
ME.
MY NAME IS MOHAMMED BELA I'M A
FATHER I'M A GRADUATE OF
STANFORD UNIVERSITY -- MY WIFE
AND OUR VACCINE INJURED AND WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS BERTIE WALLACE NOT
OPPOSE SP.
TWO SEVENTY SIX MY NAME IS GRACE
ERICKSON AND A BUSINESS LEADER.
BOARD MEMBER AND MOTHER OF TWO
FROM OAKLAND CALIFORNIA AND NOW
A FORMALLY REGISTERED DEMOCRATS.
I OPPOSE ANY BILL THAT TARGETS
THE WONDERFUL POPULATIONS
INSTITUTION.
OR MINORITIES THANK YOU FIVE
DOLLARS.
PHILOMENA LANDIS I'M AN ATTORNEY
AND ALSO GRANDMOTHER UP.
TO SB TWO SEVEN SIX IS BAD BAD
LAW FIVE TRONG THE ALL PURPOSE.
HI MY NAME'S KATHERINE BRIDE
MOTHER OF THREE AND THE TEACHER
IT DAVIS UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS DANGEROUS
AND DISCRIMINATORY BILL.
HI I'M ROCHELLE AND MOTHER OF
TWO AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME'S AMANDA BELKNAP I'M --
VACCINE INJURED MOTHER AND A
MOTHER OF ONE SON WHO'S VACCINE
INJURED RIO ONE TO CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME'S MELISSA I'M FROM
LONG BEACH AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME SERRANO WALKER FROM FAIR
OAKS CALIFORNIA BORN AND RAISED
IN CALIFORNIA BUSINESS OWNERS
FATHER I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
HI THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
LISTENING TO US TODAY MY NAME'S
COCOA WALKER I DROVE HERE FROM
LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA THIS
MORNING.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
AND I URGE YOU TO VOTE NO THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS JESSICA VAN HILL
HEART I'M A MOM AND AID MEDICAL
PROFESSIONAL AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS MURDEROUS.
HI MY NAME IS SHANNON I'M FROM
LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA MOTHER OF
THREE I BELIEVE MOTHERS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ATKINS AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME'S KATHERINE BROWN
FROM SAN DIEGO CALIFORNIA I'M A
VACCINE INJURED ADULTS AND A
MOTHER OF TWO CHILDREN WITH
VALID MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS I ASK
THAT YOU VOTE NO OR IT STAINED.
SIR HEART MODESTO CALIFORNIA
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
ACTUALLY BROWN VACCINE INJURED
MOTHER FROM PLASTER COUNTY I
URGE YOU TO VOTE NO OR ABSTAINED
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS SHE IN A ROOM I'M
FROM OAKVILLE CALIFORNIA I AM A
MOTHER OF FOUR I'M OF THAT.
I'M A CAREER FIREFIGHTER AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU OBTAIN
OR VOTE NO ON THIS BILL THINK
AGAIN.
PAULO WOULD -- FORMER MEDICAL
ASSISTANT MOTHER OF TWO MARRIED
TO A POLICE OFFICER AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS HEATHER POND I'M
VACCINE INJURED.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MAGYAR GAS FROM ALBAY CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS OWNER AND MOTHER.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MELANIE QUITE UPON
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
MY NAME IS SERRA SAM'S MY
HUSBAND AND I OWN A
MANUFACTURING BUSINESS THAT WE
WILL MOVE OUT OF STATE IF YOU
VOTE FOR THIS BILL PLEASE OPPOSE.
STEVE REFRAINING FROM CINEMA
CALIFORNIA OPPOSES BILL.
MY NAME IS NICOLE DORFMAN I'M
FROM MORO BAY CALIFORNIA I HAVE
A MASTER'S DEGREE IN SOCIAL WORK
MY HUSBAND AND I OWN A SMALL
BUSINESS.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO
ABSTAIN OR VOTE NO ON THIS
DISASTROUS.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS POPPY FROM CINEMA
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL -- HI MY NAME'S AS MAY AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSES.
HI MY NAME IS IS A AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSES THEM.
HI MY NAME'S LISA WELLS AND I'M
A TAKE A TEACHER AND I I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS TAMERA WELLS THIS
IS AS ME SHE HAS SEIZURES AND A
SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHER.
AND I URGE YOU TO VOTE NO ON
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS PENELOPE
SULLIVAN I'VE BEEN IN THE
NATURAL HEALTH FIELD FOR TWENTY
FIVE YEARS.
AND I'VE BEEN FOCUSING ON
CHILDREN'S HEALTH FOR THE PAST.
SIXTEEN I REPRESENT HUNDREDS OF
PEOPLE FROM NEVADA COUNTY FROM
THAT AT A COUNTY FOR VACCINE
AWARENESS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JESSE I'M A MOTHER
AND A REGISTERED NURSE WIFE OF
THE PHYSICIAN AND SURGEON AND
FORMER NAVAL OFFICER AND WE BOTH
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS SCANDALOUS RAN I'M A
REGISTERED NURSE SPAMMERS WILL
CALIFORNIA.
I I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE SPELL
WITH.
EVERY FIBER OF MY BEING AND IT'S
NOT ALLOWING THE DOCTORS OUT
PULLED THEIR I AM GRANDFATHER
FOUR FIVE KEYS I AM A PARA
EDUCATOR FOR SPECIAL NEEDS KIDS
AND STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL -- MY
NAME IS MICHELLEAND I DO NOT
BELIEVE THAT MEDICAL CARE SHOULD
BE LEGISLATED I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS DANA I'M STORM
GLOBAL -- OPPOSED HIS BAIL THANK
YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS NOT TELL YOUR
MUSCLE AND I'M A REGISTERED
NURSE AND MOTHER OF THREE
CHILDREN ONE OFF EACH IS THE
BACKS AN INJURED.
AND I'M STRONG WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS AMANDA BLOKUS
YAMAMOTO KEVIN KILEY AS MY
REPRESENTATIVE I HAVE A SON WHO
SUFFERED NEUROLOGICAL DAMAGE
FROM THE HEAD THE VACCINE I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS LEAVE ME ALONE
I CAME TO THIS COUNTRY FOR
FREEDOM STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL GOD BLESS YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MINDY FROM WHERE I
STRONGLY OPPOSE WHO'S DYING FOR
MEASLES.
HI MY NAME IS IDA YEAH I'M A
CLINICAL PSYCHOLOGY TO TWIRL
STUDENT AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI I MY RING GARCIA FROM NORWALK
MOTHER OF ONE REPRESENTING MY
FAMILY AS WELL AS THE MANY
FAMILIES WHO OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS MARYLAND FOR
DANIEL FROM ORANGE COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I AM -- COREY ISLAND I'M A GOD
FEARING ADVOCATE OF A TIME TO ME.
AND MY GOD GIVEN RIGHT SAYS TO
OPPOSE WHAT'S CONTAINED IN THIS
BARBARIC LAW [inaudible]
BILL.
HI MY NAME'S SERRA I LIVE IN
CHESTER COUNTY AND I'M -- MOTHER
OF THREE AND I'D STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL.
MY NAME IS LISA FOR I AM A
MOTHER AN EDUCATOR FROM NEVADA
CITY AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ROBERT BURKE I'M
FROM NEVADA CITY OF MY FATHER
AND GRANDFATHER AND I PLEAD WITH
YOU TO PLEASE OPPOSE THIS BILL I
OPPOSE THIS YEAR WILL.
I'M LAURIE MAST FROM READING AND
I OPPOSE.
MY NAME IS TAMMY OVERALL AND I'M
A CONSTRUCTION MANAGER IN REAL
TO HER IN CALIFORNIA MY I AM A
CONSTITUENT OF JOAQUIN ERIN YOU
A LOT.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
I IMMEASURABLE TOP FROM FRESNO
CALIFORNIA I GREATLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU SEE YOUR ISSUE
NOT BE NORMAL.
AND MICHELLE TELL FROM FRESNO
CALIFORNIA.
I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
CRAIG CARRY ON A GRANDPARENT TWO
HEALTHY KIDS.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M HEATHER MARTIN FROM
SAN CARLOS MOTHER OF TWO PT
PRESIDENT I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
JULIE HOOPER MOTHER OF TWO I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
TRAVIS SUPER FATHER OF TWO AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
NICOLE RAFFERTY FROM SAN BENITO
COUNTY I'VE.
OF INDIGENOUS CALL WE IN DISSENT
I REPRESENT SIXTY PLUS
GRASSROOTS FAMILIES.
THAT GOT ONTO BUSES WITH ME LAST
NIGHT FROM DISTRICTS ALL OVER
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
ON BEHALF OF MY HUSBAND TWO
CHILDREN MY OWN INJURY AND
FAMILY HISTORY I OPPOSE THIS
OPPRESSIVE BILL.
MY NAME IS NICE LEVINSKY AND I
HAVE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
CHELSEA K. HAND FROM SAN DIEGO
AND I AM IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS RIDER I LIVE IN
ANAHEIM CALIFORNIA AND I'M HERE
FROM MY UNCLE CHAD THAT PASSED
AWAY FROM THAT SCENE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
HELLOMY NAME IS AS MILDER FROM
ANAHEIM CALIFORNIA I'M A
BUSINESS OWNER.
AND I'M A MOTHER OF TWO AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THAT
VIOLATES OUR CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT YES.
HI MY NAME IS ANGELA I'M A
PEDIATRIC ARE AN I AM A MOTHER
OF THE VACCINE INJURED CHILD
THAT WAS INJURED ON HIS THIRTY
NIGHT DOSE OF VACCINES.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE MY SON
LOSING HIS RIGHT TO SCHOOL BY
THIS BILL.
HI ASSEMBLY HEALTH MY NAME IS
GLEN FROM ORANGE COUNTY AND I'M
A MOTHER.
TO DAUGHTER OF TO MEASLES
SURVIVORS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL PLEASE ABSTAINED
PLEASE.
THANK YOU.
HI DOCTOR PAN.
MY NAME IS CHRISTINA ACHEN ST%
I'M FROM HUNTINGTON BEACH
CALIFORNIA I'M THE DAUGHTER OF
AN IMMIGRANT WHO FLED A
COMMUNIST DICTATORSHIP NOT TO
COME TO ANOTHER ONE AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS TAINA
BAGLEY I AM A SPECIAL EDUCATION
ADVOCATE AND EDUCATOR IN ROCKLIN
CALIFORNIA.
I'M ALSO THE MOTHER OF A VACCINE
INJURED CHILD AND I OPPOSE THIS.
MY NAME IS MICHAEL BASICALLY I
AM FROM ROCKLAND I'M A FATHER OF
TWO FACTS SEEN INJURED CHILDREN
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MARIA RIVERA FROM YOUR BELINDA
REPRESENTING MY LAW ENFORCEMENT
FAMILY AND OUR TWO DAUGHTERS WHO
SUFFERED ANAPHYLACTIC ALLERGIC
REACTION.
I'M ALSO REPRESENTING WE DID
VACCINE INJURED FAMILIES WHO
HAVE BEEN MEDICALLY BULLIED AND
POLITICALLY CENSORED BY HAND AND
IN THE BACKS COLD.
WE OPPOSE THANKS I'M GOT THE
BILL.
MY NAME IS HEIDI GLAZER FROM THE
SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA I'M A
MOTHER OF A TWENTY EIGHT WEEK
PREMATURE BABIES.
I'M HERE REPRESENTING TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF OTHER PREMATURE
BABIES AND THEIR PARENTS THEY'VE
BEEN VACCINE INJURED AND THEY
ARE NOT ALLOWED TO SUE THE
GOVERNMENT TO THE STATE OR
ANYBODY I REPRESENT THE
CONSTITUTION OF HELLO MY NAME IS
DAN CARNEY -- FROM NEWPORT BEACH
CALIFORNIA I RESPECTFULLY I WISH
THAT ALL OF YOU GUYS FIND THE
COMMON GROUND.
MY NAME'S MELISSA KEELER OF FROM
SACRAMENTO COUNTY I'M A
RESPIRATORY THERAPIST AND A
MOTHER AND A WIFE OF THE VACCINE
INJURED HUSBAND AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS FELICIA WOFFORD
I AM A NATIVE CALIFORNIAN I'M
FROM LONG BEACH CALIFORNIA I
HAVE A MEDICALLY FRAGILE --
DAUGHTER WITH A HEART DEFECT TO
OPEN HEART SURGERY AND I
ABSOLUTELY OPPOSE THIS BILL AND
I HOPE THAT ALL OF YOU DO.
TOO MY NAME IS JESSE I AM A
NANNY FROM LOS ANGELES -- I AM A
GOOD GENERATION ANGELINO I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AND
OUR FORM OF FUNDED GOVERNMENT.
HELLO MY NAME IS DAVID BALL FROM
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA -- WHEN
LOOKING AT THE LANGUAGE OF --
DOCTOR PANTS BILL HE ADMITS THAT
SOME CHILDREN WILL BE INJURED I
THINK WE SHOULD FIND A WAY TO TO
PROTECT THOSE CHILL AT A TIME.
IT'S NOT.
HI MY NAME IS CAMERON MALL AND I
ABSOLUTELY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
JUST GOT A CANON TELLO FROM SAN
JOSE.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL AND PAN
IN TO STOP LYING.
HI MY NAME IS MARGIE DEFELICE A
PHYSICIAN ASSISTANT IN A
CALIFORNIA LICENSED MIDWIFE AND
AYE OPPOSED SB TWO SEVEN SIX
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SUSAN PELICAN LIMóN
ARE AND FROM WOODLAND CALIFORNIA.
I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
I MEAN I JACKSON I OPPOSE THIS
DANGEROUS BILL [inaudible]
MOM.
TRISH SEWN MOM MSW I OPPOSE THIS
BILL I DO NOT CONSENT.
HI MY NAME IS CAROLINE YOUNGER --
FROM ALBANY CALIFORNIA PLEASE
VOTE NO ON SB TWO SEVEN SIX
THANK YOU.
HI I'M JOY JOHNSON FROM
PLEASANTON CALIFORNIA OF MOTHER
BUSINESS OWNER AND I'M HERE
REPRESENTING HUNDREDS OF
MILITARY FAMILIES THAT RESIDE IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS LEASES A POT I
REPRESENT MY VACCINE INJURED
EMMA IMMUNO COMPROMISED FAMILY I
AM A WIDOW.
I AM ANGEL MOMS.
I AM AN EDUCATOR I AM A
CONSTITUENT OF ROB BONTA.
OUR CHILDREN WENT TO SCHOOL
TOGETHER AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JAMIE WHITE I'M FROM
SAN RAMON CALIFORNIA.
I AM A LICENSED MARRIAGE AND
FAMILY THERAPISTS AND
CREDENTIALED SCHOOL COUNSELOR
MOTHER OF TWO I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS SERRA AND THE GUY
I'M FROM CARMEL I'M A MOTHER OF
THREE I AM VERY VERY VERY MUCH
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
IT HURTS OUR FAMILY.
MY NAME IS JACQUELINE I'M A
DISTRICT -- SEVEN AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL HI CAN.
MY NAME IS KERRY BERMAN I'M FROM
CAMARILLO CALIFORNIA I'VE BEEN A
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER
FOR THIRTY SIX YEARS.
I AM A MOTHER OF TWO A
GRANDMOTHER OF FOUR AND HE
OPPOSE THE SPELL.
MY NAME IS SERRA GREGSON I AM
FROM CARMICHAEL CALIFORNIA AND
THE MOTHER OF FOUR ONE VACCINE
INJURED I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
I'M PULVER I'M A RETIRED.
DO D. EMPLOYEE A VACCINATED ONE
AT THAT.
WHO HAD MONTHS AND MEASLES THANK
YOU
AND I OPPOSE A SINGLE THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS LAUREN ANDERSON
I'M A SPECIAL EDUCATOR.
I'M A MASTER'S DEGREE STUDENT IN
A STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME'S MEREDITH FITZ
GERALD FROM NAPA CALIFORNIA AND
THE BUSINESS OWNER AND IT
PROFESSIONAL MOTHER OF TWO AND A
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS GREG FITZ
GERALD FROM NAPA CALIFORNIA I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS BARBARA FARLEY OF
SANTA ROSA CALIFORNIA I'M A
MOTHER OF TWO MY HUSBAND IS A
DISABLED COMBAT VETERAN HE
FOUGHT FOR MEDICAL FREEDOM WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS VICTORIA AND I'M A
MOTHER OF TWO AND I'M AN
EDUCATOR AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS FASCIST BILL.
MY NAME IS ANGELA JOHNSON I POSE
THIS BILL IT'S STILL IN THERE.
MY NAME IS NINETY SEVEN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
BECAUSE MY DAUGHTER CAM.
MY NAME IS ELIZABETH SOMEWHERE
I'M FROM MADERA CALIFORNIA AND
I'M A MOTHER TO FOR ONE CHILD
THAT WAS NEVER THE SAME AFTER
RECEIVING VACCINES.
I STRONGLY STRONGLY OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
YES MY NAME IS NICHOLS Là
MORILLO FROM MADERA COUNTY AND I
AM A BUSINESS OWNER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
HERE I AM A CHILD OF THE LIVING
GOD WHO IS HERE AND IS WATCHING
AND I ALSO REPRESENT THE MOTHERS
OF AMERICA WHO HAVE BEEN A WEEK
INTO THE DANGERS OF VACCINES AND
I AM A MAMA BEAR.
AND I'M HERE TO OPPOSE SB.
TWO HI MY NAME IS STEPHANIE HER
SKIN FIRMER SAID CALIFORNIA I AM
AN INFORMED MOTHER PLEASE A POLL
DEMOCRACY TODAY I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS FASCIST BILL.
MY NAME IS CURRENTLY IRISH THE
MOTHER OF FOUR AND I'M FROM OUT
WATER CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS TRACY ALLEN I'M A
MOTHER OF THREE BEAUTIFUL
CHILDREN I AM AN EDUCATOR AND I
AM SO PROUD TO STAND HERE TODAY
AND TELL YOU SENATOR PAN.
THAT WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS AMANDA PENNY ON
SHORE ALSO -- THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT
YOU.
VOTE NO ON THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JIMMY I'M ALSO HERE
ON BEHALF OF MY FATHER REDEEMING
WHO HOLDS A PHD IN MICROBIOLOGY
WE ARE TENEMENT SQUARE REFUGEES
AND NATURALIZED CITIZENS AND WE
BOTH OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JULIE MEAN OF
CUPERTINO CALIFORNIA I'M A
CONSTITUENT OF MARC BERMAN AND I
ALSO OPPOSE THIS BILL AS A
MOTHER OF TWO IMMUNO CLINICALLY
IMMUNO COMPROMISED CHILDREN
THANK YOU.
IF.
MY NAME IS MY ROUNDED OUT THE
FROM KINGS FOR CALIFORNIA.
MOTHER OF TWO I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS KATHY SCAMPERED DO A
LOT AND MOTHER IN SAN FRANCISCO
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HI I'M MICHELLE TRAINER A
BUSINESS OWNER FROM DISTRICT
ELEVEN AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOU TO OPPOSE SB TWO SEVEN SIX
THANK YOU.
IN THE FAMILY DISTRICT ELEVEN I
AM AN EDUCATOR AND A PARENT AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK.
SB TWO SEVEN SIX THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS NICOLAS SOMEONE
AND I HAVE [inaudible]
COMING DOWNSTAIRS.
MY NAME IS SERRA HAIL AND I'M
THE MOTHER OF TWO VACCINE
INJURED CHILDREN WHO ARE NOW
ADULTS.
AND I OPPOSE THIS LEGISLATION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MELISSA BOND FELL
FROM LOOMIS CALIFORNIA I IN THE
MOTHER TO THESE THREE HEALTHY
AND BEAUTIFUL CHILDREN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS KATHERINE BALL THE
I'M FROM ALAMEDA COUNTY AND WE
CAN IN THE CONSTITUENCY OF ROB
BONTA WHO HAS REFUSED TO LISTEN
TO US I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
HI MY NAME IS LISA JENKINS FROM
SACRAMENTO AND A CONSTITUENT OF
SENATOR PAN I AM VACCINE INJURED
MYSELF -- THERE'S ABSOLUTELY NO
EVIDENCE OF ANY FRAUDULENT
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS HAVING BEEN
WRITTEN AND I OPPOSE THIS.
HELLO MY NAME IS ALIDA WICKS AND
I AM A RESIDENT OF SACRAMENTO.
AND AS AN EARLY EDUCATION CHILD
DEVELOPMENT SPECIALIST ACTIVIST
FOR MEDICAL FREEDOM AND SINCE IN
A FREE COUNTRY I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS CHARITY MILLER I
AM A FULL TIME WORKING MOM OF
TWO CHILDREN.
IF THEY ARE DENIED EDUCATION I
WILL BE FORCED TO TAKE MY JOB
AND MY SIGNIFICANT TAX DOLLARS.
HELLO MY NAME IS GRETA MCAULIFFE
AND I'M FROM DISTRICT.
SEVENTY FOUR I AM A MOTHER OF
TWO CHILDREN ONE IS VACCINE
INJURED.
I AM A NURSE AND A MOTHER INFANT
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONAL AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M MICHAEL MILLER OF
DUBLIN CALIFORNIA -- I'M NOT
EXCEEDING YOUR FORTUNE AND ALSO
FATHER -- TO AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI I'M CLAUDETTE COGAN OUR FROM
DISTRICT ELEVEN FAQ AVAIL I'M A
MIDWIFE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS JULIETT HOBAN I'M
A PARENT WHO IS HAD ADVERSE
REACTIONS AND MOTHER TO THREE
CHILDREN WHO HAVE HAD FIRST
REACTIONS I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
HELLO MY NAME IS MONIQUE NO GM
FROM DISTRICT TEN PETALUMA
CALIFORNIA.
I WORK IN SKILLED NURSING AND
THERAPY I ASK YOU GUYS TO COME
CAN RECONSIDER AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AND I PRAY FOR YOU EVERYDAY PAN.
KELLY MY GRAPH NAPA CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
GABRIEL BIRD FROM PETALUMA
CALIFORNIA I'M A STUDENT AT A
JUNIOR HIGH SCHOOL AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL FOR MY
EDUCATION.
MY NAME IS MELISSA I'M FROM
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA I AM A
MOTHER OF ONE A FORMER NURSE.
AND NO MEDICAL PROCEDURE SHOULD
EVER BE MANDATORY IN A FREE
SOCIETY THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS GALINA I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS EVA I'M A MOTHER A
GRANDMOTHER A PHARMACIST AND A
BUSINESS OWNER AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES.
AROUND THE ROCK -- FROM LOS
ANGELES CALIFORNIA I'M A PARENT
AND BUSINESS OWNER I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AND GOVERNMENT
OVER REACH.
HI I'M GILBERT GOOD HEART AND I
OPPOSE.
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MAYA I'M AN IMMIGRANT
FROM THE FORMER COMMUNIST SOVIET
UNION AYE MAN -- CONSTITUENTS
CENTER PAN AND A STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS TOO MUCH NOT
TOO FAR I AM A FATHER OF THREE I
COME FROM A COMMUNIST COUNTRY
WERE SIMILAR LAWS WERE MADE AND
I CAME HERE TO FIND FREEDOM.
IN THIS LOW IS UNAMERICAN THANK
YOU.
I AM GRANDMA LARA.
AND I JUST WANNA SAY ONE
STATEMENT.
IMMUNE SYSTEMS ARE PRIVATE
PROPERTY PROTECTED BY THE FOURTH
AMENDMENT.
JUST YOUR NAME AND POSITION AN
ORGANIZATION TO MIGHT REPRESENT
PLEASE LET ME LIKE NINETY OF I'M
A NURSE AND I'M ALSO A MOTHER OF
TWO HEALTHY UNVACCINATED KIDS.
AND I DO NOT SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ROSE I LIVE IN
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA THEY JUST
URGE YOU TO LISTEN TO THE
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE THAT ARE
SHOWING UP -- TO OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU.
I AM LUDMILLA LE GETTING YAK
RESIDENTS SACRAMENTO I AM FORCES
IS A BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS DANIEL MARGEN HAMMER
I'M A MOTHER PROTECTOR OF MY
THREE CHILDREN.
PAN I'M PRAYING FOR YOUR SOUL.
HELLO MY NAME IS CALLED.
WHEN IN THE SCENE AND HE KEEPS
KINDA I AM BERENDT DONE BUSINESS
OVER THERE I'M STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL IT'S DISCRIMINATION
AND GAZED DISABLED AND INTERPRET
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS LOUIS ON MOTHER I'M A
REGISTERED NURSE IN THE ER AND
OPPOSES BILL.
MY NAME A SOLAR T. SECOND FROM
THE BAY AREA OF BELMONT I WAS
THE HEAD OF HOUSEHOLD SINGLE
MOTHER.
I WOULD STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS RIA MARIANO I'M
NERVOUS I LIVE IN SACRAMENTO
DISTRICTS SIX IN A OPPOSE THE
BILL.
I AM JACKSON AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL BECAUSE I'D LIKE.
SCHOOL.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS BECAUSE THE I
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO SPELL I LOVE
TO GO TO SCHOOL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS CRYSTAL SO VAL I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB TWO SEVEN SIX
I'M A MOTHER OF THREE CHILDREN
THREE HEALTHY CHILDREN.
AND I REALLY HOPE TO KEEP THEM
HEALTHY.
HI SHELLEY MORE FROM THE MISS
CALIFORNIA A MOTHER OF THREE AND
DON'T BELIEVE THE STATE SHOULD
DECIDE WHAT GETS INJECTED INTO
MY CHILDREN EXPERIENCE.
MY NAME IS AMY I AM A MOTHER OF
TWO AND I OWN A LICENSED DAYCARE.
I AM CONCERNED LIMITING THE
NUMBER OF MEDICAL EXAM THE
DOCTOR CAME RIGHT.
A YEAR BEFORE I BECAME.
NAME IS JENNIFER BORE BAY I AM
FROM SANTA CRUZ COUNTY APTOS AND
I AM HERE IN OPPOSITION OF SB
TWO SEVEN SIX FROM MY DAUGHTER
BROOKLYN.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS SERRA --
CONSTITUENT OF HEATH FLORA.
I'M THE MOTHER OF THREE TWO FAX
NEEDED AT ONE VACCINE INJURED
CHILD.
I BEG YOU TO PLEASE.
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME SENIOR MOMENTS OVER
AND I OPPOSE SB.
TWO SEVEN SIX AS IT FINALLY IF
THE CONSTITUTION AND MY WRITING.
TO HI MY NAME IS ELIZABETH LEVIN
ALL I AM THE MOTHER OF TO
VACCINATE THEIR CHILDREN ONE WHO
HAS SPEECH DELAYS AND ANOTHER
ONE WHO HAS AN M. TEACHER FOR
GENE MUTATION CANNOT DETOX.
VACCINE CHEMICALS.
THANK YOU HI MY NAME IS
MARGARITA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ALL THERE THE
MARTINEZ AND I OPPOSE SB TWO
SEVEN SIX THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JULIA TO MY FAVOR I'M
ON A TWO AND A STRONGLY OPPOSES
BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS NATE THEN AND I'M
A FATHER OF TO HELP THE CHILDREN
AND I AM A BUSINESS OWNER IN LOS
ANGELES AND I STRONGLY STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THEY CARE ARE HIGHLY DELAY KAREN
AND AND I'LL GIVE.
WELL.
THANK YOU.
ADULTS WE WE JUST ASK THE
PARENTS TO SPEAK PLEASE.
DO YOU WANT TO FINISH.
HI MY NAME IS THERESA BURNELL
AND WE HAVE THREE HEALTHY
AMAZING CHILDREN.
AND WE JUST WANT TO OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
JUST ONCE AGAIN LIKE GAS AT THE
ADULTS TO SPEAK PLEASE.
HI MY NAME IS CHRISTINA MA'AM
FROM GRAND A CALIFORNIA --
MECHANICAL ENGINEER MASTER'S
DEGREE IN THAT ANALYSIS.
I DIDN'T USED TO BE SCARED OF
AXING.
NOW AFTER EIGHTEEN YEARS.
I THANK YOU.
PLEASE.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MELISSA SARITA I AM A
FIFTH GRADE SCHOOL TEACHER IN
CALIFORNIA AND I DOES THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR CARI ALLEN
HAMMER I AM A CONSTITUENT OF
KEVIN MCCARTY IS AND SENATOR PAN
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
WHICH IS.
A SOUND SINCE.
THREE POLICIES.
ONCE AGAIN WE JUST ASK FOR THE
ADULTS TO TESTIFY PLEASE.
HI MY NAME IS MELODY ANDERSON
AYE LIVING GOING ON CALIFORNIAN
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU NAME IS DARCY WOMACK
I'M A MOTHER FOR CHILDREN TO
ABORTION AXING INTER.
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS AMBER FROM CINEMA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS TONY WOMACK FATHER
FOR OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI I'M JENNIFER LIAM FROM GLEN
ELLYN I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
A MARK MARK TAYLOR FROM CINEMA
CALIFORNIA -- WITH ZERO EVIDENCE
YOU OF FRAUDULENT MEDICALLY
EXEMPTION.
HI MY NAME IS SIERRA SWENSON AG
GRADUATED FROM UC BERKELEY A
LIVE IN THE BAY AREA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HEY MY NAME IS WINDOW RAN FROM
SNOW WITH COUNTY AND PER THE
UNESCO DECLARATION ON BIO ETHICS
AND INFORMED CONSENT.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS TERRA LIVINGSTON I'M
FROM WEST MORAN FROM THE MOTHER
OF TWO AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE
SPELL.
I'M SHELTON LIVINGSTON.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
I'M CARE GRAYSON REDDING
CALIFORNIA THIS IS AN OVER REACH
OF GOVERNMENT AYE OPPOSED.
MY NAME IS RAINY HALF FROM
BEVERLY HILLS CALIFORNIA AND I
THINK PEOPLE'S LIVES AND MONEY
THANKS JOHN.
I'M DR OSBORNE FROM NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND ON BEHALF OF ALL
OF MY PATIENTS I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AND MY SON WHO'S
HANDICAP BECAUSE OF IT.
HI MY NAME IS OLGA FOND OF
MOTHER OF TWO AND I ASK YOU TO
PLEASE OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS JOSHUA FROM DISTRICT.
FORTY I AM A CHICKEN POX AND
MEASLES SURVIVOR AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS BARBARA I'M FROM
DISTRICT.
FORTY MR ROMMEL'S PLEASE.
TO DO NOT SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JUDY I'M FROM
SACRAMENTO I'M A MILITARY
VETERAN AND I WAS BACK SEEN
ENTER THE MILITARY I ALSO HAVE
AN EIGHT YEAR OLD GRANDSON.
WHO IS VACCINE INJURED AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL BILL?
HI MY NAME IS ZERO MASON FROM EL
DORADO COUNTY ON BEHALF OF MY
SON WHO WILL LOSE HIS EXEMPTION
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO I'M I'M JULIANA CARMEN
FROM CINEMA COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
I'M TELEGRAPH.
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA MOTHER OF
FIVE ONE VACCINE INJURED.
GRANDMOTHER TO TO AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS LISA CLING AND I'M
A NURSE I'VE WORKED IN THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT FOR EIGHT YEARS
AND WE SEE NO EVIDENCE OF FRAUD
IT AT ALL I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS LES LIKE CATS AND THE
MOTHER OF A VACCINE INJURED SON
DEMOCRATS BELIEVE WOMEN
[inaudible]
LEAVE US [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS PREVIEW IN NAPA
COUNTY MOTHER OF FOUR CHILDREN
WHO ARE SIX GENERATION TO NAPA
COUNTY.
I OPPOSE THIS BILL ASK YOUR
NEIGHBOR WHEN THEY HI I'M
BRIANNA I'M FROM FOLSOM I OPPOSE
THIS BILL AND THEY'RE COMING
AFTER YOU NEXT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS NATALIE RASH I AM
A RESIDENT OF GRANITE BAY
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUENT OF KEVIN
KILEY MOTHER OF TWO COLLEGE
PROFESSOR AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
I'M MARYLAND -- AND FREDDIE FOR
MERCED AND MOTHER OF THREE
GRANDMOTHER OF SEVEN A RETIRED
TEACHER HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI I'M STEPHANIE GONZALEZ A
CONSTITUENT OF SENATOR PAN AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KEN COOLEY AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI I'M LIZ HOW AGAIN MOTHER OF
THREE BUSINESS OWNER.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
OPPRESSION IS WRONG STOP HUNTING
OUR KIDS.
HI MY NAME IS LISA LOPEZ I'M
FROM ELK GROVE CALIFORNIA I'M A
MOTHER TO ONE CHILD.
AND THE SISTER TO AN AUTISTIC
BROTHER AND MEDICALLY FRAGILE
SIBLINGS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS SHAWNA NICOLAY AND
FROM SANTA CRUZ CALIFORNIA THE
MOTHER OF TWO REGISTERED NURSE
FOR OVER TEN YEARS.
BOARD CERTIFIED MY SPECIALTY
WHICH IS LABOR AND DELIVERY AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS NOT A LINDA AND I
LIVE IN SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA I
MEAN UNVACCINATED ADULTS AND A
MOTHER AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS TRAVIS AND FROM
SANTA CRUZ CALIFORNIA FATHER OF
TWO AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS IRENE A PACK OUN I
AM FROM SACRAMENTO COUNTY I'M A
MOTHER OF TWO AND I URGE YOU TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
YOUR HAND IS LYING.
HI MY NAME IS JESSICA FREEMAN
I'M A REGISTERED NURSE I'M A
MOTHER OF THREE AND I URGE YOU
TO OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ANA TELL.
TEN I AM A MOTHER OF TWO FROM
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS MERRIAM SINGER I'M
A BUSINESS OWNER AND A MOTHER OF
THREE I FLEW IN TODAY FROM SAN
DIEGO TO SUPPORT MEDICALLY
FRAGILE CHILDREN I'M AND BACKS
ADULTS AND I'M A FREEDOM KEEPER
PLEASE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JENNIFER I'M AWARE OF
SAN DIEGO I'M A BUSINESS OWNER
AND A MOTHER OF TWO AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ARIANNA -- FROM
OXNARD CALIFORNIA IN A STRONGLY
OPPOSES ON UNCONSTITUTIONAL BILL.
MY NAME IS NEEDS THE JENSEN FROM
SAN DIEGO CALIFORNIA I AM A
BUSINESS OWNER TO TOO MUCH AND I
HAVE TWO CHILDREN AND WHERE
THERE IS RISK THERE MUST BE
CONSENT.
I WILL NOT FORCE ANYTHING IT'S
MY CHILD'S BODY GOES THEN WELL
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS GILLIAN I'M FROM
NORTHERN CANNOT CALIFORNIA IN
THE NINETEEN HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONAL MOTHER.
TWO WANNA VACCINE INJURED
DISABLED CHILD I'VE SPENT THE
LAST SEVEN YEARS RECOVERING IT'S
BEEN AND HUNDREDS OF THOUSAND
DOLLARS. ONE I'M VACCINE HEALTHY
CHILD I STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL
AND SUNDAY GOD WITH YOU YOUR
DOCTOR AND YOU.
MY NAME IS VICTORIA I AM VACCINE
INJURED I'M A MOTHER OF FOUR AND
I DO BELIEVE THAT SB TWO SEVEN
SIX IS RATE I STRONGLY OPPOSE
YOU.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME SIERRA PILOT I'M FROM
GRASS VALLEY AND I'M A FUTURE
MOTHER AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS SAMANTHA SANTI STEVAN.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S TRAVIS SEDAM I'M FROM
GRASS VALLEY CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
I THANK MY NAME IS JULIA
MCGINNIS I OWN TWO BUSINESSES IN
SACRAMENTO AND I ALSO HAVE TWO
CHILDREN THAT HAVE THE IN.
AND TO CANNOT DETOX.
AND YOU SHOULD.
HELLO I'M JENNIFER RILEY FROM EL
DORADO COUNTY AND A MOTHER OF
ONE INTO YOUR FOR A BUSINESS
OWNER.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
I ALSO OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS BETHANY I AM A
TEACHER WHO LISTENED JACQUI
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THE
SPELL.
MY NAME IS THE FINAL VEGA -- A
FATHER FOR ALL THIS CHILD --
SUFFER A VACCINE INJURY ON THE
DETACHED -- I CHOOSE NOT TO HAVE
MOTHER CHOSE LAKE SWELLED UP
LIKE A BALLOON BECAUSE YOU.
THINK IT'S SAFE FOR THEM THANK
YOU I STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
MY NAME IS ANGELIC MENDEZ I AM A
MOTHER AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES
BILL.
I'M ANGELA MERYL AND I MOTHER TO
THIS LITTLE SUNSHINE AND THEN
FROM REDDING CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS BRIAN MENDEZ FOR
TRUCK CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS YOU COULD SIT
IN THE SUCH COOL I'M FROM WEST
SACRAMENTO I MOTHER OF TWO KIDS
AND I'M STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL [inaudible]
YEAH.
HI IRAN AN HERBAL SCHEIMER
SHASTA COUNTY I'M A LICENSED
ACUPUNCTURIST AND A MOTHER AND
I'M AGAINST THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME DE SUMA FACE THAT
SCORE I AM FROM WEST SACRAMENTO
I FIND THE TWO KEYS -- I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THESE BILLS WILL
BE GREAT FOR YOU.
HI AND JUST GO WILL BORN IN FROM
EL DORADO HILLS LIMóN KEVIN
KILEY IS DISTRICT AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES SPELL I BELIEVE FARMING
NEEDS TO BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
I'M SHEILA RICHARD SOME FROM
CINEMA COUNTY A RETIRED
REGISTERED NURSE SUPPLY.
CHILD OF TWO MEASLES SURVIVORS
AND I REPRESENT NINE OF THE
FAMILIES WHO COULDN'T MAKE IT
HERE AND WE LL OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS MARIAH STANLEY AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ANGELA BERGESEN
FROM WINDSOR CALIFORNIA I'M A
MOTHER OF MY DAUGHTER MIA AND
I'M AN EDUCATOR AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS DRACONIAN BILL I AM
PRAYING FOR EACH AND EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF YOU GOD BLESS YOU
RICHARD PAN THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS STEPHANIE STANLEY I'M
FROM BACK OF BILL AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS BRINA SAMMER
CALIFORNIA AND THE FATHER THREE
GIRLS IN A RETIRED MARINE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS DANA POMPEII -- I'M
FROM PACIFICA CALIFORNIA AND I'M
A FIREFIGHTER IN SAN FRANCISCO
AND THREE BOYS ONE VACCINE
INJURED LIKE STRONGLY OPPOSES.
HELLO MY NAME IS ELAINE I
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK.
HI MY NAME'S ANGEL PRESS I'M
FROM JUDGE OF THE CALIFORNIA I'M
A BUSINESS OWNER -- FATHER OF
THREE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES
BILL.
HI MY NAME IS MELANIE I'M FROM
PACIFICA CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME'S LISA PRESENT FROM
CHURCHILL A CALIFORNIA -- IT'S
NOT ONE IN A MILLION AND I WILL.
HI MY NAME IS RINA FONG I'M A
BIOCHEMIST AT A TOP
PHARMACEUTICAL COMPANY AND AFTER
THOUSANDS OF HOURS OF RESEARCH I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO I'M READY TO COOLEY FROM
PALO ALTO CONSTITUENT OF MARC
BERMAN AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES
BILLS WELL THANK YOU.
HI AM PATSY LEGAL SMELL MOTHER
BY VACCINE INJURED SON ALSO A
MOTHER OF A TAXIING FREE HEALTHY
DAUGHTER WHAT COULD POSSIBLY BE
THE DIFFERENCE [inaudible]
THIS BILL.
LUCAS ETS FATHER TO FROM
SAUSALITO AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
SUSAN L<c.cyan>G FAIR OAKS I HAVE</c>
TWO CHILDREN I'M OPPOSED SENATOR
PAN IF THIS PASSES I WOULD.
HI MY NAME IS SVETLANA I'M FROM
SACRAMENTO AND I'M.
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S MEGHAN COURAGE SO I
LIVE IN MID TOWN HI EDUCATE MY
KIDS OUT OF THE STATE BECAUSE OF
THIS BILL AND OTHERS I STRONGLY.
OPPOSE.
TWO SEVENTY SIX HI EMILY SFE AND
CODY I'M A MOTHER OF SIX I
OVERCAME CANCER NATURALLY
WITHOUT PUTTING HARSH TOXINS IN
MY BODY.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
I WANT MY CHILDREN TO LIVE THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS ERIN MASSING GAIL
WALNUT CREEK I'M A CLINICAL
HERBALIST AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS BELLA CODY I'M A
STUDENT AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES.
RACHEL WHEN MEYER SAID AMOUNT
CALIFORNIA IS STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL I DO NOT CONSENT.
HI MY NAME IS HOLLY SKY AMP.
CELLS AND HERE'S THE FOR THOSE
WHO NO LONGER HAVE A VOICE TO
THE VACCINATION.
HELLO MY NAME IS PAULA HIS AWSKI
I'M WITH EMPOWER FAMILIES THE
CALIFORNIAN EDUCATE ADVOCATE I
AM THE MOTHER TO THAT SCENE IN
YOUR CHILDREN I AM A SCHOOL
TEACHER.
AND YOU WILL NOT COME BETWEEN.
HI MY NAME THE LASER NAME IN
YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL PLEASE
HI MY NAME IS MILLION AS A FAN
I'M SIXTEEN UNVACCINATED AND AYE
OPPOSED.
MY NAME IS MATTHEW RE COR AND
THIS BILL WILL FORCE ME TO LET
GO OF THE EMPLOYEES FOR THE
THREE COMPANIES THAT ARE RUN YOU.
THANK YOU JUST AYE OPPOSED THANK
YOU JUST TO NAME A BECAUSE I'M
BORING HURTS FROM ORANGEVILLE
CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF OF MY
FUTURE FAMILY AND THESE FAMILIES
I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI AND THE JOURNEY IS A THIRTEEN
YEAR OLD HONOR STUDENT OF THE
COSTA COUNTY AREA.
pIT'S TAKING AWAY MY MEDICAL
EXEMPTION.
HI MY NAME IS A LEASE HAZARD
FROM CALIFORNIA AND THE MOTHER
OF TWO WITH MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS
PLEASE DO NOT DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST MEDICALLY FRAGILE.
HELLO MY NAME IS NATALIE AND
SOME FROM PLASTER COUNTY BORN
AND RAISED IN SAN DIEGO YOU SEE
GRADUATE AND THIS WOULD TAKE
AWAY MY TWO KIDS MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS I DO NOT I OPPOSE.
HI MY NAME IS.
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA AND BECAUSE
I LOVE MY CHILDREN AND EVERYONE
CHILDREN I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS LUDMILLA TELETOON
AND I AM A MOTHER OF TWO I'M
FROM SACRAMENTO.
AND I CAME TO UNITED STATES FOR
FREEDOM AND I DO.
VALUE FREEDOM WE ARE NOT CHINA
WE'RE NOT NORTH
. TO JUST TO NAME
A POSITION ON THE BILL PLEASE.
HI MY NAME IS ANDREAS AN ALOE
WE'RE I'M A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER
I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB TWO SEVEN
SIX THANK YOU CONSTITUENTS.
ON TOP THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS AMY PURCELL --
FROM MARIPOSA -- PLEASE OPPOSE
THIS BILL OF MY DAUGHTER GOT
VACCINE MEASLES WAS SICK FOR TWO
WEEKS BUT SHE DOESN'T NOW HAVE
NATURAL IMMUNITY PRES.
JUST TO NAME A POSITION PLEASE
RACHEL GREEN FRIENDLY CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY.
THANK YOU.
MANY WELL I AM A MOTHER OF THREE
AND I OPPOSE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AMY OSEM FROM CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS TANYA GOING GO AND
I'M SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
SOCIOLOGY.
OF FATHER CONCERNED FATHER AND
UNCLE TO AN INJURED CHILD PLASE
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
I POSES BELL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS VICTORIA SO ISSUE
DOWN ON MOTHER OF TWO KIDS ON OP
CLOSED HIS BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS VICTOR SUCH AS
FATHER OF THREE A HUMAN BEING
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS A ON A SIGN SAYS
I'M THE FUTURE AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
HI MY NAME IS SKYLER BRIGHT THE
MOTHER OF TWO NEVADA CITY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ANDREA CONTEST
FROM ALLEY COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS MARI ABELARD AND
FROM GRASS VALLEY CALIFORNIA I'M
A BUSINESS OWNER AND MOTHER.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
HI MY NAME IS G. A. L. SON KIDS
AND I AM PROCESS.
THANK YOU JUST SIT DOES PLEASE.
MY NAME IS ALICIA COOLEY AND I
OPPOSE THE SPELL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS TINY BIT NEAR I AM A
REGISTERED NURSE IN THE CBA CEO
AND A Q..
AND A MOTHER I AND EIGHT WIFE OF
A RETIRED MARINE CORPS OFFICER
IN A STRONG PLEA THEN IMMENSELY
OPPOSE THE SMELL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS RACHEL MCDONALD
FROM COSTA COUNTY I'VE TO
VACCINE INJURED CHILDREN AND ONE
HEALTHY I'M BACK.
A CLEAR THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS TO MARRY ROMAN
FROM SAN JOSE I'M A MOTHER OF
FIVE WHICH I HOME SCHOOL.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI I'M CINDY ROSADA I'VE BEEN AN
EDUCATOR WITH SPECIAL NEEDS FOR
ALMOST TWENTY YEARS I'VE SEEN
THE HISTORY OF AUTISM PLEASE
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS JOSH ARAMBULA
FROM SAN JOSE CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE HIS BILL.
I'M DO NEED TO LEON FROM KAREN
PARK I'M A MOTHER AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU -- GIOVANNI
ROMAN FROM SAN JOSE AND I HOPE.
TO HEAR.
MY NAME IS CARLY ROSE OUT I'M A
PEDIATRIC OCCUPATIONAL THERAPIST
FROM ORANGE REEL CALIFORNIA AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS JULIE THE PENCIL
AND I'M FROM SAN JOSE CALIFORNIA
AND I SUDDENLY.
OPPOSES.
MY NAME IS HEIDI WOULD FROM FOR
SOME CALIFORNIA MOTHER OF FOUR
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MARY WILL MAKE A NICE
TRUCK.
MY NAME IS THEIR HAIR SAN I FLEW
UP FOR THE THIRD TIME IN TWO
MONTHS BECAUSE I OPPOSE THIS
BILL WITH EVERY CELL OF MY BEING
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JOHN THE ROMAN FROM
SAN JOSE AND OPPOSES BILL.
WHEN HE WAS A HONDA AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL I CHALLENGE YOU TO THE
RIGHT THING THANK YOU?
MY NAME'S VENEMAN SO I'M SAN
JOSE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
Q..
MY NAME IS CYNTHIA GILLETTE I'M
A MOTHER OF TWO CHILDREN AND I'M
A BUSINESS OWNER I LIVE IN SAN
RAFAEL CALIFORNIA I'M HERE
REPRESENTING EIGHT OTHER
FAMILIES WHO COULDN'T BE HERE.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BROKEN
PROMISES THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS DOCTOR JOSEPH TO
LUNA I'M A LICENSED CHILD
PSYCHOLOGIST IN GRADUATE SCHOOL
PROFESSOR IN LA COUNTY.
I HIGHLY VALUE THE DOCTOR
PATIENT RELATIONSHIP WITH MY
CLIENTS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI MARYLAND HARLAN FROM FAIR
OAKS AN EDUCATOR GRANDMOTHER OF
FOUR AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
JENNIFER TO LUNA GARDEN GROVE
MOTHER OF TWO BOYS WHO WILL LOSE
THEIR MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS AT THIS
BILL PASSED.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
I'M ELEANOR AND I OPPOSE.
ADULTS ONLY PLEASE.
CAROL NELSON BY SO YEAH
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU -- MICHAEL
SO THAT MARIN COUNTY I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
JERRY BAKER FROM BY SAY
CALIFORNIAN I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MARINA CALLS OFTEN
ARE FROM SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
LISA SORTS DROVE HERE FROM KINGS
FOR CALIFORNIA TO OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME'S WINDY KIßM FROM
LINKIN I'M OF MOTHER OF THREE
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES.
HI MY NAME IS ANDREA WAYNE I'M
FROM STANTON CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CURTIS KATY I'M A
PROFESSOR OF CHEMISTRY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
RIGHT IN WAYNE FROM STAND A
CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US THANK
YOU.
HI AM HEATHER.
I CAN'T PAY YOU A BIG PHARMA --
BUT I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
OKAY -- I'M HERE REPRESENTING
MORE THAN A DOZEN FAMILIES WE
ALL OPPOSE THIS VERY.
IN JUST BILL.
HI MY NAME IS DANIEL WERFEL FROM
GARDEN GROVE CALIFORNIA MOTHER
OF THREE DOCTOR PHYSICAL THERAPY
TREATING CHRONIC ILLNESS AND
AUTOIMMUNITY I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME'S LATE FEE OKAY LEE
I'M BORN AND RAISED IN
SACRAMENTO I HAVE A VACCINE
INJURED CHILD THAT IS AT HOME.
AND IF THIS BILL PASSES I HAVE
NO OTHER CHOICE BUT TO LEAVE
CALIFORNIA.
MY NAME IS TONY WERE FULL AND I
HOPE YOU COME BACK AS A VACCINE
CHECK OUT HER CHILD.
MARY HUGGY JUST A REMINDER THAT
MORE THAN FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
HAS BEEN PAID FOR THANKS ANY
GEORGE FAMILY PLEASE DROP THIS
BILL.
AND WATER WITH YOUR CONSCIOUS
TODAY I BEG YOU.
THINK YOU WOULD ASK THAT PEOPLE
DIRECTOR COMMENTS TO THE BILL IN
YOUR POSITION.
AND NO ONE ELSE PLEASE.
MY NAME IS AMANDA QUINN TERO
FROM STOCKTON CALIFORNIA MOM OF
TO MY HUSBAND AND I BOTH
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
I KNOW MY NAME IS LESLIE
VIOLENCE WELL UP FROM OCEANSIDE
I'M A HOME EDUCATOR AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL.
MY NAME'S ANGEL IN US I'M HERE
WITH MY BROTHER AND MY MOM'S NOT
HERE BUT WE BUT WE ALWAYS POSES
BILL.
THANK YOU MY NAME'S ROCKY WILL
THIS.
AND SAYS.
THANK YOU ARE JUST JUST ADULTS
PLEASE.
MY NAME IS ERICA SCHOOL LET
ALONE I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
MANY MAIL ME TO LEAVE FROM
CARLSBAD CALIFORNIA I DROPPED MY
KIDS OFF AT SCHOOL THIS MORNING
AND HAD TO JUMP ON A PLANE TO
COME TELL YOU HOW STRONGLY
OPPOSE I AM TO THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JENNA FROM APPLEGATE
CALIFORNIA AND I'M HERE BECAUSE
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME'S JUSTIN THE TEARS
MOTOR THIS MY DAUGHTER MIA
MILLER WHERE FROM MISSION VIEJO
AND I ASK THAT YOU SAY NO TO
THIS BILL AND I OPPOSE IT THANK
YOU.
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
DIANA MEDIA FROM MERCED
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING MY
HUSBAND AND MY FAMILY STRONGLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU.
JENNIFER SEE LOS ROSEVILLE
CALIFORNIA MOTHER FOR AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
CLAUDIA FIGUEROA SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
EMILY HENDERSON OF ROSEVILLE
CALIFORNIA TEACHER MOTHER OF ONE
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY TIME CHASING
FIGURE OFF OTHER TOO STRONG.
KRISTIN CHILDREN'S FALLS IN
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL MOTHER FOR THANK YOU.
JESSICA DELYLAH MOTHER OF THREE
AND MY HUSBAND AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
LARA NORRIS FROM FAIR OAKS
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
DANA TANK HELL.
I AM A CHIROPRACTOR REPRESENTING
MY VACCINE INJURED CHILDREN --
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
JOHNNY NORRIS I OPPOSE THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CHRISTINE LANDERS AND
I AM A MOTHER OF TWO I REPRESENT
MANY FAMILIES FROM SAN JOSE
CALIFORNIA WHO COULDN'T MAKE IT
TODAY.
WE ALL STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
I'M KIRSTEN FLORES ON BEHALF OF
MY CHILDREN AND MY VACCINE
INJURED STEP SON I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. EIGHT ALSO
CONTROL CALIFORNIA HAVE CLOSE.
I'M LIVES MATTER AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB TWO SEVEN SIX THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS SANDY OLSSON I
REPRESENT CENTRAL VALLEY
ADVOCATES FOR PARENTAL RIGHTS
WERE A GROUP OF EIGHT HUNDRED
PARENTS IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
THAT ARE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL SB.
TWO SEVEN SIX WE OPPOSE.
I AM DOCTOR JANET HANSON
LIVERMORE CALIFORNIA STRONGLY
OPPOSE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS GINA AND I'M IN
OUR IN HOME FROM ROSEVILLE AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ARIANNA SYMONENKO AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS DESTINY ANDREESSEN
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS CHRISTINA WATSON AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE GRANDPARENT
MEDICALLY FRAGILE CHILDREN THANK.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH JUST
YOUR NAME AND YOUR AND IN WHAT
DO YOU OPPOSE I OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED TO INCLUDE LIABILITY IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS LAUREN TORRANCE
VERY DISTRICT NINE WITH JIM
COOPER AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HI I'M SHANNON BURR WELL I'M AN
ADOPTION CONSULTANT I REPRESENT
THE PARENT TEACHER ORGANIZATION
FROM MY SCHOOL WHO STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU FOR
PAYING ATTENTION THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MELISSA ORNELAS SAN
JOAQUIN RESIDENT AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS VIVIAN GRAY I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THIRTY
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA CONSTITUENTS
PARENTS WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS TO MAKE SURE OF A
SURE HEARD I'M A PARENT AN
EDUCATOR HERE IN DISTRICT SIX IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE SPELL
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI AM KATHRYN QUICK FROM
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA REPRESENT A
LARGE HOME SCHOOLERS GROUP.
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS VICTORIA WAGNER
AND ON BEHALF OF THE HALF OF MY
VACCINE INJURED TWO YEAR OLD
DAUGHTER MEET VACCINEOR ITS
VACCINE INJURED EIGHTEEN ALL
BROTHER I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL IF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FORCED TO FLEE
THE STATE.
HELLO THERE MY NAME IS ALSO
HERNANDEZ AND FROM SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA I AM VACCINATED
MYSELF MY NIECE.
IS HOME SCHOOLED AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES THE AMENDED BILL THANK
YOU [inaudible]
HI MY THIS IS AFTER AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M KELSEY
SCHROEDER FROM TAHOE CITY
CALIFORNIA AND ON BEHALF OF
MYSELF AND MY TWO CHILDREN WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS EMILY DETRACT FROM
SARATOGA CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS NIKKI FROM LIVERMORE
CALIFORNIA AND ON BEHALF OF MY
CHILDREN AND THE REST OF MY
FAMILY WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR LISTENING TO US
TODAY MY NAME'S LEON BELIEVE
CHINA I'M A PEDIATRIC INTENSIVE
CARE NURSE CERTIFIED BY THE
CRITICAL CARE ASSOCIATION NURSES
OF THE UNITED STATES.
AND I BEG YOU TO LISTEN THAT
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THOUSANDS
MORE CHILDREN MY HUSBAND'S ALSO
PIECE I CENTERS A. STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
MY NAME IS CYNTHIA RISER JEVONS
FROM WILLITS CALIFORNIA ON
BEHALF OF MY FAMILY AND MYSELF I
URGE YOU TO STRONGLY I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS NOT SEE BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU YOU.
MY NAME IS MEGAN HARLOW FROM
GRASS VALLEY CALIFORNIA AND THE
MOTHER OF THREE I HAVE A DEGREE
AND HOLISTIC MEDICINE AND I
STRONGLY.
OPPOSE THIS BILL PLEASE HERE I
ANGELINA FOREMAN FROM FROM
PLASTER COUNTY -- STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AND YOU HAVE A
FOR FAMILIES THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS THE TIANA I'M A
MOTHER OF THREE AT FROM
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
CITY NICOLE'S MOTHER OF TWO AND
ON BEHALF OF MY FAMILY I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I'M FRANCINE MASK I'M A MOTHER
OF THREE AND MY HUSBAND AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
THANK YOU.
CHEN AND SELLERS FROM LOS
ANGELES MOTHER OF ONE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
HI THERE I'M JENNY PRIOR FROM
SACRAMENTO AREA IN A THIRD
GENERATION CALIFORNIA AND I'M A
CREDENTIALS THAT CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHER AND
HAS MY OWN.
TO BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI I'M LOUISE NAMAN MOTHER OF
TWO WIFE OF AN AIR FORCE VETERAN --
FROM SHARED IN CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HI AM CHAYANNE AND I'M A MOTHER
AT SIX TWO AM HOME SCHOOL AND I
STAND HERE ON BEHALF OF MY
FAMILY.
AND MANY FAMILIES IN MY
COMMUNITY AND WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
HI I THINK YOU'RE A WILLIAMS I'M
FROM THE US OF CALIFORNIA AN
EDUCATOR FOR TWENTY YEARS A
MOTHER OF FIVE AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
HI AM SHELLS AB FROM BACKFILL
CALIFORNIA I HAD TO DO CPR MY
SON AFTER HIS SHOTS AYE OPPOSED
TO SPELL.
THANK YOU.
HI THANK YOU FOR LISTENING TO US --
ROSALINA AUBURN CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT AT TWENTY TWO YEARS
HERE -- I OPPOSE.
HI MY NAME IS SHELLY CLUES I'M A
HOMESCHOOLING MOM OF THREE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AND MAYES IN MARIN COUNTY HELLO.
HI MY NAME IS MONA MEIER MY SON
GRACE AND WE BOTH STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI JULIE SCHIFFMAN FROM MARIN
COUNTY CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS MARCELLO LOPEZ
JUNIOR AND THE PRESIDENT OF THE
OLDER WISER LEARNERS CLUB AT UC
DAVIS US TO IMPAIR ORGANIZATION
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I'M DINEEN HINES FROM SAUSALITO
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS DIANA DOMINGUEZ AND
ON BEHALF OF MY ENTIRE FAMILY WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THE CHANT OF OUR ELK GROVE
OPPOSE.
MY NAME IS ERIN SHERBRO I AM A
CONSTITUENT OF ASSEMBLYMAN GRAY
AND I AM HERE ON BEHALF OF FOUR
OF MY FIVE CHILDREN THESE ARE
FOR MY FIVE CHILDREN.
ON BEHALF OF MY FAMILY AND MY
HUSBAND WE IMPLORE YOU TO PLEASE
VOTE NO OR ABSTAIN ON SB TWO
SEVEN SIX THANK YOU.
HI MARC FORGET ON BEHALF OF A
VOICE FOR CHOICE ADVOCACY -- AND
THE TWENTY THOUSAND SIGNATURES
WE HAVE ON A STATE -- PETITION
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL AND
HOPE WOULD BE ALLOWED TO ENGAGE
IN FUTURE NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE
SENATOR.
I AM SHANNON PRIMER AND FROM SAN
DIEGO I AM HERE FOR ON BEHALF OF
EDUCATE ADVOCATE I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF OUR MILITARY SPOUSES
WHO FEEL LIKE.
THEY'RE HELD HOSTAGES BY OUR
STATE I ALSO REPRESENTS FAMILIES
IN FIVE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA --
DISTRICTS THAT ARE ALL OPPOSE
SCENE AND ALL OF OUR FAMILIES
WHO HAVE DISABLED CHILDREN WHO
CANNOT -- TESTIFY I'M HERE ON
THEIR BEHALF THAT WE FEEL THIS
IS DISCRIMINATION AGAINST OUR
FAMILIES THANK YOU I OPPOSE
[inaudible]
YEAH.
MY NAME IS A BILL IN NAME --
FROM WALNUT CREEK CALIFORNIA AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU [inaudible]
AND YEAH.
DOCTOR LINE ONLY BOARD CERTIFIED.
EMERGENCY MEDICINE DAUGHTERS
VACCINE INJURED -- PLEASE --
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GIVE.
HI.
MY NAME IS ANNE MARIE FARAONE
FROM BACK WILL KILL CALIFORNIA
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CARRIER OIL I'M FROM
ON THE CREEK CALIFORNIA CONTRAST
ANY.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
MASON IS AND COMPROMISED AND
WITH.
HIS FRIENDS THANK YOU. TO ANYONE
ELSE.
NO ONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION OKAY
[inaudible]
OKAY.
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS.
WE'LL INVITE -- SUPPORTERS.
AND WILL BUY THAT THERE'S ROOM
WE CAN INVITE THE OPPOSITION TO
THE TABLE AS WELL [inaudible]
WHAT ABOUT?
WELL IT'S HARD IT WE ARE I DON'T
REALLY KNOW WHERE THE QUESTIONS
WILL COME FROM SO WE'D LIKE TO
HAVE REPRESENTATIVES FROM BOTH.
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION DOESN'T
NECESSARILY MEAN WE NEED.
EVERYBODY IN OPPOSITION OF THE
TABLE.
OR EVERYBODY IN SUPPORT.
SUMMER SUPPORT YES.
WHEN ASKED I WOULD ASK MY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS QUESTIONS WILL
COME THROUGH ME?
AND WE WILL NOT AND LESS YOU AS
A COMMITTEE MEMBER ONE AT DIRECT
QUESTION FROM AN ANSWER FROM
SOMEBODY ELSE WOULD ASK THAT
PEOPLE NOT INTERJECT THEIR
ANSWERS LET THE QUESTIONS COME
TO ME.
COME TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PLEASE OKAY.
SOUTH MR BONTA.
I THINK IT OUT TO PAN FOR YOUR
YOUR PRESENTATION AND FOR
BRINGING THIS BEFORE I'VE HAD A
COUPLE CLARIFYING QUESTIONS
BASED ON SOME OF THE DISCUSSION
THAT WE HAD SOME OF THE COMMENTS
THAT WE HEARD.
FROM -- MEMBERS THE PUBLIC TODAY.
MY FIRST QUESTION IS ABOUT
FAMILY HISTORY -- THEY'VE BEEN
SOME COMMENTS ABOUT THAT TODAY
CAN CAN FAMILY HISTORY ALONE.
BE GROUNDS FOR A MEDICAL
EXEMPTION AND IF SO -- Q. TALK
ABOUT WHERE THAT IS IN THE BILL
OKAY SO FIRST OF ALL ACTUALLY
THERE ARE CONDITIONS WHERE
FAMILY HISTORY ALONE -- WOULD
WARRANT A MEDICAL EXEMPTION.
AND IN FACT I WOULD POINT OUT
THAT IN THE ACTUAL CDC
GUIDELINES THEMSELVES -- SO EVEN
NOT EVEN LOOKING BEYOND THAT
WHICH THIS BILL DOES ALLOW BY
THE WAY YOU KNOW YOU CAN
STANDARD CARE BUT EVEN THE CDC
GUIDELINES SAY THE FOR EXAMPLE
OF YOU HAVE.
A FAMILY HISTORY WHERE THE CHILD
A FIRST DEGREE RELATIVE A CHILD
HAS AS THEY CAN GENERAL OR
HEREDITARY IMMUNO DEFICIENCY --
THEY CAN BE GRANTED A MEDICAL
EXEMPTION.
SO ON SOLELY ON THE FAMILY
HISTORY ALONE -- I PERHAPS I
SHOULD ALSO POINT OUT THAT I WAS
THE AUTHOR OF A BILL TO BE SURE
WE SCREEN ALL NEWBORNS FOR
SEVERE COMBINED IMMUNODEFICIENCY
WHICH WE NOW IT'S ON IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SO -- I THINK ABOUT I'M THE ONE
WHO ALSO -- AUTHORED THE
LEGISLATION TO BE SURE WE SCREEN
CHILDREN WHO MIGHT BE AT RISK
THAT TO BE SURE THEY'RE TESTED
AND FOUND BEFORE THE EVEN
RECEIVE -- IT THE OTHER TWO
MONTH EXCEEDS.
MISTER MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU MISTER POTTER THANK
YOU -- YOU AND I HAVE TALKED
ABOUT FAMILY MEDICAL HISTORY I I
TALKED ABOUT IT BEING AN
IMPORTANT CONSIDERATION FOR FOR
ME.
AND YOU'VE TAKEN AMENDMENTS THE
THEIR IMPRINT.
DO YOU REMEMBER SPECIFICALLY
HAVE THE WORDS FAMILY MEDICAL
HISTORY IN THE BILL YES THAT
THAT YES THAT THAT WORDING IS IN
THE BILL CORRECT OKAY ANNA AND
I'M LOOKING AT RIGHT NOW.
IT'S ON PAGE TEN LINE SEVENTEEN
IT'S CLEARLY THERE.
SO I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY THAT
SO WE'RE ALL TALKING ABOUT THE
SAME SET OF FACTS WHILE TALKING
ON THE SAME BILL.
WHEN WE HAVE OUR DIALOGUE IN OUR
OUR DISCUSSION TODAY -- ANOTHER
THING AT MISTER CHAIR IT IS TO
WOULD LIKE TO GET OTHER MEMBERS
FIRST BEFORE PLEASE GO AHEAD IF
YOU WANT TO CONTINUE IN YOUR
LINE OF QUESTIONING -- TURNING
TO ANOTHER TOPIC YES.
THE ISSUE OF DOCTORS PROVIDING
FIVE MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS A YEAR
IS THAT A LIMIT OR A CAP ON HOW
MANY MEDICAL EXEMPTION AS THEY
CAN PROVIDE ORDERS THAT TRIGGER
SOMETHING ELSE.
NO IT IS NOT A LIMIT OR CATH I
WOULD POINT OUT THAT WHAT THIS
BILL DOES IT SAYS THAT IF YOU
WRITE MORE THAN FIVE MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS -- THERE IS SOME
ADDITIONAL SCREENINGS THAT'S
FAIRLY UNUSUAL I'M A
PEDIATRICIAN I PRACTICED AT UC
DAVIS WHERE MY PRACTICE AS A
PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIAN INCLUDED
MANY CHILDREN THE COMPLEX
CONDITIONS BECAUSE WE WERE TO
SHERRY CARE CENTER RIGHT WHERE
AN ACADEMIC HEALTH CENTER.
AND FRANKLY I DON'T THINK I'VE
WRITTEN EVEN TEN MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS IN TWELVE YEARS WHEN
I WAS THERE TO FAIRLY THE VERY
RARE.
BUT I WOULD ALSO POINT OUT THAT
IF YOU HAVE FOR EXAMPLE MAYBE
IT'S AN COLLEGES MIGHT HAVE
WRITTEN MANY MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS.
SO THEY WILL BE LOOKED AT AND
THEY'LL POINT OUT THAT THE
PATIENTS HAVE.
CANCER TO MEET YOU FOR CANCER
AND THOSE AT ALL BE LEGITIMATE
THE ONLY THING THAT TRIGGERS THE
PROBLEM IS THAT IF YOU HAVE.
FIVE SUSPECT EXEMPTIONS THAT
THEN AFTER ONLY AFTER REVIEW
WHERE IT'S BEEN VIEWED BY
CLINICAL STAFF AT C. P. H. THEN
PERHAPS REJECTED BY A PEER
REVIEW PANEL.
AND WE SAY WELL YOU KNOW THAT
THAT'S A LITTLE CONCERNING AND
PERHAPS -- THERE OUGHT TO BE
GREATER SCRUTINY BY THE MEDICAL
BOARD WHICH WOULD STILL HAVE TO
DO AN INVESTIGATION SO THERE ARE
SO MANY LAYERS BEFORE ANYTHING
WOULD HAPPEN.
SO I JUST POINT OUT THAT IF THEY
IF YOU WROTE.
DEL -- TEN TWENTY LEGITIMATE
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS IS ALSO
LEGITIMATE YOU'RE FINE AND
THAT'S THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
TO KEEP IN MIND WE SIMPLY SAYING
THAT YOU'RE TAKING A LOOK AT
THEM.
BUT THERE FIND A FINE.
THANK YOU FOR THE CLARIFICATION
SENATOR DR PAM I HAVE ONE MORE
QUESTION IF IT'S OKAY OF THE
CHECK -- YOU MENTION PEER REVIEW
RIGHT CAN YOU TALK ABOUT THE
ROLE OF PEER REVIEW IN THE
PRACTICE OF MEDICINE YES SO --
TRADITIONALLY PEER REVIEW IS THE
MECHANISM BY WHICH WE JUDGE
WHETHER A PRACTICING PHYSICIAN
IS.
A IS ACTUALLY PRACTICING A
WITHIN THEIR PROCREATE SPHERE OR
THEY ARE PERHAPS DOING SOMETHING
THAT MIGHT BE UNJUSTIFIED ON
ETHICAL -- SO WE HAVE YOUR
REVIEW BODIES AND HOSPITALS TO
LOOK AT QUALITY IMPROVEMENT AND
BEHAVIOR WE HAVE PEER REVIEW
BODIES AND MEDICAL SOCIETIES
WHEN THERE ARE COMPLAINTS ABOUT
POSITIONS.
I WOULD POINT OUT THAT ACTUALLY
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE FOR
EXAMPLE WE'VE ALL IF SOME OF US
OF ALL THE LEGISLATION BELIEVE
YOU HAVE A SUMMER BONTA WHERE
ACTUALLY IF THERE IS A CHALLENGE.
TO THE WAY SOMEONE BILLS THERE
IS A PURE PERSON WHO REVIEWS
THAT DEPARTMENTS HEALTH CARE TO
LOOK AT THE DAY BEHAVIOR
PROGRAMS APPEAR IF YOU IS
SOMETHING THAT IS COMMONLY USED
IN THE KNOWLEDGE AND AND THE
BEST EARLY IN THE MEDICAL
PROFESSION. TO ASSESS HAS A
POSITION ACTED OUTSIDE OF WHAT
WOULD BE STANDARD OF CARE NO
MORE PRACTICE AND ARE THEY
POTENTIALLY ENDANGERING OTHER
PATIENTS ARE NOT PRACTICING UP
TO QUALITY -- THEY MAY BE
IMPAIRED WE USE PEER REVIEW IS A
WAY TO MAKE THAT JUDGMENT.
AND HAVE USED.
YOU IN SB TWO SEVENTY SIX AS
WELL YES SO THIS AND SO WHAT
HAPPENS IS THAT -- WHILE THE
INITIAL REVIEWS DONE BY A
TRAINED CLINICIANS SIDE THEY ARE.
ON THIS ISN'T PHYSICIANS WHO
HAVE EXPERTISE -- THAT IF THERE
IS AN APPEAL IT WILL GO TO A
PEER REVIEW PANEL OF PHYSICIANS
WHO.
ARE APPOINTED BY THE SECRETARY
AND I WOULD POINT OUT THE REASON
APPOINTED BY THE SECRETARY IS
BECAUSE THAT'S THE WAY WE
NORMALLY DO THINGS -- IN TERMS
OF HAVING BODIES HERE IN
REGARDING OVERSIGHT IN THE STATE
RIGHT AND IN FACT THE BILL DOES
SAY THAT THAT BODY SO THAT
SOMEONE SAID WELL IT'S A
SECRETARY THE SIDES.
BUT ACTUALLY THAT'S RIGHT THE
SECRETARY IS REQUIRED TO TAKE
THE RECOMMENDATION OF THIS PANEL
SO THAT THEY THEY THEY CAN'T THE
PANEL SAYS WELL TO THE GYM AT
THEN THE SECRETARY SAYS OKAY
IT'S LEGITIMATE THAT'S THE WAY
THE BILL THIS FRIEND.
AND YOU CAN SEE THAT ANALYSIS.
THANK YOU SENATOR DR PAN I AM
WITH SB TWO SEVENTY SEVEN WITH
YOUR BILL TODAY I BELIEVE THAT
YOU ARE PUTTING FORWARD IN
PROMOTING GOOD.
SCIENCE BASED PUBLIC HEALTH
POLICY AND I THINK YOU'VE TAKEN
IMPORTANT STEPS TODAY WITH
PROVIDING ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
FIVE YOU'LL ILLEGITIMATE AND NON
SCIENCE BASED.
MEDICAL RECORD MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS WHILE CONTINUING TO
ALLOW A ROBUST SET OF LEGITIMATE
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS I PLAN TO
SUPPORT A BILL TODAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANKS MUCH SOMETHING
ABOUT.
WITH RESPECT AT SOME POINT.
LET'S JUST EXCUSE ME UNLESS IT'S
YOUR ASK DIRECTLY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS -- THESE GO THROUGH ME
OR TO DIRECTLY TO DOCTOR PANTS
SO THERE IS NO INTERJECTION OF
ASKING QUESTIONS UNDERSTOOD.
SO THIS MONTH.
THANK YOU I I WANT TO START OFF
BY SAYING THAT DESPITE WERE WE
ALL MAY BE ON THIS ISSUE -- THAT
DAY YOU KNOW A FIND ITS --
REALLY BUT A HARD TO TO SEE HOW
MANY PERSONAL ATTACKS YOU YOU
TOOK -- ON THIS ISSUE.
THIS IS A HARD ISSUE AND FOR
MANY OF US THE DEBATE IS NOT.
BASED ON A POLITICAL SIDE IT'S
NOT BASED ON ANY ORGANIZATION IT
IS NOT BASED ON A GOOD VERSUS
BAD.
IT IS HOW DO YOU HELP PARENTS
WHO LOVE THEIR KIDS RIGHT.
AND WANT THE BEST FOR THEM.
AND HAVE DIFFERENT OPINIONS
ABOUT WHAT IS BEST FOR THEM.
AND SO I I JUST I I WANT TO SAY
THAT BECAUSE AS I HEARD THE
COMMENTS I THINK THAT'S LOST ON
FOLKS I THINK IT'S EASY TO SAY
THAT IT'S THIS GROUP OR THAT
GROUP -- WHILE SO MANY PEOPLE
DEBATE HOW DO WE KEEP ALL THE
KIDS HEALTHY.
I AND ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
REALITIES ARE PART OF EVERYONE'S
LIVED EXPERIENCE -- SO EIGHT
THINK THAT THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO DO I
CAN ONLY IMAGINE HOW DIFFICULT
IT'S BEEN TO YOU I THINK MANY OF
US GOT A TASTE OF WHERE THIS IS
GOING -- BUT IT BUT I DO THINK
IT'S REQUIRES US TO HAVE
THOUGHTFUL AND RESPECTFUL
CONVERSATIONS IN TERMS OF HOW WE
MOVE FORWARD.
I HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS AND IF
THAT'S OKAY WITH IT WITH IT WITH
THE CHAIR -- COME WE TALK FIRST
ABOUT IT AND I THINK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM OAKLAND --
ALREADY ADDRESSED THE FAMILY
HISTORY AND ALSO CITED WHERE IT
IS MENTIONED IN IN THE
LEGISLATION -- AS WELL AS THE
DISTINCTION BETWEEN THE WILL --
WORD REVIEW AFTER FIVE
EXEMPTIONS AS OPPOSED TO LIMIT.
ON BOTH IN THE DICTIONARY THOSE
ARE DIFFERENT THINGS AND
CERTAINLY A LAW THEY ALSO MEAN
DIFFERENT THINGS CAN YOU SPEAK
TO THE CONCERNS -- ABOUT --
PRIVACY AND DATA I KNOW YOU AND
I HAVE HAD MULTIPLE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT OTHER.
REGISTRIES OR OTHER FORMS OF
DATA THAT'S COLLECTED AND GIVEN
SOME EXAMPLES OF CAN YOU PLEASE
ADDRESS THAT YES NO THANK YOU SO
MUCH AS A MARYLAND ON HEALTH TRY --
HEALTH PRIVACY IS SOMETHING THAT
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO ME --
FIRSTLY AS WELL AS CERTAINLY THE
SPONSORS OF THE BILL AS WELL AS
IN OUR STATE GOVERNMENT ARE
DEPART PUBLIC HEALTH AND OTHER
AGENCIES ARE MEDICAL BOARD.
AND SAID AND I WOULD JUST WANNA
POINT OUT THAT THE CURRENTLY THE
MEDICAL BOARD ACCOUNT I MEAN
THAT THIS CALIFORNIA PART OF
PUBLIC HEALTH FIRST OF ALL
MAINTAINS.
DATABASES WITH VERY SENSITIVE
INFORMATION -- NOR TO PROTECT
PUBLIC HEALTH YEAH SO THOSE ARE
PEOPLE WITH STDS AND HIV WE HAVE
A CANCER REGISTRY WE ACTUALLY
HAVE THE IMMUNIZATION REGISTRIES
SO FOR PEOPLE ACTUALLY IMMUNIZE
YOUR YOU'RE.
YOU'RE IN THAT REGISTRY AND
CERTAINLY.
MY COLLEAGUE HERE IS THAT CAN
HELP US RECORD FOR ASKING SPEAK
TO OTHER -- DATA SETS AS WELL
AND ALSO POINT OUT BY THE WAY
THE MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA
ALSO MAINTAINS PRIVACY SO FOR
EXAMPLE -- IN THEIR LAWSUIT
AGAINST -- THE DOCTOR KENNEDY
WE'RE TRYING TO OBTAIN MEDICAL
RECORDS -- THEY'RE NOT SAYING
THAT WE WANT TO IN THE MEDICAL
RECORDS TO PUBLISH THEM.
WE NEED ACCESS IS A MEDICAL
RECORDS IN ORDER TO DO AN
INVESTIGATION AND IN FACT WE
WILL KEEP THOSE RECORDS PRIVATE
IT'S WE'LL KEEP THOSE RECORDS
PRIVATE WHILE WE'RE DOING THE
INVESTIGATION.
AND THAT THEY THINK THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT AND I WOULD POINT OUT
THAT ALSO IN THIS BILL WE
EXPLICITLY STATE ALTHOUGH IT'S A
CERTAINLY IMPLICIT READY BUT WE
EXPLICITLY STATE.
ALL STATE AND FEDERAL PRIVACY
LAWS WILL HAVE TO BE OBEYED THAT
WE THAT THAT NOTHING THEY CANNOT
VIOLATE STATE AND FEDERAL
PRIVACY LAWS AND THAT'S WHY IT'S
SO.
SO WE DEFINITELY WANT TO PROTECT
THE PRIVACY OF ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WOULD BE
AFFECTED IN THIS BILL WHILE
ALLOWING US TO PERFORM OUR
OVERSIGHT FUNCTION RIGHT.
IS THAT OVERSIGHT FUNCTIONS
IMPORTANT TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC --
WE WANT TO KEEP IT TRY TO
ACTUALLY DO IT. TO BE SURE THAT
NO.
GIVE PEOPLE AS MUCH FREEDOM AS
THEY CAN BUT AT THE POINT WHERE
YOU YOU SWING YOUR FIST AND YA
IT SOME TOUCH SOMEONE'S NOSE-ACTUALLY GET THEIR NOSE.
THEN THERE'S A PROBLEM RIGHT AND
WE NEED TO BE SURE WE PROTECT
ALL THE KIDS SO WE NEED TO GIVE
THEM THE ABILITY TO HAVE THE
INFORMATION TO DO THAT WHILE
KEEPING INFORMATION PRIVATE.
AS WELL AND THAT'S WHAT THE THIS
BILL WILL DO AND THAT IS
ACTUALLY THE WAY WE HANDLE
THINGS HERE TAKE OUT FOR FOR
OTHER ISSUES AS WELL THAT MAY
INVOLVE THE MEDICAL BOARD A
CALIFORNIA DEPART PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND CAN YOU CLARIFY.
WHAT TYPE OF EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS YOUR BILL APPLIES
TO YOU?
SO IT THE SO BASICALLY EXISTING
LAW SAYS IT UP -- APPLY TO OF
COURSE AT ALL K. THROUGH --
TWELVE SCHOOLS -- SO PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE -- WE ALSO HAVE A RULES
REGARDING -- CHILD CARE AS WELL
IN TERMS OF SO WE DON'T CHANGE
THAT BUT WHAT HAPPENS AND FACT
THAT SAID INVOLVED IN TWO SEVEN
SEVEN AS WELL.
AND SO WHAT WE'RE SAYING IS YOU
HAVE A MEDICAL EXEMPTION THERE
IS THIS -- MECHANISM FOR
OVERSIGHT -- IF -- WE KNOW THAT
THERE ARE A LARGE NUMBER MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS AND IT DOES NOT APPLY
TO HOME SCHOOL NO SO FRED FOR
ACTUALLY FOR ALL THE PEOPLE WHO
TESTIFIES THAT ARE HOME
SCHOOLING THEIR CHILDREN OR IF
YOU'RE INDEPENDENT STUDY.
IN A PUBLIC SCHOOL THIS IS NOT
APPLY SO THERE'S NO EFFECT ON
THOSE CHILDREN AND THOSE
FAMILIES.
AND THEN -- CAN YOU ALSO TALK
ABOUT THERE'S BEEN A LOT
FLOATING OUT THERE WHETHER THIS
GRANDFATHER'S OR DOZEN
GRANDFATHER CURRENT EXEMPTIONS
AND A AND I THINK PEOPLE USE
GRANDFATHER IN DIFFERENT WAY BUT
CAN YOU PLEASE CLARIFY THAT.
SO WHAT WE'RE WHAT THE BILL SAYS
IS THAT -- BY -- TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WE NEED TO HAVE ALL MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS ALL EXISTING MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS HAVE TO BE FILED WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF THE CULT'S
REMAIN BALLOT.
OKAY SO THAT DOES INCLUDE THAT
CONVENTIONS THAT HAVE ALREADY
BEEN GRANTED -- AND SO THAT THAT
AND THEN WHAT WILL HAPPEN IS IS
THAT -- BASICALLY THE DEPART
PUBLIC HEALTH FIRST OF ALL
STARTING.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE PHYSICIANS
WILL HAVE TO APPLY FOR THEM BUT
THEY CAN ALSO EXAMINED FOR ONLY
THE SCHOOLS AND THE PHYSICIANS
WITH THEIR TRIGGERS THEY CAN
EXAMINE THOSE -- MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS AS WELL -- THE FIRST
IS THAT SINCE YOU HAVE THIS OKAY
AND I I'D LIKE TO SEE IF THE
OPPOSITION WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT
ON ANY OF THE QUESTIONS THAT I
ASKED OF THE AUTHOR.
I THANK YOU FOR THAT I
APPRECIATE IT -- I WOULD LIKE TO
JUST ADDRESS FAMILY HEALTH
HISTORY -- BRIEFLY BECAUSE I
THINK IT IS A PIVOTAL POINT FOR
A LOT OF YOUR INTERNAL ANALYSES
ON WHETHER YOU'RE GOING TO VOTE
A CERTAIN WAY ON THIS BILL OR
NOT.
THE RELEVANT LANGUAGE OF TWO
SEVENTY SIX AS AMENDED STATES
THE DEPARTMENT MAY ACCEPT A
MEDICAL EXEMPTION -- THAT IS
BASED ON FAMILY HISTORY -- AS
LONG AS THE DOCTOR PROVIDES
WRITTEN DOCUMENTATION TO SUPPORT
THE MEDICAL EXEMPTION.
THAT IS CONSISTENT WITH THE
RELEVANT STANDARD OF CARE.
IF WE WERE TRULY LEAVING THIS AT
FAMILY HEALTH HISTORY.
THERE WOULD BE NO NEED FOR THAT
LETTER CLAUSE.
WE LIKE YOU WANTED TO BE VERY
CLEAR WHAT THIS BILL MEANT AND
WE LIKE YOUWANT TO SENATOR PANS
OFFICE YESTERDAY.
AND WE SPECIFICALLY ASKED IS
FAMILY MEDICAL HISTORY GOING TO
BE ALLOWED UNDER SB TWO SEVENTY
SIX BECAUSE I THINK WE ALL
RECOGNIZE THE NEW AMENDMENTS
WERE -- THERE WERE A LOT OF THEM
AND THEY WERE KIND OF FUN AND
INTERESTING TO READ THROUGH.
AND REPEATEDLY WHAT WAS TOLD
BACK TO US IS IT WILL BE
RELEVANT STANDARD OF CARE.
RELEVANT STANDARD OF CARE
DEFAULTS TO CDC GUIDELINES AND A
SEVEN AND A. P. WHICH IF YOU
HAVE READ THEM OR MIRROR IMAGES
OF EACH OTHER SO THE ADDITIONAL
LANGUAGE THAT YOU SEE IN THAT
BILL.
BASICALLY DOESN'T GET US
ANYWHERE OTHER THAN CDC
GUIDELINES AND CDC GUIDELINES DO
NOT.
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT FAMILY HEALTH
HISTORY FOR THE VAST MAJORITY OF
VACCINES THAT THEY COVER.
WHICH IS TO SAY IF WE VOTE THIS
INTO A FACT.
A CHILD WHO IS A SIBLING.
OF A CHILD WHO DIED FROM A
CERTIFIABLY PROVABLY DONE
VACCINE REACTION BY THE VACCINE
COURTS WOULD NO LONGER QUALIFY
FOR A MEDICAL EXEMPTION I WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK. TO MY SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTISE.
I SKIPPED HIGH SCHOOL I STARTED
COLLEGE AT FOURTEEN I WAS
ACCEPTED TO YALE LAW SCHOOL IN
PRETTY MUCH EVERY OTHER OSS ON
THE COUNTRY AT AGE SEVENTEEN AND
A HALF.
I REPRESENTED LARGE FORTUNE FIVE
HUNDRED COMPANIES ASK THE
QUESTION I I JUST I I WOULD LIKE
TO STICK TO THAT QUESTION SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR AND I
REPRESENTED A PLANE WE SEE THEIR
ANSWER AND I WOULD PLEASE.
I WOULD LIKE TO ASK THE AUTHOR
YES -- IF.
THE COMMENT MADE ABOUT THE
LATTER PART OF I KNOW I DIDN'T
HEAR THAT IT WAS AMENDMENTS AND
AMENDMENTS BUT I HEARD THAT IT
WAS A CONCERN IF YOU COULD JUST
REPLY.
SO SO WE APPLY STANDARD OF CARE
RIGHT SO OTHERWISE IF YOU DON'T
HAVE STANDARD OF CARE THEN
YOU'RE SAYING THAT SO WHAT I
KNOW WE ALL.
WE ARE FAMILIES AND WE ALL HAVE
FAMILY HISTORIES RIGHT.
SO YOU HAVE A UNCLE WHO MIGHT
HAVE HAD A HEART ATTACK YOU HAD
ON TO DEVELOP CANCER YOU HAD A
COUSIN WHO.
SO.
WE ALL HAVE FAMILY HISTORIES.
AND EVEN PEOPLE ARE ADOPTED HAVE
ONES THEY MAY NOT KNOW BE AWARE
OF WE ALL HAVE FAMILY HISTORY SO
IF YOU DON'T SAY STANDARD OF
CARE.
THAN JUST HAVING A FAMILY
HISTORY THEN BECOMES A REASON
FOR AN EXEMPTION.
I MEAN WE APPLY STANDARD OF CARE
FOR EVERYTHING SO IF YOU.
SAY YOU HAVE A SYMPTOM OF
SOMETING AND SO THE PHYSICIAN
FOR EXAMPLE SAYS WELL YOU KNOW
WHAT YOU SAID YOU HAVE A LITTLE
YOU KNOW ACHE IN YOUR TOOTH.
I'LL GIVE YOU A LARGE DOSE OF
OPIOIDS AND THEN YOU SAY WELL
YOU KNOW WHAT PAIN YOU KNOW IS
IS A REASON FOR THAT.
AND I THINK WE WOULD SAY WELL
WAIT A MINUTE.
THAT LEVEL PAYING ME NOT NESTLE
WARRANTED AND SO WHAT IS THE
STANDARD OF CARE THAT SOME
PEOPLE WOULD ACTUALLY SAY
STANDARD OF CARE IS A LITTLE
BROAD BECAUSE YOU KNOW IT'S
ESTABLISHED BY PHYSICIANS FOR
EACH OTHER.
AND LIKE WELL OKAY DOCTORS ARE
TEND TO BE A LITTLE MORE
FORGIVING OF EACH OTHER AND SAY
WELL YOU KNOW WHAT.
WILL GIVE YOU A LITTLE LATITUDE
BECAUSE GOT FOR THE GRACE OF GOD
I DON'T KNOW IF I WAS AT BECAUSE
CLINICAL SITUATION SO.
SO I WOULD JUST POINT OUT THAT
BY ELIMINATING STANDARD OF CARE
DOESN'T WHAT WAS THAT SUPPOSED
TO MEAN THAT.
IF YOU SIMPLY HAVE A FAMILY
HISTORY YOU CAN EXEMPTION HI I
THINK MOST OF US WOULD SAY THAT
WOULD BE INAPPROPRIATE -- TO TO
DO THAT -- SO I WOULD ALSO POINT
OUT THAT BY THE WAY -- WELL
CERTAINLY THE OPPONENTS -- HAVE
COMPLAINED THAT THE ACIP IN A P.
VERY EACH OTHER I WOULD SAY THAT
THERE YOU ARE STAFF LIST
INDEPENDENTLY.
DAVE HE EVALUATES THE DATA ON
THEIR OWN ACHT EVALUATES THE
DATA IF THE FACT THAT THEY'RE
SIMILAR PRIDE JUST SPEAKS TO THE
FACT THAT THE EVIDENCE BUT HE'S
POINTS TO THE SAME DIRECTION.
AND ALSO IN THIS BILL WE
ACTUALLY DON'T SAY IT'S JUST A
C. I. T. AND A. P..
IT IS STANDARD CARE BY THE WAY
THE REVIEW PANEL THE APPEALS
PANEL FAXING PHYSICIANS IT'S
PURELY STAND OF CARE BASICALLY --
IF THERE'S IF IT'S REASONABLE
THE THINK THAT SOMETHING WITHIN
REASON OF PER OF PHYSICIAN
PRACTICING CALIFORNIA IS
PRACTICING GOOD MEDICINE.
ARE THESE RETAIL DECENT MEDICINE.
THINKS IT'S OKAY THAT WOULD SET
THAT THAT WOULD BE FINE SO IT
THAT THAT'S ROUTE IT'S I THINK
IT'S A VERY -- LIBERAL STANDARD
ACTUALLY AND IS THAT STANDARD A
STANDARD THAT IS APPLIED OR USE
IN THIS CONTEXT OR OTHER
CONTENTS EQUIVALENT TO THIS BY
THE MEDICAL BOARD BY OUR STATE
MEDICAL BOARD YES THE MEDICAL
BOARD ITSELF RIGHT WHEN THEY
EVALUATE DID A PHYSICIAN VIA YOU
KNOW AT SHOULD BE PENALIZED.
THEY CONSULT -- PHYSICIANS AND
THEY YOU KNOW THEY BRING IN A
POSITION BECAUSE ALL THEY SAY
WAS THIS SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE
NORMALLY WITHIN THE SCOPE OF THE
NORMAL PRACTICE OF THE POSITION
IN THAT FIELD.
AND THAT'S THAT'S ALL THE MAKE
THAT JUDGMENT WHETHER THEY WOULD
PURSUE AFTER INVESTIGATION WILL
BE PURSUE ANY PENALTIES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
JOINING THEIR FROM AN OPPOSITION
IS A PHYSICIAN ACTUAL NOW
ACTUALLY IT'S UP TO THE
DISCRETION OF THE I NEVER WANT
TO HEAR FROM SOMEONE IN THE
OPPOSITION IT DIDN'T NECESSARILY
MATTER AND I THINK -- THAT WEEK
WE HAD SOME COMMENTS.
SO THIS TO RAMESES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I HAVE A
SERIES OF QUESTIONS ON THE FOR
THE AUTHOR.
ON TALKING AGAIN ABOUT THE
FAMILY HISTORY WHEN SOMEONE
COMES IN WITH A A CHILD NEWBORN
TWO MONTH OLD -- IF THEY COME IN
ARE THEY ASKED ABOUT THAT FAMILY
HISTORY BEFORE THE IMMUNIZATIONS
WERE FALSE.
YES -- SO I USUALLY IF YOU HAVE
A PLEASE.
GIVE THE GIVEN US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DEBATE THIS
PLEASE NO NO APRS.
YES AND IN FACT ACTUALLY I WOULD
REFER YOU -- TO THE GUIDELINES
THAT -- THE PUT OUT THE BRIGHT
FUTURES GUIDELINES WHICH ARE
ACTUALLY THE GUIDELINES FOR WELL
CHILD CARE NOT THAT VACCINE
SPECIFICALLY IT JUST ABOUT WELL
CHILD CARE WHAT YOU SHOULD BE
DOING AT YOUR TWO MONTH VISIT
FOR MONTH VISIT. SIX MONTH VISIT --
TWO WEEK VISIT -- YOU'LL SEE AND
THERE THAT THERE'S OF RIGHT
DIFFERENT THINGS INCLUDING --
ASKING ABOUT THE FAMILY HISTORY --
SO THAT IS PART OF THE REGULAR
WELL CHILD EXAM ACTUALLY IF YOU
COME IN AND YOU HAVE A COLD
THERE YOUR CHILD'S AND YOUR
FACTION.
WE WILL ALSO -- OFTEN INQUIRE
ABOUT FAMILY HISTORY AS WELL YOU
COME OF ASTHMA ATTACK WE WILL
ASK ABOUT FAMILY IF YOU FOCUS ON
THOSE PARTICULAR ISSUES BUT
CERTAINLY GETTING A FAMILY
HISTORY AND IF YOU WELL CHILD
EXAM IT IS A MUCH BROADER FAMILY
HISTORY.
THAT WAS A CELL OKAY WHAT KIND
CONDITIONS HAVE THE SIBLINGS HAD
THE PARENTS HAD AUNTS AND UNCLES
COUSINS GRANDPARENTS THAT IS
PART OF OF NORMAL MEDICAL
PRACTICE IN THOSE QUESTIONS ARE
ASKED PRIOR TO ANY IMMUNIZATIONS
YES BEING CONDUCTED PLEASE SEND.
IF THERE IS DISAGREEMENT ON THAT
WHAT IS THE RECOURSE OF THE
PARENT OR GUARDIAN IS OUR
PROCESS FOR THEM TO FOLLOW OKAY
SO I AM NOT SURE WE KEY ACTUALLY
IF YOU APPRECIATE.
WITH THE GUIDELINES OF OF US
THERE.
WE'VE HAD A SERIES OF QUESTIONS
OF THE PARENTS THAT HAVE COME
THROUGH THAT HAVE SAID THAT.
THEY WEREN'T ASKED ABOUT THAT
HISTORY OF THE FAMILY PRIOR TO
THE IMMUNIZATION SO I JUST WANT
TO GET CLEAR -- IS THERE A
PROCESS FOR THAT FOR THE MEDICAL --
EXAM AND IF IT WASN'T FOLLOWED
WHAT IS THE REQUEST FOR THE
PARENTS ARE SET óRDENES AT THAT
POINT SO LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
PROCESS OF VACCINATION -- SO
WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT RIGHT YOU
BRING YOUR CHILD AND IF YOU HAVE
CHILDREN YOU BRING YOUR CHILD TO
YOUR DOCTOR'S OFFICE RIGHT FOR
THEIR EXAM.
SOMETIMES YOU MAY EVEN FILL OUT
AN INTAKE FORM THAT THE ONLY GO
AND THE DOCTOR ASK USERS BUT
HOW'S YOUR CHILD DOING WHERE
THINGS ARE DOING OTHER
CONDITIONS IN THE FAMILY THAT
HAS TO BE DOCUMENTED BY THE WAY
IN THE MEDICAL RECORD.
THEY DO THE PHYSICAL EXAM RIGHT
AND THEN THEY SAY OKAY THESE ARE
SOME OUR RECOMMENDATIONS OF
THINGS YOU SHOULD DO AND WE
RECOMMEND THAT YOU VACCINATE
RIGHT.
AND THEN WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT
THERE'S GOT THAT YOU ARE -- FOR
THERE'S DISCUSSION ABOUT
VACCINATION IF YOU HAVE
QUESTIONS OF COURSE YOU CAN ASK
THOSE QUESTIONS YOU GET THEM
ANSWERED YOUR PROVIDED YOU
ACTUALLY ROUTE MANDATED BY LAW
TO PROVIDE A VACCINE INFORMATION
SHEETS WHICH ACTUALLY CONTAINS
ALL OF THE SIDE EFFECTS.
OF THE VACCINE THE IDEA THE
THINGS THAT THE VACCINE MAY
CAUSE INCLUDING BY THE WAY DOES
ALSO IT DOWN THERE AND NUMBER TO
CALL IF THERE'S ANYTHING THAT
HAPPENS YOUR CHILD'S ALL THE
VACCINE.
THAT'S ACTUALLY PRINTED OFTEN
THE VACCINE INFORMATION SHE WAS
YOUR MANDATED BY LAW TO HAND OUT
SO YOU DO YOU DO THAT IF YOU
CHOOSE NOT TO VACCINATE YOUR
CHILD.
YOUR CHILD'S NOT VACCINATED
THERE'S NO PHYSICIAN TO
VACCINATE CHILDREN AGAINST THEIR
PARENTS WELL SO THAT'S BASICALLY
YOU HAVE TO CONSENT TO THE
VACCINE IF YOU STILL HAVE
QUESTIONS YOU DON'T WANT.
TO YOUR CHILD DOESN'T GET
VACCINATED AND FACT YOU HAVE TO
SIGN THE THAT THE THE CONSENT
BEFORE YOUR CHILD CAN YOU TAX
NATIVE AND IF YOU HAVE FURTHER
QUESTIONS OF COURSE YOU.
TALK TO YOUR POSITION SAID WELL
I I HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
THAT MIGHT YOU KNOW SOMEONE IN
MY FAMILY HAD SOME SORT OF EVENT
THAT HAPPENED IS THERE GONNA BE
A PROBLEM THAT BACK TO YOU HAVE
THAT DISCUSSION WITH YOUR
PHYSICIAN BOTH IMMENSELY IT'S
APPARENT TO MAKES A DECISION.
IN THE END WHETHER TO VACCINATE
YOUR CHILD OR NOT BUT CERTAINLY.
HEY THAT'S THE IDEA OF HAVING.
A GOOD DOCTOR PATIENT
RELATIONSHIP IS IS THAT YOU'RE
HAVING THAT CONVERSATION WITH
YOUR PHYSICIAN ABOUT WHY THEY
WANT YOU TO GET YOUR CHILD
VACCINATED WIRED TO RISKS OF
THAT WORD OF BENEFITS OF THAT
AND THAT IS PART OF THAT.
THE DIALOGUE BEFORE YOUR CHILD
GETS VACCINATED YOU ULTIMATELY
IS THE PARENTS STILL MAKE THAT
DECISION.
WITH THE THANK YOU FOR THAT NOW.
ELEVEN A CLARIFYING THAT PROCESS
AND MISTER CHAIRS A FEW MORE
QUESTIONS.
ON IN PAGE TEN LINE THIRTY FIVE
WOULD START TO TALK ABOUT --
EXEMPTIONS AND THE DENIAL THE
REVOKING AND PENDING APPEAL.
IT TALKS ABOUT A CHILD SHALL
COMPLY WITH CONDITION EMISSIONS
SCHEDULE FREE MUTATIONS.
AND CONTINUED ATTENDANCE
REQUIREMENTS DOES THAT TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THAT IF THERE'S AN
APPEAL FOR AN EXISTING EXEMPTION.
THAT THEY WOULD -- STUDENTS
WOULD BE ALLOWED TO STAY IN
pBE IMMUNE IS -- IMMUNIZED IN
ORDER TO STAY IN SCHOOL SO WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN IS IS THAT -- YOU
HAVE TO COMPLETE THE WHOLE
PROCESS RIGHT SO LANDS OF YOU.
GETS REJECTED YOU ASK FOR
APPEALED APPEAL HAS TO HAPPEN
THAT THE FUEL COMES BACK DOWN
AND SAYS NO YOU'RE ACTED THEN
WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT YOU HAVE TO
COMPLY WITH THE AT THE
ENROLLMENT LAWS.
YOU ACTUALLY HAVE THIRTY DAYS TO
DO SO ALL RIGHT YOU HAVE THIRTY
DAYS TO DO SO SO YOUR CHILD CAN
STILL ATTEND SCHOOL FOR ANOTHER
THIRTY DAYS AFTER YOU'VE GOTTEN
THE FINAL DECISION THAT AFTER
THE PEEL.
SO THAT NO POINT IN TIME UNTIL
THE WHOLE PROCESS HAS GONE
THROUGH.
AND THEN YOU HAVE THIRTY DAYS
BEYOND THAT TO COMPLY -- TO
REMAIN ENROLLED IN THE SCHOOL
YOU CAN OF COURSE CERTAINLY
CHOOSE TO INDEPENDENT STUDY
YEARS CHILD YOU CAN CHOOSE.
TO HOME SCHOOL YOUR CHILD IF YOU
DO NOT WANT TO VACCINATE YOUR
CHILD THERE ARE ALWAYS THOSE
OPTIONS AVAILABLE FOR YOUR CHILD
WANTS TO CONTINUE TO ATTEND.
THE SCHOOL -- YOU WILL NEED TO
GET THEM -- CAUGHT UP ON THEIR
VACCINES BY THE WAY WHAT YOU CAN
GET A CONDITIONAL WHICH MEANS IS
THAT FOR EXAMPLE THE CHILD AND
RECEIVE ANY VACCINES ARE
INTERVALS BETWEEN VACCINE SO
SOMETIMES THIS HAPPENS BECAUSE A
FAMILY MEMBER A FAMILY.
YOU KNOW WAS TOO BUSY TO GET THE
VACCINE DATA BECAUSE VACCINES
AND THEY SAID OKAY I NEED TO
CATCH THEM UP.
SO YOUR CHILD AS SOON AS YOU'RE
ESSENTIALLY IF THEY'RE CAUGHT UP
AS MUCH AS THEY CAN BE NOT
THEY'RE FULLY IMMUNIZED THEY CAN
GO AND ATTEND SCHOOL AS A
CONDITIONAL.
ENTRANCE AND SO -- THAT'S ALL
THAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN IN THAT
THIRTY DAY PERIOD BEFORE THEIR
CHILD CAN THEN CONTINUE IN
SCHOOL AND STAY IN SCHOOL SO.
DURING THE PROCESS UNABLE TO
STAY IN SCHOOL YES OUT YES AND
TELL THE PROCESS IS ACTUALLY NOT
SO GREAT STATE EXISTING THE
COULD BE UP FOR SOME TIME TO
REVIEW WILL BE ABLE. TO TO BE A
ALL REMAIN AS THEY CAN REMAIN IN
SCHOOL UNTIL THE ENTIRE PROCESS
IS COMPLETED SO THEY CAN APPLY --
DECISION DATA FILE THAT THE PART
OF THE HEALTH IS A VALUE IN THIS
PART OF HEALTH.
REJECT SAID THEY SUPPLY FOR THE
APPEAL GUARD UNTIL THE APPEAL
BOARD ITSELF IS DECIDED -- THEY
CAN STAY IN SCHOOL AND THEN EVEN
IF THE FUEL BOARD DANCE AS WELL
THIS IS NOT APPROPRIATE YOU THEN
HAVE THIRTY DAYS BEYOND THAT
POINT -- THE FOR YOU.
TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THAT AND
ON PAGE -- TWELVE TALKS ABOUT
THE CREATION OF THE INDEPENDENT
EXPERT REVIEW PANEL -- WHEN
WITHIN THAT EXPERT REVIEW PANEL --
BY THE THROUGH THE THROUGH THE
STATE -- THOSE THAT WILL BE
DECIDING WHO GETS ON THAT PANEL
WILL COME DIRECTLY FROM THE
SECRETARY OR FROM FROM WHERE
WELL THEY JUST APPOINTED BY THE
SECRETARY OF THE PART OF HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AND I WILL
THOSE THAT.
IT DIDN'T GO DEEPER INTO IN A
AND THANK YOU FOR COMING TO MY
OFFICE EXPLAINED I KNOW WE SPENT
A LOT OF TIME TALKING ABOUT THIS
ISSUE -- SO.
BEING ABLE TO DECIDE WHO'S GOING
TO BE ON THAT EXPERT REVIEW
PANEL IS SOLELY IN THE
DISCRETION OF THE SECRETARY.
OR IS THEIR QUALIFICATIONS FOR
THOSE THAT WOULD BE ON THAT
EXPERT PANEL FOR INSTANCE THOSE
THAT HAVE ISSUED -- EXEMPTIONS
THOSE THAT HAVE SEEN SOME OF
THESE CASES RIGHT TO HAVE SOME
INTIMATE KNOWLEDGE OF IT SO THAT
THEY CAN ACTUALLY VIEW MORE OF
THAT DOCUMENTATION SO WHAT WE IT
SAYS IS THAT SAID THEY HAVE THE
THEY HAVE TO EXPERIENCE EITHER
AS A PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIAN
WHICH IS WHO.
WOULD NORMALLY BE IT GETTING
EXEMPTIONS OR HAVE EXPERTISE AND
AND VACCINES AND IN AND EFFECTS
DISEASE WHICH IS OF COURSE WHAT
VACCINES ABOUT PREVENTING SO YOU
HAVE TO HAVE SOME.
EXPERTISE IN MEDICAL PRACTICE --
IN PRIMARY CARE ABOUT I DON'T
THINK WE SPECIFY CARE OF
CHILDREN BUT BUT WE SAY PRIMARY
CARE BECAUSE THE AND AND ALSO --
KNOWLEDGE OF VACCINATION AND AND
FIX THE SEASONS.
WE WILL AT ANY POINT I KNOW IT'S
STILL BEING WORKED ON BUT AT
THAT POINT AS FAR AS EXPERTS --
BEING.
THOSE ARE TO BE ON THAT PANEL
WOULD THERE BE ANY --
CONSIDERATION TO PARENTS OR
GUARDIANS OF THOSE THAT MIGHT
HAVE AN OPINION OF OF WHO MIGHT
BE ON THAT EXPERT PANEL.
SO I WOULD SAY IS THAT IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT'S OPEN FOR
DISCUSSION DOWN THE ROAD.
WELL I WOULD SAY IS THAT THIS IS
A PEER REVIEW PANEL SO PEER
REVIEW MEANS OTHER PHYSICIANS --
THAT'S USUALLY UP YOUR REVIEW
WORKS AND IT REALLY IS ABOUT
MAKING A JUDGMENT ABOUT.
THE APPROPRIATENESS OF THE
VACCINIA VACCINE WHICH IS REALLY
A IN MANY WAYS A PRACTICE TAKE A
TECHNICAL ISSUE.
LOOKING AT THE EVIDENCE SO --
AND ALSO WHAT'S WITHIN THE RANGE
OF NORMAL PRACTICE -- AND THAT'S
HOW BY THE WAY THE MEDICAL BOARD
WORKS THEY HAVE -- IF YOU'RE
BEING INVESTIGATED THEY BRING IN
PHYSICIANS WHO ARE KNOWLEDGEABLE
ABOUT THAT MODE OF PRACTICE --
AT THAT TO TO REVIEW WHETHER --
THE MEDICAL PORTION PURSUE --
THAT CASE SO YOU ANTICIPATE THAT --
DOES IT WOULD BE ON THE PANEL
WOULD HAVE SOME TYPE OF
KNOWLEDGE OF ISSUING EXEMPTIONS
UNDERSTAND THAT HOPE YASIN'S
CORRECT YES THANK YOU THANK YOU --
SENATOR PAT THANK YOU JIM.
AS CHAIR WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LIKE A RESPONSE FROM THE
OPPOSITION.
ONLY AT THE DISCRETION A MEMBER.
GIVE ME DO YOU WISH THAT MR
RAHMAN THE THROUGH THE AUTHOR --
WOULD YOU LIKE TO HAVE
TERRIFYING POINTS TO ANY OF
THOSE QUESTIONS ARE.
EXCUSE ME PLEASE.
WOULD YOU LOOK TO SOME OF THE
THE PANEL DISCUSSION TO CLARIFY
SOME OF THOSE QUESTIONS I US
THROUGH THE AUTHOR.
OKAY SO BASICALLY EVERY TALK
ABOUT THE ROUTE THE APPEALS
PANEL.
YES SO -- THE SET.
IT CAN ACTUALLY CAN YOU REPEAT
YOUR QUESTION I WANT TO BE CLEAR
I'LL ANSWER EXACTLY WHAT THEY
CONSIDER PAN.
MISTER CHAIR I WOULD LIKE TO
HEAR FROM OPPOSITION OKAY WELL
THAT IS A PARTICULAR ARE YEAH
SOMEONE PARTICULARLY LIKE TO
HEAR FROM MR RAHMAN. FOR THE
MEDICAL HI I WOULD LIKE TO REFER
TO THE SECTION FIVE ABOUT THE
APPEAL PROCESS.
AND I CAN READ -- DEFINITIVE AN
EXEMPTION IS PENDING APPEAL THE
CHILD MUST COMPLY WITH THE
CONDITIONAL.
ADMISSION SCHEDULE FOR
IMMUNIZATIONS AND CONTINUED
ATTENDANCE REQUIREMENTS THAT
MEANS.
THE CHILD DOES HAVE TO CONTINUE
VACCINATING WHILE THEY'RE
EXEMPTION APPEAL PROCESS IS
MOVING FORWARD.
SO THAT MEANS FOR EXAMPLE IF I
SEE A PATIENT IN MY OFFICE AND
THE PATIENT HAS A SEIZURE AFTER
VACCINATION.
AND I DECIDE THAT CHILD SHOULD
NOT GET ANY MORE DOSES OF THAT
VACCINE.
MORE DOSES MIGHT BE DO -- ONE OR
TWO MONTHS LATER FOR THAT CHILD --
AND I WANT TO SUBMIT TO AN
EXEMPTION TO SAY THAT EXEMPTION
IS TO NINE AND GOES TO THE
APPEAL PROCESS SAID APPEAL
PROCESS TAKES MONTHS AND MONTHS
SIX MONTHS A YEAR I DON'T KNOW
HOW LONG IT'S GONNA TAKE.
THIS WILL REQUIRE ME TO CONTINUE
VACCINATING THAT CHILD THE SAME
VACCINE WHICH WAS BECAUSE THAT
SEIZURE IN ORDER FOR THAT CHILD
TO STAY IN SCHOOL.
AND TO ME THAT IS DOES NOT MAKE
SENSE NOR IS THAT IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE CHILD AND I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT THE PENDING
OUR OUR CURRENT AMENDMENTS
THAT'S NOT THE CASE.
YEAH IS NOT THE CASE OKAY THANK
YOU THINK HERE IN THE THE
CLARIFICATION THROUGH THE AUTHOR
THAT IT IS CLEAR A YES WITH A
QUESTION.
THAT THOSE THA ARE GOING
THROUGH A PROCESS OF OF EITHER --
THE APPEAL PROCESS OR ANY THE
PROCESS A SPELL IT OUT IN THIS --
LINE ITEM THAT YEAR THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT A PAGE.
TEN THAT.
THE STUDENT WOULD BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE SCHOOL WITHOUT HAVING
TO GO THROUGH ANYMORE SACCHI
VACCINATIONS DURING THAT TIME.
THIS IS A PART AMENDMENTS THAT
THAT THAT IS HAPPENING ACCEPTED
BY THE AUTHOR THROUGH THE FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU AND THAT CONCLUDES BUT
SOME MEMBERS CAN I RESPOND THAT
FAMILY HISTORY LESSON LOSING MY
QUESTION THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH DOCTOR REGULAR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND IF I
MAY I WANTED TO ASK THE MEDICAL
BOARD WHO I BELIEVE IS HERE IN
ATTENDANCE.
QUESTION BUT ONLY THROUGH YOU
MISTER CHAIR.
I'M I'M SORRY I WAS I'D LIKE TO
ASK A QUESTION OF THE MEDICAL
BOARD IF THE HOUSE OKAY.
SORRY PANEL IN FRONT.
PLEASE.
I NOTICED YOU'RE A TWEENER
EARLIER AND SO REALLY WANTED.
TO ASK YOU A FEW QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE PROCESS NOW OKAY HOW HAVE
PHYSICIANS BEEN IN COOPERATING
WITH INVESTIGATIONS.
RELATED TO IMMUNIZATIONS SO --
AS I STATED IN MY TESTIMONY WE
WE ARE HAVING.
ISSUES ITH LOOKING AT THESE
MEDICAL EXEMPTION CASES BECAUSE
I THINK A CENTER PAN MENTION
THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE
AUTHORIZATION FROM THE PARENT IN
ORDER TO GET THE RELEASE FOR THE
MEDICAL RECORDS.
IN A CENTER PAN SAID THAT'S THE
FIRST STEP IN OUR FOR SOME
PROCESS.
SO WHAT WE DO IS WE HAVE ANOTHER
POSITION EXPERT LOOK AT THE
MEDICAL RECORDS THE AND WHICH
INCLUDES THE HISTORY AND AND
THEY BASICALLY MAKE THE DECISION
ON WHICH TO THAT CASE GO FOR FOR
AN INVESTIGATION.
IF WE CAN'T GET THOSE MEDICAL
RECORDS WE DO HAVE ISSUES AND
LOOKING AT THESE CASES HOW MANY
INVESTIGATIONS HAVE YOU BEEN
ABLE TO COMPLETE.
ACTUALLY HAVE SOME STATISTICS
WHERE DOES PULL NOT REALLY FAST.
AND IF YOU CAN WHILE YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THOSE STATISTICS HOW
MANY HAVE YOU BEEN UNABLE TO
COMPLETE SO I DON'T HAVE THAT
INFORMATION BECAUSE IT'S NOT
CATEGORIES THAT WAY BUT I CAN
GIVE YOU THE INFORMATION I HAVE
SO -- WE HAVE RECEIVED A HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY NINE COMPLAINTS --
WE'VE TAKEN ONE ACTION THAT
RESULTED IN PROBATION WE HAVE A
HUNDRED AND THREE INVESTIGATIONS
CURRENTLY PENDING -- AND THE
NUMBEROF COMPLAINTS CLOSED AS
INSUFFICIENT EVIDENCE IS FORTY
NINE AND SO THAT COULD BE FOR A
VARIETY OF THINGS BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE A CATEGORIES THAT WE
IN OUR SYSTEM SO COULD BE.
THAT WE DIDN'T GET THE MEDICAL
RECORDS WE COULD LOOK AT THOSE
CASES IT COULD BE THAT WE ARE
ABLE TO LOOK AT HIM AND OUR
EXPERTS SAID THERE WAS
INSUFFICIENT EVIDENCE.
BUT THAT NUMBER IS FORTY NINE
HOW LONG ON AVERAGE DOES ONE OF
THESE INVESTIGATIONS THANK YOU
I'M OUR INVESTIGATIONS ON
AVERAGE AND THESE INVESTIGATIONS
ARE LIKE THE OTHER INVESTIGATION
SO THEY CAN TAKE -- A YEAR A
YEAR AND A HALF TO INVESTIGATE
JUST BECAUSE WE HAVE TO GET THE
MEDICAL RECORDS WE HAVE TO
DECIDE OF THAT NEEDS AN
INVESTIGATION THEN IT GOES TO
THE INVESTIGATION PROCESS AT DCA.
WHAT A CONSUMER AFFAIRS THE BILL
THAT'S BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE
STREAMLINED?
THE PROCESS FOR THE MEDICAL
BOARD SO THAT YOU CAN DO THESE
INVESTIGATIONS IN A MORE
EFFICIENT MANNER YES IT WOULD
AND THAT IS ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE SUPPORT IN THIS BILL
WOULD ALLOW US. TO BE ABLE TO
GET THOSE MEDICAL RECORDS AND SO
WE CAN LOOK INTO THESE CASES.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
WITH THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIKE A
RESPONSE [inaudible]
MISTER MAY.
THANK YOU A THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I JUST WANTED TO BUT ALSO
TO OF SAY -- TO THE AUTHOR I IT
IS INCREDIBLY UNFORTUNATE --
THAT YOU'VE HAD TO TAKE -- THE
THE THE BRUISING -- THAT YOU
THAT YOU HAVE -- A FOR THOSE
THAT ARE OF COURSE -- LET EVEN
SAYING THAT THE THE FOLKS THAT
HAVE BEEN IN THE ROOM -- THEY
WHAT THEY MIGHT NOT KNOW IS I
ACTUALLY I DO NOT SUPPORT SB --
TWO SEVEN SEVEN AND I'M
STRUGGLING WITH THIS -- ONE I
WILL TELL YOU A THAT AND I'VE
NEVER IN MY LIFE AND IN PUBLIC
OFFICE EVER.
BEEN INSULTED BY SOMEONE THEY
GOT ME WANTED IT TO SUPPORT
THEIR EFFORTS -- IF SOMEBODY WAS
OPPOSING ME IN A CONSULTING IT
USUALLY MOVE ME IN THE OTHER
DIRECTION SO -- I THINK IT'S
IT'S UNFORTUNATE.
THAT WE'VE WE'VE HAD WE HAVE
SOME OF THIS THIS BEHAVIOR AND
YOU HAD TO TAKE AN AWFUL AN
AWFUL LOT SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PERSEVERANCE ON THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT YOU DO.
THAT YOU DO BELIEVE AND GIVE.
DO YOU HAVE A A QUESTION -- IN
REGARDS.
TO THIS IDEA OF A ONE DOCTOR
ONLY BE ABLE TO HAVE FIVE
EXEMPTIONS.
I HAD SPOKEN EARLIER TODAY WITH
A VERY CLOSE FRIEND OF MINE --
AND THEY HAD -- A LITTLE A
LITTLE BABY GIRL -- THAT WENT
AND GOT -- AN MMR VACCINATION
AND OF AND VERY NEXT DAY --
THERE IS A RASH THAT DEVELOPED --
AND THAT RASH STATE -- FOR A
LITTLE OVER OVER A YEAR.
AND SO THEY SOUGHT OUT -- BUT
THEY WERE ALL THIS AND VERY
SCARED -- DIDN'T KNOW WHAT TO
THINK GOT ONLINE STARTED DIGGING
UP A BUNCH OF INFORMATION AND
THEN ONE OUT AND SOUGHT OUT A
DOCTOR -- TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE --
THEM -- SOME SOME GUIDANCE AND
SO IF YOU'RE SEEKING EIGHT A
DOCTOR WHO SPENDS A LOT OF TIME
ON THESE ISSUES AND I HAVE TO
BELIEVE THAT THERE.
ARE SOME BAD DOCTORS BUT THERE'S
ALSO SOME GOOD DOCTORS AS WELL
WHO SPENT AN AWFUL LOT OF TIME.
ON THIS ISSUE AND IF THAT ONE
GOOD DOCTOR WHO'S BECOME AN
EXPERT IN THESE ISSUES WHY WOULD
BE UNACCEPTABLE.
OF FOR THEM TO WRITE MORE THAN
FIVE OR FOR THAT MATTER ON THE
BE AT RISK OF FOR TEN TWENTY
THIRTY FORTY HUNDREDS OF THESE
BECAUSE ALL OF A SUDDEN EVEN
EXPERT THERE'S GOING TO BE THE
PEOPLE GOING TO SEE SEEK THEM
OUT WHY WOULD THAT BE
UNACCEPTABLE.
WHAT FIRST OF ALL I POINT OUT
THAT THE FIVE IS NOT A CAP?
IT'S A TRIGGER FOR EXAMINATION
RIGHT SO IT'S NOT A CAP -- IT SO
WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT IF YOU SO
IF YOU ARE AN AS AT POINT OUT
EXAMPLE MIGHT BE AN ECOLOGIST OR
YOUR SONY TAKES A LOT TRANSPLANT
PATIENTS RIGHT.
YOUR TO FROLIC JUST AND YOU HAVE
A LOT OF KIDS OF KIDNEY
TRANSPLANTS CORRECT AND AND
MAYBE BECAUSE THEY SPEND A LOT
OF TIME WITH YOU IT'S JUST
EASIER TO ASK YOU ARE YOU YOU
MIGHT WANT TO BE THE ONE TO
RAISE THE ISSUE OF I THINK YOU
NEED. TO HAVE A MEDICAL
EXEMPTION FACT I WOULD POINT OUT
THAT MOST OF THE TIME.
YOU SHOULD IT'S USUALLY THE
DOCTOR WHO'S TAKING CARE OF THE
PATIENT IS AS YOU WELL YOU HAVE
A CONDITION I DON'T THINK YOU
CHARGING GET THE VACCINE THAT
WHICH MEANS THEN I SHOULD GIVE
YOU MEDICAL SENSE AND NOT THE
PARENT GOING -- I WANT A MEDICAL
EXEMPTION IT'S USUALLY THE OTHER
WAY AROUND ACTUALLY WHERE OF
PHYSICIANS TAKING CARE OF A
CHILD TO DO YOU KNOW WHAT I
CONCERNED WHETHER A VACCINE
WOULD BE.
YOU KNOW THE BEST THING FOR YOUR
CHILD THEREFORE I I WOULD
RECOMMEND YOU NOT GET THE
VACCINES AND I'M GOING TO GO
RIGHT YEAH SUBMIT A MEDICAL
EXEMPTION.
AND SO WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IS IS
THAT -- IS IT ANY PHYSICIAN HIS
WRITING APPROPRIATE LEGITIMATE
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS HAS NOTHING
TO FEAR.
BECAUSE THAT FIVE TO SIMPLY FOR
EXAMINATION WE WANTED TO BE MORE
TARGETED THAT'S WHY WE PICKED
THE FIVE BUT THE BASICALLY IF
THE THIS IS A LEGITIMATE YOU'VE
JUSTIFY THE REASON -- THEN --
WE'VE APPROVED AND WAS APPROVED
THERE'S NO NO ISSUE IT'S THAT IF
YOU'RE SUBMITTING NUMEROUS
EXEMPTIONS.
THAT ARE SUSPECT AND THEY GO
THROUGH THE PROCESS AND BOTH ALL
THE REVIEW SAYS YOU KNOW WHAT
WE'RE REJECTING THIS ONE
REJECTING ANOTHER ONE REJECTING
ANOTHER.
ONE THEN THAT LEADS TO GREATER
THAN THAT LEADS TO AN ISSUE SO
ITS ROUTE SO THIS IS THE
OVERSIGHT PART RIGHT SO WHAT
HAPPENS IS THAT IT WE WANT -- TO
BE SURE THAT WERE -- BE SHOULD
BE SURE THAT THE PERSON
EXERCISING RESPONSIBILITY BY THE
EVIDENCE SHOWS THE PROOF SHOWS A
SUBMIT THEM OF THEIR EXAMINED
AND THOSE ARE ALL LEGITIMATE
THEY CAN WRITE AS MANY AS THEY
WATCHED.
THERE'S NO CAP IT SIMPLY SAYS IF
YOU WRITE MORE AND FIVE IN THE
YEAR YOUR SUBJECT -- TO SOME
ADDITIONAL SKILLED YEAH I WAS
WITH YOUR SAID THAT THAT THE
EXEMPTION ITSELF ACTUALLY IS IT.
SUBJECT TO SCRUTINY YOU'RE NOT
LESS YOU'VE BEEN WRITING A LOT
OF THE ONES THAT BEEN REJECTED.
AND I WOULD POINT OUT THAT --
THE EVEN A COLLEGE JUST -- WHO
MAY END UP WRITING MORE FIVE IN
A YEAR DESPITE NOT GONNA WRITE
HUNDREDS BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
REALLY TAKING CARE THAT MANY
PATIENTS THAT WOULD REQUIRE THEM
BUT THAT AGAIN DEPENDS ON THE
CIRCUMSTANCE?
THANK YOU KNOW IF -- MISTER
ACTUALLY WOULD LIKE TO ASK
DOCTOR SEARS ABOUT THAT BECAUSE
I THINK DOCTOR SEARS MIGHT BE
ONE OF THOSE -- DOCTORS THAT
PEOPLE UP C. SEEK OUT -- AND US
SO WELL.
YOU KNOW BUT WE CAN SPEAK TO
THAT.
YES I'M MY MY CONCERN IS CALLED
TELL YOU GUYS WHAT I'VE BEEN
DOING UNDER SP TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOR THREE FOUR YEARS NOW.
WHEN I SEE A CHILD WITH A SEVERE
VACCINE REACTION?
THAT'S NOT A CUT CDC GUIDELINES
BUT IT'S SOMETHING NOT ME --
IMMEDIATELY LIFE THREATENING
SUCH AS A SEIZURE OR IN YOUR
EXAMPLE THE CHILD WHO DEVELOPED
CHRONIC EXAM A RASH AFTER MMR
VACCINE FOR SOMEONE AT A
TEMPORARY NERVE INJURY AFTER
VACCINATION.
NONE OF THOSE ARE CDC GUIDELINES
TO TO STOP ACTIVATION BUT UNDER
SB TWO SEVEN SEVEN WHEN I WAS UP
TO MY JUDGMENT AS A DOCTOR I CAN
JUDGE.
THAT CHILD SHOULDN'T GET MORE
DOSES OF THAT VACCINE SO THAT I
CAN DECIDE THAT THAT CHILD TO BE
EXACT AND I BELIEVE THAT'S FAIR
AND I WOULD.
I WOULD IMAGINE A LOT OF YOU
WOULD NOT WANT TO GIVE YOUR
CHILD MORE DOSES OF THE VACCINE
IF THEY HAD A SEIZURE.
OR NERVOUS IN JURY OR SEVERE
EXAM OR ANY OTHER KINDS OF
DOZENS OF OTHER SEVERE REACTIONS
SO THAT'S ALL UNDER SB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN AND THAT'S TIME PRACTICING
NOW.
MY CONCERN WITH THIS BILL IS
IT'S GOING TO TAKE EVERY
EXEMPTION I'VE EVER DONE UNDER
THOSE GUIDELINES WHICH ARE NOT
RESTRICTED TO CDC COUNTRY
NEGATIONS.
UNDER THOSE ALL GUIDELINES THEY
CAN NOW REVIEW EVERY SINGLE ONE
OF MY EXEMPTIONS OF TIME AND
JUST QUALIFY EACH AND EVERYONE
OF THEM.
AND KICK THOSE KIDS OUT OF
SCHOOL THEY'RE SORT OF RETRO
ACTIVELY CHANGING THE GUIDELINES
ALL THE EXAMPLES I'VE EVER DONE
AND OTHER POSITIONS OF EVER DONE.
AND TO ME THAT'S A VERY VERY
CONCERNING PRECEDENT FOR
GOVERNMENT TO GO BACK LIKE THAT
AND THE GATE YEARS OF MEDICAL
CARE THAT'S BEEN DONE.
LEGALLY AND PROPERLY UNDER THE
GUIDELINES OF TWO SEVEN SEVEN SO
IT IT DOES SEEM AS THOUGH LEAST
FROM.
SOME OF THE SOCIAL MEDIA -- AND
THAT THAT IS PUBLIC RECORDS
PEOPLE POSTED THAT THERE ARE
SOME DOCTORS -- WHO ARE -- A
TAKING MONEY AND WRITING MEDICAL
EXCEPTIONS IT SEEMS PRETTY
CLEARLY IS THE PUBLISHER OF HAVE
DISCLOSED THAT.
AM I AM AND MY SENSE IS THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT THE AUTHOR IS
TRYING TO SOLVE A FOR OUR OUR
OUR SOME UNSCRUPULOUS DOCTORS
THAT ARE WILLING TO TAKE A CHECK --
TO RIDE A MEDICAL EXEMPTION
BECAUSE THAT -- THAT THAT WAS.
NOT THE POINT OF OF TWO SEVEN
SEVEN SO HOW DO WE CREATE THEN A
NEW RULE OR NEW STANDARD AND I'M
GONNA HAVE DOCTORS YEARS ANSWER
THIS ALL COME BACK TO THAT THE
AUTHOR THEN.
HOW DO WE CREATE A STANDARD NO
THAT WOULD SEEM TO HAVE SOME
DOCTORS THAT ARE NOT DOING THIS --
JUST OF FOR A PROFIT MAKING
SCHEME -- AND FOR THOSE WHO ARE
HOW DO YOU HOW DO YOU SOLVE FOR
THAT IT'S A GREAT QUESTION I
WILL TELL YOU WHAT I DO
PERSONALLY AS I CHARGE.
THE SAME AMOUNT OF MONEY FOR
PATIENTS WHO I SEE FOR A MEDICAL
EXEMPTION AS I DO FOR NEW
PATIENTS COMING IN TO ME FOR A
CHECK UP.
OR CONSULTATION I DON'T CHARGE
ANYMORE IN FACT MY MEDICAL
EXEMPTION APPOINTMENTS ACTUALLY
TWO APPOINTMENTS I'M I DON'T
MAKE ANY MORE MONEY FROM DOING A
MEDICAL EXEMPTION BY MINUTES
ANYTHING ELSE.
SO THAT'S THAT'S ALL I DO I CAN
ESOS SPEAK TO A TUNE US OR
WHATEVER OTHER DOCTORS DO I'M
JUST SAYING.
I FEEL LIKE I'M DOING THIS IN A
VERY SCRUPULOUS WAY I DO NOT
ADVERTISE FORT I DON'T ADVERTISE
ON SOCIAL MEDIA I DON'T EVEN
HAVE A WEST SO I'M GONNA MAKE
THE ASSUMPTION AND ASK YOU I'M
GONNA MAKE THE ASSUMPTION THAT
YOU'RE A GREAT DOCTOR AND YOU DO
A GOOD.
WORK AND THE TH THE THE THAT YOU
ARE NOT ONE OF THESE PEOPLE THAT
THAT ARE DOING IT FOR THE
PURPOSE OF MAKING MONEY.
LET'S MAKE THAT THIS JUST AT THE
ASSUME THAT THERE ARE BECAUSE I
THINK IN FACT I'M I'M PRETTY
SURE LEASE FROM SOME OF SOCIAL
MEDIA POSTS THAT I'VE SEEN THAT
THERE'S SOME DOCTORS ARE DOING
THIS JUST MAKING MONEY.
HOW FROM THE STATE'S PERSPECTIVE --
HOW WOULD YOU PUT TOGETHER SOME
GUIDELINES OR HOW WOULD YOU COME
UP WITH SOME RULES STATE LAW TO
BE ABLE TO SOLVE FOR THAT?
HERE AND I NOTICED THE THE
SENATOR OR DO YOU HOW DO A
LITTLE BIT OF LANGUAGE IN THE
BILL TOWARDS THAT WERE THERE NOT
ALLOW YOU TO CHARGE EXTRA FOR
FOLLOW UP EXAMS ETCETERA.
I MEAN IF THE I'M NOT AN EXPERT
IN THIS BUT THE STATE CERTAINLY
IT'S IN YOUR PURVIEW IN THIS LAW --
TO CREATE SOME SORT OF
GUIDELINES WHERE PEOPLE ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO OVER CHARGE. FOR NOT
ALLOWED TO BE UNSCRUPULOUS WITH
THEIR WITH THEIR BILLING I KNOW
I'M NOT AND YOU CERTAINLY COULD
WORK THAT A NOT ENOUGH UNISOURCE
SOME SORT OF PRICE LIMIT OR YOU
KNOW THAT WOULD BE KIND OF UP TO
YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
AND WILL SPEND BUT I DO WANT TO
SAY.
ALONG THOSE LINES IS A
PEDIATRICIAN I'M FULL AND BUSY
LIKE EVERY DAY I DON'T HAVE TO
DO ANY OF THESE EXEMPTIONS I'M
FULL JUST DOING CHECK UPS.
AND SICK VISITS SO WHY WOULD I
RISK MY LICENSE TO JUST START
DOING YOUR TIME THE MEDICAL
EXAMINER'S WHEN I I DON'T ME I
CERTAINLY DON'T NEED THE EXTRA
BUSINESS.
AND THERE TO SERVE THESE
FAMILIES WERE BAD SEVERE
REACTIONS KICKED OUT OF THEIR
OWN DOCTORS OFFICE AND THAT'S
WHAT I HAVE TO COME LOOKING FOR
SOMEBODY LIKE YOU SAID IS AN
EXPERT.
ON THAT SO THANK YOU FOR THE
REST RIGHT LOOK IN IN AND BACK
THAT POINT I WASN'T MAKING IS
SOMETHING THAT WAS YOUR CASE I'M
JUST SAYING THAT WE KNOW THERE
ARE SOME DOCTORS.
AND I ALSO THINK THAT'S PROBABLY
WHY THE THAT CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION CARE SO DEEPLY ABOUT
THIS ISSUES AND FORTUNATELY
THERE ARE THAT THEIR THEIR
REPUTATION IS ON THE LINE
BECAUSE YOU'VE GOT SOME DOCTORS
THAT ARE -- THAT THAT THAT ARE --
USING THIS IS A PROFIT MAKING
SCHEME I MEAN IT IS PRETTY CLEAR
THE EVIDENCE.
AND THE MEDICAL BOARD DOES HAVE
THE AUTHORITY TO TO LOOK INTO
THAT AND INVESTIGATE DOCTORS
BASED ON THEIR FINANCIAL
PRACTICES THAT THAT WOULD BE ONE
STOP.
THEY COULD TAKE A YOU'RE RIGHT
YOU COULD ALSO CREATE GUIDELINES
FOR US THAT THAT WE WOULD HAVE
TO FOLLOW RIGHT.
DR THANK YOU JUST A LITTLE BIT
OF A SEARCH TO HEAR YOU SAY YOUR
FIRST OF ALL OF COURSE YOU KNOW
WE ARE ESTABLISHING IN THIS --
BELL GUIDELINES -- FOR OVERSIGHT --
WE'VE HEARD ALREADY FROM THE
MEDICAL BOARD ABOUT THEIR
CHALLENGES I WOULD POINT OUT
THAT TO ACTUALLY THE ONE PERSON
MEDICAL BOARD HAS -- ACTUALLY
PUT ON PROBATION FOR IN A
PROBABLY MEDICAL EXEMPTION IS
DOCTOR SEARS HIMSELF IS HERE.
THE THE MAN HERE HE'S ALSO PUT
HE'S USED TO HAVE A LIST OF CODE
VACCINE FAMILY PHYSICIANS ON HIS
WEBSITE HE SINCE TAKEN IT DOWN --
SO -- HE SO HE'S BEEN HI IT
HEAVILY INVOLVED IN.
IT AND ACTUALLY THIS KIND OF
ACTIVITY -- AND SO I THINK IT'S
INTERESTING THAT HE'S THE ONE
WHO'S A TRYING TO SAY THAT WELL
YOU CAN LOOK AT FINANCIAL OR
WHATEVER ELSE.
BASICALLY WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS
IS AS WE APPLY STANDARDS RIGHT
WE'RE GONNA HAVE STANDARDS AND
BY THE WAY THE STAND IS GONNA BE
THE FIND.
BY SCIENCE THE EVIDENCE AND WHAT
IS.
NORMAL MEDICAL PRACTICE RIGHT
THAT'S THAT THAT'S WHAT THE
STANDARDS WE ESTABLISHED SO WE
CREATE YEAH WE CREATE SOME
LATITUDE.
THERE.
STANDARD OF CARE RIGHT IS THAT
SOMETHING A NORMAL -- PHYSICIAN
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHICH
IS TO BE EXPECTED WITH EXPECT
EXPECTED TO DO IS THAT WITHIN
THIS THE DISCO WAS THAT IS THAT
WITHIN THE QUALITY STANDARDS THE
EVIDENCE.
SO FORTH AND SO THAT IS WHAT
WE'RE DOING WE'RE SAYING THAT
YOU NEED TO MEET THE BASICALLY
THE SMELL TEST YOUR EXEMPTION.
WOULD NEED TO MEET THAT SMELL
WELL THAT CERTAINLY IS NOT
APPROPRIATE -- THAT IS AND DON'T
GET KEEP IN MIND THIS IS
SCISSION TO GRANT A MEDICAL
EXEMPTION SO VITALLY AGAIN OF
ONE EMPHASIZED -- YOU CAN STILL
YOU CAN CHOOSE WHETHER TO
VACCINATE YOUR CHILD OR NOT.
THAT'S YOUR DECISION THERE IS NO
FOUR SAKS NATION.
RIGHT THERE IS A CONSEQUENCE TO
THAT.
THE CONSEQUENCES NOT TO PENALIZE
THE CHILD IS NOT VACCINATED
THEIR FAMILY THE CONSEQUENCES
ABOUT THE SAFETY OF THE SCHOOL
WHICH THEY'RE TENDING.
AND THAT THE REASON WE'RE DOING
THIS BILL.
IS NOT TO GET DOCTOR BOB SEARS
AS MUCH AS HE MIGHT DISAGREE.
IT'S REALLY TO BE SURE THE
SCHOOLS ARE SAFE SO IN FACT I
JUST MENTIONED IN MY OPENING WE
HAVE THE SAN JOSE MERCURY LOOKED
AT EIGHT SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
AND FOUND THAT. FIVE POSITIONS
ARE WRITING OVER HALF OF ALL THE
MEDICAL EXEMPTION SAN DIEGO ONE
PHYSICIAN ROAD ALMOST A THIRD BY
LATE DOCTORS YEARS OF PRACTICE
DOWN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WROTE
WHEN AN EXEMPTION.
AFTER YOU GUYS PROBATION UP IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA SO EIGHT I
THINK YOU KNOW THERE ARE SOME
QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT THAT'S WHY
WE NEED TO HAVE THE STANDARD
AGAIN YOU HAVE A MEDICAL
EXEMPTION.
WE'RE NOT SAYING IT'S AUTOMAT IT
WE'RE NOT SAYING THAT ALL OF YOU
RIGHT MORE THAN FIVE THAT
THEREFORE WE REJECT ALL
EXEMPTIONS WE JUST SAY THAT WE
SHOULD LOOK AT THEM BECAUSE THEY
NEED TO BE OVERSIGHT BECAUSE
REALLY.
WE HELP THE NEEDS TO BE
RESPONSIBILITY RIGHT BECAUSE WE
NEED TO KEEP THE KIDS SAFE AT
SCHOOL SOMEONE A CHILD ATTEND
SCHOOL THEY NEED TO KNOW THAT
THE OTHER CHILDREN IN THE SCHOOL
IF THEY HAVE A GENUINE.
WITH A GENUINE MEDICAL CENTER
THEM IS THEY'RE NOT VACCINATED
THEY NEED TO KNOW WHERE TO GO TO
SCHOOL THAT THE OTHER SCHOOLS IN
THEIR KIDS AND THEIR THE OTHER
KIDS IN YOUR SCHOOL.
WHO CAN BE VACCINATED ARE SO
THEY CAN STAY SAFE THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL IS ABOUT?
AND JUST OF THE FOLLOW UP IS
THERE SOME OTHER BACK TO THIS
IDEA OF A SPECIALIST IN THIS --
COULD THERE BE SOME OTHER.
STANDARD IN WHICH BY A
SPECIALIST -- COULD DO MORE OF
THESE -- SURE YES.
I I THINK THAT IF I WOULD SAY IS
THAT SO WHAT SOME THE THINGS WE
CRAFT.
NO NO NO YOU TO PLEASE.
YEAH SO WHERE THINGS HERE WE WE
CRAFTED THIS AND I WANT TO THANK
THE AGAIN TO HEALTH COMMITTEE
STAFF -- SO WHAT -- EXCUSE ONE
THE CHANGES TO THE BILL -- AT
THE REQUEST OF THE ASSEMBLY
INSTANTLY I AGREE IS IS THAT IF
YOU'RE A PHYSICIAN WHO'S NOT THE
NORMAL SAYS THE OTHER NOR THE
REGULAR PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIAN
FOR THAT CHILD.
RIGHT AND YOU'RE SUBMITTING AN
EXEMPTION THAT -- WELL FIRST OF
ALL YOU HAVE TO TEST WITH YOU
ARE THE PRIMARY CARE DOCTOR NOT
IF YOU'RE NOT THEN YOU HAVE TO I
SEE NOTIFY THE PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIAN SO THEY'RE AWARE THAT
YOUR NOW PLAYING FOR A MEDICAL
EXEMPTION FOR A CHILD THAT
THERE'S A PRIMARY CARE DOCTOR.
FOR RIGHT.
WE ALSO HAVE TO TEST YOU
ACTUALLY EXAMINE THE CHILD -- I
THINK THAT ONE OF THE ISSUES
THAT -- THAT COMES UP AS WE FOR
THE WE KNOW THAT THAT PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN GRANTED MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS SIMPLY THROUGH AN
INTERVIEW OR SOMETHING ONLINE
THAT THEY'VE NEVER EXAMINED THE
CHILD -- IF YOU NEED TO HAVE AN
ON GOING RELATIONSHIP AS WELL SO
I MEAN THOSE ARE THINGS THAT THE
ASSEMBLY ASK FOR THAT -- I AGREE
WITH BECAUSE WHEN WE PASSED TWO
SEVEN SEVEN AGAIN AS I MENTIONED
WE DIDN'T REALLY TOUCH THE
MEDICAL EXEMPTION.
BUT WHAT WE OUR EXPECTATION IS
THAT IT'S GOING TO BE YOUR
CHILD'S REGULAR DOCTOR WHO KNOWS
THE CHILD HE'S GRANTING THEM AND
WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS IS THAT.
ACTUALLY WE HAVE PHYSICIANS AND
OF THE MEDICAL WORDS THAT'S THE
CASE YOU HAVE A PHYSICIAN AND
ANTI AGING CLINIC -- DOESN'T
REALLY TAKE YOUR PEDIATRICS WHO
IS WRITING A LOT OF MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS IN THE MEDICAL WORTH
LOOKING INTO THAT WE SAW IN SAN
DIEGO YOUR PHYSICIANS WHO DON'T
NORMALLY TAKE CARE OF CHILDREN I
KNOW DOCTOR SEARS HIMSELF AS A
PEDIATRICIAN.
BUT WE HAVE PHYSICIANS WHO ARE
NOT REALLY THE PRIMARY CARE
DOCTOR AND YEAH I THINK THIS
IDEA OF HAVING MEDICAL EXEMPTION
VISITS KIND OF INTRIGUING
BECAUSE YOU SHOULDN'T REALLY
HAVE MEDICAL EXEMPTION VISITS
YOU EITHER YOUR DOCTOR YOU'RE
NOT IN YOUR DOCTOR YOU SHOULD
TAKE CARE OF THEM YOU HAVE.
THAT RELATIONSHIP AND IF THEY
HAVE AN ISSUE WITH VACCINES DO
YOU RECKON THE EXEMPTION THAT'S
IT THAT'S WHAT SUPPOSED TO
NORMALLY HAPPEN PEOPLE SHOULDN'T
BE GOING OUT FINE THE OTHER
DOCTORS FOR EXEMPTIONS IF YOU
HAPPEN TO SEE A SPECIALIST.
AND THEY THINK YOU CAN'T GET
VACCINATED SAFELY THEN THE THERE
SOME OF THE EXEMPTION UNTIL YOUR
PRIMARY CARE DOCTOR BY THE WAY.
THAT CHAO'S INACTIVE VACCINATED
WE SHOULD GET AN EXEMPTION
THAT'S HOW SHOULD NORMALLY WORK.
THANK YOU DR GRANT THANK.
SURE OF COURSE MR MCCARTY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I I HAVE
SOME SOME THOUGHTS IN JUST ONE
QUESTION FOR DOCTOR PAN BUT BUT
BEFORE WE GET THERE -- I DID
APPRECIATE THE DEBATE AND AND
FRANKLY THERE WERE A LOT OF
THOUGHT FULL PARTICIPANTS PRETTY
MUCH ALL ON THE NEGATIVE SIDE ON
THE BILL -- THEIR WORST MAINLY
SINCERE -- WELL IN THE STORM
YEAH VERY THOUGHTFUL AND SO I
APPRECIATE THAT MANY FROM MY
DISTRICT HERE IN DISTRICT SEVEN
OF COURSE.
THE WORST TIME WHO HAD SOME
PERSONAL ATTACKS ON YOU WHICH I
FIND VERY TROUBLING AND
DISTURBING AND CERTAINLY DOESN'T
HELP MAKE THE CASE FOR THEM TO
TO GO AGAINST THIS BILL SO.
I JOIN MY COLLEAGUES IN
CONDEMNING THAT AND I JUST
WANTED. FOR THOSE OF YOU.
DATA.
THE QUESTION DOCTOR PAN IN HIS
BELIEFS BEFORE DOCTOR PAN.
WAS THAT SENATOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BEFORE I WAS AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
HOUSING COUNCILMEMBER HERE FOR
TEN YEARS AND MY TEN YEARS ONLY
ONE PEDIATRICIAN EVER KNOCKED ON
MY DOOR AND SAID HEY.
HOW CAN I HELP KIDS IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD GET HEALTHCARE FOR
KIDS LOVE ACCESS TO CARE SO I
KNOW?
IN YOUR HEART WHAT YOU CARE
ABOUT AND PUBLIC HEALTH ACCESS
TO CARE MAKING SURE THAT KIDS
GROW UP HEALTHY SO I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT AND THAT'S NOT
THE BILL RAY BYE SO NO THAT.
IS -- IS IS SOMETHING THAT I
WANT TO REFLECT AS FAR AS YOUR
LEGACY IN OUR COMMUNITY SO SO
WITH THAT I DID VOE.
FOR FOR TWO SEVEN SEVEN BECAUSE
I THOUGHT THE PERSONAL --
PERSONAL BELIEF EXEMPTION.
WAS -- WAS FLAWED PUBLIC POLICY
WASN'T BASED ON SCIENCE PER SE
WE WENT TO THIS -- THIS IS
SCIENCE DRIVEN THING BASED UPON
YOUR YOUR YOUR DOCTOR AND I GET
THAT.
AND AS MR MAYES -- COLLUDED TO
KINDA LIKE WE SAW ON THE AND THE
MEDICAL MARIJUANA.
FIELD LAST YEAR'S.
PEOPLE HAD A BACK ACHE A TOE
INJURY THEY CAN GO GET SOMEBODY
TO WRITE WHATEVER THEY WANTED.
AND AND EVEN THE THE THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO SINCERELY
BELIEVE THERE SHOULD BE THIS.
DOCTOR INDIVIDUAL RELATIONSHIP
BASED UPON.
HEALTH AND SCIENCE THAT THEY
PUBLIC KNOWLEDGE THAT THERE ARE
SOME SAMPLES THAT JUST -- DON'T
MAKE SENSE AND THAT REALLY ARE
FRAUDULENT.
AND WE SHOULDN'T HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA -- AND YOUR YOUR BILL
HERE FIRST EFFORT YOU TRY -- TO
ADDRESS THAT -- I WOULD SAY SOME
PEOPLE SAID THAT YOU MAY WANT TO
FARM YOUR FIRST DRAFT AND I DID
HAVE SOME SOME MEETINGS AND SOME
CONCERNS THE LAST FEW WEEKS AND
AND APPRECIATE THE CHANGES THAT
YOU PUT FOR THAT.
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE BUT FOR THE
GOVERNOR BEFORE -- I KNOW YOU'RE
NOT GONNA RE SURE A LOT OF
PEOPLE IN THE AUDIENCE TODAY
ABOUT THIS BUT I WANT TO GIVE
YOU ONE MORE CHANCE TO TALK WITH
THIS THE BIG PICTURE.
THAT THAT WILL WHERE YOU STARTED.
AND THE CONCERNS THE MAIN
CONCERNS OF I HEARD PEOPLE
COMING IN MY OFFICE SAYING.
THE CDC POLICY IS TOO NARROW
IT'S TOO NARROW.
AND THAT THERE ARE OTHER
EXAMPLES THAT WE SHOULD --
BROADENED THE SCOPE TO MAKE SURE
THAT TRUE.
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS FROM ONCE
DOCTOR NOT DOCTOR SHOPPING
DOCTOR BUT A TRUE DOCTOR CAN
EVALUATE AND CAN PROVIDE TO THE
STATE THAT WOULD THAT WOULD BE
APPROVED.
SO IF YOU WOULD GIVE.
US ONE MORE CHANCE TO OUTLINE
HOW YOU THINK THAT.
THAT THOSE WILL BE ADDRESSED IN
THE VERSION BEFORE US TODAY YES.
SO AGAIN WHAT THIS BILL DOES IT
SAYS THAT -- CERTAINLY REFERS TO
A SAID A C. I. P. C. C. WHICH IS
AN EVIDENCE BASED.
APPROACH IT ALSO HAS THE
AMERICAN CAB PEDIATRICS WHICH IS
A NON GOVERNMENTAL IT'S
PROFESSIONAL SOCIETY.
INDEPENDENT EVALUATION -- AND
THEN WE ALSO STATE STANDARD OF
CARE WHICH MEANS THAT IS IF
THAT'S SOMETHING RECENTLY DONE
BY PHYSICIAN AND CALIFORNIA ARE
IN THAT COMMUNITY.
THEN THAT WOULD BE SIR VALID.
AND I WOULD SAY IS THAT YOU KNOW
WHAT WE WANT TO TRY TO DO IS WHY
KEEP KIDS SAFE IN SCHOOL.
AND IN FACT THE REASON WE'RE
DOING IT TARGET APPROACH --
WHICH WAS ON REGIONAL BILL BUT I
CERTAINLY WAS AGREEABLE TO THAT --
FOR BOTH -- THE GOVERNOR AND
FROM -- THIS ASSEMBLY IS IS THAT
WHAT WE REALLY WANT TO DO IS SAY
NO WE WANT YOUR KIDS ARE SAFE AT
SCHOOL SO THE SCHOOL IS ABOVE
THE THRESHOLD.
YOU KNOW IT'S POSSIBLE THAT
EXEMPTION MIGHT NOT BE VALID OR
NOT BUT YOU KNOW WHAT THAT
SCHOOL SAFE -- THE KIDS WHO HAVE
THE EXEMPTIONS WHO NEED
EXEMPTION STILL BE OKAY RIGHT
THERE'S A HIGH ENOUGH LEVEL OF
PROTECTION.
BUT IF IT DROPS BELOW THAT.
WELL WE KNOW THERE'S SOME KIDS
WHO HAVE LEGITIMATE EXEMPTIONS
AND WE NEED TO KEEP THEM SAFE
RIGHT AND SO THE KIDS WHO HAVE A
LEGEND EXEMPTIONS WE NEED TO
KEEP THEM SAFE AND SO WE GOT
LOOK AT WELL WHO ALSO HAVE
EXEMPTIONS AND SOME OF THEM
DON'T HAVE IT.
WELL MAYBE THEY SHOULDN'T KEEP
THEM BECAUSE THAT'S ACTUALLY
ENDANGERING THE ONES WHO REALLY
NEED IT NOW I ALSO POINT OUT
THAT -- THE IDEA IS IS THAT.
WHEN WE SAY STANDARD OF CARE AND
AND WHAT'S REASONABLE FOR A
POSITION IS IS THAT YOU KNOW
THAT THE GOAL IS NOT TO SAY THAT
WILL?
DILATES NOT ABOUT PROVING -- THE
THE SAYING THAT -- YOU HAVE TO
PROVE THE VACCINE BECAUSE THE
PROBLEM RIGHT SO SOMETHING
HAPPENED RELATED AND YOU THINK
IT'S RELATED ACCEDE.
YEAH IT IT'S NOT ABOUT SAYING
THAT YOU HAVE TO PROVE THE
VACCINE CAUSED IT I THINK IT'S
REALLY MORE ABOUT SAYING WELL IF
YOU HAVE A CONDITION.
AND LET'S LOOK AT THE EVIDENCE
AND IF WE CAN SAY THAT THAT
ACTUALLY CONDITIONS BEEN CAUSED
BY SOMETHING ELSE NOT THE
VACCINE WE SHOULD ACCEPT THAT.
OR IF WE'VE ACTUALLY DISPROVED
THAT THE VACCINE ANYTHING TO DO
WITH IT IF THERE'S ANY QUESTION.
THE THAT WE CAN'T DISPROVE
VACCINE DIDN'T BECAUSE IT.
OF ANY WE CAN'T PROVE THE
VACCINE DIDN'T BECAUSE IT OR WE
CAN'T PROVE THAT THE THING THAT
HAPPENED HAD SOMETHING THAT WAS
THAT WAS THAT WAS DUE TO
SOMETHING VERY SPECIFICALLY NOT
THE VACCINE.
AND SO THAT MEANS THAT MAYBE IT
COULD BE THE VACCINE THEN WE'D
PROBABLY SAY OKAY YOU KNOW WHAT.
LET'S LET'S GIVE THEM THE
BENEFIT THE DOWN SAY IT COULD BE
THE VACCINE AND IT DOESN'T MEAN
IT IS BUT LET'S GIVE THE BENEFIT
DOWN SAID SO MUCH TO GET THE
THEIR EXEMPTION.
BECAUSE WE KEEP WE'RE NOT SURE
WHAT WHAT REALLY BECAUSE IT AND
THAT IT'S IT AND WE CAN'T THIS
PROVES THE VACCINE AND WE CAN'T
PROVE IT SOMETHING ELSE.
SO LET ME GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE --
SO FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU HAVE A
SEIZURE WITHIN SIXTY DAYS OF
GETTING THE THE FEAR TETANUS
PROTEST THIS VACCINE -- ACTUALLY
IT THE I LIKE THIS IS WITHIN THE
CDC GUIDELINES I KNOW WE'RE
GONNA TALK ABOUT YOU KNOW A
LITTLE BEYOND BUT EVEN THE CDC
GUIDELINES OR TERMS IS TOO
NARROW ACTUALLY SAYS IF YOU GET
A SEIZURE -- YOU KNOW PROLONGED
SEIZURE AFTER YOU RECEIVE THAT
VACCINATION WITHIN SIX DAYS WE
CAN'T SHOW IT'S CAUSED BY
SOMETHING ELSE LIKE I THAT IS
THAT -- YOU KNOW WHAT WE DID
YOUR NECK THAT'S A MASON FROM
THE NO IT DOESN'T COUNT IF WE
CAN SAYIT'S ACTUALLY CAUSED BY
SOMETHING IT'S NOT THE VACCINE.
THEN OF COURSE WOULD SAY IT'S
NOT REALLY TO THE VACCINE BUT WE
CAN'T SAY DOUBTS.
THEN.
YOU'D QUALIFY FOR MEDICAL
EXEMPTION UNDER THE CDC
GUIDELINES WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
COSTS THAT WE DON'T KNOW THE
VACCINE BUT WE DON'T KNOW IT'S
NOT [inaudible]
EXEMPTION.
NO MORE DETACHED YOU'RE DONE
EXEMPTION ON THAT VACCINE SO --
SO THAT IS THE WAY THAT -- THIS
THIS WORKS WE WHAT WE WANT TO
GIVE AS MUCH LATITUDE AS
POSSIBLE WHILE STILL BEING SURE
RECOGNIZED WITH EVERY EXEMPTION
WE GIVE.
WE ALSO WEAKENING THE COMEDIAN
UNITY IN THE SCHOOL AND THAT'S
FINE AS LONG AS WE'RE AS LONG AS
WE THINK THAT YOU KNOW WE DON'T
WANT FIRST PRIORITY IS TO BE
SURE WE KEEP THAT CHILD SAFE AND
THEN BE SURE WE KEEP THE SCHOOL
SAFE SO THERE'S ANY CONCERN.
THE VACCINE MIGHT BE WHAT'S
CAUSING THE PROBLEM EVEN IF WE
CAN'T PROVE IT.
OKAY LET'S GIVE THE MEDICAL
EXEMPTION BUT IF WE CAN SAY WELL
YOU KNOW WHAT WE KNOW IT'S NOT
THE VACCINE THAT WE KNOW ITS --
THEN ITHINK WOULD HAVE TO SAY
SO A OCT WE HEARD A COUPLE
PEOPLE SAY AUTISM.
ALRIGHT WE'VE HEARD A COUPLE
PEOPLE TESTIFY AND SAY AUTISM
AND BUT THERE'S AN EXTENSIVE
RESEARCH TO SHOW THERE'S NO SAYS
HE ASIAN BETWEEN VACCINES AND
AUTISM.
VACCINES DO NOT CAUSE AUTISM
RIGHT THERE'S BEEN NUMEROUS
STUDIES IS THAT IT TO THE ALL
THE INTO THE PRESENT THAT SHOWS
THAT.
SOME PEOPLE MAY STILL WANT TO
SEE HIM WITH HEARD SOME PEOPLE
SAY PAUL MIGHT YOU KNOW I HAVE I
AM A CHILD IS AUTISM SOME
RELATIVE HAS AUTISM WE WANTED
EXEMPTION.
I I THINK YOU KNOW TO BE LET'S
BE REALLY DIRECT THE EVIDENCE
DOESN'T SUPPORT THAT WE'VE
THAT'S BEEN STUDIED AND BEEN
EXAMINED.
NOW THERE'S OTHER THINGS THAT
MAY NOT HAVE BEEN AND WE SHOULD
GIVE PEOPLE THE BENEFIT OF DOUBT
WHEN WE DON'T KNOW.
WE DON'T KNOW GIVE PEOPLE THE
BENEFIT THAT WE DO NOW.
WE NEED TO PROTECT PEOPLE.
WOULD YOU LIKE A RESPONSE FROM
THE OPPOSITION ON A POINT YES.
AND THAT I JUST HAVE.
ONE MORE QUESTION ON CLOSING
COMMENT. FOR YOU DR GRANT THAT
SO I THINK SO MEMBER LIMóN
ACCESS AN HOUR AGO AND THAT AND
I CAN HEAR YOUR ANSWER BUT MAYBE --
MAYBE TWO IF YOU COULD HELP US
GOING TODAY AND GOING FORWARD --
WHAT ARE YOUR PLANS WITH WITH --
BASIC MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS GOING
BACK.
OTHER WORDS IT THERE'S GET
THROWN OUT THERE THAT ONLY POINT
007% HAVE THESE THE POPULATION
AND THERE'S THAT 1% THRESHOLD AS
FAR AS RESULT.
IS THERE IS THERE IS THERE A
NEED TO GO BACK AND IS THAT YOUR
INTENTION. TO CHAT GOING BACK OR
AS A GOING FOR POLICY SO SO I
THINK YOU KNOW CERTAINLY THE THE
ONE OF CONCERNS.
THAT -- BROUGHT ABOUT THIS BILL
OF COURSE AGAIN WORD THE FACE OF
THE LARGEST MEASLES -- CAN NEVER
CASES AND OVER AQUARTER CENTURY
BUT ALSO WE SAW THE MEDIC
EXEMPTION RATE.
YEAH BASICALLY QUADRUPLED NOW --
SO I IS AS I MENTIONED TO SOME
OF THE SOME OF YOU IN PRIVATE
CONVERSATIONS I AM CERTAINLY
OPEN TO THINKING ABOUT WHAT
POINT DID HOW FAR BACK DO WE
LOOK RIGHT -- PROBABLY -- VERY
FEW -- OP PEOPLE WHO ARE
INTERESTED IN BUYING MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS WHEN THEY COULD GET A
PERSONAL BELIEF EXEMPTION SO WE
PROBABLY DON'T NEED TO GO Vì
FOR THE INVITATION.
TO SEVEN SEVEN BUT WE MAY ALSO
SAY THAT YOU KNOW IN THE
BEGINNING THERE WASN'T THAT MUCH
SO WE MAY NOT NEED NEED TO GO
BACK AS FAR.
I I I LOOK WELCOME THAT
CONVERSATIONWE COULD THINK
ABOUT THAT.
AND SO THAT'S A CONCERN I'D
CERTAINLY BE VERY HAPPY TO WORK
WITH -- THAT THE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
ALSO OTHER -- YOU COLLEAGUES AND
AND ASSEMBLY ON THAT THE DESIRE
AGAIN IS TO KEEP KIDS SAFE NOT
TO CHASE DOWN EVERY PERSON AND
TRADED AT A DINNER MEDICAL
EXEMPTION -- THAT'S SO I WOULD
TAKE IT TARGETED APPROACH AND
CERTAINLY OPEN TO HAVING THAT
CONVERSATION I THINK THAT WE
WERE HAVING THOSE SOME OF THOSE
DISCUSSIONS OF US.
RIGHT BEFORE THIS HEARING SO WE
AND I THINK WE CAME TO I I THINK
WE NEED TO HAVE SOME TIME TO
SORT OF FORMULATE WHAT THAT
WOULD BE AN AGREEMENT -- PRIOR
IF WE WERE DECIDED TO YOU DISNEY
AMEND THE BILL BUT I'M CERTAINLY
VERY OPEN TO THAT CONVERSATION
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND THEN.
IT IN SOME AYE AYE SUPPORT THIS
TODAY THANK YOU I AM.
I WOULD EVER I HAVE LITTLE KIDS
IN SCHOOL AND SO THIS IS ABOUT
KEEPING KIDS SAFE.
AND AND PUBLIC HEALTH AND AND
I'LL NEVER FORGET THAT FIRST MY
WHEN I TOOK MY KIDS TO GET THEIR
THEIR VACCINES IN THE LOOK IN
THEIR EYES LOOKED AT ME LIKE.
DADDY YOU'RE LETTING THIS PERSON
STAB ME FOR THIS VACCINE -- BUT
I REALIZED THE GREATER GOOD AND
THE OVERALL. TO TALLY I'M
CERTAIN THAT THIS IS ONE OF THAT --
MARCH ADVANCES IN PUBLIC HEALTH
IN TWENTY FIRST CENTURY AND AND
THIS IS A SOUND PUBLIC POLICY
BUILT ON SITE SO I'M I'M IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU KNOW THEY JUST SAY I'M
I'M THE ONE WHO'S TAKING ALL MY
CHILDREN FOR THEIR VACCINES AND
I WAS THE ONE WITH THEM
[inaudible]
MISS WALDRON.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- MY FOR
I HAVE JUST A COUPLE QUESTIONS
SO.
AND I'M NOT SURE WHO TO ASK THIS
QUESTION OF BECAUSE IT WAS A
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS SO
[inaudible]
WE CAN.
WHOEVER KNOWS BEST [inaudible]
SO. ONE OF THE AMENDMENTS
REQUIRES THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY TO ESTABLISH
PROCESS AND GUIDELINES FOR THE
APPEALS PROCESS.
WHICH THE BILL ITSELF DOESN'T
SAY REALLYMUCH ABOUT WHAT THE
PROCESS WOULD LOOK LIKE.
AND IT EXEMPTS DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH AND AGED JUST FROM
THE ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURE ACT.
FOR THE PURPOSE OF IMPLEMENTING
THE BILL.
SO MIKE MY QUESTION BASICALLY IS.
THE REQUIREMENTS IN THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURE ACT
DESIGNED TO PROVIDE.
THE PUBLIC WITH A MEANINGFUL
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE ADOPTION OF STATE
REGULATIONS AND TO ENSURE THE
REGULATIONS A CLEAR.
NECESSARY AND LEGALLY VALID.
BY BY PASSING THE ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCEDURE ACT THE BILL WOULD
DENY PARENTS AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS AND MEANINGFUL
OPPORTUNITY. TO WEIGH IN ON
IMPLEMENTATION OF A LAW.
THE COULD HAVE CONSEQUENCES FOR
THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS SO I'M JUST
WONDERING WHY.
WAS DPH AND AGES S. EXEMPTED
WHAT'S THE BENEFIT OF THAT OF
THE PURPOSE OF THAT. FIVE TO
LEAVE THAT UP.
TO NOW THANK THANK YOU I BELIEVE
THAT -- WAS PART OF DISCUSSION
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
TIMING OF THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
OF THIS -- PARTICULAR BILL AND
SO THAT'S THAT THIS IS BY WAY
THAT THIS IS NOT UNIQUE -- I'VE
SAYS CHAIR OF BOTH THIS HEALTH
COMMITTEE PREVIOUSLY AND NOW IN
THE SENATE AT THAT ESPECIALLY
WHEN -- WE HAVE -- ISSUES THAT
WE NEED TO DEAL WITH MORE
RAPIDLY -- THE THIS IS
FREQUENTLY A PROVISION THAT IS
IN -- THOSE BILLS TO ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT TO ACT MORE QUICKLY.
CORRECT SO IF THEY COME OUT WITH
THE GUIDELINES THAN ME OR THEIR
PROCESS.
IF THEY COME OUT WITH IT AND
THEN THAT'S IT THERE'S NO.
COMMENTS ON THAT THERE'S NO.
WE WILL CERTAINLY PEOPLE.
DID YOU WANT ME.
TO YOU KNOW I I THINK DOCTOR PAN
WAS CORRECT I MEAN THERE I
BELIEVE THERE IS AN URGENCY TO
THIS AND I THINK THAT'S THAT IS
PART OF THE REASON THAT IT'S
DRAFTED THIS WAY.
BUT IT BUT IF THERE IS A
CHALLENGE THESE ARE NOT THESE
ARE REGULATIONS ARE CAN BE
DEVELOPED BY THE AGENCY OF
SOMETHING VOWED COMES FORWARD
THERE'S NOTHING TO PRECLUDE SEE
AGENCY FOR MAKING CHANGES TO THE
GUIDELINES. FOR OR THE OR THE OR
THE APPEAL PROCESS SO SO IT IS
NOT IT IS NOT RESTRICTED THIS AT
THE RIVER THE REASON WE'RE DOING
THIS IN THIS WAY IS TO EXPEDITE
THE PROCESS.
AND FOR THE PROTECT CHILDREN
THAT'S THE BOTTOM LINE OKAY SO
YOU'RE SAYING THAT THE WHEN YOU
SAY MINISTRATION THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE THE ADMINISTRATION IS
YEAH EXTENSION OF THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE CORRECT.
OKAY.
SO THEN THE OTHER QUESTIONS
REGARDING APPEALS.
AND IT JUST KIND OF BROUGHT
BECAUSE OF PERSONAL THING THAT
HAPPENED YOU KNOW TO MIND THAT.
IT'S KIND IT'S BEEN STATED THAT
THERE'S POTENTIALLY DOCTORS WHO
ARE NOT ACTUALLY SEEING PATIENTS
AND PER.
PERSON BUT ARE WRITING EXEMPTION --
SO THIS PANEL OF THE THREE
DOCTOR PANEL.
AND IN MY OPINION THEN SHOULD
ALSO HAVE TO MEET WITH THE
DOCTOR.
WHO'S WRITING THE EXEMPTION.
THE PATIENT OR THEIR FAMILY
PRIOR TO DENYING THE EXEMPTION
ALSO SO IT KIND OF GOES BOTH
WAYS -- DAYS.
I'M THINKING YOU KNOW IF WE'RE
REQUIRING THAT THE DOCTOR WHO
WRITES EXEMPTION SEES THE
PATIENT WHICH I THINK IS
PROBABLY A GOOD.
STANDARD OF CARE ANYWAY.
BUT THE PANEL WHO COULD BE
REMOTE AND NOT KNOW EVERYTHING
ABOUT THE PATIENT AND WHY THAT
CAME TO MIND IS BECAUSE I HAD TO
BRING MY SON TO THE EMERGENCY
ROOM.
LAST YEAR RIGHT AFTER SESSION
AND HE WAS PRESENTING WITH STIFF
NECK PAIN HEADACHE AND A FEVER
SO THE FIRST THING WE THOUGHT OF
BECAUSE IT WAS A MENINGITIS
OUTBREAK GOING ON AT THIS YEAR'S
DO.
THAT THIS COULD BE A CONCERN AND
HIS COUSIN GOES THERE AND HE WAS
JUST WITH HIM.
SO I IMMEDIATELY WENT INTO THE
EMERGENCY ROOM BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT THE DOCTOR SAID TO GO.
AND IT TURNED OUT IT WASN'T THAT
ALTHOUGH THE FIRST THING THEY
DID WAS SLOT MASK ONE EVERYBODY
EXCEPT ME I THINK IN A MASS BUT
I WAS ALREADY EXPOSED SO -- SO
IT WAS TAKEN VERY SERIOUSLY HE
IMMEDIATELY WENT AND WITHIN
MINUTES THEY DID ALL KINDS OF
BLOOD WORK SWAP THIS ROAD AND
EVERYTHING ELSE AND IT CAME IT
WAS INCONCLUSIVE.
BUDGET JUST TO MAKE A LONG STORY
SHORT.
HE DIDN'T HAVE MENINGITIS THE
COUPLE OF DAYS LATER THEY
DETERMINE A STRIP OF WAS WEIRD
TYPE A STRAP NOT THE NORMAL SO
ANYWAY.
BUT IN THE DOCUMENTS THAT WERE
WRITTEN.
THE NOTES COMING OUT IN THE
EMERGENCY ROOM IT SAYS --
SOMETHING VERY VAGUE LIKE FEVER
SORE THROAT OR SOMETHING.
SO TO ME.
IF IF THERE IS A SOMETHING
WRITTEN AND IT JUST KIND OF
SKIMS OVER THE ISSUE DOESN'T SAY
WHY I BROUGHT HIM IN THERE WHY
EVERYONE TOOK IT SO SERIOUSLY OF
FIRST.
WE COULD EASILY BE SWAYED HAVING
NOT MET WITH THE PARENTS ARE NOT
MET WITH THE DOCTOR IN
ATTENDANCE IN KNOW.
ABOUT THAT ISSUE THAT'S THAT'S
WHAT BROUGHT THAT TO MY WHAT WAS
FIRST OF ALL I WOULD SAY IS IS
THAT -- WE DO HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY POSITIONS TO
DOCUMENT ADEQUATELY -- RIGHT YOU
HAVE A REASON TO DOCUMENT
ADEQUATELY YES -- AND THE AND
ALSO BY THE WAY THE EVEN IN THE
C. P. H. REVIEW PROCESS WITH THE
CLINICIANS.
APART THE REASON WE WANT THAT
THE ALLOW THE RECORD RELEASE --
FROM THE FROM THE PARENT IS IS
THAT THAT ALLOWS THE PHYSICIAN
TO THEN SHARE INFORMATION
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION THAT THE
PUBLIC HEALTH MAY SEEK SO WE WE
DON'T WANT TO HAVE SOMEONE THE
KNIGHTS OF THE BECAUSE THERE'S
INSUFFICIENT INFORMATION.
SO WE WANT TO CREATE AN
OPPORTUNITY -- FOR IF THERE IS
INSUFFICIENT INFORMATION TO MAKE
THAT JUDGMENT TO ALLOW THE
PHYSICIAN WHO ACTUALLY SAW THE
PATIENT TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION AND THAT'S PART OF
THE PROCESS BOTH NOT JUST AT THE
PEEL PROCESS BUT EVEN AT THE C.
PH LEVEL -- SO SO I THINK THAT
THAT THAT'S THAT'S THE NORMAL
PEER REVIEW PROCESS SO FOR
EXAMPLE I SERVED ON THE QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT COMMITTEE WAS AT UC
DAVIS.
AND YOU KNOW WE LOOKED AT WACO
CRITICAL INCIDENTS THINGS WHEN
THINGS DIDN'T GO RIGHT.
WE DIDN'T PULL AND ALL THE
FAMILIES AND EVERYTHING WHAT
HAPPENS IS WE WOULD GO LOOK AT
THE RECORD SOMETIMES WE THEN
SEND INCREASED TO INVOLVE TO THE
INVOLVE PROFESSIONALS WHO WERE
THERE AND SAY.
SO BASED ON THE RECORD WE STILL
HAVE THESE QUESTIONS WHAT
HAPPENED CAN YOU TELL US AND SO
FORTH.
AND I THINK THAT WE DO HAVE IN
THIS BILL THAT'S WHY WE INCLUDED
THE THE PIECE WHERE IT SAYS WELL
WE WANT THE PARENTS TO GIVE
INFORMATION FOR BOTH THE PART
THE MEDICAL BOARD BUT ALSO THE
PART PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND THAT'S REALLY TO BE SURE
THAT BECAUSE I AS A PHYSICIAN
HAS A WELFARE DIDN'T GIVE YOU.
TO SHARE THAT WITH YOU THAT THAT
NOW THAT TAKING CARE OF SO NOW
THE PHYSICIAN CAN SAY OKAY WE
DON'T NEEDTO DELAY I CAN SHARE
WITH YOU THE KIND OF INFORMATION
THAT YOU NEED TO KNOW BECAUSE
THE THE THE THE CLINICIAN MAY
SAY.
WELL -- YOU COULDN'T YOU GAVE ME
THIS THING BUT I STILL DON'T
KNOW ABOUT THAT RIGHT ICE THIS
IS STILL A FACTOR WHICH WOULD
HELP ME MAKE A DECISION.
AND SO DO YOU HAVE INFORMATION
ABOUT THAT ABOUT THE PATIENT AND
THE PHYSICIAN WOULD SAY.
WELL ES I DO ARE MAYBE I DON'T
YET MAYBE I'LL GO AND THEY'LL
TALK TO THE PATIENT AND GET THAT
FROM THEM SO SO THAT SO THAT IS
PART OF THE PROCESS NOT AND NOW
OF COURSE ALSO BE AVAILABLE TO
REVIEW PROCESS WHEN THE
POSITIONS LOOK AT THAT.
AND THEY SAY THERE'S A MISSING
INFORMATION BECAUSE WE WANT
PEOPLE TO MAKE THE RIGHT
DECISION I WANT TO BE SURE EVERY
CHILD WHO NEEDS A MEDICAL
EXEMPTION GETS.
ONE THAT IS THE PART OF THE
PURPOSE OF THIS BILL BE SURE
EVERY CHILD WHO NEEDS MEDICAL
ATTENTION WILL GET.
ONE AND THAT'S WHY WE HAVE THIS
PROVISIONS IN THE BILL.
NO JUST BECAUSE WE JUST AB FOR
CLARIFICATION MISS WALDRON THERE
IS A SECTION.
IN SECTION FOR THE BILL WHICH
SAYS THAT PARENTS OR GUARDIANS
MAY PROVIDE THE NECESSARY
INFORMATION FOR PURPOSES OF THE
APPEAL SO IF YOU DIDN'T FEEL
THAT THE DOCTOR GAVE THE ENTIRE
HISTORY AND YOU AS IN THE CASE
OF YOUR SON.
YOU COULD PROVIDE THAT AS AS
PART OF THE APPEAL AND AND BE A
PARTICIPANT IN THE APPEAL
PROCESS [inaudible]
OKAY.
SO JUST REALLY QUICK ONE LAST
QUESTION SO.
AND I HEARD.
IT I GUESS I HAVE TO DRESS THE
TO THE OPPOSITION OR THE TWEEN
OR PEOPLE -- MISS SCOTT I THINK
WAS ONE OF THE PEOPLE WHO SAID
IT SO WITH THE FIVE EXEMPTION
RULE.
AT UNITS TOUCHED ON THAT A COULD
ADVERSELY IMPACT YOUR ABILITY TO
GET A VALID MEDICAL EXEMPTION
[inaudible]
HOW?
DO YOU SEE THAT.
THIS BEING THE CASE [inaudible]
I WILL.
OKAY I'M SORRY.
I IS SO BEING IMMUNE COMPROMISED
AND CHILDREN THAT HAVE HAD
VACCINE EXAM X..
VACCINE THEY HAD BACK SEEN
EXEMPTIONS BECAUSE OF OUR
VACCINE REACTIONS BOTH AND
MYSELF AND MY CHILDREN.
IT'S A VERY COMPLEX SITUATION
WHERE WE ACTUALLY FOR A PORTION
OF OUR EXEMPTION WE ACTUALLY
QUALIFY FOR TWO OF THEM VACCINES
UNDER THE CDC CONTRA INDICATIONS
THE OTHER VACCINES WE DO NOT
QUALIFY THOSE WOULD.
I MOVE INTO THE CATEGORY OF THE
VACCINE REACTIONS TO THOSE
SPECIFIC VACCINES.
AND SO WITH.
WITH THAT FALLING WITHOUT AN
OUTSIDE OF THE CDC CONTRA
INDICATIONS.
MY CONCERN IS WE WOULD OBVIOUSLY
BE SEEN BY AN IMMUNOLOGIST I
HAVE AN IMMUNOLOGIST BECAUSE OF
MY PRIMARY IMMUNE DEFICIENCY.
WE WOULD BE SEEN BY THEM OR A A
PEDIATRICIAN AT A LARGE HOSPITAL
THAT SPECIALIZES IN IMMUNOLOGY.
AND IT GETS VERY CONFUSING.
AS I'M SURE I'M PROBABLY
CONFUSED YOU GUYS WITH THIS --
IT GETS VERY CONFUSING WHEN A
VACCINE EXEMPTION OF THAT TYPE
IS GIVEN AND SO WE ARE NOT
SORRY -- SO WE DON'T FALL WITHIN
THAT AND SO WE WOULD FALL
OUTSIDE AND I THE BEST.
THE BEST JUDGMENT OF THE DOCTOR
AT THAT POINT TO GIVE US THAT
VACCINE EXEMPTION MY FEAR WITH
THOSE WITHOUT FIVE EXEMPTION
ROLE IS MY IMMUNOLOGIST IS
WRITING AND VACCINE EXEMPTIONS
EVERY DAY FOR PRIMARY IMMUNE
DEFICIENCIES THAT FALLS WITHIN
THE CDC CONTRA INDICATIONS THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO BE
AUTOMATICALLY FLAG.
AT THAT POINT.
AND SO IF ALL OF THEIR VACCINE
EXEMPTIONS ARE REVIEWED.
THAN MINE BEING OUTSIDE OF THAT
SCOPE OF THE CDC CONTRA
INDICATIONS IS GOING TO BE
SCRUTINIZED AND SO IN THAT CASE.
WHEN MINE IS BEING LOOKED UP SO
CLOSELY AND WE HAVE SUCH A?
COMPLEX MEDICAL ISSUE AND AND
HISTORY IN OUR FAMILY MY CONCERN
IS THAT A PANEL OF THREE DOCTORS
THAT ARE GENERAL PRACTITIONERS.
FOR PEDIATRICIANS AREN'T GOING
TO UNDERSTAND OUR COMPLEX
IMMUNOLOGY ISSUE AND SO THAT'S
WHERE I THINK YOU WERE ASKING
THE PEER TO PEER COMMENT IS WHEN
A INSURANCE COMPANY DID DIDN'T
DENY IS A PEER TO PEER REVIEW.
THEY ACTUALLY GET ON THE PHONE
AND HAVE A CONFERENCE CALL WITH
THE DOCTOR THAT WROTE THAT IN SO
I THINK THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
ASKING FOR IS FOR THAT PEER TO
PEER REVIEW TO BE.
REAL TIME LIVE WITH THAT DOCTOR
SO THAT THE WHOLE COMPLEX
SITUATION LIKE OURS IS
UNDERSTOOD.
A I AND AND THAT'S WHERE I WOULD
LIKE TO SEE AN AND LIKE I SAID
I'M IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IF
AMENDED PROPERLY TO INCLUDE
ITEMS LIKE THAT WHERE IS THAT
DOCTOR AND NOT THREE DOCTOR
PANEL.
THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO
COMMUNICATE NOT JUST BY PEOPLE
WORK PASSED BACK AND FORTH
BECAUSE A COMPLEX SITUATION LIKE
OURS IT'S NOT GOING TO FULLY BE
ABLE TO BE UNDERSTOOD AND AND
I'M.
GUESSING THAT WE WILL END UP THE
TOP THIRD LEVEL AND BE IN FRONT
OF THOSE THOUGHT THREE PANEL AND
I PERSONALLY BECAUSE DOCTOR PAN
HAS MENTIONED THAT.
YOU KNOW WE'RE TRYING TO GET RID
OF THESE DOCTORS THAT ARE
GETTING THAT DON'T HAVE THIS
FACE TO FACE CONTACT THAT ARE
WRITING THESE EXEMPTIONS WE
SHOULD ALSO.
GIVE PATIENTS LIKE MYSELF AND MY
CHILDREN THAT BENEFIT TO OF
BEING IN FRONT OF THAT PANEL OR
ON A CONFERENCE CALL SO WE CAN
EXPLAIN OUR SITUATION AS WELL
BECAUSE IT IS SO COMPLEX.
AND I'VE HAD IT IS THE SAME
THING THAT YOU'VE HAPPEN IT HAD
HAD HAPPENED WHERE MY CHILDREN'S
RECORDS HAVE BEEN KEPT IN
CORRECTLY OR MY RECORDS HAVE
BEEN KEPT IN CORRECTLY AND I AM
CONSTANTLY FILING HIT BY --
VIOLATIONS AND REQUESTING FOR MY
RECORDS TO BE UPDATED AFTER
EVERY SINGLE DOCTOR'S
APPOINTMENT OR PROCEDURE THAT I
HAVE I HAVE TO REVIEW THE CHART.
AND THEN FIX IT BECAUSE IT
HAPPENS.
ALMOST EVERY TIME I HAVE A
PROCEDURE WHICH IS VERY VERY
OFTEN WITH PRIMARY IMMUNE
DEFICIENCY.
SUPER COMPLEX AND SO.
AGAIN THAT'S JUST WHAT I WANT TO
SEE IS THAT THIS IS AMENDED
WHERE WE HAVE THESE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THIS PANEL
WHEN WE GET IN FRONT OF THEM
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK [inaudible]
YOU.
DOCTOR YOU'REA RAMP INTO TERMS
FOR YOU HAVE ANYMORE QUESTIONS.
OKAY DOCTOR REGULAR.
I'D LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL ONE
APPROPRIATE MISTER CHAIR.
IT'S ALWAYS APPROPRIATE WHEN
THERE'S A QUORUM.
SECOND WE HAVE A SECOND BY
MISTER BONTA OR SOMEBODY ELSE I
DIDN'T HEAR THAT.
SOMEBODY -- MISS BURKE
[inaudible]
OKAY -- SO I I TO AS SOMEBODY
WHO IS WAS NOT A SUPPORTER OF
TWO SEVEN SEVEN I WANT TO SAY
THAT -- IT IS THIS IS AN
EMOTIONAL TOPIC AND SO I DO
UNDERSTAND THAT THOSE AROUND US
HAVE BEEN A MOTIONAL HOWEVER TO
REITERATE.
THE FACT THAT THAT THE NEGATIVE
PERSONAL DIRECTS ARE
INAPPROPRIATE NINE I DO KNOW YOU
TO BE DOING THE BEST YOU CAN
FROM PUBLIC HEALTH AND ALTHOUGH
WE DIFFERENTIATE ON WHAT THAT
LOOKS LIKE.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE HERE -- FOR
AND I'M HOPING THAT IN THIS
CONVERSATION WERE ABLE TO
EXPRESS OF DIVERSITY OF
PERSPECTIVES THAT WILL GET YOU
TO A PLACE WHERE.
WHERE ARE YOU WILL HAVE A BILL
THAT THAT REALLY REPRESENTS ALL
OF US IN THIS ROOM I DON'T KNOW
BUT I'M I AM HOPEFUL?
WITH THAT I HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS
AND SOME OF THEM ARE ARE
HONESTLY JUST THEIR THEIR
EDUCATION QUESTIONS FOR MYSELF --
SO IN THIS SITUATION I THINK
THIS WOMAN HAD OF A VERY GOOD
POINT WHERE WHERE SOME THINGS
ARE JUST MORE COMPLICATED THAN
OTHERS -- AND I AM CURIOUS --
AND THE CONCERT MY ONE OF MY
BIGGEST CONCERN IS THIS KIND AND
NEEDS MEDICAL EXCEPTION RIGHT.
AS IN THE EXAMPLE YOU GAVE YOU
SAID FOR EXAMPLE A PRO LONG
SEIZURES WITHIN SEVEN DAYS OF
ADMINISTRATION OF A VACCINE
RIGHT SO LET'S SAY MY DAUGHTER
HAS.
WHICH I'VE SEEN IN PAPERS WHERE
THEY SAY MY DAUGHTER HAD A
SEIZURE MY DAUGHTER DIDN'T HAVE
A SEIZURE OF MY DAUGHTER HAD TO
ME WHAT I FELT WAS A STRONG
REACTION. TO A VACCINE AND THEN
I OPTED FOR A PRO LONG SCHEDULE
MY DAUGHTER HAD HER BACKSEAT HAS
HAD HER VACCINATIONS BUT OVER A
SCHEDULE THAT I WAS COMFORTABLE
WITH IT BECAUSE I WANTED HER TO
BE SAFE AND I WANT TO
COMMUNITIES.
SO BUT LET'S SEE ONE DOES ONE
CHILD DOES HAVE A SEIZURE AND BE
CLEAR AS A MOTHER MY DAUGHTER
HAS ONE SEIZURE THERE'S NOTHING
YOU'RE SAYING TO ME.
YOU PUT ME IN JAIL.
THERE'S NOTHING YOU CAN SAY TO
ME THAT IS NOT GOING TO TRY TO
LOOK VERY VERY CAREFULLY AND
EVERYTHING THAT HAPPENED WITHIN
THAT TWENTY FOUR HOURS OR FORTY
EIGHT HOURS OR WHATEVER IT WAS
THAT CHANGED.
RIGHT FOR ME TO UNDERSTAND.
HOWEVER MY CONCERN LIKE A GET
WITH NEEDS MEDICAL EXEMPTION AND
MY QUESTION IS.
IS IT SAYS PROLONGS FEATURES.
THIS IS MY DAUGHTER HAS ONE
SEIZURE FROM A VACCINE.
WHY DOES NOT NOT QUALIFY AS A
REASON FOR ME NOW TO BE ABLE TO
INVESTIGATE AND THEN MY OTHER
QUESTION IS?
IS THAT INVESTIGATION ONLY ON
THAT.
ONE VACCINE OR IS IT ON THE
WHOLE COURSE IS IT.
ON THE WHOLE COURSE OF AXE
SCENES.
OKAY IT'S A YES YES SO SO FIRST
OF ALL -- IN REGARDS -- TO THE
SEIZURES I I WOULD SAY IS THAT
WHAT WE WANTED TO IS IS THAT --
YOU KNOW WE WE BASE OUR MEDICAL
DECISIONS AGAIN ON SCIENCE AND
THE EVIDENCE -- AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER IS THAT THERE ARE THINGS
WE KNOW AND THEN THERE'S THINGS
WE DON'T KNOW ALL RIGHT SO WE
KNOW THAT BACK OUT YEAH OF AXES
ON CAUSE AUTISM.
THAT'S SETTLED YEAH THAT'S BEEN
STUDIED -- OVER AND OVER AGAIN
RIGHT -- LET ME SHOULD I SHARE
WITH YOU.
PERHAPS THERE'S ACTUALLY A STORY
DOES A STORY WRITTEN IN THE
WASHINGTON POST AND I SHOULD GET
THAT TO YOU -- SO WHAT HAPPENED
IS IS THAT -- WHEN THEY CAME
FIRST CAME OUT WITH THAT THAT
FEAR TETANUS FOR TOSSES VACCINE
OKAY?
THERE'S CAME OUT THEY DID NOTE
THAT THERE IS A SLIGHTLY HIGHER
RATE OF SEIZURES AND A FEVER AND
SEIZURES ASSOCIATED WITH.
OUR CHILDREN WHO GOT THAT
VACCINE RIGHT AND SO IN FACT IT
WAS.
IN THE CONSERVATION PRECAUTIONS
IT SAYS WELL IF YOU HAVE A
SEIZURE -- WE DON'T GIVE ANYMORE
AND I REMEMBER AS A TRAINING
DEATHS -- WE SAID LIKE OKAY WELL
THEY HAVE A HISTORY OF SEIZURES
DON'T GIVE THAT THE TAP BACKS AT
THE EDGE OF DENNIS D. T. P. IS
BEFORE THE FIRE WITH YOURSELF.
AND FOR THE PEOPLE ALSO WANT
INVESTIGATED BECAUSE IT DIDN'T
KNOW THEY COULD THEY DIDN'T KNOW
THAT THEY SAID WELL THIS IS IT
THIS VACCINE OURS ARE NOT.
AND PEOPLE ACTUALLY DID STUDIES
AND ACTUALLY WHAT THEY FOUND OUT
THAT A LOT OF THEM WERE ACTUALLY
DUE TO A GENETIC CONDITION.
CALLED SURVEYS SYNDROME.
SURVEYS SYNDROME IS A GENETIC
CONDITION WHERE CHILD WILL
DEVELOP SEIZURES AND SOME
DEVELOPMENTAL DELAY -- AND AND
THEN IN A FAT AND OF COURSE IT
AND IT'S TRIGGERED THE FIRST
SYMPTOMS ARE TRIGGERED YOU BUY
SOME INFLAMMATORY EVENTS SO
COULD BE GETTING A VACCINE IT
COULD BE.
A COLD BUT IT'S NOT BECAUSE BY
SO IN FACT THE THEY INVESTIGATE
AND THEY FOUND THAT.
CHILDREN WHO -- WHETHER THEY'RE
VACCINE OR NOT HAD THE SAME RATE
OF SEIZURES AND OTHER SYMPTOMS
RELATED TO THIS AND OKAY I THINK
BUT LET'S GO BROADER THAN THAT
OKAY BECAUSE YOU KNOW IT'S I
KNOW WHAT YOU'RE TRYING I GET
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING THERE BUT
LET'S SEE THERE IS IT LET'S SEE.
MY TARGETS A HUNDRED AND FOUR
FEVER OKAY AND OBVIOUSLY THAT'S
NOT PROLONG BUT IT'S DANGEROUS
ARE IS THAT DOESN'T MEAN I'M NOT
A DOCTOR SO AND A HUNDRED FOR
FEVERS QUALIFIES TO ME IS
DANGEROUS EMERGENCY ROOM TIME
RIGHT -- NO NOT NECESSARILY BUT
LET ME JUST GET SOMETHING THAT
HAPPENS THAT WE'LL SEE TO ME I
FELT LIKE A FEVER WAS AND FOR ME
TO RECONSIDER TO CONSIDER HOW TO
DEAL WITH MY BUT MY QUESTION IS
IS SOMETHING A SITUATION HAPPENS
THAT IS DIRE ENOUGH THAT.
MY DAUGHTER NEEDS TO GO TO AN
EMERGENCY ROOM.
AND IT'S OBVIOUSLY TEMPERS UP
SEVEN DAYS WHATEVER THAT
SITUATION IN.
WHAT WE IT WHY DOESN'T THAT
QUALIFY FOR SOME A REASON FOR ME
TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
A MEDICAL EXEMPTION TO REVIEW
WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE AND THEN
WHY DO I NEED TO BE CONCERNED
THAT AS IT GOES THROUGH THE
APPEALS PROCESS THAT SOMEBODY
ELSE MIGHT DECIDE?
THAT THEN MY DAUGHTER STILL
NEEDS TO HAVE THE BACKSEAT
VACCINATIONS SHE COULD I ORDER
TO RED WINE I HAVE A GLASS OF
RED WINE I DIDN'T KNOW IT.
I KNOW IT'S A TOTAL BUMMER -- A
SINGLE MOM OF A FOUR YEAR OLD HE
BEING ALLERGIC TO READ ONE SUCKS --
BUT JUST DOESN'T CUT IT RIGHT
YEAH -- BUT I DRINK WAY RUN
FOREVER I WAS ALLERGIC TO IT ONE
DAY HAD A GLASS OF RED WINE MY
THROAT CLOSE AND I WAS IN AN
AMBULANCE.
I WAS SCARED.
WHAT IS THIS THING I MEAN IF
SITUATIONS LIKE THAT OCCUR I'M
NOT SURE I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY
THAT DOESN'T QUALIFY I DON'T
WANT TO JUST TO QUALIFY FOR THAT?
ONE VACCINE I THEN SHOULD HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO EXPLORE THEM
ALL OKAY SO SO I WOULD SAY IS
FIRST OF ALL AGAIN THIS GOES
BACK TO WHAT.
YEAH IS IT.
IS IT EVEN IS IT LIEU POSSIBLE
THAT'S CAUSED BY THE VACCINE
RIGHT AND IS IT JUST THINGS WE
KNOW THERE'S THINGS WE DON'T
KNOW SO ACTUALLY IF I CAN JUST
REFER YOU SAID IGH FEVER WE
THERE'S A CONDITION WE KNOW THAT.
CHILDREN CAN DEVELOP WHAT'S
CALLED FEBRILE SEIZURES RIGHT --
AND THAT THAT'S ACTUALLY CAUSED
BY RAPID RISE IN YOUR
TEMPERATURE RIGHT AND THEY CAN
HAVE A SEIZURE WE ALSO KNOW BY
THE WAY THAT CHILDREN HAVE
FEBRILE SEIZURES.
ACTUALLY GROW OUT OF THEM AND
THERE'S NO LONG TERM
NEUROLOGICAL SEQUELAE ALRIGHT
AND IT'S NOT DIRECTLY SO TO A
VACCINES ALTHOUGH SOME VACCINES
CAN CAUSE FEVER AND THEIR FIRST
CAN.
THAT THIS CAN HAVE TRACKED
TRIGGER RIGHT ACTION BUT THAT
WOULD NOT.
THAT BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THIS
CONDITION BECAUSE WE UNDERSTAND
THIS CONDITION YOU KNOW THIS
CONDITION IS NOT A CAUSED BY THE
VACCINE INTO IS NOT.
DOES NOT LEAD -- TO LONG TERM
HARM -- THAT THAT WOULD NOT BE A
PERMANENT CONTRA ELLA A PERMIT
REASON NOT TO GET YOUR CHILD
VACCINATED BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
THAT'S NOW IF YOU HAVE FOR
EXAMPLE SO.
IF IF THAT'S WHAT THEY HAVE
RIGHT I MEAN.
RIGHT THAT'S NOT THE ONLY THING
THAT.
HOUSING AND IF YOU'RE THE
EXCEPTION RIGHT WELL AT THE END
NOT THE RULE AND WHICH IS WHAT
THIS ENTIRE CONVERSATION IS
ABOUT RIGHT.
IT'S NOT FOR THE PLETHORA PEOPLE
WHO CAN GET A VACCINE WHO GET
THEM EVERY DAY WHO ARE FINE AND
THERE'S NOT AN ISSUE IT'S ABOUT
THOSE OF US WHO MAYBE HAVE.
THAT FALL INTO THE CRACKS AND
THAT WANT TO MAKE SURE WE
UNDERSTAND THAT A BILL THAT'S
GOING TO AFFECT EVERY CHILD IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT IT
IT TAKES INTO ACCOUNT THOSE
EXCEPTIONS.
THAT'S WHAT I THINK THE MY
CONCERN IS SO I I I LET YOU
FINISH AND THEN ON THE
OPPOSITION FINISH HOWEVER I'M
GOING TO SEE A DOCTOR I WOULD
PREFER SOMEONE ELSE ANSWER THIS
QUESTION OKAY SO LET ME JUST
FINISH INTO YOUR QUESTION I
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION SO WHAT.
WE WANNA DO IS BECAUSE AS I SAID
BEFORE EVERY MEDICAL EXEMPTION --
OF COURSE WEAKENS THE COMMUNITY
OF THE SCHOOL RIGHT BUT WE WON'T
BE SURE EVERY CHILD WHO NEEDS
MEDICAL THAT SHE GETS.
ONE AND IN FACT AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER -- WE WANT TO ACTUALLY
LEAN IN FAVOR OF WE DON'T KNOW
RIGHT IS IT'S IN THE SPACE OF WE
DON'T KNOW IT MIGHT BE THE
VACCINE THAT MIGHT NOT.
THEN WILL WE WANNA LEAN IN FAVOR
OF THE CHILD NOT AS SAYING THAT
WELLOKAY WE'LL GIVE YOU THE
EXEMPTION BILLS WE KNOW FOR IF
IF WE LIKE NOW WE RECOGNIZE THIS
CONDITION IT'S NOT SO TO THE
VACCINE.
THEN I'D I THINK WE OWE IT TO
THE US THE REST OF THE CHILDREN
INCLUDING THE ONES WHO REALLY
NEED THE EXEMPTION.
THAT WE'RE NOT GRANTING
EXEMPTION FOR THOSE CONDITIONS
AND THAT'S AND THAT'S WHERE THE
MEDICAL THAT'S WHERE THE WE LOOK
AT THE EVIDENCE AND THAT'S THE
THE JUDGMENT SO WE DON'T KNOW.
WE WANT TO GIVE THE LATITUDE
THAT'S WE'RE TRYING TO STRIKE
THE BALANCE WITH APPEAL PANEL SO
FORTH -- WE DON'T CREATE A
LOOPHOLE THINGS UNFORTUNATELY
THAT'S THERE ARE.
THAT HIS GROUP A HANDFUL IT'S
GOOD POSITIONS WILL TAKE A
LITTLE LOOPHOLE AND TURN IT INTO
A BUSINESS OPPORTUNITY
UNFORTUNATELY AND ENDANGER
CHILDREN THE PROCESS AND THAT WE
WANT TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE KEEP
THAT FROM HAPPENING.
YOU KNOW AND I ACTUALLY DON'T
EITHER.
AS I JUST HAVE TWO MORE
QUESTIONS -- I GUESS MY OTHER
QUESTION IS IS WE HAVE ONE
DOCTOR WHO'S BEEN SUSPENDED IS
THAT CORRECT AS A RESULT OF
BETTER EXTENDING.
OKAY WHICH IS A WHAT IS A CALL.
PROBATION IS ON PROBATION.
A DIFFERENT STAGES OF PROBATION
OKAY AND I UNDERSTAND AND I HAVE
NO DOUBT THAT THERE ARE PEOPLE
WHO TAKE THERE ARE ALWAYS PEOPLE
WHO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE SYSTEM --
OF ANY SYSTEM [inaudible]
REALITY -- AND YOU SAID YOU HAD
TWO HUNDRED IS IT TWO HUNDRED
COMPLAINTS ARE CASES OF OTHERS
IN.
IN PROCESS OF BEING AND
PROBATION HOW MANY DOCTORS
BESIDES THE ONE ANOTHER THING IS
THE MEDICAL BOARD PERSON YOU
KNOW ANSWER THE QUESTION.
MEDICAL ONE SHE LIKE SHE ALL
RIGHT SO OF YOUR CLOSE IT'S A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY NINE
COMPLAINTS THAT WE RECEIVED.
AND THEN ANOTHER COMPLAINTS
ABOUT DOCTORS WHO ARE JUST OVER
MEDICAL ATTENTION OKAY RELATED
TO MEDICAL EXEMPTION.
AND THEN -- WE'VE HAD LIKE YOU
SAID ONE ACTION TAKEN RESULT IN
A PROBATION WE HAVE.
HE SAID OVER WHAT TIME PERIOD
SORRY -- OVER WHAT TIME PERIOD
SINCE -- SB TWO SEVENTY SET WILL
SINCE THE LAST FEW YEARS.
YEAH. THREE YEARS THREE OVER
THREE YEARS.
SINCE THAT BILL HAD OKAY CAM
INTO LAW AND THEN -- WE HAVE
CURRENTLY HUNDRED THREE
INVESTIGATIONS PENDING SO
THEY'RE GOING THROUGH THE
PROCESS AND WE'VE HAD TO COME TO
CLOSE FORTY NINE COMPLAINTS DUE
TO INSUFFICIENT EVIDENCE.
YOU KNOW I GUESS MY QUESTION IS
IS ONE HAS BEEN IN THREE OF A
ONE IN THREE YEARS HAS BEEN
FOUND -- IS IN PROBATION AND DO
YOU HAVE ABOUT SOMEWHERE IN TWO
HUNDRED AND INVESTIGATION I JUST.
PART OF ME WONDER IF MAYBE THIS
MIGHT BE A LITTLE HEAVY HANDED A
LITTLE BIT BUT THAT'S A QUESTION
PROBABLY FOR ANOTHER LEADER
CONVERSATION I KNOW WE'RE NOT
GOING ALL AGREE ON THAT.
I ONLY HAVE I HAVE. TO HAVE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS.
I THINK I'M GOOD I THINK I'M NOT
GOOD -- LET ME BACK THAT A YOU
KNOW IT'S JUST FOR ME LIKE I
SAID THIS IS KIND OF ONE OF
THOSE SUPER A MOTIONAL.
CONVERSATIONS AND WELL ACTUALLY
I DO HAVE A QUESTION ONE IF
SOMEONE HAS A FAMILY IF THE
FAMILY MEDICAL HISTORY IS PART
OF THE CONVERSATION.
WHAT CAN YOU GIVE ME AN EXAMPLE
OF A TIME?
WHEN?
FAMILY MEDICAL HISTORY WOULD
ALLOW ME A MEDICAL EXEMPTION
THAT WOULD NOT REQUIRE MY CHILD
TO GET A VACCINATION ON AT THE
ON SET.
SO FOR EXAMPLE AT AT ACTUALLY IN
THE CDC GUIDELINES THEMSELVES IF
YOUR CHILD HAS A FIRST DEGREE
RELATIVE WHO HAS A CONGENITAL
HEREDITARY IMMUNO DEFICIENCY --
YOU AUTOMATICALLY YOU GET A
MEDICAL EXEMPTION FOR THE MMR
AND VARICELLA SO BASICALLY JUST
TO WELL THOSE ARE THE ONES WHERE
THERE'S A RISK BECAUSE THEY'RE
LIVE VIRUS VACCINES I ALSO IF I
NEED TO SAY IS IS THAT -- AND
BLANK.
RIGHT THINKING YOUR NAME AGAIN.
EIGHTY LAZY SCOTT YEAH I THINK
IF YOU'RE BEING FOLLOWED BY AN
IMMUNOLOGIST YOU'LL BE FOLLOWED
BY IN YOUR LAWS SEE OF A COMPLEX.
SITUATION -- THAT AGAIN.
YEAH I CAN'T PREDICT INTO THE
FUTURE BUT THAT'S THE KIND OF
SITUATION I WOULD.
THINK THAT KNOWING MY COLLEAGUES
WOULD BE THAT IF I WAS ON A PEER
REVIEW PANEL IT'S A WORLD THIS
THIS SEEMS LIKE THIS IS THIS
LOOKS REAL RIGHT THIS THERE
FOLLOWED BY IMMUNOLOGIST.
THAT PERSON IS SOMEONE WHO'S
YEAH AND AND AND I MEAN IT'S
CLEARLY IMMUNE SUPPRESSION --
THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS INVOLVED.
THAT'S THE SPACE WHERE IT'S LIKE
YOU KNOW I WANT TO GIVE THEM THE
BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT WE'RE NOT
SAYING IT'S STRICTLY CZ BY THE
WAY THIS THESE GUYS DO GIVE.
YOU KNOW SAYING IF YOU'RE IN
SUPPRESSED AND SO FORTH THEY DO
ACTUALLY ALLOW YOU TO GET
EXEMPTIONS FOR THOSE REASONS.
SO I I UNDERSTAND THE CONCERN
THAT MAYBE WE DON'T QUITE FIT IN
THE BOX YOU'RE NOT SURE WHAT DO
YOU FIT IN THE BOX BUT THAT'S
WHY WE ALSO PUT IN THE PROCESS
BY THE WAY WE ALSO SEE THE C. P.
H. CLINICIANS.
CAN DO STANDARD OF CARE TO SO
THEY'RE NOT ENTIRELY TIED THE
THINK THOSE ARE THE ONES WHERE
YOU GO YOU KNOW WHAT -- THERE
FOLLOWED BY A SPECIALIST THEY
CLEARLY HAVE YOU KNOW IT'S WELL
DOCUMENTED THAT PERSON IS GOING
TO IS LIKE OKAY LET'S GIVE THAT
PERSON THAT EXEMPTION THE PERSON
SAYS WELL I YEAH I I YEAH I HAD
SOME SOMETHING HAPPENED TO MY
UNCLE AND I WANT TO MEDICAL
EXEMPTION FOR MY KID.
AND SOMEONE'S WRITING A LOT OF
YOU KNOW SAYING THAT -- THERE'S
A FAMILY HISTORY OF IMMUNE
DEFICIENCY BUT THE CHILD AND
THERE'S NO DOCUMENTATION WITH AN
EFFICIENCY IS A DISTANT RELATIVE.
THAT GETS A LOOK I THINK THAT
REQUIRES MORE INVESTIGATION AN
INQUIRY INTO THAT WE CAN'T PROVE
IT THEN THAT WOULD -- THAT'S
FINE MORE OF AN EXCUSE THAN
ANYTHING ELSE.
SO IS ACTUALLY UNDER CARE BY A
SPECIALIST IN IMMUNOLOGY -- FRY
WOULD GET GET QUITE A BIT OF
DIFFERENCE TO THAT SPECIALIST
HOWEVER LACY IS STILL CONCERNED
SO CAN I JUST HEAR FROM YOU
[inaudible]
APOLOGIZE.
AND MAYBE THIS COULD CLEAR IT UP
IF I EXPLAINED REALLY QUICK WHAT
HAPPENED IN OUR SCENARIO AND
THEN YOU CAN EVEN ANSWER HOW YOU
WOULD SUGGEST IT WOULD BE
TREATED SO -- BEFORE I FOUND OUT
THAT I WAS IMMUNO COMPROMISED I
WAS RECEIVING VACCINES AND I
RECEIVED A T. DOT.
D. TAP VACCINE AND HAD A VERY
SEVERE SEVERE REACTION -- THAT
INCLUDED VERTIGO FOR TWO AND A
HALF WEEKS I COULDN'T GET OUT OF
THAT.
I HAD A HORRIBLE JOINT AND JOINT
PAIN AND SWELLING WHERE THEY HAD
TO CUT OFFERINGS.
I HAD FLU LIKE SYMPTOMS --
HORRIBLE STOMACH ACHES -- I HAD
VISION DISRUPTIONS WHERE I WAS
SEEING FLOATERS BESIDES THE
VERTIGO.
AND I LOST PARTIAL HEARING IN MY
RIGHT EAR FOR UP TO TWO MONTHS
IT LIKELY CAME BACK SO I CAN
HEAR AGAIN.
BUT THIS WAS A VERY EXTREME
REACTION AND WHEN I WENT BACK TO
MY DOCTOR I I ACTUALLY CALLED
BECAUSE I COULDN'T GO BACK RIGHT
AWAY BECAUSE I COULDN'T GET OUT
OF BED.
THEY TOLD ME THAT I MUST A
CAUGHT A VIRUS.
WE DIDN'T KNOW THAT I WAS IMMUNE
COMPROMISED AT THE TIME -- I
STARTED VACCINATING MY CHILDREN
THEY ENDED UP HAVING -- THEIR
FIRST DE TAP AND DID NOT A HAVE
A VACCINE REACTION IT WASN'T
UNTIL THEIR SECOND DO YOU TAP
THAT THEY HAD THE SAME EXACT
VACCINE REACTION THAT I DID.
I CALLED THEIR PEDIATRICIAN AND
THEY TOLD ME THEY MUST OF CAUGHT
A VIRUS.
AND SO IT MADE ME AS A MOTHER
REALIZE I NEED TO LOOK DEEPER
INTO WHAT WAS GOING ON WITH OUR
IMMUNOLOGY AND I I HAD ALREADY
BEEN DIAGNOSED WITH AUTOIMMUNE
DISORDER SO I KNEW THAT THERE
WAS SOMETHING OFF WITH MY BODY.
SO THAT'S WHEN I FINALLY WAS
REFERRED TO YOU SEE US OFF AND
THEY DID THE MILLION DOLLAR WORK
UP BECAUSE CV IDEAS AND
DIFFICULT DIAGNOSIS.
ONLY ABOUT ONE IN SEVEN HUNDRED
PEOPLE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAVE WHAT I HAVE SO
IT'S RARE.
ETAN'S.
LUCKILY WE DIDN'T IN THE
MEANTIME VACCINATE THEM AGAIN WE
HAD HELD OFF SO LIKE YOU SAID
YOU YOU START LOOKING AT THIS
AND AND WAITING AND HOLDING
OFFICE OF PARENT.
AND BUT WE WOULDN'T UNDER THIS
LAW I DON'T FEEL LIKE WE WOULD
HAVE BEEN GIVEN THE TIME TO DO
THAT THIS.
OKAY SO THIS TOOK ME.
OVER A YEAR AND A HALF TO BE
DIAGNOSED WITH US SO THIS WAS
THIS WAS A LONG SO I DON'T THINK
THAT THE THIRTY DAYS WHAT OF
APPLY TO ME AND I KNOW YOU'RE
SAYING THAT IT WOULD HAVE BUT
OKAY.
WE CAN OKAY SO.
IT SAYS SO THAT HAPPENED IN THE
MEANTIME I WAS ALSO VACCINATED
AGAIN AND HAD ANOTHER FAX THE
REACTION YOU ACTUALLY HAVE TO BE
DIAGNOSED WITH C. B. ID BY KEVIN
A VACCINE.
AT PNEUMOCOCCAL VACCINE IN YOU
HAVE YOUR TIGHTER COUNT TAKEN
BEFORE.
AND MAKE SURE THAT YOU DON'T
HAVE TITERS FOR PNEUMONIA IS
WHAT THAT VACCINE IS FOR THEN
YOU WERE GIVEN THE VACCINE THE
PNEUMOCOCCAL VACCINE.
AND THEN THEY TAKE THE TIGHTER
COUNT AGAIN AFTER AND THEN THEY
DID IT AGAIN BECAUSE I DIDN'T
RESPOND AT ALL I HAD NO TIGHTER
COUNTS SHOW UP.
THEN THEY DID IT AGAIN TWO
MONTHS AFTER STILL NO TIGHTER
COUNT.
AND SO AT THAT POINT I WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH CV ID.
AND WE REALIZED THAT THAT WAS A
VACCINE REACTION THAT MY
CHILDREN HAD.
AS WELL AS MYSELF.
AT THAT POINT THEN.
I HAD TO GO GET A VACCINE
EXEMPTION WHICH YES IT WAS VERY
EASY AT THAT POINT BUT I'M
CONCERNED WITH THIS FIVE
EXEMPTION RULE.
IS WELL DOCTORS STICK THEIR NECK
OUT ON THE LINE FOR PEOPLE LIKE
ME THEY DON'T FIT INTO THAT
CATEGORY SPECIFICALLY.
YES.
AND SENATOR PAN IT SAID WERE
EXEMPT COMPLETELY FOR MM ARE AND
FOR SALAS BEING.
ODD BEING A MOVIE I'M YOU KNOW
COMPROMISED THAT'S NO QUESTION
BUT THE DETAIL BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T FALL WITHIN THOSE
GUIDELINES AND MY PEDIATRICIAN
DIDN'T EVEN DOCUMENT THEIR CHART
BECAUSE IT WAS JUST A NORMAL
VIRUS IS WHAT SHE HAD SAID.
IT WORRIES ME BECAUSE OUR
DOCUMENTATION.
YOU KNOW I HAD TO ADD IT
AFTERWARDS WHICH WHAT A SECOND
LOOK MAKE ME LOOK LIKE ADDING TO
MY CHILDREN'S CHART.
AND THEN ALSO -- WHEN WHEN I
COMPLAINED ABOUT MY VACCINE WHAT
I WAS THINKING WAS A VACCINE
REACTION TO MY DOCTOR AGAIN
DIDN'T DIE YOU KNOW DIDN'T WRITE
IT ON MY CHART IS A VACCINE
EXAMPLE S. VACCINE REACTION AT
THAT TIME EITHER?
AND SO IT STARTS TO GET TURKEY
AND THEN HEPATITIS B. SO WE HAVE
WHAT IS CALLED SERUM SICKNESS
AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE REACTING SO
YOU YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH SIR --
SICKNESS.
AND SO SIR I'M SICK YES I KNOW
THIS GETS VERY COMPLEX AND I
KNOW YOU ALL ARE NOT DOCTORS BUT
THIS IS WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
WITH PEOPLE LIKE MYSELF.
IS SIR -- SICKNESS THEY SAY THAT
THE REASON WHY WE REACT THIS WAY
IS BECAUSE IT'S A AND BOTH THE
D. TAPI ON THE PNEUMOCOCCAL MADE
ME REACT THIS WAY IS.
MY ANTIBODIES GET TRAPPED INSIDE
MY TISSUE JOINTS.
IT COULD EVEN BE BRAIN AND MAKE
YOUR BRAIN SWELL.
AND SO MY ANTIBODIES WILL GET
TRAPPED AND I FOR SOME REASON MY
BODY DOESN'T GET RID OF THEM.
AND THEY ARE GUESSING THAT
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING TO MY
CHILDREN TOO ALTHOUGH AGAIN IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT TO DIAGNOSE FIX
CV ID AND AT ANY TIME YOU CAN
DEVELOP CB ID SO IT'S NOT
SOMETHING I WAS BORN WITH.
YOU DEVELOP IT OVER TIME AND SO
RIGHT NOW THEY DON'T THINK THAT
THEY HAVE SEE THE ID AND THEY
DON'T KNOW WHY.
THEIR BODIES ARE REACTING TO
VACCINES LIKE MINE SO I AGAIN
HAVE THIS KIND OF SWISS CHEESE
OF MEDICAL RECORDS NOT
EXPLAINING IT AND SO THESE ARE
THE TYPES OF SITUATIONS THAT
WERE TRULY CONCERNED ABOUT AND
JUST TO BE CLEAR WE ARE
CONCERNED.
ABOUT THE LIMIT OF FIVE IS THAT
NO ONE LIKES TO BE CALLED TO THE
PRINCIPAL'S OFFICE RIGHT LIKE NO
ONE WANTS TO BE NO ONE WANTS
THEIR FIVE EXEMPTIONS AND THEN
GET CALLED IN ALL OF THEIR STUFF
IS REVIEWED AND THEN.
ALL THE SUDDEN BY SUBJECTIVE
WITH APPEAR OF THREE PEOPLE WHO
MAY OR MAY NOT HAVE A DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE -- WHO MAYBE MORE
HEAVY HANDED OR LESS HAVING
ENDED THAT MAKING A CHOICE ON
THIS DOCTORS RIGHT AND THAT
REALLY NEEDED A SIGN OR TO
ANALYZE AND THEN IF YOURS DOES
NOT QUALIFY ON THE HIGHER END OF
THOSE? TEN MAYBE I I'M YOU CAN
KEEP YOUR MACHINE THIS IS A
LEGITIMATE CONCERN AND SHE HAS
IT SO I THINK IT SHOULD BE
EXPRESS AND I I THINK THIS IS
WHAT SHE'S TRYING TO SAY.
IS THAT THE CONCERN IS IS THAT
ONCE THERE IS THAT THRESHOLD.
YOU HIT THAT THRESHOLD YOU GET
CALLED TO THE PRINCIPAL'S OFFICE.
FIRST OF ALL DOES ANYONE EVER
WANT TO GET CALLED TO THE
PRINCIPAL'S OFFICE NO NO AND
THEN SECOND OF ALL ONCE THERE'S
LET'S SAY TEN OF THOSE.
IS THERE THE FEELING OR NEED BY
THIS PEER REVIEWED DEPENDING ON
THE PERSPECTIVE OF THAT.
WHICH IS OUT OF ALL OF OUR
CONTROL THEN -- WHETHER OR NOT
YOU WILL QUALIFY ARE NOT BECAUSE
MAYBE THERE'S SOMEONE WHO DOES
FALL DEAD IN LINE WITH THE CDC
GOT AND I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
I'M CLEAR YOU DON'T HAVE TO
WRITE YOU CAN ADD A LOT YOU KNOW.
NO THAT'S OKAY AND I AND ONE OF
MY CONCERNS TO IS WILL THAT PEER
TO PEER REVIEW TRULY BE AS A
QUESTION WAS ASKED EARLIER.
A DOCTOR THE DOCTOR BECAUSE THEY
DO THAT FOR INSURANCE SO MY
IMMUNOGLOBULIN THERAPY GETS
TONIGHT ALL THE TIME TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH THAT MY
INSURANCE COMPANY SO THEY TRY TO
GET OUT OF THAT AND WHEN A TRUE
PEER TO PEER REVIEW IS.
IS DONE MY IMMUNOLOGIST GETS ON
THE PHONE WITH MY INSURANCE
DOCTOR AND THEY TALK BACK AND
FORTH THEY HAVE MY RECORDS AND
BUT THEY'VE DENIED MY CLAIM.
AND SO I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THIS
THREE DOCTOR PANEL THEY'LL HAVE
ME AND THEY DON'T HAVE THAT PEER
TO PEER TALKING WITH MY
IMMUNOLOGIST REVIEW AND SO
THAT'S WHY I THINK IT WOULD BE.
REALLY GREAT TEN CLUED IN THE
SPELL AND AND AN INTELLIGENT ADD
TO THIS BILL WOULD BE HAVING
THAT PEER TO PEER REVIEW EITHER
A CONFERENCE CALL OR IN PERSON
AND ALLOW.
I I MEAN I'M LIKELY VERY HEAVILY
IT EDUCATED ON THIS TOPIC
BECAUSE OF WHAT I'VE GONE
THROUGH BUT ALLOW PARENTS LIKE
MYSELF TO BE THERE AND EXPLAIN
OUR SITUATION TO AND MAKE SURE
IT'S NOT JUST SOME DOCTOR.
MISSING SOMETHING THAT HAS
HAPPENED TO US OR MISS
UNDERSTAND THAT JUST.
BY LOOKING AT A PIECE OF PAPER
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THE TIME THINKING.
AYE AYE HOPEFUL LIKE I SAID I
THINK IT.
I MEAN.
I DON'T GO UP ON THESE ARE EVER.
I NEVER GO UP ON THEM BECAUSE
THEY JUST I WANT THE FREEDOM TO
MAKE THE CHOICES FOR MY FAMILY
AND MY CHILD AND I AND I HAVE.
AND I STRUGGLED WITH THAT WHEN I
CAME HERE BECAUSE MY DAUGHTER
WAS AN INFANT WHEN I FIRST GOT
ELECTED AND I GOT ON AIRPLANES.
pMY DAUGHTER BACK AND FORTH.
AND I AND AFTER HAVING AN
INCIDENT WITH THE VACCINE IT WAS
REALLY A HARD CHOICE IT WASN'T
SOMETHING THAT CAME EASY I
DIDN'T PUT HER ON A PRO LONG
SCHEDULE BECAUSE IT WAS
CONVENIENT FOR ME.
I DID IT BECAUSE I TRULY WAS
CONCERNED ABOUT THE WELL HEALTH
AND WELL BEING OF MY DAUGHTER
WHILE STILL OBVIOUSLY WANTING TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE COMMUNITY AND
HOW THE COMMUNITY AT THE SAME
PLACE AS WELL AND SO.
ALTHOUGH I UNDERSTAND HOW
IMPORTANT NO HOME FOR NEEDS ARE
I KNOW I'M FOR THIS ISSUE IS TOO
AND SO MANY PEOPLE MY COLLEAGUE
NEXT TO ME AS WELL I AM A HUGE
FAN OF HOWEVER -- I HOPE YOU'RE
LISTENING AND THAT SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT ARE THAT ARE
PART OF THIS BILL AND I REALLY
DO THINK THE COMMITTEE FOR AT
THE TIME AND EFFORT THAT YOU
GUYS HAVE PUT INTO TO MAKING
INTO MAKING THE ADJUSTMENTS.
ON THIS BUT TODAY I WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT IT BUT I THINK
YOU FOR THE TIME THAT YOU PUT
INTO IT SO FAR.
ANYONE ELSE OTHER.
JUST MAKE YOUR PARTS -- I'LL
MAKE THIS QUICK -- FIRST OF ALL
DR THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BRING
THIS FOR IT I KNOW IT'S BEEN
VERY DIFFICULT IN THIS PART OF A
DEMOCRACY IS ALL ABOUT.
THAT WE SIT HERE AND WE LISTEN
AND WE TRY TO FIND OUT THE BEST
SOLUTION.
AND I WANT TO THANK ALL THE
PEOPLE THAT HAVE YOU KNOW WAITED
ON THIS I KNOW IT'S BEEN TOUGH
FOR MANY OF US.
LOVE LITTLE GIFTS SHOWED UP IN.
BERMAN TO SUBJECT -- BUT I DO
WANT.
A BILL THE HOUSE WRITTEN -- BUT
I DO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THIS
AND I WANT TO THANK MY
CONSTITUENTS REBEKAH CAME AND
TALKED TO MY OFFICE NUMEROUS
TIMES IN -- THE MANAGER TERRY I
THINK YOU REALLY DID A GOOD JOB
AND IS THIS ALL ABOUT
IMPLEMENTATION WHAT REALLY COMES
DOWN TO HOW WE CAN IMPLEMENT
THIS TO MAKE SURE THAT IT WORKS
FOR EVERYONE -- MAN MAY NOT WORK
FOR EVERYONE -- I REALLY
APPRECIATED YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY
HER TESTIMONY TODAY WAS WAS
PHENOMENAL AND I HOPE THAT YOU
MIGHT BE ABLE TO FIGURE
SOMETHING OUT ON ON THOSE
SPECIFIC SPECIFIC ONES BUT AGAIN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
FOR THE FORD -- THIS BILL THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT -- YOU KNOW
OTHER THINGS WHEN WE RUN FOR
OFFICE IT'S ALL ABOUT SAFETY.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT IT IS
WHEN THERE'S WATER LIGHT STREETS --
HEALTH THAT ALL COMES UNDER THE
UMBRELLA OF WHAT OUR JOBS ARE
HERE AND SO I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR BEING THERE FOR AND I WILL
BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY.
MISTER IS THERE.
THANK YOU STRUCTURE.
I THOUGHT I WAS GONNA SPEAKER
EARLIER BUT I WANTED TO GET A
CHANCE TO HEAR FROM ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES FIRST -- MISTER PAN
THANK YOU SO MUCH DOCTOR PAN
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR WORK
A VERY MUCH VALUE YOUR TENACITY
I ADMIRE YOUR BRING YOUR
EXPERTISE TO TO THIS INSTITUTION
AND AND I REALLY ADMIRE YOUR
YOUR RELENTLESSNESS AND WANTING
TO ADVANCE WHAT YOU FEEL IS
IMPORTANT.
I REALLY DO VALUE THAT I THINK
THAT'S WHY WE'RE ALL HERE -- FOR
I WAS VERY PROUD TO BE A CO
AUTHOR ON YOUR FIRST BILL.
I VERY MUCH VALUE WHAT THAT DID
I THINK IT ADDRESSED A LOT OF
ISSUES.
WHEN I ASKED LA USD TO PRODUCE
THE NUMBERS?
IT'S AT A ONE TO AT LEAST TWO IF
NOT HIGHER THAN 2% INCREASE IN
EVERY SEGMENT OF THE SIX
SUBSECTIONS.
OF LAUSD -- AVERAGE OF LA U. S.
THE I BELIEVE IT'S SOMEWHERE ON
91%.
UP MOST OF THE PLACES ARE
ANYWHERE FROM 94% TO ABOUT 93%
92%.
UNFORTUNATELY THE ONE SECTION
WHICH IS THE WEST SIDE OF LA U.
S. THE IS AT 87% AND THAT'S WHY
IT'S WEIGHING DOWN THE AVERAGE
[inaudible]
OTHERWISE.
AT TWO SEVENTY SEVEN WORKED --
INCREASE THE OUTCOMES OF
IMMUNIZATION EVERYWHERE.
AND WHEN I'M LOOKING AT WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH NOW.
BECAUSE WE'VE SPENT.
BUT FOR A FIVE AND A HALF HOURS
MAYBE NO FIVE HOURS. FOUR
O'CLOCK WE STARTED AS CRUZ
COUNTY ARE.
I'M TRYING TO JUST FIGURE OUT
EXACTLY WHAT IT IS WE'RE TRYING
TO ACCOMPLISH AND I APPRECIATE
THE CONVERSATION WE HAD LAST
WEEK AS WELL.
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS I HAD
DIDN'T GET RESOLVED.
MY GOAL WAS IF WE'RE GONNA IF
YOU'RE GOING TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH THIS AND I WOULD HAVE
JOINED YOU AS A CO AUTHOR AGAIN.
WHY NOT LOOK AT?
THE PHYSICIANS.
THAT ARE SPECIFICALLY CONDUCTING
IN A WAY THAT WE WANT TO HOLD
ACCOUNTABLE.
IF THERE ARE PHYSICIANS THAT WE
ARE AWARE OF WHO ARE OFFERING
THESE EXEMPTIONS.
WITHOUT EVEN SEEING THEIR
PATIENT.
WHY CAN'T WE ADDRESSING THAT
DIRECTLY -- INSTEAD OF CREATING
THIS PROCESS.
THAT WE HAVEN'T REALLY TALKED
ABOUT HOW MUCH IT'S EVEN GONNA
COST THE STATE.
AND I BRING THIS UP BECAUSE MOST
OF MY COLLEAGUES HERE.
ESPECIALLY THOSE OF US WHO HAVE
BEEN SERVING HERE NOW FOR IN OUR
FOURTH TERM.
WE'VE AND AND WE'VE BEEN WORKING
AND HEALTH RELATED ISSUES WILL
CONSTANTLY WORK ON AREAS THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO IMPROVE HEALTH
OUTCOMES.
AND ONLY TO HAVE.
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH PUBLIC
HEALTH COME IN SB SIX SEVEN
EIGHT MONTHS INTO THE BILL'S
LIFE AFTER WE'VE DONE A LOT OF
WORK.
AND SAY THERE'S A BIG COST
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS.
AND TURNING THE BILL AND THEN
DOCTOR HAS TO TURN THE BILL INTO
TO YOUR BILL WORK THROUGH THE
VARIOUS AMENDMENTS WORK THROUGH
THE VARIOUS ISSUES.
UNTIL WE GET INTO A PLACE THAT
WE CAN MOVE FORWARD AGAIN -- BUT
YET IN THIS CASE WHEN WE'RE
LOOKING AT WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
PERCENTAGES [inaudible]
THANK.
WE WE SO.
IN -- TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN WE
WERE AT ABOUT POINT 17% NINE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN
STUDENTS.
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN SIXTEEN
SCHOOL YEAR.
AND IT'S GONE UP TWO POINT 7%.
AROUND FOUR THOUSAND A HUNDRED
STUDENTS.
IN.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT FOUR THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED
STUDENTS ROUGHLY.
OUT OF A POPULATION OF FORTY
MILLION IN THE STATE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT A TENS.OF A OF A HUNDREDTH OF A
PERCENTAGE [inaudible]
PERCENT POINT.
SO THAT'S WHY I WAS ALSO ASKING
WENT WITH WHEN MISS BURKE RIGHT
AROUND NOW THAT RED WINE SOUNDS
VERY GOOD BY THE WAY.
WHEN MISS BURKE WAS ASKING ABOUT
THE NUMBERS AGAIN I WANTED TO
CLARIFY BECAUSE?
A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY NINE CASES
IN THREE YEARS.
I FEEL LIKE WE IT'S INCUMBENT ON
US TO WANT TO DO A STUDY AND ASK
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
TO FIGURE OUT.
WHAT ARE THE REASONS WHY WE
DON'T HAVE WATER THAN NON
VACCINATION NUMBERS ATTRIBUTABLE?
TO SO THAT WE COME UP WITH THE
BEST PRACTICES SO THAT WE CAN
BETTER ADDRESS WHAT THE NEEDS
ARE AND AND I DON'T WANT TO GO
ON AND ON MISTER CHAIR BUT I
HAVE SEVERAL OTHER QUESTIONS.
SO I I'M I'M HAPPY TO HAVE A
BACK AND FORTH AND I HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS FOR THE OPPOSITION AS
WELL.
SO WHENEVER YOU FEEL.
HAPPY TO ALLOW THE AUTHOR.
TO RESPOND OKAY SO ALL RIGHT SO
I A HAVE YOU MADE A LAST
STATEMENT SAY WHAT THIS AND I
WILL LET ME DRESS THOSE I'M NOT
SURE AND MUCH NOT SURE EXACTLY
WHAT THE QUESTION YOU WANT
ANSWERED BUT FIRST OF ALL.
I WOULD POINT OUT THAT -- DO
WHAT DID YOU LIKE ME TO REPEAT
JUST SO YOU KNOW WELL I KNOW I
THINK IF YOU WANT TO JUST -- BUT
LET ME JUST GO SEE IF I ANSWER
YOUR QUESTIONS RIGHT AND FIRST
OF ALL I I WOULD JUST POINT OUT
FIRST OF ALL THE DENOMINATORS
NOT THE ENTIRE POPULATION THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WHAT WE'RE DOING IS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT EACH ENTERING
KINDERGARTEN CLASS AND A CHILD
WHO HAS A MEDICAL EXEMPTION --
IS TO TRY AND LIKELY TO GET
VACCINATED AND IF THEY HAVE A
GENUINE MEDICAL EXEMPTION SHOULD
BE VACCINATED THE FOLLOWING YEAR
THEY HAVE A FROM THE MEDICAL
EXEMPTION I'M SORRY BUT I GOT TO
STOP YOU RIGHT THERE BECAUSE
WHEN YOU'RE POINTING OUT TO THE
EXAMPLES OF THE OUTBREAKS.
DOES INCLUDE MANY ADULTS SO OKAY.
LET ME LET ME AND THEN YOU GET
TO THAT SO FIRST OF ALL IT'S ALL
RIGHT SO WHAT HAPPENS IS -- TWO
SEVEN SEVEN IS -- WAS DOING ITS
JOB ALL RIGHT -- EVEN THOUGH
IT'S ONLY BEEN IN PLACE FOR
THREE YEARS NOW BUT WE ALSO NOTE
WAS IS THAT THE SO WE AFTER --
TWO SEVEN SEVEN WE GOT THE
MUSICIAN RATE -- FOR OVERALL
ACROSS THE STATE ABOVE 95% --
FOR THE FIRST TWO YEARS IT'S NOW
ACTUALLY ENFORCING SLIP BELOW
THAT -- BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY IS
THAT WE HAVE SCHOOLS OF MEDICAL
EXEMPTION RATES OF 10% OF OVER A
HUNDRED SCHOOLS OVER 10% SO THE
QUESTION IS IS AND IT'S NOT THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT RATE IT'S THE
SCHOOL RIGHT IN FACT THAT'S A
TRIGGER ESPECIALLY THE SCHOOL
NOT THE SCHOOL DISTRICT SO YOU.
MENTIONED THERE SOME SCHOOLS IN
PARTICULAR PARTS OF LA U. S. T.
THAT HAVE LOWERED THAT THAT'S
WHAT WOULD TRIGGER IT'S NOT THE
OVERALL SCHOOL DISTRICT -- I
WOULD ALSO POINT OUT THAT.
RIGHT SO WHAT HAPPENS IS IS THAT.
MOST OF THE MORE READ THIS THIS
YEAR'S IT ARE IN -- YOUNG ADULTS
ACTUALLY -- SOMETIMES A CALL
THAT THE WEEK FEEL GENERATION --
THOSE ARE THE FOR KIDS KIDS --
TO THOSE ARE THE PEOPLE WHO THE
REASON ARE NOW YOUNG ADULTS
DATING GET VACCINATED WHEN THEY
WERE.
CHILDREN RIGHT BECAUSE THAT'S
WHEN ANDREW WAKEFIELD CAME OUT
WITH THE STUDY THAT -- BASICALLY --
FALSELY CLAIMED THAT VACCINES
CAUSE AUTISM FRIGHTENED MANY OF
PARENTS FROM WILL BE ON THEIR
BACKS AND THEY'D BUT WELL
UNFORTUNATELY NOT BEYOND THAT
BECAUSE THOSE CHILDREN ARE THE
UNVACCINATED CHILDREN THAT HAVE
BEEN GETTING THE MEASLES IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND WE ALSO SAW THIS BY THE WAY
IN ENGLAND AS WELL HE'S -- SO SO
SO YOU'RE RIGHT NOW OF A LOT OF
THE CASES -- ARE IN YOUNG ADULTS
IN TERMS OF THIS -- THIS
PARTICULAR -- YEAR IN TERMS OF
WE LOOK AT WHAT THE MEASLES
CASES ARE.
WHAT WE DON'T WANT TO DO IS WE
DON'T WANT TO GO ACTUALLY?
YEAH ADD TO THE GROUP OF PEOPLE
OR AN VACCINATED RIGHT SO IS
AGAIN AS YOU MEMBERS A CO AUTHOR
OF SB TWO SEVEN SEVEN IT'S
REALLY ADDRESSING IT YEAR BY
YEAR SO WHEN WE LOOK AT IT WHEN
WE SAY WHAT'S THE VACCINATION
RATES REALLY ONLY THE
VACCINATION RATE. FOR THE
KINDERGARTEN CLASS OF THAT YEAR.
YEAH I IT'S NOT THE VACCINATION
RATE FOR ALL THE SUBSEQUENT YEAH
ALL THE YEARS AHEAD OF THEM YOU
HAVE TO LOOK AT WHEN THEY WERE
KINDERGARTNERS THE END IDEA
ABOUT ROUGHLY WHERE THEY ARE.
YOU'RE RIGHT SOME YOU KNOW ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT IT'S NOT ALL
JUST ABOUT MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS
RIGHT SO ONE OF THINGS THAT WE
DEFINITELY NEED TO PUBLIC HEALTH
IS DONE IS WORK WITH SCHOOLS TO
BE SURE.
KIDS WHO HAD CONDITIONAL ONES
THAT THEY WERE FOLLOWINGUP TO
BE SURE THEY GOT THE REMAINDER
OF THEIR VACCINATIONS RIGHT WE
NEED TO BE SURE CHILDREN ACCESS
TO HEALTH CARE.
RIGHT AND SO THAT'S WHY WITH THE
VACCINE FOR CHILDREN FIND WE'VE
ACTUALLY SPEND IT -- ACCESS TO
MEDICARE FOR FOR FOR CHILDREN
WHO ARE TEN WHO WHO LIVE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES BECAUSE THAT WAY
THEY CAN GET THEIR VACCINES IT'S
NOT A ECONOMIC BARRIER TO GET
THE VACCINATIONS.
BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE
EXEMPTION RATE HAS QUADRUPLED
AND I WOULD POINT OUT THAT
ACTUALLY YOU ADD PERMANENT SO BY
THE WAY IF YOU HAVE PERMANENT
AND TEMPORARY.
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS YOU'RE
ACTUALLY ABOVE ONE POINT 1% AND
THIS IS THE CHALLENGES THIS IF
WE DO NOTHING AND IT KEEPS GOING
UP AT THE CURRENT RATE.
WE ARE GOING TO BE BACK IN THE
SAME PROBLEM WE HAD THE FOUR TWO
SEVEN SEVEN I MEAN.
WE WE COULD YOU KNOW AND SO WE
SEE THE TREND LINE MISTRANSLATED
TREND LINES WHICH IS.
CONTINUING TO INCREASE SO YEAH
SO BUT PLEASE.
BUT THAT'S EXACTLY THE POINT SO
WHY NOT FIRST FIGURE OUT WHY THE
TREND IS GOING BACK UP AGAIN
BECAUSE WE KNOW WHY THAT THE PAR
PUBLIC HEALTH IS LOOK AT YOU
KNOW BECAUSE WE DON'T EXACTLY
KNOW HOW MANY OF THE INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE GOING FOR PERSONAL
BELIEF EXEMPIONS.
MAY HAVE NOT WANTED TO GET A
MEDICAL EXEMPTION SO YEP.
WE DON'T THERE'S A LOT OF
QUESTIONS WE STILL DON'T KNOW.
SO INSTEAD OF JUMPING TO A
LEGISLATIVE FIX WELL I I WOULD
REFER YOU TO ACTUALLY RESEARCH
DONE BY DOCTOR OVER SAY AT HIS
TO LOOK AT THESE DATA THERE'S
BEEN NUMEROUS PAPERS PUBLISHED
ABOUT WHAT'S.
HAPPENING CALIFORNIA AFTER TWO
SEVEN SEVEN BECAUSE AFTER ALL WE
ARE THE FIRST STATE TO HAVE
ROLLED BACK THE NONMEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS SO RESEARCHERS HAVE
BEEN VERY INTERESTED IN SEEING
WHAT HAVE.
WHAT HAS HAPPENED IN THE THING
THEY MADE NOTE OF THE BIGGEST
PROBLEM THAT'S HAPPENED AFTER
TWO SEVEN SEVEN IS A RISE IN?
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS THAT IS
THAT'S WHY THERE IS THAT STUDY
AS FOLLOWS IN PEDIATRICS THE
TALK -- TO COUNTY HEALTH
OFFICERS.
WHO MAY KNOW THAT THAT WAS A BIG
PROBLEM BY THE WAY NOT EVERY
PERSON IS ACTUALLY REFERRED TO
THE MEDICAL BOARD FOR FOR A FOR
A COMPLAINT TO EAT WE NEED A
ALWAYS HEARD FROM SCHOOL NURSES?
WE UP PEOPLE LOOKED AT SO WHAT
HAPPENED TO THE CONDITIONALS
WHAT HAPPENS IS AS YOU JUST THE
PAPER PUBLISHED.
RECENTLY IN PEDIATRICS LOOK AT
ALL THE DIFFERENT POTENTIAL
CATEGORIES CALLED SUBSTITUTION
EFFECT RIGHT SO WHO HAD PERSONAL
BELIEF EXEMPTIONS BEFORE WHAT
WAS THAT RATE NOW TO SEND SEVEN
THAT'S DRIVEN THAT DOWN THE
CENTURY THE ZERO SO WHAT'S
HAPPENING NOW AND BASICALLY THEY
SAID IT'S BEING REPLACED BY.
YOU KNOW SLOWLY OVER TIME BY
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS AS MEDICAL
ATTENTION RATES HAVE BEEN
INCREASING SO THE RESEARCH IS
BEING DONE THERE IS THERE ARE
PUBLISHED PAPERS HAVE LOOKED AT
THIS AND THEN A FIVE THIS IS THE
PROBLEM I DIDN'T DO THIS BILL
RIGHT AFTER WE DID.
TWO SEVEN SEVEN RIGHT WE HAVE
TWO SEVEN SEVEN WE HAVE THREE
YEARS OF DATA NOW AND THE REASON
I'M DOING THIS BILL NOW IS WE
HAVE A LARGE MEASLES OUTBREAK
AND THE RESEARCH HAS COME OUT OF
WHAT'S HAPPENED POST.
TWO SEVEN SEVEN AND WHAT'S GOING
ON ARE WE LOSING WHAT WE TRY.
TO THE GOALS THAT WE TRIED TO
ACHIEVE A TWO SEVEN SEVEN AND
THE RESEARCH IS SAYING YES NO
BECAUSE OF MEDICAL EXAMS I'M
GLAD YOU SAID THAT BECAUSE THE
DATA IS ACTUALLY SHOWING THAT
WERE IMPROVING.
IMMUNIZATION IS ACTUALLY GONE UP
NOW IF IF YOU'RE GONNA LET
CERTAIN SUBSECTIONS.
WILL WIN.
THAT'S WHY I WAS REFERRING TO
DALY U. S. THE NUMBERS WHEN I'M
LOOKING AND SEEING THAT ALMOST
EVERY SUBSECTION IN THE ENTIRE
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
HAS IMPROVED BY EITHER 2% 1% OR
MAYBE A LITTLE BIT ABOVE 2% --
AGAIN THE EVERYTHING EVERYWHERE
IN THE DISTRICT IS ABOVE 90% THE
ONLY PLACE IS THE WEST SIDE
WHICH IMPROVED FROM.
WHICH ALSO IMPROVED BY A POINT
BUT IT'S STILL BELOW 90% AND
IT'S SIGNIFICANTLY BELOW THE
HERD IMMUNITY LEVEL I UNDERSTAND
THAT AND I WANT TO HELP.
IN ADDRESSING THAT.
BUT I DON'T KNOW IF THIS
NECESSARILY ADDRESSES IT WHEN IT
GOES AFTER SUCH A SMALL SEGMENT.
AS OPPOSED TO TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW IS IT THAT WE CAN GO
AFTER YOU KNOW.
TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHETHER TO
EDUCATION OR THROUGH OTHER
INCENTIVES.
AMONG THE NON COMPLIANCE
STUDENTS AND PARENTS WERE
KEEPING THEIR KIDS NON COMPLIANT.
SO.
I THINK WE HAVE JUST SUCH A
BIGGER MARK THAT WE CAN BE GOING
AFTER RATHER THAN LOOK AT THIS
NARROW AREA.
THAT THAT IT IT THAT'S WHY I WAS
ASKING STARTED BY ASKING WHAT IS
IT EXACTLY THAT WERE AFTER
BECAUSE IF WE WANT TO DISCIPLINE
DOCTORS THE BILL DOESN'T
NECESSARILY DO THAT -- BILL.
I WOULD BEG TO DIFFER --
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN -- LET ME DOWN.
PLEASE EDUCATE ME BECAUSE FROM
WHAT I UNDERSTAND THE HARSHEST.
HARSHEST DISCIPLINE IS ACTUALLY
TEND NOT ALLOW A DOCTOR. TO OF
RIGHT EXEMPTIONS UP FOR TWO YEAR
PERIOD.
BLACK IS THAT IS THAT IS NOT THE
HARSHEST THAT WE CAN DO.
SO ACTUALLY THE REFERRAL TO THE
MEDICAL RECORDS.
SAID TO BE A FRAUDULENT LEVEL OF
ACTIVITY FIRST OF ALL I DON'T
EVEN SEE THE DEFINITION OF
FRAUDULENT REALLY IN THE MET IN
THE BILL SO.
CAN WE MAYBE DISCUSS THAT AS
WELL.
I'M INTERESTED TO KNOW.
YEAH.
WHY DOESN'T THE BILL WHITE IS
THE BILL HAVE A DEFINITION OF
FRAUDULENT MEDICAL EXEMPTION --
REFERRING TO WHAT THE CDC ACAP
AND EIGHTY P. CRITERIA.
WOULD BE DENIED UNDER WHAT WHY
IS IT THAT DAY AND WHAT THAT
RIGHT TO BE A CHANGE OVER TIME
SO AND JUST HEARING ROGER Là IS
NOT IN THE BILL ANY LONGER.
I I WOULD POINT OUT -- THE
SENATE IS AREA AND THAT THE THE
HIGHEST SANCTION WOULD ACTUALLY
BE A LOSS OF YOUR LICENSE WHICH
WOULD.
MEAN YOU CAN'T PRACTICE ANYMORE
AND OF COURSE LOTS OF THE
LICENSE CAN ONLY BE PERFORMED BY
THE MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA.
SO WHEN YOU REFER TO THE TWO
YEAR SUSPENSION THAT WAS THROUGH
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
BUT THAT WE'VE ALSO INCLUDED
LANGUAGE FOR REFERRAL TO THE
MEDICAL BOARD YOU'VE HEARD FROM
THE MEDICAL BOARD THAT THEIR
BIGGEST BARRIER IS.
AN ABILITY TO GET THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED FOR THEIR
INVESTIGATION THEY CAN'T EVEN
GET OFF FIRST BASE AND SO THIS
BILL.
I CREATE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
MEDICAL BOARD TO GET THAT
INFORMATION THAT THEY NEED TO
CONDUCT INVESTIGATIONS THAT
INVESTIGATION CAN LEAD
EVENTUALLY.
TO VARIOUS PENALTIES UP TO LOSS
OF THE MEDICAL LICENSE WHICH
WOULD MEAN THAT THAT POSITION
COULD NO LONGER PRACTICE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA I'M NOT SURE
WHAT IF THERE'S OTHER PENALTIES
ONE SUGGEST -- YOU CAN -- PLEASE
DO SO BUT I I THINK THAT THAT IS
THE THE HYATT THAT IS THE
SANCTION THAT IS AVAILABLE FOR
PHYSICIANS WHO ARE AT FOR FOR
ACTING UNPROFESSIONALLY
UNETHICALLY.
I AM.
I'M SORRY DOCTOR BUT THAT'S NOT
VERY CONVINCING -- HI.
I WOULD HAVE WELL KNOW HOW MANY
LICENSES HAVE BEEN LOST.
YOU JUST EXPLAIN THAT THERE WAS
ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY NINE
WELL I THINK PART OF THE ISSUE
IS CASES WERE NOT NECESSARILY
GETTING COMPLAINTS ON MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS AND WHEN WE DO WE
DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO GET
THE MEDICAL RECORDS AND MANY OF
THESE CASES BECAUSE PARENTS
AREN'T SIGNING.
OFF ON RELEASING THOSE MEDICAL
RECORDS SO THAT IS THAT THE
OBSTACLES THAT WERE FACING RIGHT
NOW SO WE DOING ANOTHER
LEGISLATION TO ENSURE WERE.
EXACTLY WHAT NOW SO BASICALLY
ALLOW US TO GET THOSE MEDICAL
RECORDS AND THEY WILL ALSO HAVE
CD PIERCE COUNTY JUST TO
LEGISLATION THAT EXACT IN A
PRECISE WAY ALLOWS THAT.
AUTHORIZES YOU AND GIVES YOU THE
CAPABILITY OF DOING THE THINGS
AS OPPOSED TO CREATING THIS
PROCESS THAT.
AT HAVE WE TALKED ABOUT THE COST
OF WITH
THIS IS POTENTIALLY GONNA MAN ON
THIS IS NOT A FISCAL COMMITTEES
THE POLICY COMMITTEE.
OKAY HAS BEEN TO WITH BUSCA
FISCAL COMMITTEE IN THE SENATE
SO -- AND IT IS WITH US IT NOW
AND THIS IS A POLICY COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
ABSOLUTELY TRUE.
BUT I CAN'T HELP BUT TO FEEL
THAT YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE TRYING
TO SET UP A PROCESS THAT WHOSE
COST WE DON'T KNOW.
THAT'S GOING TO ADDRESS THE VERY
SMALL [inaudible]
CONSTITUENCIES.
VERSUS TRYING TO DO SOMETHING ON
A BIGGER PICTURE IF IF IF IF.
MR SURE YOU DON'T MIND.
I WANT TO KNOW FROM WHOEVER FROM
THE OPPONENTS WANTS TO ANSWER.
WHAT ENTAILS THE PROCEDURE
EXAMINATION FOR A MEDICAL
EXEMPTION BASED ON FAMILY
MEDICAL HISTORY OR GENETICS
TESTING THAT?
YOU BELIEVE WILL NOT BE
CONSIDERED BY THE STATE UNDER
THE CDC GUIDELINES IF SOMEONE
CAN ANSWER THAT
I'D BE INTERESTED TO KNOW.
AND THEN I WOULD LIKE TO ASK THE
SUPPORTERS FOR THE SAME QUESTION.
SO THE QUESTION IS WHAT WOULD BE --
MEDICAL EXEMPTION UNDER FAMILY
HISTORY.
THAT WOULD NOT QUALIFY UNDER CDC
GUIDELINES.
THE QUESTION.
IS IT'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THOSE CDC
GUIDELINES ARE AND THAT THE
SENATOR DID ANSWER ABOUT THE
ONLY CDC FAMILY HISTORY
GUIDELINE.
IS IF A MOM OR DAD OR FIRST
DEGREE RELATIVE HAS A SEVERE
IMMUNE DEFICIENCY.
AND OF THE CHILDREN MIGHT HAPPEN.
THE ONLY EXEMPTS YOU FROM MMR
CHICKENPOX VACCINE.
THAT'S THE ONLY FAMILY HISTORY
FACTOR IN ALL THE GUIDELINES
THAT ARE IN THIS BILL.
THERE'S A SMALL FAMILIES YOU
FACTOR ABOUT CAESAR'S OF
SOMEONE'S HAD SEIZURES YOU CAN
GET THIS ONE BRAND OF VACCINES.
YOU CAN GET OTHER BROWN'S THAT
THAT QUALIFY SO THAT DOESN'T
WORK SO THERE'S ONLY ONE FAMILY
HISTORY FACTOR.
STUDENTS HAVE TO REALIZE FOR
EXAMPLE ALL SEE A FAMILY.
THE MOM HAD A SEIZURE AFTER
VACCINES HER FIRST CHILD HAD A
SEIZURE AFTER VACCINES -- AND
SHE HAS A NEW BABY AND SHE
DOESN'T WANT TO GIVE THAT BABY
VACCINES AND OTHER DOCTOR I
WOULD AGREE.
THAT'S A GOOD FAMILY HISTORY
REASON NOT TO VACCINATE THEIR
CHILD -- OR MAYBE TO BE DELAY
THEM DO A TOLL YEARS LATER I
DON'T KNOW MAYBE THE TEMPORARY
EXEMPTION IS THEIR BABY.
THERE IS NO SINGLE CDC
GUIDELINES THAT WOULD ALLOW ME
TO WRITE THAT EXEMPTION UNDER
THIS NEW LAW.
DID NO FAMILY HISTORY INVOLVED
WHATSOEVER THAT I THAT WOULD
JUSTIFY ME WRITING EXEMPTION FOR
THAT FAMILY BECAUSE THAT IS NOT
IN THE CDC OR THE A. P. OR THE
ACIP GUIDELINES.
AND APPRECIATE THAT THAT THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS OF ASKED A LOT
ABOUT FAMILY HISTORY.
YOU HAVE TO REALIZE HOW NARROW
THAT IS.
THIS NEW AMENDMENT DID NOT
BROUGHT IN THAT IN ANY WAY
EXCEPT FOR THE SELECT FEW AS AS
THE THE LADIES EXAMPLE -- RIGHT
SO THERE'S SO MANY BUT I MEAN I
COULD LIST SO MANY SEVERE
REACTIONS OF SEEN MOMS OR DADS
HAVE OR THEIR FIRST KIDS HAVE
AFTER VACCINES.
THAT I WILL USE AS LEGITIMATE
FAMILY HISTORY TO WRITE AN
EXEMPTION FOR NEW BABY IN THAT
FAMILY.
TELL IT ALL GO AWAY UNDER THIS
NEW BUILD THOSE ALL BE
DISQUALIFIED.
THE THAT'S IMPORTANT FOR YOU
GUYS TO UNDERSTAND THAT TO THAT
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION.
SIR BUT WE HAVE WE HAVE A A MOM
YOUR EXPERIENCES EXACT THING AND
WE LOVE. FOR YOU TO HEAR FROM
HER IF YOU WOULD LIKE.
MY SON WAS COMPENSATED BY THE
VACCINE INJURY COURTS -- HE WAS
ACTUALLY DIAGNOSED WITH SERUM
SICKNESS AS A RESULT OF HIS
EIGHTEEN MONTH WELL BABY VISIT --
VACCINES ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT --
I FOUND WAS THAT I DIDN'T KNOW
THAT HE WAS EXPERIENCING VACCINE
ISSUES PRIOR TO THAT LAST
REACTION THAT HE HAD THAT WAS
HIS MOST SEVERE WHICH HAD HIM IN
AND OUT OF THE HOSPITAL FOR
EIGHT LONG WEEKS -- HE WAS SEEN
BY MULTIPLE SPECIALIST HE HAD
SEIZURES HE HAD A A CONDITION
CALLED THROMBOSIS I TOOK PINA
CORPORATE WHERE HE LOOKED LIKE
HE HAD BRUISING ALL OVER HIS
BODY -- SO OVER THE COURSE OF
THE WHOLE ENTIRE ON EIGHT WEEKS
THAT WE WERE IN AND OUT OF THE
HOSPITAL AND SPECIALISTS OFFICE
NOT ONE OF THOSE -- THE
SPECIALIST -- WELL ALL OF THEM
ACTUALLY ASKED ME IF HE HAD A
HISTOGRAM A HISTORY OF SITS IN
OUR FAMILY IF WE HAD A HISTORY
OF AUTOIMMUNE CONDITIONS IN THE
FAMILY IF HE HAD.
EXISTING AUTO IMMUNE CONDITIONS
AND WHEN I ASKED WHY IT WAS THAT
THEY WERE ASKING THESE QUESTIONS
THEY SAID THAT THOSE WERE ALL
COUNTRY INDICATIONS OF VACCINE
REACTIONS.
THEY ALSO ASKED ME IF HE HAD
PRIOR VACCINE REACTIONS I DIDN'T
KNOW WHETHER OR NOT HE HAD OR
NOT I DUTIFULLY TOOK MY CHILD IN
FOR EVERY WELL BABY VISIT HADN'T
VACCINATED.
WHAT ENDED UP HAPPENING WAS THAT --
THE IMMUNOLOGIST -- HAD
SUGGESTED THAT WE CROSS
REFERENCE HIS RECORD GET HIS
MEDICAL RECORDS AND CROSS
REFERENCES VACCINE RECORDS TO
ALL OF THE TIMES THAT HE WAS
ADMITTED INTO THE MURDER ZERO OR
HAD -- ON SCHEDULE OF A DOCTOR'S
VISIT WE ENDED UP FINDING OUT
THAT HE HAD -- WITHIN FORTY
EIGHT HOURS HE HAD SYMPTOMS THAT
MATCHED THE HEPATITIS B.
MANUFACTURE INSERTS AND THE HIS
TWELVE MONTH BABY VISIT --
MANUFACTURE INSERTS AS WELL --
AND OF COURSE AT EIGHTEEN MONTHS
OLD HE THE REACTIONS THAT HE WAS
SHOWING WHICH THEY DID DETERMINE
WERE A RESULT OF THOSE VACCINES --
ALSO MATCH THE MANUFACTURE
INSERTS FOR THE SYMPTOMS -- ALL
OF THOSEINCIDENTS WERE VIABLE
IN TERMS OF THE VACCINE INJURY
COMPENSATION PROGRAM.
AND I DID -- HE WAS AWARDED
THROUGH THE VACCINE COURT AND
THERE WAS ONLY A FEW.
DOCTORS THAT ACTUALLY KNEW WHAT
WAS GOING ON SO WHEN YOU WERE
SPEAKING TO THE FACT I FORGET
WHO WAS THE DIRECTOR OF THE
SPECIALIST -- WHO UNDERSTAND
VACCINE INJURY [inaudible]
MY CHILD.
HAD TO GO THROUGH SEVERAL
VACCINE INJURIES WITH SEVERAL
DIFFERENT ACTIONS I KNOW THAT
MOST OF US KNOW WHEN WE TAKE OUR
CHILD AND IF NOT USUALLY JUST
ONE VACCINE THAT YOU'RE GETTING.
SO ONE OF THE ISSUES WITH MY
CHILD AND THE REASON THAT HE
ENDED UP RECEIVING I'M A MEDICAL
EXEMPTION WHICH WAS PRIOR TO SB
TWO SEVEN BEFORE ALL OF THIS
LEGISLATION START HAPPENING.
WAS BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT NOT
ONE MEDICAL EXPERT COULD
PINPOINT WHAT COMPONENT OF WHICH
VACCINE HE RECEIVED BECAUSE OF
THE REACTION BECAUSE WE RECEIVE
SO MANY DIFFERENT.
VACCINES AND MOST CHILDREN DO AT
A BABY VISIT THEY DON'T NESTING
AND I MEAN WE DON'T NORMALLY GET
ONE TAXING IN A BABY VISIT
THERE'S USUALLY OF MANY VACCINES.
SO WITH THAT HE WAS GIVEN A
PERMIT -- MEDICAL EXEMPTION DUE
TO THE FACT THAT NO ONE COULD
TELL ME WHAT COMPONENT OF THE
VACCINES AND I FOUND OUT THAT IT
COULD HAVE BEEN A REACTION -- TO
THE FETAL CELLS THAT WERE THERE
ON THEIR IN VACCINES IT COULD
HAVE BEEN THAT -- OTHER TOXINS
LIKE FORMALDEHYDE AND ALL THE
OTHER INGREDIENTS NO ONE COULD
TELL ME EXACTLY WHAT IT WAS SO
WITH THAT HE HAD TO HAVE -- AIDS
VACCINE -- EXEMPTION FOR ALL
VACCINES AND THE IMMUNOLOGIST
HAD SAID THAT THE NEXT SHOT
COULD KILL HIM.
SO AT THIS POINT SB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN IS FORCING ME TO DECIDE ON
CHOOSING BETWEEN MY SON'S
EDUCATION AT AND HIS LIFE AND I
THINK THAT THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
NEEDS TO BE.
TAKEN INTO CONSIDERATION.
WITH US AND WE WOULD ALSO LIKE
EITHER SO -- SO FIRST OF ALL --
YOU KNOW ITS -- A APPRECIATE THE
THE PRESENTATION I YOU KNOW I I
THINK THERE ARE A LOT OF
STATEMENTS THAT -- THAT ARE MADE
THAT -- DO RAISE SOME QUESTIONS --
SO AGAIN I APPRECIATE THE THE
PRESENTATION -- CERTAINLY I
THINK WOULD BE IMPORTANT TO GET
MORE -- INFORMATION ABOUT
EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED THIS CASE
I I DO -- YELLED Là THINGS ARE
MENTIONS FOR EXAMPLE INSERTS
SAID SO WE KNOW THAT SINCE RATES
HAVE BEEN GOING DOWN THERE NOW
SAYS WHO VACCINES.
ALL RIGHT SO SAID RATES OF WE
GOING DOWN WITH INCREASED
VACCINATION RATES.
WE TALK ABOUT TOXINS IN THE
VACCINE -- ACTUALLY THE LOW FOR
MALAHIDE IN A VACCINE IS -- LESS
THAN WHAT IN A PAIR THAT YOU
EACH AND BY THE WAY YOUR BODY
NORMALLY PRODUCES FORMALDEHYDE
AS A BY PRODUCT OF METABOLISM --
THERE ARE NO FETAL CELLS IN
VACCINES SO THAT'S A ALL RIGHT
YES PLEASE KEEP.
PLEASE.
OKAY SO YOU SOME SO SOME OF THIS
THE VACCINES ARE DEVELOPED.
INITIALLY USED IN FUEL CELLS FOR
DEVELOP VACCINE.
THOSE ARE CONTINUE CULTURED AND
AGAIN THEY'RE NOT WHOLE CELLS
AND VACCINES -- AND THEY'RE
COMPLETELY WATCH SO -- INSERTS
BASICALLY IF ANYONE FAMILIAR
WITH HOW THE FTA WORKS AND
INSERTS BASICALLY THEIR REPORTS
OF ANY -- EVENTS NOT NOT
ASSOCIATE A SAID WITHOUT
CAUSALITY ANY OF THAT THAT
HAPPENS DURING.
CLINICAL EVALUATION SO IF YOU'RE
IN A CAR ACCIDENT.
AND YOU GET INJURED THAT GOES
INTO THE INSERTS IF YOU'RE A
PARTICIPANT IN THE EVALUATION OF
THAT -- MEDICATION -- INCLUDING
A VACCINE -- SO THERE ARE A LOT
OF STATEMENTS IN THERE THAT --
RAISE SOMEQUESTIONS I CERTAINLY
WHY IT WOULD LIKE TO KNOW MORE
ABOUT THE EXACTLY WHAT -- WHAT --
WHAT HAPPENED WITH THE CHILD BUT
I I WOULD POINT OUT THAT -- IN
TERMS OF THAT EVALUATION I MEAN
WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS IS THAT --
WE NEED TO LOOK AT THE SCIENCE
WE NEED TO LOOK AT THE EVIDENCE
AND I SAID BEFORE WE GIVE THE
BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT.
BASED ON THE SCIENCE AND THE
EVIDENCE TO THE CHILD SO IF WE
HAPPEN TO KNOW.
WE HAPPEN TO KNOW THAT.
THERE IS SOME OTHER CAUSE FOR
THE EVENTS.
ARE OF WE HAPPEN TO KNOW THAT
THE VACCINE BECAUSE THERE'S
EXISTING RESEARCH SHOWS IS NOT
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT WE NEED TO
ACCEPT THAT.
IF WE'RE NOT SURE BECAUSE THAT'S
WHY WE CONTINUE TO RESEARCHERS
THINGS WE DON'T KNOW THEN YES I
THINK WE SHOULD -- GIVE SOME
BENEFIT THE DOUBT IN FACT THAT
IS -- BY THE WAY HOW WHEN THEY
SET UP THE GUIDELINES THAT'S
GENERALLY HOW THEY LOOK AND
THAT'S HOW EXPECT A REIEW PANEL
WILL ACT AS WELL.
I THINK THAT CERTAINLY ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT -- ONE DO THAT
IF YOU HAVE YOUR FOLLOWING AN
IMMUNOLOGIST AT UCSF WHO HAS
WHAT IS SAYS THAT YOU HAVE A
RARE IN YOU CAN JUST BUY ALL YOU
DON'T EVEN NEED AND HAVE A
DIAGNOSIS IF YOU SAID LOOK.
I'M AN IMMUNOLOGIST AT UCSF
HERE'S THE WORK I'VE BEEN DOING
I FOLLOW A LOT OF PEOPLE WITH
THESE IMMUNE CHALLENGES OF STILL
WORKING IT OFF AND I THINK
THERE'S A CONCERN BECAUSE I'M
WORKING UP I HAVEN'T FIGURED OUT
WHAT IT IS.
THAT PERSON SHOULD WILL GET.
A MEDICAL EXEMPTION I MEAN THAT
THAT IS WHAT A THAT'S WHY WHEN
WAS THIS IS GET TOGETHER WE SAY
OKAY WELL LET'S WHAT ARE WE
GOING WHAT SHOULD WE DO RIGHT --
IF SOMEONE SAYS THAT -- YOU KNOW
MY I A CHILD WHO DIED OF SIDS.
AND I DON'T OF X. NIGHT MIGHT
FUTURE CHILD NEXT CHILD.
I THINK THERE'S A QUESTION THERE
BECAUSE THERE HAS NOT BEEN SHOWN
TO BE AN ASSOCIATION BETWEEN
SITS IN VACCINES IN FACT BACKS --
SITS RATES HAVE FALLEN -- WITH
ENTRIES VACCINATION ARGUE SAID I
HAVE A CHILD WITH AUTISM BY THE
WAY IT'S STUDY HAS BEEN DONE.
ALREADY BEEN DONE SAYING THAT
LOOK WE LOOK AT SIBLINGS OF
CHILDREN THE AUTISM TO SEE
WHETHER DAY ACTUALLY MIGHT HAVE
A HIGHER RATE OF AUTISM THEN --
THAT AFTER B. C. VACCINES
BECAUSE SOME PEOPLE SAY WELL
MAYBE THERE'S A GENETIC
COMPONENT -- TO AUTISM AND THEY
HAVE FOUND THERE'S NO DIFFERENCE
AND THEREFORE JUST BEING A
SIBLING OF A CHILD WITH AUTISM
CERTAINLY SHOULD NOT BE A REASON --
TO GET AN EXEMPTION FOR VACCINE
OR DEVOID VACCINATION SO IF WE
HAVE TO LOOK AT THE EVIDENCE OF
SOMEONE'S ON THE STUDY AND THEY
FOUND THE RESULT WE NEED TO
ACCEPT IT THE ONLY OF THE
SCIENCE WE HAVE TO ACCEPT IT.
IF WE IF IT IF THERE'S A
QUESTION SURE WE SHOULD GET THE
BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT TO THE
CHILD.
CAN I JUST AND I'M SORRY I WENT
TO WAS RESERVE [inaudible]
ADD SOMETHING.
MR SURE IF YOU DON'T MIND BY
THANK YOU.
OKAY I JUST WANTED TO ADD THAT --
MY SON'S SETTLEMENT WAS NOT
BASED ON THE CC PINK BOOK AND IN
THE FEDERAL VACCINE COURT THEY
DO NOT CONSIDER THE CDC PINK
BOOK THEY HAVE A SEPARATE.
VACCINE INJURY TABLE THAT THEY
GO BY IN TERMS OF QUALIFYING IN
AWARDING -- PEOPLE WHO HAVE HAD
VACCINE INJURIES SO THE LIST OF
OF THE CDC GUIDELINES THAT ARE
BEING PROPOSED IN SB.
TWO SEVEN SIX THEY ARE NOT EVEN
CONSIDERED IN THE COURT OF A
VACCINE I MEAN THEY'RE NOT EVEN
CONSIDERED IN VACCINE COURT.
THOSE ARE NOT THE SYMPTOMS THAT
THEY GO BY IN ORDER TO AWARD
PEOPLE -- AND IN TERMS OF SB TWO
SEVEN SIX IF I WERE TO HAVE
ANOTHER CHILD MY SON I ME MINE
MY NEXT CHILD WOULD NOT BE WOULD
NOT QUALIFY UNDER SB TWO SEVEN
SIX EITHER.
SO SHE'S REFERRING TO THE NEXT
NATIONAL VACCINE -- COMPENSATION
THERE RIGHT AWAY THAT IS A NO
FAULT -- SYSTEM THOSE
ESTABLISHED BY CONGRESS IN FACT
YOU EVEN HEARD.
SOMEONE TESTIFY WE SHOULD
ACTUALLY REPEAL THAT -- SO IT'S
INTERESTING THAT -- THEIR PEOPLE
WANT IT REPEALED -- I WOULD MAKE
NOTE THAT -- THAT'S A NO FAULT
COMPENSATION SYSTEM THERE ARE
WHAT THEY CALL TABLE INJURIES --
SO FOR EXAMPLE WHEN A TABLE
INJURIES IS THAT IF YOU RECEIVE
VACCINE AND YOU FAINTING YOU
FALL YOU GET COMPENSATED FOR
THAT INJURY RIGHT -- DOESN'T
MEAN THAT YOU CAN'T SIN GET
FUTURE VACCINES BECAUSE YOU
FAINTED WHEN YOU GOT THE VACCINE
SO THAT THAT THE TABLE INJURIES
ARE A VERY DIFFERENT SET OF
THINGS THEN THINGS THAT SHOULD
LEAD TO MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS
BECAUSE SOME OF THE TABLE
INJURIES.
ARE ASSOCIATED WITH THE THINGS
THAT MIGHT RESULT THAT MIGHT
BEEN SO SEATED WITH THE VACCINE
BUT IS NOT SOMETHING THAT IS IS
A SITE A FACTOR -- ADVERSE
EFFECT OF THE VACCINATION SO I
THINK WE JUST NEED TO BE CLEAR
ABOUT -- THIS PROGRAM AND WHAT
THE STANDARDS ARE ARE USED BY
THE WAY -- MOST OF THE MANY OF
THE PEOPLE WHO -- RECEIVE
COMPENSATION IT'S WITHOUT
CAUSALITY.
RIGHT AND IN FACT SO IT'S IT'S
SO YOU CAN GET COMPENSATION
WITHOUT CAUSALITY YOUR LEGAL
FEES ARE PAID -- FOR EVEN IF YOU
LOSE YOUR CASE -- SO IT IS THE
IDEA IS TO PROVIDE COMPENSATION
TO PEOPLE WHO -- YEAH MIGHT HAVE
SUFFERED AS SOME KIND OF DAMAGE.
AT THAT MIGHT POSSIBLY BE
ASSOCIATE THE VACCINE BUT EVEN
IF THERE'S NOT PROVEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR HI YOU
KNOW.
DOCTOR PAN AGAIN I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR TENACITY AND YOU
ARE GOING TO RESPOND TO EVERY
POINT -- AND I THINK THE REALITY
IS THAT THIS IS NOT A BLACK AND
WHITE ISSUE.
AND AND SCIENCE CHANGES.
EVERY BASS LINO THAT BETTER THAN
I DO EVEN.
YOU YOU LIVE AND BREATHE AND
WORK THIS.
SO I'M NOT GONNA.
SEE MORE ON THAT IT JUST I I
FEEL THAT THIS IS OVER REACHING
IF THE INTENT OF THIS TO GO WAS
TO GO AFTER.
DOCTORS WHO ARE ERRONEOUSLY
OFFERING [inaudible]
EXEMPTIONS -- I I DON'T I THINK
THERE'S A BETTER WAY OF DOING IT.
THEN CREATING THIS SITUATION
THAT WILL FOCUS SO MUCH MONEY ON
SUCH A SMALL AREA.
AND I REALLY DO WISH YOU WOULD
CONSIDER -- MAKING FURTHER
CHANGES TO THIS BECAUSE I WOULD
VERY MUCH WANT TO SUPPORT IT BUT
AS IT STANDS NOW I STILL.
I CAN'T SUPPORT THIS.
SO -- THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE BEFORE.
FIRST OFF.
THANK YOU -- TO EVERYONE -- AND
I WANT TO APOLOGIZE YOU
PERSONALLY DOCTOR PAN -- I
SHOULDN'T I SHOULD INTERVENE
WHEN PEOPLE STARTED TO
PERSONALLY ATTACK YOU AND I
DIDN'T UNTIL LATER AND I
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT I THINK
THAT'S COMPLETELY INAPPROPRIATE.
YOU DON'T LIKE OUR BILL THAT'S
ONE THING BUT YOU DO NOT ATTACK
THE PERSON CERTAINLY NOT IN OUR
HOUSE I DON'T FIND THAT
APPROPRIATE AND I APOLOGIZE YOU
PERSONALLY FOR THAT -- I DON'T
FIND THAT ACCEPTABLE ANYWHERE --
IN OUR BUSINESS.
I WANT TO I WANT TO HIT ON A
VARIETY OF THINGS HERE AND I
KNOW THERE'S A LOT BUT A LOT
SAID IN -- THE PATIENCE IS
RUNNING THIN AND PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN HERE A LONG TIME -- BUT I
WANNA I WANNA I WANNA HAVE A
COUPLE THINGS AND THE REASON I
ASK IS THE MEDICAL BOARD TO STAY
HERE HAVE A QUESTION -- OF OF
THE MEDICAL BOARD.
AND THAT IS OF THE CASES THAT
ARE BEING AND INVESTIGATED OR
HAVE BEEN INVESTIGATED HOW MANY
OF THOSE CASES WERE SUCH THAT.
THAT EXEMPTIONS WERE PROVIDED
WITH OUT AN EXAMINATION OF THE
PATIENT.
I DON'T HAVE THAT INFORMATION
WITH ME WITHOUT TAKE A MANUAL
LOOK THROUGH THE INVESTIGATIONS
TO SEE YOU KNOW WHAT BACK OUR
SECOND SAID ALRIGHT.
AND YET MAYBE I SHOULD HAVE
THOUGHT OF THAT -- SO BUT IS
THAT IS THAT PART OF WHAT'S
GOING ON IN IN SOME OF THE ON
GOING INVESTIGATIONS WHERE
PEOPLE HAVE NOT REALLY BEEN
EXAMINED THAT MAYBE IT'S A
TELEPHONE CONSOLE TO WORK.
OR EVEN LESS THAN THAT I MEAN I
THINK I AM GENERALLY SPEAKING AS
INVESTIGATIONS ARE CONFIDENTIAL
BUT IN SOME CASES AND YES THE
THE APPROPRIATE YOU KNOW EXAM
HAS NOT HAPPENED BUT THAT'S IN
THE THIS CASE IS IN.
ANOTHER CASES LIKE OPIOID
PRESCRIBING CASES AND THINGS
LIKE THAT BUT YEAH I BELIEVE
THAT IN THESE CASES THAT IS ONE
OF THE FACTORS BUT LIKE I SAID
TO ACTUALLY GET NUMBERS OUT HAVE
UNDERSTAND UNDERSTAND THE
CONFIDENTIALITY ABOUT SO -- WELL
TODAY OBVIOUSLY THE A LOT OF
TALK IS AROUND MEASLES -- AND
AND THE MMR -- IN PARTICULAR --
I HAVE CONCERNS -- AND A PRODUCT
FROM A BROADER PERSPECTIVE -- I
THINK OF FOR EXAMPLE -- WHEN I
PRACTICED DENTISTRY -- SEEN
PATIENTS WHO HAD -- ADULT
PATIENTS OLDER ADULT PATIENTS
WHO HAD POST POLIO SYNDROME --
THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT SURVIVED
POLIO -- HAD COMPROMISED LIVES
AND AS THEY GOT OLDER THEY
EXPERIENCED WASTING OF THE
MUSCLES IN ABILITY TO FUNCTION
WELL THEIR QUALITY OF LIFE WAS
PRETTY AWFUL.
NOW MOST THE PEOPLE IN THE
AUDIENCE PROBABLY.
DON'T KNOW A LOT ABOUT POLIO
[inaudible]
BUT IT IS A IT IS A SERIOUSLY
DEBILITATING DISEASE WHAT PEOPLE
DIED IMPRINT WITH POLIO.
AND AND WE HAVE NEARLY
ERADICATED POLIO FROM THE PLANET
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF A COUPLE
COUNTRIES.
YET I FEAR THAT WILL GO
BACKWARDS THAT WILL BRING POLIO
BACK. TO TO TO TO THE U. S..
AND I AND THAT THAT THAT THAT
CONCERNS ME ALSO CONCERNS ME IN
TALKING -- TO TALKING TO THE
MEDICAL PROFESSIONAL RECENTLY.
WHEN A I'M A MOTHER MIGHT TAKE A
CHILD TO A -- TO A GROCERY STORE
AN INFANT.
MAYBE ONLY A COUPLE WEEKS OLD
MAYBE YOU KNOW I'D.
PURSUANT TAKEN AND FAN OUT THAT
YOUNG BUT SOME PEOPLE MIGHT.
AND THERE COULD BE PEOPLE THAT
ARE ON IN YOUR ON IMMUNIZED WHO
MAY HAVE PER TOSSES.
THE POTENTIAL IMPACTS OF THAT
INFANT WHO CAN'T BE IMMUNIZED AT
FIFTEEN DAYS OR WHATEVER.
IS VERY VERY SERIOUS.
AND SO WE ALSO TALK ABOUT I'VE
HEARD PEOPLE SAY I HAD MEASLES
AND YOU KNOW I'M FINE AND I HAD
MONTHS I'M FINE.
BUT IT IS A SERIOUS.
ILLNESS.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO SUFFER
YEARS DOWN THE LINE WITH
COMPLICATIONS LIGHT HEARING LOSS --
LIKE VISION LOSS OR LIKE SOME
OTHER THINGS THAT HAPPENED YEARS
AFTER THEY HAVE HAD THE MEASLES
AND IT CAN BE TRCED BACK TO
HAVING HAD THE MEASLES.
SO SO TO PUT COULD THIS IS AS A
INNOCENT CONDITION OF CHILDHOOD
IS I THINK IS IS MISTAKEN.
ASK THE THAT'S THE YOUNG CHILD
WHO SPENT FIVE FOR FIVE DAYS AND
I SEE YOU AND IN OREGON -- WITH
COMPLICATIONS FROM THE MEASLES
HOUSE IN SERIOUS THAT IS -- AND
AND SO IT IS IT IS HERE IS RIGHT
AND I DO SO I DO TAKE YEAH I DO
TAKE UMBRAGE WITH PEOPLE DO KIND
OF POOH POOHED THIS AS AS NOT
BEING SERIOUS.
I THINK THE CRITICAL THING I'VE
HEARD ALSO THAT -- WELL YOU KNOW
WE GOT 95% YOU KNOW IMMUNITY
THEREFORE IT'S ALL GOOD IT
DOESN'T WORK THAT WAY IT'S
REGIONAL IT'S BY SCHOOL IS BY
YOUR COMMUNITY IT'S BY YOUR
CHURCHES BY YOUR PLAYGROUP IT'S
A VARIETY OF THINGS.
AND WHEN I THINK OF LISTENING
LISTENING TO LACI WAS NOT IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL SHE'S
JUST CONCERNED ABOUT AN
EXEMPTION THAT WOULD PROTECT HER.
BECAUSE IF THERE ARE MORE AND
MORE PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT
IMMUNIZED.
SHE'S AT RISK.
HER BECAUSE HER CHILDREN COULD
CONTRACT THE DISEASE BECAUSE
WE'VE ARMY AS ASCERTAIN THEIR
CHILDREN SHOULDN'T GET THE EXIT
COULD SHOULD GET THESE.
SO.
THE END OF IT THE THE INABILITY
FOR PEOPLE THE OR THE THE DESIRE
PEOPLE TO NOT IMMUNIZE OUR
CHILDREN PUTS OTHER KIDS AT RISK
WITH LACI AT RISK.
AND SO THAT'S A SERIOUS THAT'S A
SERIOUS CONCERN ABOUT I
HAPPENINGS.
IT'S MY TURN THANK YOU -- I HAVE
A AYE DATA HERE -- AND THAT SAYS
THAT WE HAVE -- FIFTEEN MEMBERS
OF THIS COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE A HUNDRED AND NINETY
FIVE SCHOOLS AMONG THE FIFTEEN
MEMBERS THAT IMMUNIZATION RATES
LESS THAN 95%.
A HUNDRED AND NINETY FIVE
SCHOOLS FIFTEEN MEMBERS THAT'S
ABOUT.
TEN PER MEMBER ROUGHLY.
WE GOT ONE MEMBER WHO HAS ONE
SCHOOL.
WE HAVE ANOTHER MEMBER BEST.
THIRTY TWO THIS IS CLEARLY NOT
DISPERSED EVENLY ACROSS THE
POPULATION.
THIS IS REGIONAL THIS IS LOCAL
AND THIS IS THIS THIS IS A
CHALLENGE WHAT'S MORE DISTURBING
TO ME.
IS THAT WE HAVE THIRTY SEVEN
SCHOOLS.
THEY HAVE REPORTED AT ALL EVEN
THOUGH IT'S REQUIRED.
MATTER FACT THAT NUMBER MAY
APPROACH A THOUSAND THERE MAY BE
A THOUSAND SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA
THAT ARE NOT REPORTING THE
IMMUNIZATION.
THE PROBLEM COULD BE BIGGER THAN
WE ACTUALLY KNOW.
AND THAT AND THAT THAT TROUBLES
THAT TROUBLES ME AS WELL.
SO -- THERE'S BEEN A LOT SAID
HERE TODAY THERE'S BEEN A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF WORK ON
THIS WE HAVE BEEN WATCHING THIS
BILL.
SENSE YOU INTRODUCED IT SENATOR
PAP.
AND WE HAVE BEEN WORKING ON THIS
BILL AND THINKING ABOUT THIS
BILL SINCE IT WAS HEARD IN THE
SENATE.
AND OTHER PEOPLE OF ENGAGE IT
MINISTRATION IS ENGAGE THE
SECRETARY OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES ENGAGED WE BELIEVE.
THAT WE ARE AT A PLACE THAT THIS
IS THIS THROUGH THE OUR PROCESS
IS A IS A BETTER BILL I STILL
THINK YOU HAVE A HER CONCERN AND
AND I APPRECIATE THE CONCERN OF
LACI.
CAN THERE BE A WAY TO ADDRESS
HER CONCERN AS WE MOVE FORWARD
AND I AND I KNOW THAT YOU.
YOU ARE GOING TO TAKE THAT
SERIOUSLY AND AND AND WE WILL WE
WILL DO THAT.
SO THIS IS AYE KNOWS A LOT OF
EMOTION HERE -- AND AND A LOT OF
CHALLENGES HERE AND IT IS
DIFFICULT AND AND BEING SOMEONE
WHO -- HAS BEEN IN THE MEDICAL
FIELD FOR MOST OF MY LIFE.
HI -- I UNDERSTAND BECAUSE WE'RE
NOT ALWAYS TRUSTED AS PRINT
PRACTITIONERS.
WITHOUT A WAS TRUST IS.
SO I DO WANT TO SAY -- BEFORE --
BEFORE I ASK YOU TO CLOSE I
WANNA -- I WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY WHO CAME HERE TODAY I
KNOW ANY PEOPLE TRAVEL LONG
DISTANCES WANT TO THANK THE
WITNESSES ON BOTH SIDES --
SUPPORT AND THE OPPOSITION I
THINK IT'S BEEN A VERY ROBUST
DISCUSSION -- AND I APPRECIATE --
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE A PART OF
THIS PROCESS.
WELL I WILL BE SUPPORTING YOUR
BILL TODAY -- AND I LOOK FOR TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU -- AS
IF THE BILL WAS FOR TODAY AND I
THINK YOU -- FOR YOUR
PERSEVERANCE -- AND I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SERVICE TO YOUR
COMMUNITY.
AND WITHOUT IT GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY CLOSE.
THANK YOU -- DOCTOR CHAIR AND I
FIRST OF ALL -- I KNOW IT'S BEEN
A LONG DAY AND WE'VE HAD A VERY --
ROBUST DISCUSSION I WANNA THANK
ALL OF THE PEOPLE OF CAYMAN
TRAVEL TO TESTIFY ON THE BARE
BILL AND EXPRESS THEIR OPINIONS --
SO THE WITNESSES I WANT TO THANK
EACH ONE OF YOU AS WELL -- BOTH --
FOR THE MEETINGS WE'VE HAD TO
TALK ABOUT THE BILL AND THEN OF
COURSE THE DISCUSSION WE'VE HAD
HERE AT THIS HEARING.
AND I THINK IT'S A IT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT PART OF THE PROCESS
SOMEONE THANK.
YOU CHAIR WORDS IN YOUR STAFF
THAT HELPED ME STAFF -- FOR THE
FOR THE TREMENDOUS WORK I KNOW
THAT IN EVEN IN THE MIDDLE AS
WE'RE TRYING TO THE BUDGET
EVERYTHING ELSE WE'RE SPENDING
MANY HOURS HAMMERING OUT.
SPECIFICS WITH THE BILL AND ALSO
ONE OF RECOGNIZE AND THANK THE
GOVERNOR AND THE SECRETARY GOLLY
AND HIS TEAM AS WELL AS WE HAD
SERVICE TRIPARTITE TO A
DISCUSSION AND I APPRECIATE THAT
THE GOVERNOR HAS PUBLICLY STATED
THAT HE IS LOOKING.
FOR TO A SIGNING THIS BILL WHEN
IT LANDS ON HIS DESK SO.
DESIGN BRIEFLY SAY THIS IS
REALLY ABOUT RESPONSIBILITY.
RIGHT WE WANT TO BE SURE WE GIVE
EVERYONE AS MUCH FREEDOM AS
POSSIBLE WE WANT TO BE SURE THAT
WE PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF ALL
CHILDREN THAT INCLUDES.
THE CHILDREN WHO GENUINELY NEED
A MEDICAL EXEMPTION BECAUSE THEY
NEED THAT PROTECTION FROM THE
OTHER PEOPLE IN THEIR SCHOOL.
AND THAT'S THE RESPONSIBILITY
PART BECAUSE AND THAT'S WHY WE
NEED THE OVERSIGHT UNFORTUNATELY
I MEAN WE WE'VE HEARD PEOPLE
CLAIM THERE'S NO FAKE MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS WELL I THINK THE
MEDICAL BOARD OF BEG TO DIFFER I
THINK OUR PUB COUNTY HEALTH
OFFICER TO BEG TO DIFFER OUR
SCHOOL NURSES WOULD.
BEG TO DIFFER THERE IS A PROBLEM
AND THAT PROBLEM IS ERODING THE
GAINS THAT WE ACHIEVE A TWO
SEVEN SEVEN WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
NUMBERS PEOPLE HAVE DONE
RESEARCH I DIDN'T.
SUBMIT THIS DO A BILL RIGHT AWAY
AND SAID WELL THERE'S A LOOPHOLE
ON SCHOOL CLOSE IT WE WAITED TO
SEE WHAT HAPPENED WE HAD
RESEARCHERS LOOK AT THE DATA.
WE HAD PEOPLE LOOK AT THE DATA
AND WE HAVE A PROBLEM WE DON'T
WANT TO WAIT TO FOR THE PROBLEM
TO GET WORSE WE ALREADY HAVE ON
THE LARGEST MEASLES OUTBREAKS
CALIFORNIA IS ACTUALLY SHOWN
IT'S BEEN THAT RESIST NOW WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO HOLD IT OFF.
BUT WE WANNA STAY THAT WAY WE
DON'T WANT THAT TO GO AWAY AND
SO THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS
ABOUT IT'S ABOUT PROTECTING THE
RIGHTS OF THE CHILD TO ACTUALLY
NEED WHO TRULY NEEDS MEDICAL
EXEMPTION.
SURE THEY GET THE MEDICAL
SENTIENT AND THEY'RE SAFE AND
THEY'RE IN SCHOOL BUT THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR PAN BEFORE WE
ACTUALLY ACTUALLY S. GOVERNMENT
SECTOR COLOR I WANT TO THANK OUR
OUR SERGEANTS WHO BEEN WORKING
WITH US ALL DAY TO HELP MAKE
THIS A IS.
AS EASY EXPERIENCE AS POSSIBLE
AND AND TRY TO MAKE IT ORDERLY
AND MAKE IT EASY FOR PEOPLE
COMING AND GOING HERE SO I VERY
MUCH THANK OUR SERGEANTS ARE
CHIEF SERGEANT.
AND MISTER COOLEY THE CHAIR OF A
RULES COMMITTEE FOR HIS WORK ON
ON AND I'M TRYING TO MAKE THIS A
BETTER DAY FOR EVERYONE SO.
SO WITH THAT -- MADAM SECRETARY
WE HAVE A MOTION BY DOCTOR
ARAMBULA A SECOND BY MISTER
BONTA THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
WITH THAT MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL WOOD HI WHAT I
MAYES.
MAYES NOT VOTING.
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BIGELOW.
BONTA.
BONTA AYE BURKE.
BURKE NO CARILLO [inaudible]
I FLORA [inaudible]
LIMON.
LIMON I'D MCCARTY MCCARTY I IN
THIS AREA.
THIS AREA NOT VOTING RAMOS.
BY TODAY AND LOOKING FORWARD TO
DISCUSSION THE FINAL BILL.
I ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON.
WATER NO.
YOUR BILL HAS NINE VOTES ITSELF
MANY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
MEMBERS [inaudible]
THINGS [inaudible]
MEETING ADJOURNED